artificial intelligence is transforming
various sectors by replicating human
intelligence ranging from virtual
assistance to self-driving Vehicles
while it promises enhanc efficiency and
Innovation it's essential to prioritize
ethical consideration and responsible
development to fully utilize ai's
potential AI stands as a formidable
Force shaping the landscape of the 21st
century due to growth in technology AI
Engineers AI Specialists machine
learning Engineers are in high demand
and tend to earn handsome salary
packages on an average AI engineer earns
up to
$157,000 per year so if you are looking
to step into this field this cost will
be perfect to get the basic knowledge of
AI and its algorithms and Hands-On demo
using python for all the aspiring AI
experts get certified into postgraduate
program in Ai and machine learning in
partnership with pu University and IBM
elevate your career with skills in
machine learning deep learning natural
language processing computer vision chat
GPD and more one year of experience is
preferred to enroll into this course
enroll now for in demand expertise grab
the course now from the link in the
description box so let's dive into the
artificial intelligence full course with
python over to our tutors and if you
like these videos then like share and
subscribe to our Channel and now
starting with who is an AI professional
so an AI professional is an expert in
the field of artificial intelligence
possessing the Knowledge and Skills to
design develop and Implement AI
solutions they play a crucial role in
various Industries leveraging AI
Technologies to solve complex problems
and enhance decision- making process
they are in high demand due to the
increasing use of AI in Industries like
healthcare finance and technology and
now we will explore the various career
paths for an AI professional starting
with AI research scientist then we have
machine learning engineer data scientist
NLP engineer computer vision engineer AI
ethics and bias analyst AI product
manager AI software developer so these
are the career paths for an AI
professional now we'll move to the RO
roles and responsibilities for each
profession so starting with AI research
scientist so the roles and
responsibilities are conduct research to
advance Ai and machine learning
Technologies then we have developed and
Implement Noel algorithms and models and
another work is integrate AI into
products and services and then publish
research findings in conferences and
journals then stay updated with the
latest developments in AI research so
these are the roles and responsib
abilities for AI research scientist now
moving on to the next role that was
machine learning engineer and now we'll
see its tools and responsibilities that
is design and build machine learning
models and systems collect and
pre-process data for model training tune
and optimize algorithms for performance
deploy models into production
environments and monitor and maintain
machine learning systems and now moving
on to the next role that is data
scientist data scientist roles and
responsibilities are as
follows they analyze large data set to
extract meaningful insights they develop
predictive models and data driven
Solutions and they create data
visualizations and reports for decision
making they collaborate with business
teams to identify data driven
opportunities they also ensure that data
privacy and security compliance keep in
handy and now moving on to the next Ro
that is natural language processing
engineer NLP engineer and their roles
and responsibilities are they develop
NLP models for language understanding
and generation they pre-process and
clean Text data for NLP task they work
on sentiment analysis chat boards and
language translation they collaborate
with linguist and domain experts for
specialized NLP projects they stay
current with NLP research and
Technologies and now moving on to the
next Ro that is computer vision
engineer so the computer vision engineer
buil computer vision algorithms for
image and video analysis they develop
object detection image recognition and
facial recognition systems they
collaborate with Hardware teams for
embedded Vision applications they
Implement image and video processing
techniques they also stay updated on
computer vision advancements so these
were the roles and responsibilities for
computer vision engineer now moving on
to the next role that is AI ethics and
bias analyst so starting with their
roles and responsibilities the first one
is assess and mitigate ethical concerns
and biases in AI systems develop and
Implement fairness and bias detection
algorithms andure AI systems that comply
with ethical guidelines and regulations
they educate teams on ethical AI
practices and they conduct Audits and
assessments of AI models now moving on
to the next role that is AI product
manager now moving on to the next role
that is AI product manager and now we'll
see their roles and responsibilities so
they Define the AI product strategy and
road map they collaborate with
stakeholders to GA requirements and they
prioritize features and functionalities
for AI products they also manage the
development and deployment for AI
solutions they also monitor product
performance and gather user feedback now
moving on to the next role that is AI
software developer so AI software
developer develop software applications
that incorporate AI capabilities they
integrate AI apis and libraries into
existing software systems they write
code for AI model deployment and
inference they collaborate with AI
researchers and Engineers on software
projects they debug and maintain AI
related code and applications these
roles and responsibilities can vary
depending on the specific industry I'm
talking about all the roles they can
vary on specific industry organization
and the level of experties is required
so AI professionals may also specialize
further Within These roles based on
their areas of interest and expertise
and now I have an insightful for you
guys that is if you are one of the
aspiring AI or ml Enthusiast looking for
online training or graduating from the
best universities then I have the short
of Simply learn skel Tech a& ml boot
camp and you can find the boot camp
details with the link and you will
navigate to The Boot Camp Page now
moving to the career road map for AI
professional so these are the steps you
need to follow to become an AI
professional so the step one is
mastering the fundamentals then we have
introduction to machine learning then
the third step is delving deeper into
deep learning then we have practical
experience with data then introduction
to natural language processing and then
we have immersion in computer vision and
then introduction to reinforcement
learning and then engage in Practical
projects and continuous learning so
starting with the step one so what
should you do to be a AI professional so
the first step is mastering the
fundamentals
so begin your AI journey by establishing
a strong foundation in Core Concepts get
acquired with essential mathematical
principles such as algebra calculus and
probability additionally take the time
to become proficient in a beginner
friendly programming language like
python which is widely utilized in the
field of AI explore various online
tutorials and education resources to
grasp the fundamental aspects of Python
Programming now moving to step two that
is Introduction to machine learning so
machine learning constitutes a pivotal
component of AI start by comprehending
the concepts of supervised and
unsupervised learning supervised
learning involves the training of models
using label data while unsupervised
learning revolves around the
identification of patterns within
unlabelled data familiarize yourself
with popular machine learning algorithms
like linear regression and decision
trees prioritize gaining an inuitive
understanding of these algorithms before
delving into their mathematical INRI
cases and now moving on to the step
three that is delving deeper into deep
learning deep learning has witnessed
significant Acclaim in recent years
commence your deep Learning Journey by
acquiring knowledge about neural
networks the fundamental building blocks
of deep learning gain insight into the
structure of neural networks the data
learning mechanisms and their predictive
capabilities explore crucial Concepts
like activation functions back
propagation and gradient descent so this
was about the step three Now we move to
the the step four that is practical
experience with data so data is the
lifeblood of AI applications learn how
to efficiently manipulate and
pre-process data discover techniques for
data cleaning addressing missing values
and transforming data into format
suitable for model training put your
skills into practice by working with
libraries like pandas and numpy which
simplify data manipulation task now
moving on to the step five that is
Introduction to natural language
processing natural language processing
is focused on enabling machines to
comprehend human language begin by
building a foundation in essential NLP
Concepts such as tokenization the
division of text into words or sentences
stemming reducing words to their root
forms and part of speech tagging
identifying grammatical elements gain
practical experience by experimenting
with NLP libraries like nltk now moving
on to the step six that is immersion in
computer vision so computer vision
involves the teaching of machines to
interpret visual information Begin by
exploring image processing techniques
including filtering and feature
extraction learn about widely used
computer vision algorithms such as
object detection and image
classification repeat put your knowledge
into action by experimenting with
libraries like open CV and tensorflow to
implement computer vision applications
now moving on to the step seven that is
Introduction to reinforcement learning
reinforcement learning centers on
training agents to make decisions
through a process of trial and start by
understanding Core Concepts such as
rewards States and actions familiarize
yourself with popular algorithms like
q-learning and engage in the
environments like open AI gym to
practice reinforcement learning then we
have the step eight engaging in
Practical projects and continuous
learning apply your new found knowledge
through Hands-On projects begin with
small scale projects and progressively
take on more complex challenges
participate in AI communities and
contribute to online forums to
collaborate with fellow Learners and
gain insights from experienced
practitioners stay updated with the
latest developments in AI by following
AI blogs attending webinars and
exploring AI related new sources so in
conclusion I want to say that commencing
your AI Journey as a no I may appear
daunting but by following this
structured road map you can progress
systematically and establish a solid
foundation in AI Concepts remember to
prioritize a deep understanding of the
fundamentals engage in Hands-On learning
with real world data and undertake
projects to reinforce your knowledge
Embrace continuous learning and leverage
online resources and communities to
enhance your AI skills now moving on to
the companies hiring AI professional so
Amazon Cap Gemini orle TCS asenta sap
IBM cognizant so these are the companies
and these are the top most companies
that hire AI
professionals and now moving on to the
average salary for AI professionals so
in US a bner AI professional can earn up
to $882,000 to
$128,000 and an experienced professional
can earn from
$99,000 to
$200,000 and if we talk about India a
beginner can earn from 5 lakhs to 12
lakhs per anom and if we talk about the
experienced professional they can earn
from 7 lakhs to 20 lakhs perom so these
data adjust the stats from the glass
door and they can vary on the different
states and the country
so well there you have it folks and
before ending I want to take a minute to
hear from our Learners who have
experienced massive success in their
careers by opting out the boot camp and
the postgraduate program in Ai and
machine learning artificial intelligence
artificial intelligence AI has emerged
as a transformative technology that is
Revolution various aspect of our lives
with its ability to simulate human
intelligence and perform complex task AI
has found application in the field range
in from healthare Finance to
transportation and entertainment and
many other fields so let me share you
some fascinating stats with you that
illustrate the impact of the potential
of this gamechanging technology before
we delve into the fascinating world of
artificial intelligence so according to
glass door the average salary of AI
engineer is $160,000 in United States
and in India it's up to 11 lakh perm in
India so learning AI offers numerous
benefits ranging from career
opportunities and Innovation to personal
growth and ethical consideration it
equips you with valuable skills and
knowledge that can have profound impact
on various aspect of society and the
World At Large but before choosing the
right course to excel in the field of AI
can be challenging so with so many
option available out there in the market
how do you know which one is the right
for you well we are here to help you
without any further Ado let's discuss
the top a certification for 20 24 number
one on the list is postgraduate program
in Ai and machine learning this
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning in collaboration with P
University and IBM offered you by simply
is an online program designed you to
provide students with a comprehensive
understanding of AI and machine learning
Concepts tools and techniques these
programs cover various topics such as
data science stat deep learning computer
vision and NLP natural language
processing and help you gain the right
skills on a various tools such as kasas
matplot lip tensor flow Jango and many
more furthermore the curriculum is
structured around interactive online
class live session with industry expert
and Hands-On projects the program also
includes access to Simply L learning
management system which provides a
student with additional resources such
as practic exercise quizzes and
simulation overall the Purdue
postgraduate program in Ai and machine
learning offered by simply learn is a
well structured and comprehensive
program that can help a student student
gain expertise in Ai and machine
learning Concepts and enhance their
career Prospect in the field upon
completing the program student will
receive a postgraduate certificate from
P University and IBM indicating that
they have acquired the skills and
knowledge necessary to apply Ai and
machine learning Concept in the real
world situation admission to this
postgraduate program in AIML course
requires 2 plus years of experience
preferred bachelor degree with an
average of 50% of her higher marks basic
understanding of programming concept and
mathematic so hurry up enroll now in the
per postgraduate program in AIML and
create your own successful career the
course link is in the description box
below number two number two on the list
is IIT can for professional certificate
course in Ai and machine learning
accelate your career in Ai and ml with a
comprehensive professional certificate
course in Ai and machine learning in
collaboration with IIT kpur this machine
learning course will equip with highly
coated skill in ml deep learning NLP
generative AI prompt engineering chat
gbt and much more through live classes
by industry expert master classes from
IIT Cano faculty and Hands-On projects
you will stay ahead in the field of AI
this AI ml course covers Concepts like
machine learning deep learning natural
language processing reinforcement
learning computer vision speech
recognition generative ai explainable ai
prompt engineering chat gity and much
more this state of art of machine
learning course covers modules that can
help you Kickstart a thriving career in
AIML you will also receive the
opportunity to delve into cutting a AI
topics such as generative AI chat GPT
GPT models and explainable ey for
admission to this artificial
intelligence course candidate should
have a bachelor degree with an average
of 50% or higher marks preferably 2 plus
years of experience prior knowledge or
experience in programming and
Mathematics so why wait androll now and
unlock exciting AIML opportunities so
why wait join now seats are feeling fast
the course link is in the description
box below number third on the list is
AIML boot camp by celtech this AIML boot
camp program May develop your career as
an expert in artificial intell and
machine learning boot camp in the
collaboration with CCH University the
AIML boot camp offers master classes by
calch professors live classes taught by
industry expert interactive labs and
projects relevant to this industry this
boot camp offers scel Tech academic
Excellence simply lar career assistance
campus immersion and handson experience
this AIML boot camp will help you get
notied by top hiring companies and helps
you in the industry relevant Capstone
project the AIML boot camp at celtech is
the best option for anyone wishing to
get a Competitive Edge in the era of
Cutting Edge Technologies this boot camp
offers complete understanding of AI
based Technologies like machine learning
natural language processing deep
learning speech recognition
reinforcement learning and much more
this course covers tools and techniques
like python tensorflow kasas met plot
and many more along with the industry
projects like social media e-commerce
manufacturing at teag Healthcare and
many more Amazing Project choosing the
boot camp can get you hired by the reown
companies like Microsoft Google IBM
Amazon Samsung and Adobe this boot cam
has benefited many aspiring AIML
engineers and professional candidate
applying for AIML boot camp should have
the following this boot camp is for the
United States only be at least 18 years
old and have a high school diploma or
equivalent have prior knowledge or
experience in programming and
Mathematics preferably 2 plus years of
formal work experience so hurry up
enroll now in the a ml boot camp and
create your own successful career the
course link is in the description box
below finally we have Masters in
artificial intelligence program this
master program in artificial
intelligence is one of the most sought
after courses offered by simply learn
this artificial intelligence master
program in collaboration with IBM
introduces student to Blended learning
and prepares them to be specialist in Ai
and data science this program will teach
you the necessary skills you need to
become an AI expert and Lear in your
dream job this course covers the basic
fundamental of Python programming
languages and its popular libraries like
numpy and pandas from scratch to some
Advanced topic like machine learning
algorithm deep learning natural language
processing computer vision and AI
deployment by covering some important
tools like kasas tensorflow CPI and
manyo so what else you can expect from
this program well this course also
include three capson and 12 industry
relevant projects from the likes of
Amazon Walmart mercedesbenz Uber and
many more immersive learning experience
aex higher in life interaction in the
live AI online classes delivered by
season trainers and Industry expert and
simply learn job assist programs sound
interesting right so what are you
waiting for don't miss out on this
chance to take career to the next level
enroll in our artificial intelligence
master program course course today and
start your journey to become AI expert
the link is added in the description box
below and the comment section moving
forward let's see the future of AI the
future of AI hold tremendous promising
and potential as technology advances AI
is expected to become more sophisticated
and capable some key trends that will
shape the future of AI include ethical
AI emphasis on Fair transparent and
unbiased AI system grows with efforts of
address privacy accountability and bies
ethical concerns Drive regulation and
responsible AI development AI in
robotics integrating with AI robotics
create intelligent robots for complex
task in manufacturing logistic and
Health Care AI in iot AI combined with
iot enables smart hom cities and
industries enhancing decision making and
automation through interconnected
devices AI in personalization AI enhance
personalized experience in entertainment
e-commerce and marketing by
understanding user preferences and
delivering tailored recommendations the
fifth one is autonomous system
self-driving cars drones and Robotics
Advan relying on AI algorithms and
sensor transforming Transportation
logistic and other industry rather than
replacing humans AI is expected to
augmented human capabilities and enable
more effective collaboration AI system
can assist in decision- making automate
repetitive task and provide personalized
recommendations allowing humans to focus
on higher level task that require
creativity and critical thinking AI is
changing the world a lot it's like
having helpful friends onor devices like
Siri and Alexa who can understand us
really well also AI is like a secret
helper in the internet World suggesting
things we might like when we watch shows
or shop online but it's not just about
making life easy AI is doing big things
too for example in healthcare it's
finding new medicines faster and helping
doctors spot problems early and is also
good for the planet because it helps us
save energy and predict the weather more
accurately the future looks even better
with AI making a world more Innovative
and efficient at the same time it's like
a kind of a magic the more magical thing
about this field is the salary this
field offers to the professionals it's
mind-blowing and fascinating a Gartner
study reports that AI is an emerging
field that will create 2.8 million jobs
by 2025 so this video will discuss the
top five AI jobs in 2024 which highest
salary this video will help you in
getting the answer to one of the most
sought after questions related to
artificial intelligence why you should
consider a career in this exponentially
growing field but before we begin if you
enjoy watching these videos and find
them interesting then subscribe to our
YouTube channel because we bring the
best videos for you daily also press the
Bell icon to never miss any updates from
Simply so let's talk about the top five
AI jobs with the highest salaries at
number five we have a computer vision in
engineer a computer vision engineer is a
programmer skilled in creating software
using visual input sensors and
algorithms these systems can interpret
their environment as seen in
self-driving cars and facial recognition
computer vision Engineers uses languages
like C++ and python they work on tasks
like object detection image segmentation
facial and gesture recognition and scene
comprehension consequently the
compensation packages for computer
vision Engineers have become notably
attractive according to glaso the
average salary of a computer vision
engineer is
$155,000 in the United States and in
India it's rupees 8 lakh perm serving as
a significant incentive for individuals
venturing into this domain at number
four we have software Engineers software
Engineers handle tasks from design to
deployment but it's rare to find experts
in All Phases they usually specializes
in specific areas this specialization
applies to AI software Engineers too
they work on various applications
including machine learning inference
learning NLP and intrusion detection
covering different aspects of AI
development consequently the
compensation packages for software
Engineers have become notably attractive
according to glasso the average salary
of a software engineer is
$140,000 in the United States and in
India it's rupees 9 lakh perom serving
as a significant incentive for
individuals venturing into this domain
moving on to number three we have
machine learning Engineers a machine
learning engineer creates and deploys
training algorithms and models which is
the most demanding part of machine
learning most machine learning Engineers
hold Advanced degrees in computer
science mathematics or statistics due to
the need for advanced math skills many
also pursue specialized master's degrees
or certifications in machine learning
deep learning or neural networks
consequently the compensation package
packages for ML Engineers as well is
notably attractive according to glaso
the average salary of a machine learning
engineer is
$150,000 in the United States and in
India it goes up to 11 lakh rupees perom
with additional cash benefits at number
two we have an AI research scientist AI
research scientists often computer
scientists focuses on innovating AI
algorithms and models their duties
include creating and evaluating new AI
models collaborating in research
publishing papers and presenting at
conferences while programming is a part
of their work it's just a portion unlike
the tech industry's openness to
self-taught programmers AI research
scientists need strong backgrounds in
computer science mathematics and
statistics consequently the compensation
packages for AI research scientists have
become notably attractive according to
glaso the average salary of an AI
research scientist is
$125,000 in the United States and rupees
21 lakhs perom in India with additional
cash benefits and finally at number one
we have an AI product manager an AI
product manager is much like other
program managers they oversee teams for
AI product development handling
schedules and Milestones to do this
effectively they need to understand AI
components like hardware and programming
languages which helps them support their
teams creating AI apps differs from web
applications in structure and
development processes
consequently the compensation is the
highest for AI product managers in 2024
according to glaso the average salary of
an AI product manager is
$190,000 in the United States and in
India it goes around 26 lakh rupees per
enom with additional cash compensations
so these are the top five job roles you
should consider entering in
20124 so let's go through the reasons
why AI individuals are paid so much the
first reason is surging demand AI is in
high demand across Industries due to its
potential for Innovation and
competitiveness leading to higher
salaries for Professionals in this field
specialized expertise a specialist
possesses unique skills in areas like
machine learning and data analysis
justifying their higher pay business
impact ai's transformative potential for
businesses results in higher
compensation for experts who help
Implement AI Solutions Talent scarcity
the shortage of qualified a
professionals creates intense
competition among employers driving up
salaries and the last reason is
continuous learning and Innovation AI
experts are rewarded for staying updated
and Innovative in a rapidly evolving
field with the growing demand for AI
expertise skilled professionals have
opportunities to boost their earnings by
enhancing their skills acquiring
Advanced education and gaining practical
experience so let's dive into four
effective strategies to elevate your AI
engineer salary enabling you to excel in
a competitive job market and negotiate
more favorable compensation the first
strategy is broaden your skill set
continuously expand your expertise in AI
related domains such as machine learning
deep learning natural language
processing and of course computer vision
stay up to date with the latest tools
Frameworks and algorithms by becoming an
expert in specific areas due to
exceptional Knowledge and Skills you can
command higher compensation pursue
Advanced education consider pursuing
Advanced degrees in AI or Rel ated
Fields such as a master's or a
post-graduate course higher levels of
Education often opens doors to higher
paying career opportunities Advan
degrees not only showcase your
commitment to the field but also provide
you with an extensive knowledge and
research experience significantly
boosting your earning potential gain
practical experience engage in real
world AI projects to accumulate
practical experience and build a robust
portfolio explore options such as
internships contributions to open source
projects and involvement in AI research
initiatives and the last strategy is
pursue industry recognized
certifications attain certifications
that are widely recognized in artificial
intelligence technology and framework
domain these certifications validate
your AI skills and competence
positioning you as a valuable asset for
companies adopting AI Solutions such
credentials gives you Competitive Edge
over other candidates and result in more
generous salary offers hello and welcome
to machine learning tutorial part one
this is part part one of a machine
learning series put on by simply learn
my name is Richard Kushner I'm with the
simply learn team that's www.s simply
learn.com get certified get ahead what's
in it for you today well we'll start off
with a brief explanation of why machine
learning and what is machine learning
and then we'll get into a few of the
types of machine learning machine
learning algorithms linear regression
decision trees support Vector machine
and finally we'll do a use case where
we're going to classify whether recipe
is of a cupcake or a muffin using the
SPM or the support Vector machine sounds
like a delicious way to explore machine
learning so why machine learning why do
we even care about having these
computers come up and be able to do all
these new things for us well because
machines can now drive your car for you
still very in the infant stage but it's
just exploding as we see with uh
Google's wayo and then Uber had their
program which unfortunately crashed they
know that this is huge this is going to
be the huge industry to change our whole
Transportation infrastructure machine
learning is now used to detect over 50
eye diseases do you know how amazing
that is to have a computer that double
checks for the doctor for things they
might miss that's just huge in the
health industry pretty soon they
actually do already have that in some
areas where maybe not for eyes but for
other diseases where they're using the
camera on your phone to help
pre-diagnosed before you go and see the
doctor and because the machine can now
unlock your phone with your face I mean
that's just cool having it being able to
identify your face or your voice and be
able to turn stuff on and off for you
depending on where you're at and what
you need talking about an ultimate
automation our world we live in and as
we dig in deeper we have a nice example
of Facebook as you can see here they
have the Facebook post with Halloween
comment yes if you want it order here
nobody likes spam posts on Facebook that
annoy them into interacting with likes
shares comments and other actions I
remember the original ones were all if
you don't click on here you will have
bad luck or some kind of Fear Factor
well this is a huge thing in a social
media when people are getting spammed
and so this tactic known as engagement
bait takes advantage of Facebook's
Newsfeed algorithm by choosing
engagement in order to get the greater
reach to eliminate engagement bait the
company reviewed and categorized
hundreds of thousands of posts to train
a machine learning model that detects
different types of Engagement bait so in
this case we have we're using Facebook
but this is a course across all the
different social media they have
different tools are building and the
Facebook scroll GIF will be replaced
kind of like a virus coming in there it
notices that there's a certain setup
with Facebook and it's able to replace
it and they have like vote baiting react
baiting share baiting they have all
these different these are kind of
General titles but there certainly are a
lot of way of baiting you to go in there
and click on something so they fed all
this this data was fed into the machine
and then they have the new post the new
post comes up that takes over part of
the Facebook setup and that's what
you're looking at you're looking at this
new post that's replaced like a virus
has replaced that so what Facebook did
to eliminate this is they start scanning
for keywords and phrases like this and
checks the click-through rate so it
starts looking for people who are
clicking through it without even looking
at it or clicking through it and it's
not something that normally would be
clicked through once Facebook has
scanned for these keywords and phrases
it is now able to identify the spam
coming in and this makes your life
easier so you're not getting spammed
it's not like walking through an airport
and in a lot of countries you have like
hundreds of people trying to sell you
time share come join us sign up for this
eliminate that annoyingness so now you
can just enjoy your Facebook and your
cat pictures or maybe it's your family
pictures mine is family certainly people
like their cat pictures too another good
example is Google's Deep Mind project
Alpha go a computer program that plays a
board game go has defeated the world's
number one go player and I hope I say
his name right kyg the ultimate go
challenge game a three of three was on
May 27th 2017 so that's just last year
that this happened and what makes this
so important is that you know go is just
is a game so it's not like you're
driving a car or something in our real
world but they are using games to learn
how to get the machine learning program
to learn they want it to learn how to
learn and that is a huge step a lot of
this is still in its infant stage as far
as development as we saw what happened
with the um as I referred to earlier the
Uber cars they lost their whole division
because they jumped ahead too fast so
it's still an infant stage but boy is
this like the beginning of just an
amazing world that is automated in ways
we can't even imagine what tomorrow is
going to look like we've looked at a lot
of examples of machine learning so let's
see if we can give a little bit more of
a concrete definition what is machine
learning machine learning is the science
of making computers learn and act like
humans by feeding data and information
without being explicitly programmed we
see here we have a nice little diagram
where we have our ordinary system uh
your computer nowadays you can even run
a lot of this stuff on a cell phone
because cell phones Advanced so much and
then with artificial intelligence and
machine learning it now takes the data
and it learns from what happened before
and then it predicts what's going to
come next and then really the biggest
part right now in machine learning
that's going on is it improves on that
how do we find a new solution so we go
from descriptive where it's learning
about stuff and understanding how it
fits together to predicting what it's
going to do to postcript coming up with
a new solution and when we're working on
machine learning there's a number of
different diagrams that people have
posted for what steps to go through a
lot of it might be very domain specific
so if you're working on Photo
identification versus language versus
medical or physics some of these are
switched around a little bit or new
things are put in they very specific
specific to The Domain this is kind of a
very general diagram first you want to
Define your objective very important to
know what it is you're wanting to
predict then you're going to be
collecting the data so once you've
defined an objective you need to collect
the data that matches you spend a lot of
time in data science collecting data and
the next step preparing the data you got
to make sure that your data is clean
going in there's the old saying bad data
in bad answer out or bad data out and
then once you've gone through and we
cleaned all this stuff coming in then
you're going to select the algorithm
which algorithm are you going to use
you're going to train that algorithm in
this case I think we're going to be
working with svm the support Vector
machine then you have to test the model
does this model work is this a valid
model for what we're doing and then once
you've tested it you want to run your
prediction you want to run your
prediction or your choice or whatever
output it's going to come up with and
then once everything is set and you've
done lots of testing then you want to go
ahead and deploy the model and remember
I said domain specific this is very
general as far as the scope of doing
something a lot of models you get
halfway through and you realize that
your data is missing something and you
have to go collect new data because
you've run a test in here someplace
along the line you're saying hey I'm not
really getting the answers I need so
there's a lot of things that are domain
specific that become part of this model
this is a very general model but it's a
very good model to start with and we do
have some basic divisions of what
machine learning does that's important
to know for instance do you want to
predict ICT a category well if you're
categorizing thing that's classification
for instance whether the stock price
will increase or decrease so in other
words I'm looking for a yes no answer is
it going up or is it going down and in
that case we'd actually say is it going
up true if it's not going up it's false
meaning it's going down this way it's a
yes no 01 do you want to predict a
quantity that's regression so remember
we just did classification now we're
looking at regression these are the two
major divisions in what data is doing
for instance predicting the age of a
person based on the height weight health
and other factors So based on these
different factors you might guess how
old a person is and then there are a lot
of domain specific things like do you
want to detect an anomaly that's anomaly
detection this is actually very popular
right now for instance you want to
detect money withdrawal anomalies you
want to know when someone's making a
withdrawal that might not be their own
account we've actually brought this up
because this is really big right now if
you're predicting the stock whether to
buy stock or not you want to be able to
know if what's going on in the stock
market is an anomaly use a different
prediction model because something else
is going on you got to pull out new
information in there or is this just the
norm I'm going to get my normal return
on my money invested so being able to
detect anomalies is very big in data
science these days another question that
comes up which is on what we call
untrained data is do you want to
discover structure in unexplored data
and that's called clustering for
instance finding group groups of
customers with similar Behavior given a
large database of customer data
containing their demographics and past
buying records and in this case we might
notice that anybody who's wearing
certain set of shoes go shopping at
certain stores or whatever it is they're
going to make certain purchases by
having that information it helps us to
Market or group people together so that
we can now explore that group and find
out what it is we want to Market to them
if you're in the marketing world and
that might also work in just about any
Arena you might want want to group
people together whether they're uh based
on their different areas and Investments
and financial background whether you're
going to give them a loan or not before
you even start looking at whether
they're valid customer for the bank you
might want to look at all these
different areas and group them together
based on unknown data so you're not you
don't know what the data is going to
tell you but you want to Cluster people
together that come together let's take a
quick DeTour for quiz time oh my
favorite so we're going to have a couple
questions here under a quiz time and um
we'll be posting the answers in the part
two of this tutorial so let's go ahead
and take a look at these quiz times
questions and hopefully you'll get them
all right and it'll get you thinking
about how to process data and what's
going on can you tell what's happening
in the following cases of course you're
sitting there with your cup of coffee
and you have your check boox and your
pen trying to figure out what's your
next step in your data science analysis
so the first one is grouping documents
into different categories
based on the topic and content of each
document very big these days you know
you have legal documents you have uh
maybe it's a Sports Group documents
maybe you're analyzing newspaper
postings but certainly having that
automated is a huge thing in today's
world B identifying handwritten digits
in images correctly so we want to know
whether uh they're writing an A or
capital a BC what are they writing out
in their hand digit their handwriting C
behavior of a website indicating that
the site is not working as designed D
predicting salary of an individual based
on his or her years of experience HR
hiring uh setup there so stay tuned for
part two we'll go ahead and answer these
questions when we get to the part two of
this tutorial or you can just simply
write at the bottom and send a note to
Simply learn and they'll follow up with
you on it back to our regular content
and these last few bring us into the
next topic which is another way of
dividing our types of machine learning
and that is with supervised
unsupervised and reinforcement learning
supervised learning is a method used to
enable machines to classify predict
objects problems or situations based on
labeled data fed to the machine and in
here you see we have a jumble of data
with circles triangles and squares and
we label them we have what's a circle
what's a triangle what's a square we
have our model training and it trains it
so we know the answer very important
when you're doing supervised learning
you already know the answer to a lot of
your information coming in so you have a
huge group of data coming in and then
you have a new data coming in so we've
trained our model the model now knows
the difference between a circle a square
a triangle and now that we've trained it
we can send in in this case a square and
a circle goes in and it predicts that
the top one's a square and the next
one's a circle and you can see that this
is uh being able to predict whether
someone's going to default on Al loan cu
I was talking about Banks earlier
supervised learning on stock market
whether you're going to make money or
not that's always important and if you
are looking to make a fortune on the
stock market keep in mind it is very
difficult to get all the data correct on
the stock market it is very it
fluctuates in ways you really hard to
predict so it's quite a roller coaster
ride if you're running machine learning
on the stock market you start realizing
you really have to dig for new data so
we have supervised learning and if you
have supervised we should need
unsupervised learning in unsupervised
learning machine learning model finds
the hidden pattern in an unlabeled data
so in this case instead of telling it
what the circle is and what a triangle
is and what a square is it goes in there
looks at them and says for whatever
reason it groups them together maybe
it'll group it by the number of corners
and it notices that a number of them all
have three corners a number of them all
have four corners and a number of them
all have no corners and it's able to
filter those through and group them
together we talked about that earlier
with looking at a group of people who
are out shopping we want to group them
together to find out what they have in
common and of course once you understand
what people have in common maybe you
have one of them who's a customer at
your store or you have five of them are
customer at your store and they have a
lot in common with five others who are
not customers at your store how do you
Market to those five who aren't
customers at your store yet they fit the
demograph of who's going to shop there
and you'd like them to shop at your
store not the one next door of course
this is a simplified version you can see
very easily the difference between a
triangle and a Circle which is might not
be so easy in marketing reinforcement
learning reinforcement learning is an
important type of machine learning where
an agent learns how to behave in an
environment by performing actions and
seeing the result and we have here where
the in this case a baby it's actually
great that they used an infant for this
slide because the reinforcement learning
is very much in its infant stages but
it's also probably the biggest machine
learning demand out there right now or
in the future it's going to be coming up
over the next few years is reinforce M
learning and how to make that work for
us and you can see here where we have
our action in the action in this one it
goes into the fire hopefully the baby
didn't it was just a little candle not a
giant fire pit like it looks like here
when the baby comes out and the new
state is the baby is sad and crying
because they got burned on the fire and
then maybe they take another action the
baby's called the agent because it's the
one taking the actions and in this case
they didn't go into the fire they went a
different direction and now the baby's
happy and laughing and playing
reinforcement learning is very easy to
understand cuz that's how as humans
that's one of the ways we learn we learn
whether it is you know you burn yourself
on the stove don't do that anymore don't
touch the stove in the big picture being
able to have machine learning program or
an AI be able to do this is huge because
now we starting to learn how to learn
that's a big jump in the world of
computer and machine learning and we're
going to go back and just kind of go
back over supervised versus unsupervised
learning understanding this is huge
because this is going to to come up in
any project you're working on we have in
supervised learning we have labeled data
we have direct feedback so someone's
already gone in there and said yes
that's a triangle no that's not a
triangle and then you predict an outcome
so you have a nice prediction this is
this this new set of data is coming in
and we know what it's going to be and
then with unsupervised trading it's not
labeled so we really don't know what it
is there's no feedback so we're not
telling it whether it's right or wrong
we're not telling it whether it's a
triangle or a square we're not telling
it to go left or right all we do is
we're finding hidden structure in the
data grouping the data together to find
out what connects to each other and then
you can use these together so imagine
you have an image and you're not sure
what you're looking for so you go in and
you have the unstructured data find all
these things that are connected together
and then somebody looks at those and
labels them now you can take that label
data and program something to predict
what's in the picture so you can see how
how they go back and forth and you can
start connecting all these different
tools together to make a bigger picture
there are many interesting machine
learning algorithms let's have a look at
a few of them hopefully this give you a
little flavor of what's out there and
these are some of the most important
ones that are currently being used we'll
take a look at linear regression
decision tree and the support Vector
machine let's start with a closer look
at linear regression linear regression
is perhaps one of the most well-known
and well understood algorithms in
statistics and machine Lear learning
linear regression is a linear model for
example a model that assumes a linear
relationship between the input variables
X and the single output variable Y and
you'll see this if you remember from
your algebra classes y = mx + C imagine
we are predicting distance traveled y
from speed X our linear regression model
representation for this problem would be
y m * x + C or distance = M * speed + C
or where m is the coefficient and C is
the Y intercept and we're going to look
at two different variations of this
first we're going to start with time is
constant and you can see we have a
bicyclist he's got a safety gear on
thank goodness speed equals 10 m/s and
so over a certain amount of time his
distance equals 36 km we have a second
bicyclist who's going twice the speed or
20 m/ second and you can guess if he's
going twice the speed and time is a
constant then he's going to go twice the
distance
and that's easily to compute 36 * 2 you
get 72 kilm and so if you had the
question of how fast with somebody is
going three times that speed or 30 m/
second is you can easily compute the
distance in our head we can do that
without needing a computer but we want
to do this for more complicated data so
it's kind of nice to compare the two but
let's just take a look at that and what
that looks like in a graph so in a
linear regression model we have our
distance to the speed and we have our m
equals the ve slope of the line and
we'll notice that the line has a plus
slope and as speed increases distance
also increases hence the variables have
a positive relationship and so your
speed of the person which equals yal MX
plus C distance traveled in a fixed
interval of time and we could very
easily compute either following the line
or just knowing it's three times 10 m/s
that this is roughly 102 km distance
that this third bicep has traveled one
of the key definitions on here is
positive relationship so the slope of
the line is positive as distance
increase so does speed increase let's
take a look at our second example where
we put distance is a constant so we have
speed equals 10 m/ second they have a
certain distance to go and it takes them
100 seconds to travel that distance and
we have our second bicyclist who's still
doing 20 m/ second since he's going
twice the speed we can guess that he'll
cover the distance in about half the
time 50 seconds and of course you could
probably guess on the third one 100 ided
30 since he's going three times the
speed you could easily guess that this
is
33333 seconds time we put that into a
linear regression model or a graph if
the distance is assumed to be constant
let's see the relationship between speed
and time and as time goes up the amount
of speed to go that same distance goes
down so now your m equals a minus ve
slope of the line as the speed increases
time decreases hence the variable has a
negative relationship again there's our
definition positive relationship and
negative relationship dependent on the
slope of the line and with a simple
formula like this um and even a
significant amount of data Let's uh see
with the mathematical implementation of
linear regression and we'll take this
data so suppose we have this data set
where we have xyx = 1 2 3 4 5 standard
series and the Y value is 3 2 2 43 when
we take that and we go ahead and plot
these points on a graph you can see
there's kind of a nice scattering and
you could probably eyeball a line
through the middle of it but we're going
to calculate that exact line for linear
regression and the first thing we do is
we come up here and we have the mean of
XI and remember mean is basically the
average so we added five plus 4+ 3 + 2 +
1 and divide by five and that simply
comes out as three and then we'll do the
same for y we'll go ahead and add up all
those numbers and divide by five and we
end up with the mean value of y of I
equals 2 8 where the XI references it's
an average or means value and the Yi
also equals a means value of y and when
we plot that you'll see that we can put
in the Y = 2.8 and the xal 3 in there on
our graph we kind of gave it a little
different color so you could sort it out
with the dash lines on it and it's
important to note that when we do the
linear regression the linear regression
model should go through that dot now
let's find our regression equation to
find the best fit line remember we go
ahead and take our yal MX X plus C so
we're looking for M and C so to find
this equation for our data we need to
find our slope of M and our coefficient
of c and we have y = mx + C where m
equals the sum of x - x average time y -
y aage or y means and X means over the
sum of x - x means squared that's how we
get the slope of the value of the line
and we can easily do that by creating
some columns here we have XY computers
are really good about iterating through
data and so we can easily compute this
and fill in a graph of data and in our
graph you can easily see that if we have
our x value of one and if you remember
the XI or the means value was three 1 -
3al A -2 and 2 - 3 = a -1 so on and so
forth and we can easily fill in the
column of x - x i y - Yi and then from
those we can compute x - - x i^ 2 and x
- x i * y - Yi and you can guess it that
the next step is to go ahead and sum the
different columns for the answers we
need so we get a total of 10 for our x -
x i^ 2 and a total of 2 for x - x i * y
- Yi and we plug those in we get 210
which equals 2 so now we know the slope
of our line equals 2 so we can calculate
the value of c that'd be the next step
is we need to know where crosses the Y
AIS
and if you remember I mentioned earlier
that the linear regression line has to
pass through the means value one that we
showed earlier we can just flip back up
there to that graph and you can see
right here there's our means value which
is 3 xal 3 and Y = 2.8 and since we know
that value we can simply plug that into
our formula y = .2x + C so we plug that
in we get 2.8 = 2 * 3 + C C and you can
just solve for C so now we know that our
coefficient equals 2.2 and once we have
all that we can go ahead and plot our
regression line Y = 2 * x + 2.2 and then
from this equation we can compute new
values so let's predict the values of Y
using xal 1 2 3 4 5 and plot the points
remember the 1 2 345 was our original X
values so now we're going to see what y
thinks they are not what they actually
are and when we plug those in we get y
of designated with Y of P you can see
that x = 1 = 2.4 x = 2 2.6 and so on and
so on so we have our y predicted values
of what we think it's going to be when
we plug those numbers in and when we
plot the predicted values along with the
actual values we can see the difference
and this is one of the things is very
important with linear regression in any
of these models is to understand the
error and so we can calculate the error
on all of our different values and you
can see over here we plotted um X and Y
and Y predict and we drawn a little line
so you can sort of see what the error
looks like there between the different
points so our goal is to reduce this
error we want to minimize that error
value on our linear regression model
minimizing the distance there are lots
of ways to minimize the distance between
the line and the data points like sum of
squared errors sum of absolute errors
root mean square error Etc we keep
moving this line through the data points
to make sure the best fit line has the
least Square distance between the data
points and the regression line so to
recap with a very simple linear
regression model we first figure out the
formula of our line through the middle
and then we slowly adjust the line to
minimize the error keep in mind this is
a very simple formula the math gets even
though the math is very much the same it
gets much more complex as we add in
different dimensions so this is only two
Dimensions y = mx plus C but you can
take that out to x z i JQ all the
different features in there and they can
plot a linear regression model on all of
those using the different formulas to
minimize the error let's go ahead and
take a look at decision trees a very
different way to solve problems in the
linear regression model decision tree is
a tree-shaped algorithm used to
determine a course of action each branch
of a tree represents a possible decision
occurrence or reaction we have data
which tells us if it is a good day to
play golf and if we were to open this
data up in a general spreadsheet you can
see we have the Outlook whether it's a
rainy overcast Sunny temperature hot
mild cool humidity windy and did I like
to play golf that day yes or no so we're
taking a census and certainly I wouldn't
want a computer telling me when I should
go play golf or not but you could
imagine if you got up in the night
before you're trying to plan your day
and it comes up and says tomorrow would
be a good day for golf for you in the
morning and not a good day in the
afternoon or something like that this
becomes very beneficial and we see this
in a lot of applications coming out now
where it gives you suggestions and lets
you know what would uh fit the match for
you for the next day or the next
purchase or the next uh whatever you
know next mail out in this case is
tomorrow a good day for playing golf
based on the weather coming in and so we
come up and let's uh determine if you
should play golf when the day is sunny
and windy so we found out the forecast
tomorrow is going to be sunny and windy
and suppose we draw our tree like this
we're going to have our humidity and
then we have our normal which is if it's
if you have a normal humidity you're
going to go play golf and if the
humidity is really high then we look at
the Outlook and if the Outlook is sunny
overcast or rainy it's going to change
what you choose to do so if you know
that it's a very high humidity and it's
sunny you're probably not going to play
golf CU you're going to be out there
miserable fighting off the mosquitoes
that are out joining you to play golf
with you maybe if it's rainy you
probably don't want to play in the rain
but if it's slightly overcast and you
get just the right shadow that's a good
day to play golf and be outside out on
the green now in this example you can
probably make your own tree pretty
easily CU it's a very simple set of data
going in but the question is how do you
know what to split where do you split
your data what if this is much more
complicated data where is not something
that you would particularly understand
like studying cancer they take about 36
measurements of the cancerous cells and
then each one of those measurements
represents how bulbous it is how
extended it is how sharp the edges are
something that as a human we would have
no understanding of so how do we decide
how to split that data up and is that
the right decision tree but so that's
the question is going to come up is this
the right decision tree for that we
should calculate entropy and Information
Gain two important vocabulary words
there are the entropy and the
Information Gain entropy entropy is a
measure of Randomness or impurity in the
data set entropy should be low so we
want the chaos to be as low as possible
we don't want to look at it and be
confused by the images or what's going
on there with mixed data and the
Information Gain it is the measure of
decrease in entropy after the data set
is split also known as entropy reduction
Information Gain should be high so we
want our information that we get out of
the split to be as high as possible
let's take a look at entropy from the
mathematical side in this case we're
going to denote entropy as I of P of and
n
where p is the probability that you're
going to play a game of golf and N is
the probability where you're not going
to play the game of golf now you don't
really have to memorize these formulas
there's a few of them out there
depending on what you're working with
but it's important to note that this is
where this formula is coming from so
when you see it you're not lost when
you're running your programming unless
you're building your own decision tree
code in the back and we simply have a
log 2 of P Over p+ N minus n / p+ n *
the log s of n of P plus n but let's
break that down and see what actually
looks like when we're Computing that
from the computer script side enty of a
target class of the data set is the
whole entropy so we have entropy play
golf and we look at this if we go back
to the data you can simply count how
many yeses and no in our complete data
set for playing golf days in our
complete set we find we have five days
we did play golf and nine days we did
not play golf and so our I equals if you
had those together 9 + 5 is 14 and so
our I equals 5 over 14 and 9 over 14
that's our p and N values that we plug
into that formula and you can go to 5
over 14 = 36 9 over 14 = 64 and when you
do the whole equation you get the minus.
36 logun 2ar of 36 -64 log s Ro TK of 64
and we get a set value we get
.94 so we now have a full entropy value
for the whole set of data that we're
working with and we want to make that
entropy go down and just like we
calculated the entropy out for the whole
set we can also calculate entropy for
playing golf in the Outlook is it going
to be overcast or rainy or sunny and so
we look at the entropy we have P of
Sunny time e of 3 of two and that just
comes out how many sunny days yes and
how many sunny days no over the total
which is five don't forget to put the
we'll divide that five out later on uh
equals P overcast equal 4 comma 0 plus
rainy equal 2 comma 3 and then when you
do the whole setup we have 5 over 14
remember I said there was a total of
five 5 over 14 * the I of 3 of 2 + 4
over4 times the 4 comma 0 and 514 over I
of 23 and so we can now compute the
entropy of just the part that has to do
with the forecast and we get 693 similar
we can calculate the entropy of other
predictors like temperature humidity and
wind and so we look at the gain Outlook
how much are we going to gain from this
entropy play golf minus entropy play
golf Outlook and we can take the
original .94 for the whole set minus the
entropy of just the um rainy day in
temperature and we end up with a gain of
247 so this is our Information Gain
remember we Define entropy and we Define
Information Gain the higher the
Information Gain the lower the entropy
the better the information gain of the
other three attributes can be calculated
in the same way so we have our gain for
temperature equals
0.029 we have our gain for humidity
equals 0.152 and our gain for a windy
day equals
048 and if you do a quick comparison
you'll see the. 247 is the greatest gain
of information so that's the split we
want now let's build the decision tree
so we have the Outlook is it going to be
sunny overcast or rainy that's our first
split because that gives us the most
Information Gain and we can continue to
go down the tree using the different
information gains with the largest
information we can continue down the
nodes of the tree where we choose the
attribute with the largest Information
Gain as the root node and then continue
to split each sub node with the largest
Information Gain that we can compute and
although it's a little bit of a tongue
twister to say all that you can see that
a very easy to view visual model we have
our Outlook we split it three different
directions if the Outlook is overcast
we're going to play and then we can
split those further down if we want so
if the over Outlook is sunny but then
it's also windy if it's uh windy we're
not going to play if it's uh not windy
we'll play so we can easily build a nice
decision treat to guess what we would
like to do tomorrow and give us a nice
recommendation for the day so we want to
know if it's a good day to play golf
when it's sunny and windy remember the
original question that came out
tomorrow's weather report is sunny and
windy you can see by going down the tree
we go Outlook Sun Sunny Outlook windy
we're not going to play golf tomorrow so
our little Smartwatch pops up and says
I'm sorry tomorrow is not a good day for
golf it's going to be sunny and windy
and if you're a huge golf fan you might
go uhoh it's not a good day to play golf
we can go in and watch a golf game at
home so we'll sit in front of the TV
instead of being out playing golf in the
wind now that we looked at our decision
tree let's look at the third one of our
algorithms we're investigating support
Vector machine support Vector machine is
a widely used classification algorithm
the idea of support Vector machine is
simple the algorithm creates a
separation line which divides the
classes in the best possible manner for
example dog or cat disease or no disease
suppose we have a labeled sample data
which tells height and weight of males
and females a new data point arrives and
we want to know whether it's going to be
a male or a female so we start by
drawing a line we draw decision lines
but if we consider decision line one
then we will classify the individual as
a male and if we consider decision line
two then it will be a female so you can
see this person kind of lies in the
middle of the two groups it's a little
confusing trying to figure out which
line they should be under we need to
know which line divides the classes
correctly but how the goal is to choose
a hyperplane and that is one of the key
words they use when we talk about
support Vector machines choose a hyper
plane with the greatest possible margin
between the decision line and the
nearest Point within the training set so
you can see here we have our support
Vector we have the two nearest points to
it and we draw a line between those two
points and the distance margin is the
distance between the hyper plane and the
nearest data point from either set so we
actually have a value and it should be
equally distant between the two um
points that we're comparing it to when
we draw the hyperplanes we observe that
line one has a maximum distance so we
observe that line one has a maximum
distance margin so we'll classify the
new data point correctly and a result on
this one is going to be that the new
data point is Mel one of the reasons we
call it a hyperplane versus a line is
that a lot of times we're not looking at
just weight and height we might be
looking at 36 different features or
dimensions and so when we cut it with a
hyper plane it's more of a
three-dimensional cut in the data or
multi-dimensional it cuts the data a
certain way and each plane continues to
cut it down until we get the best fit or
match let's understand this with the
help of an example example problem
statement I always start with a problem
statement when you're going to put some
code together we're going to do some
coding now classifying muffin and
cupcake recipes using support Vector
machines so the cupcake versus the
muffin let's have a look at our data set
and we have the different recipes here
we have a muffin recipe that has so much
flour I'm not sure what measurement 55
is in but it has 55 maybe it's
ounces but uh has a certain amount of
flour certain amount of milk sugar
butter egg baking powder vanilla and
salt and So based on these measurements
we want to guess whether we're making a
muffin or a cupcake and you can see in
this one we don't have just two features
we don't just have height and weight as
we did before between the male and
female in here we have a number of
features in fact in this we're looking
at eight different features to guess
whether it's a muffin or a cupcake
what's the difference between a muffin
and a cupcake turns out muffins have
more flour while cupcakes have more
butter and sugar so basically the
cupcakes a little bit more of a dessert
where the muffins a little bit more of a
fancy bread but how do we do that in
Python how do we code that to go through
recipes and figure out what the recipe
is and I really just want to say
cupcakes versus muffins like some big
professional wrestling thing before we
start in our cupcakes versus muffins we
are going to be working in Python
there's many versions of python many
different editors that is one of the
strengths and weaknesses of python is it
just has so much stuff attached to it
and it's one of the more popular data
science programming packages you can use
in this case we're going to go ahead and
use anaconda and jupyter notebook the
Anaconda Navigator has all kinds of fun
tools once you're into the anacon
Navigator you can change environments I
actually have a number of environments
on here we'll be using python 36
environment so this is in Python version
36 although it doesn't matter too much
which version you use I usually try to
stay with the 3x because they're current
unless you have a project that's very
specifically in version 2x 27 I think is
usually what most people use in the
version two and then once we're in our
um Jupiter notebook editor I can go up
and create a new file and we'll just
jump in here in this case we're doing
spbm muffin versus Cupcake and then
let's start with our packages for data
analysis and we almost always use a
couple there's a few very standard
packages we use we use import oops
import
numpy that's for number python they
usually denoted as NP that's very comma
that's very common and then we're going
to import pandas as
PD and numpy deals with number arrays
there's a lot of cool things you can do
with the numpy uh setup as far as
multiplying all the values in an array
in a numpy array data array pandas I
can't remember if we're using it
actually in this data set I think we do
as an import it makes a nice data frame
and the difference between a data frame
and a nump array is that a data frame is
more like your Excel spreadsheet you
have columns you have indexes so you
have different ways of referencing it
easily viewing it and there's additional
features you can run on a data frame and
pandas kind of sits on numpy so they you
need them both in there and then finally
we're working with the support Vector
machine so from sklearn we're going to
use the sklearn model import svm support
Vector
machine and then as a data scientist you
should always try to visualize your data
some data obviously is too complicated
or doesn't make any sense to the human
but if it's possible it's going to take
a second look at it so you can actually
see what you're doing now for that we're
going to use two packages we're going to
import matplot library. pyplot as PLT
again very common and we're going to
import caborn as SNS and we'll go ahead
and set the font scale in the SNS right
in our import line that's with this um
semicolon followed by a line of data
we're going to set the SNS and these are
great because the the caborn sits on top
of map plot Library just like pandas
hits on numpy so it adds a lot more
features and uses and control we're
obviously not going going to get into
matplot library and caborn it' be its
own tutorial we're really just focusing
on the svm the support Vector machine
from sklearn and since we're in Jupiter
notebook uh we have to add a special
line in here for our M plot library and
that's your percentage sign or Amber
sign map plot library in line now if
you're doing this in just a straight
code Project A lot of times I use like
notepad++ and I'll run it from there you
don't have to have that line in there
cuz it'll just pop up as its own window
on your computer depending on how your
computer set up because we're running
this in the Jupiter notebook as a
browser setup this tells it to display
all of our Graphics right below on the
page so that's what that line is for
remember the first time I ran this I
didn't know that and I had to go look
that up years ago it's quite a headache
so map plot library in line is just
because we're running this on the web
setup and we can go ahead and run this
make sure all our modules are in they're
all imported which is great if you don't
have them import you'll need to go ahead
and pip use the PIP or however you do it
there's a lot of other install packages
out there although pip is the most
common and you have to make sure these
are all installed on your python setup
the next step of course is we got to
look at the data you can't run a model
for predicting data if you don't have
actual data so to do that let me go ah
and open this up and take a look and we
have our uh cupcakes versus muffins and
it's a CSV file or CSV meaning that it's
comma separated
variable and it's going to open it up in
a nice uh spreadsheet for me and you can
see up here we have the type we have
muffin muffin muffin cupcake cupcake
cupcake and then it's broken up into
flour milk sugar butter egg baking
powder vanilla and salt so we can do is
we can go ahead and look at this data
also in our
python let us create a variable recipes
equals we're going to use use our pandas
module. read CSV remember is a comma
separated
variable and the file name happened to
be cupcakes versus muffins oops I got
double brackets
there do it this
way there we go cupcakes versus
muffins because the program I loaded or
the the place I saved this particular
Python program is in the same folder we
can get by with just the file name but
remember if you're storing it in a
different location you have to also put
down the full path on
there and then because we're in pandas
we're going to go ahead and you can
actually in line you can do this but let
me do the full print you can just type
in recipes. head in the Jupiter notebook
but if you're running in code in a
different script You' need to go ahead
and type out the whole print recipes.
head and Pand is knows is that's going
to do the first five lines of data and
if we flip back on over to the
spreadsheet where we opened up our CSV
file uh you can see where it starts on
line two this one calls it zero and then
2 3 4 5 6 is going to match go and close
that out because we don't need that
anymore and it always starts at zero and
these are it automatically indexes it
since we didn't tell it to use an index
in here so that's the index number for
the leftand side and automatically took
the top row as uh labels so Panda's
using it to read a CSV is just really
slick and fast one of the reasons we
love our pandas not just because they're
cute and cuddly teddy
bears and let's go ahead and plot our
data and I'm not going to plot all of it
I'm just going to plot the uh sugar and
flour now obviously you can see where
they get really complicated if we have
tons of different different features and
so you'll break them up and maybe look
at just two of them at a time to see how
they
connect and to plot them we're going to
go ahead and use
caborn so that's our SNS and the command
for that is SNS dolm plot and then the
two different variables I'm going to
plot is flour and
sugar data equals recipes the Hue equals
type and this is a lot of fun because it
knows that this is pandas coming in so
this is one of the powerful things about
pandas mixed with Seaborn and
doing
graphing and then we're going to use a
pallet set one there's a lot of
different sets in there you can go look
them up for Seaborn we do a regular a
fit regular equals false so we're not
really trying to fit anything and it's a
scatter
kws a lot of these settings you can look
up in Seaborn half of these you could
probably leave off when you run them
somebody played with this and found out
that these were the best settings for
for doing a Seaborn plot let's go ahead
and run that and because it does it in
line it just puts it right on the
page and you can see right here that
just based on sugar and flour alone
there's a definite split and we use
these models because you can actually
look at it and say hey if I drew a line
right between the middle of the blue
dots and the red dots we'd be able to do
an svm and and a hyperplane right there
in the middle
then the next step is to format or
pre process our
data and we're going to break that up
into two
parts we need to type label and remember
we're going to decide whether it's a
muffin or a cupcake well a computer
doesn't know muffin or cupcake it know
zero and one so what we're going to do
is we're going to create a type label
and from this we'll create a numpy array
in P where and this is where we can do
some logic we take our recipes from our
Panda and wherever type equals muffin
it's going to be zero and then if it
doesn't equal muffin which is cupcakes
is going to be one so we create our type
label this is the answer so when we're
doing our training model remember we
have to have a a training data this is
what we're going to train it with is
that it's zero or one it's a muffin or
it's not
and then we're going to create our
recipe
features and if you remember correctly
from right up here the First Column is
type so we really don't need the type
column that's our muffin or cupcake and
in pandas we can easily sort that
out we take our value
recipes do columns that's a pandas
function built into
pandas got values converting them to
values so it's just the column titles
going across the top and we don't want
the first one so what we do is since it
always starts at zero we want
one colon till the
end and then we want to go ahead and
make this a list and this converts it to
a list of
strings and then we can go ahead and
just take a look and see what we're
looking at for the features make sure it
looks right let me go ahead and run that
and I forgot the S on recipes so we'll
go ahead and add the s in there and then
run that and we can see we have flow
milk sugar butter egg baking powder
vanilla and salt and that matches what
we have up here where we printed out
everything but the type so we have our
features and we have our
label Now the recipe features is just
the titles of the columns and we
actually need the
ingredients
and at this point we have a couple
options one we could rent it over all
the
ingredients and when you're doing this
usually you do but for our example we
want to limit it so you can easily see
what's going on because if we did all
the ingredients we have you know that's
what um seven eight different
hyperplanes that would be built into it
we only want to look at one so you can
see what the svm is
doing and so we'll take our recipes and
we'll do just flour
and sugar again you can replace that
with your recipe features and do all of
them but we're going to do just flour
and sugar and we're going to convert
that to values we don't need to make a
list out of it because it's not string
values these are actual values on there
and we can go ahead and just
print ingredients and you can see what
that looks
like uh and so we have just the N of
flow and sugar just the two sets of
plots and just for fun let's go ahead
and take this over here and take our
recipe
features and so if we decided to use all
the recipe features you'll see that it
makes a nice column of different data so
it just strips out all the labels and
everything we just have just the values
but because we want to be able to view
this easily in a plot later on we'll go
ahead and take that and just do flour
and
sugar and we'll run that you'll see it's
just the two
columns
so the next step is to go ahead and fit
our
model we'll go a and just call it model
and it's a svm we're using a package
called
SVC in this case we're going to go ahead
and set the kernel equals linear so it's
using a specific setup on there and if
we go to the reference on their website
for the
svm you'll see that there's about
there's eight of them here three of them
are for
regression three are for classification
the SVC support Vector classification is
probably one of the most commonly used
and then there's also one for detecting
outliers and another one that has to do
with something a little bit more
specific on the model but SBC and SV are
the two most commonly used standing for
support vector classifier and support
Vector regression remember regression is
an actual value a float value or
whatever you're trying to work on and
SBC is a classifier so it's a yes no
true
false but for this we want to know 01
muffin cupcake we go ahead and create
our model and once we have our model
created we're going to do model. fit and
this is very common especially in the
sklearn all their models are followed
with the fit
command and what we put into the fit
what we're training with it is we're
putting in the ingredients which in this
case we limited to just flour and sugar
and the type label is it a muffin or
cupcake
now in more complicated data science
series you'd want to split into we won't
get into that today we split it into a
training data and test data and they
even do something where they split it
into thirds where a third is used for
where you switch between which one's
training and test there's all kinds of
things go into that and gets very
complicated when you get to the higher
end not overly complicated just an extra
step which we're not going to do today
because this is a very simple set of
data and let's go ahead and run this and
now we have our model fit and I got a
error here so let me fix that real quick
it's Capital SVC it turns
out I did it
lowercase support
Vector classifier there we go let's go
ahead and run that and you'll see it
comes up with all this information that
it prints out automatically these are
the defaults of the model you notice
that we changed the kernel to linear and
there's our kernel linear on the
printout and there's other different set
settings you can mess
with we're going to just leave that
alone for right now for this we don't
really need to mess with any of
those so next we're going to dig a
little bit into our newly trained model
and we're going to do this so we can
show you on a
graph and let's go ahead and get the
separating and we're going to say we're
going to use a W for our variable on
here we're going to do model.
coefficient 0 so what the heck is that
again we're digging into the model so
we've already got a prediction and a
train this is a math behind it that
we're looking at right now and
so the W is going to represent two
different coefficients and if you
remember we had y = mx + C so these
coefficients are connected to that but
in two-dimensional it's a plane
we don't want to spend too much time on
this because you can get lost in the
confusion of the math so if you're a
math Wiz this is great you can go
through here and you'll see that we have
a equal minus W of 0 over W of 1
remember there's two different values
there and that's basically the slope
that we're
generating and then we're going to build
an XX what is XX we're going to set it
up to a numpy array there's our np.
linespace so we're creating a
line of values between 30 and 60 so it
just creates a set of numbers for
x and then if you remember correctly we
have our formula y equal the slope X
X Plus The Intercept well to make this
work we can do this as y y equals the
slope times each value in that array
that's the neat thing about numpy so
when I do a a * XX which is a whole
numpy array of values it multiplies a
across all of them and then it takes
those same values and we subtract the
model intercept that's your uh we had MX
plus C so that'd be the C from the
formula yal MX plus
C and that's where all these numbers
come from a little bit confusing because
it's digging out of these different
arrays and then we want to do is we're
going to take this and we're going to go
ahead and plot it so plot the parallels
to separating hyper plane that pass
through the support vectors and so we're
going to create b equals a model support
vectors pull in our support vectors out
there here's our YY which we now know is
a set of data and we have uh we're going
to create YY down equals a * XX + B1 - A
* B 0 and then model support Vector B is
going to be set that to a new value the
minus one setup and y y up = a * XX + B1
- A * B 0 and we can go ahead and just
run this to load these variables up if
you wanted to know understand a little
bit more of what's going on you can see
if we
print y y we just run that you can see
it's an array it's this is a line it's
going to have in this case between 30
and 60 so it's going to be 30 variables
in here and the same thing with y y up y
y down
and we'll we'll plot those in just a
minute on a graph so you can see what
those look
like just go ahead and delete that out
of here and run that so it loads up the
variables nice clean slate I'm just
going to copy this from before remember
this our SNS our Seaborn plot LM plot
flour
sugar and I'll just go and run that real
quick so you can see what remember what
that looks like it's just a straight
graph on there and then one of the new
things is because Seaborn sits on top of
piip plot
we can do the P plot for the line going
through and that is simply PLT do
plot and that's our xx and y y our two
corresponding values XY and then
somebody played with this to figure out
that the line width equals two and the
color black would look nice so let's go
ahead and run this whole thing with the
PIP plot on there and you can see when
we do this it's just doing flour and
sugar on
here corresponding line between the
sugar and the flour and the muffin
versus
Cupcake um and then we generated the um
support vectors the y y down and y y up
so let's take a look and see what that
looks
like so we'll do our PL
plot and again this is all against XX
the our x value but this time we have y
y
down and let's do something a little fun
with this we can put in a k dash dash
that just tells it to make it a dotted
line and if we're going to do the down
one we also want to do the up one so
here's our
YY up and when we run that it adds both
sets of
line and so here's our support and this
is what you expect you expect these two
lines to go through the nearest data
point so the dash lines go through the
nearest muffin and the nearest cupcake
when it's plotting it and then your svm
goes right down the middle so it gives
it a nice split in our data and you can
see how easy it is to see based just on
sugar and flour which one's a muffin or
a
cupcake let's go ahead and create a
function to
predict muffin or
cupcake I've got my um recipes I pulled
off the um internet and I want to see
the difference between a muffin or a
cupcake and so we need a function to
push that through and create a function
with
DEA and let's call it muffin or cupcake
and remember we're just doing flour and
sugar today not doing all the
ingredients and that actually is a
pretty good split you really don't need
all the ingredients to know it's flour
and
sugar and let's go ahead and do an F L
statement so if model
predict is a flower and Tri equals zero
so we take our model and we do run a
predict it's very common in sklearn
where you have a DOT predict you put the
data in and it's going to return a value
in this case if it equals zero then
print you're looking at a muffin recipe
else if it's not zero that means it's
one then you're looking at a cupcake
recipe that's pretty straightforward
for function or def for definition DF is
how you do that in Python and of course
we're going to create a function you
should run something in it and so let's
run a cupcake and we're going to send it
values 50 and 20 a muffin or cupcake I
don't know what it is and let's run this
and just see what it gives us and it
says oh it's a muffin you're looking at
a muffin recipe so it very easily
predicts whether we're looking at a
muffin or a cupcake recipe let's plot
this there we go plot this on the graph
so we can see what that actually looks
like and I'm just going to copy and
paste it from below where we plotting
all the points in there
so this is nothing different than what
we did before if I run it you'll see it
has all the points and the lines on
there and what we want to do is we want
to add another point and we'll do PLT
plot and if you remember correctly we
did for our test we did 50 and
20 and then somebody went in here and
decided we'll do yo for yellow or it's
kind of a orangest yellow color is going
to come out marker size nine those are
settings you can play with somebody else
play played with them to come up with
the right setup so it looks good and you
can see there it is grafted um clearly a
muffin in this case in cupcakes versus
muffins the muffin has won and if you'd
like to do your own muffin cupcake
Contender series you certainly can send
a note down below and the team at simply
learn will send you over the data they
used for the muffin and cupcake and
that's true of any of the data um we
didn't actually run a plot on it earlier
we had men versus women you can also
request that information to run it on
your data setup so you can test that
out so to go back over our setup we went
ahead for our support Vector machine
code we did a predict 40 Parts flower 20
part sugar I think it was different than
the one we did whether it's a muffin or
a cupcake hence we have built a
classifier using SPM which is able to
classify if a recipe is of a cupcake or
a muffin which wraps up our are cupcake
versus muffin today in our second
tutorial we're going to cover K means
and linear regression along with going
over the quiz questions we had during
our first tutorial what's in it for you
we're going to cover clustering what is
clustering K means clustering which is
one of the most common used clustering
tools out there including a flowchart to
understand K means clustering and how it
functions and then we'll do an actual
python live demo on clustering of cars
based on brands
then we're going to cover logistic
regression what is logistic regression
logistic regression curve in sigmoid
function and then we'll do another
python code demo to classify a tumor as
malignant or benign based on features
and let's start with clustering suppose
we have a pile of books of different
genres now we divide them into different
groups like fiction horror education and
as we can see from this young lady she
definitely is into heavy you can
just tell by those eyes and the maple
Canadian leaf on her shirt but we have
fiction horror and education and we want
to go ahead and divide our books up well
organizing objects into groups based on
similarity is clustering and in this
case as we're looking at the books we're
talking about clustering things with
knowing categories but you can also use
it to explore data so you might not know
the categories you just know that you
need to divide it up in some way to
conquer the data and to organize it
better but in this case uh we're going
to be looking at clustering in specific
categories and let's just take a deeper
look at that we're going to use K means
clustering K means clustering is
probably the most commonly used
clustering tool in the machine learning
library K means clustering is an example
of unsupervised learning if you remember
from our previous thing it is used when
you have unlabeled data so we don't know
the answer yet we have a bunch of data
that we want to Cluster into different
groups toine clusters in the data based
on feature similarity so we've
introduced a couple terms here we've
already talked about unsupervised
learning and unlabeled data so we don't
know the answer yet we're just going to
group stuff together and see if we can
find an answer of how things connect
we've also introduced feature similarity
features being different features of the
data now with books we can easily see
fiction and horror and history books but
a lot of times with data some of that
information isn't so easy to see right
when we first look at it and so K means
is one of those tools where we can start
finding things that connect that match
with each other suppose we have these
data points and want to assign them into
a cluster now when I look at these data
points I would probably group them into
two clusters just by looking at them I'd
say two of these group of data kind of
come together but in K means we pick K
clusters and assign random centroids to
clusters where the K clusters represents
two different clusters we pick K
clusters insy random centroids to the
Clusters then we compute distance from
objects to the centroid
now we form new clusters based on
minimum distances and calculate the
centroids so we figure out what the best
distances for the centroid then we move
the centroid and recalculate those
distances repeat previous two steps
iteratively till the cluster centroid
stop changing their positions and become
Static repeat previous two steps
iteratively till the cluster centroid
stop changing and the positions become
Static once the Clusters become Static
then K means clustering algorithm is
said to be converged
and there's another term we see
throughout machine learning is converged
that means whatever math we're using to
figure out the answer has come to a
solution or it's converged on an answer
shall we see the flowchart to understand
make a little bit more sense by putting
it into a nice easy step by step so we
start we choose K we'll look at the
elbow method in just a moment we assign
random centroids to clusters and
sometimes you pick the centroids because
you might look at the data in a in a
graph and say oh these are probably the
central points then we compute the
distance from the objects to the
centroids we take that and we form new
clusters based on minimum distance and
calculate their centroids then we
compute the distance from objects to the
new centroids and then we go back and
repeat those last two steps we calculate
the distances so as we're doing it it
brings into the new centroid and then we
move the centroid around and we figure
out what the best which objects are
closest to each centroid so the objects
can switch from one centroid to the
other as the centroids are moved around
and we continue that until it is
converged let's see an example of this
suppose we have this data set of seven
individuals and their score on two
topics A and B so here's our subject in
this case referring to the person taking
the uh test and then we have subject a
where we see what they've scored on
their first subject and we have subject
B and we can see what they score on the
second subject now let's take two
farthest apart points as initial cluster
centroid now remember we talked about
selecting them randomly or we can also
just put them in different points and
pick the furthest one apart so they move
together either one works okay depending
on what kind of data you're working on
and what you know about it so we took
the two furthest points one and one and
five and seven and now let's take the
two farthest apart points as initial
cluster centroids each point is then
assigned to the closest cluster with
respect to the distance from the
centroids so we take each one of these
points in there we measure that distance
and you can see that if we measured each
of those distances and you use the
Pythagorean theorem for a triangle in
this case because you know the X and the
Y and you can figure out the diagonal
line from that or you just take a ruler
and put it on your monitor that'd be
kind of silly but it would work if
you're just eyeballing it you can see
how they naturally come together in
certain areas now we again calculate the
centroids of each cluster so cluster one
and then cluster two and we look at each
individual dot there's one two three
we're in one cluster uh the centroid
then moves over it becomes 1.8 comma 2.3
so remember it was at one and one well
the very center of the data we're
looking at would put it at the one point
roughly 22 but 1.8 and 2.3 and the
second one if we wanted to make the
overall mean Vector the average Vector
of all the different distances to that
centroid we come up with 4 comma 1 and
54 so we've now moved the centroids We
compare each individual's distance to
its own cluster mean and into that of
the opposite cluster and we find can
build a nice chart on here that the as
we move that cite around we now have a
new different kind of clustering of
groups and using ukian distance between
the points and the mean we get the same
formula you see new formulas coming up
so we have our individual dots distance
to the mean centr of the cluster and
distance to the mean Central of the
cluster only individual three is nearer
to the mean of the opposite cluster
cluster two than its own cluster one and
you can see here in the diagram where
we've kind of circled that one in the
middle so when we've moved the clust the
centroids of the Clusters over one of
the points shifted to the other cluster
because it's closer to that group of
individuals thus individual 3 is
relocated to Cluster 2 resulting in a
new Partition and we regenerate all
those numbers of how close they are to
the different clusters for the new
clusters we will find the actual cluster
centroids so now we move the centroids
over and you can see that we've now
formed two very distinct clusters on
here on comparing the distance of each
individual's distance to its own cluster
mean and to that of the opposite cluster
we find that the data points are stable
hence we have our final clusters now if
you remember I brought up a concept
earlier k mean on the K means algorithm
choosing the right value of K will help
in less number of iterations and to find
the appropriate number of clusters in a
data set we use the elbow method and
within sum of squares WSS is defined as
the sum of the squared distance between
each member number of the cluster in its
centroid and so you see what we've done
here is we have the number of clusters
and as you do the same K means algorithm
over the different clusters and you
calculate what that centroid looks like
and you find the optimal you can
actually find the optimal number of
clusters using the elbow the graph is
called as the elbow method and on this
we guessed at two just by looking at the
data but as you can see the slope you
actually just look for right there where
the elbow is in the slope and you have a
clear answer that we want two different
to start with k means equals 2 A lot of
times people end up Computing K means
equals 2 3 4 5 until they find the value
which fits on the elbow joint sometimes
you can just look at the data and if
you're really good with that specific
domain remember domain I mentioned that
last time you'll know that that where to
pick those numbers or where to start
guessing at what that K value is so
let's take this and we're going to use a
use case using K means clustering to
Cluster cars into Brands using par
parameters such as horsepower cubic
inches make year Etc so we're going to
use the data set cars data having
information about three brands of cars
Toyota Honda and Nissan we'll go back to
my favorite tool the Anaconda Navigator
with the Jupiter notebook and let's go
ahead and flip over to our Jupiter
notebook and in our Jupiter notebook I'm
going to go ahead and just paste the uh
basic code that we usually start a lot
of these off with we're not going to go
too much into this code because we've
already discussed numpy we've already
discussed matplot library and pandas
numpy being the number array pandas
being the pandas data frame and matap
plot for the graphing and don't forget
uh since if you're using the Jupiter
notebook you do need the M plot library
in line so that it plots everything on
the screen if you're using a different
python editor then you probably don't
need that because it'll have a popup
window on your computer and we'll go
ahead and run this just to load our
libraries and our setup into here the
next step is of course to look at our
data which I've already opened up in a
spreadsheet and you can see here we have
the miles per gallon cylinders cubic
inches horsepower weight pounds how you
know how heavy it is time it takes to
get to 60 my card is probably on this
one at about 80 or 90 what year it is so
this is you can actually see this is
kind of older cars and then the brand
Toyota Honda Nissan so the different
cars are coming from all the way from
1971 if we scroll down to to uh the 80s
we have between the 70s and 80s a number
of cars that they've put out and let's
uh when we come back here we're going to
do importing the data so we'll go ahead
and do data set equals and we'll use
pandas to read this in and it's uh from
a CSV file remember you can always post
this in the comments and request the
data files for these either in the
comments here on the YouTube video or go
to Simply learn.com and request that the
cars CSV I put it in the same folder as
the code that I've stored so my python
code is stored in the same folder so I
don't have to put the full path if you
store them in different folders you do
have to change this and double check
your name variables and we'll go ahead
and run this and uh We've chosen data
set arbitrarily because you know it's a
data set we're importing and we've now
imported our car CSV into the data set
as you know you have to prep the data so
we're going to create the X data this is
the one that we're going to try to
figure out what's going on with and then
there is a number of ways to do this but
we'll do it in a simple Loop so you can
actually see what's going on so we'll do
for i n x. columns so we're going to go
through each of the columns and a lot of
times it's important I I'll make lists
of the columns and do this because I
might remove certain columns or there
might be columns that I want to be
processed differently but for this we
can go ahead and take X of I and we want
to go fill Na and that's a panda command
but the question is what are we going to
fill the missing data with we definitely
don't want want to just put in a number
that doesn't actually mean something and
so one of the tricks you can do with
this is we can take X of I and in
addition to that we want to go ahead and
turn this into an integer because a lot
of these are integers so we'll go ahead
and keep it integers and me add the
bracket here and a lot of editors will
do this they'll think that you're
closing one bracket make sure you get
that second bracket in there if it's a
double bracket that's always something
that happens regularly so once we have
our integer of X of Y this is going to
fill in any missing data with the
average and I was so busy closing one
set of brackets I forgot that the mean
is also has brackets in there for the
pandas so we can see here we're going to
fill in all the data with the average
value for that column so if there's
missing data it's in the average of the
data it does have then once we've done
that we'll go ahead and loop through it
again and just check and see to make
sure everything is filled in correctly
and we'll print and then we take X is
null and this returns a set of the null
value or the how many lines are null and
we'll just sum that up to see what that
looks like and so when I run this and so
with the X what we want to do is we want
to remove the last column because that
had the models that's what we're trying
to see if we can cluster these things
and figure out the models there is so
many different ways to sort the X out
for one we could take the X and we could
go data set our variable we're using and
use the iocation one of the features
that's in pandas and we could take that
and then take all the rows and all but
the last column of the data set and at
this time we could do values we just
convert it to values so that's one way
to do this and if I let me just put this
down here and print X it's a capital x
we chose and I run this you can see it's
just the values we could also take out
the values and it's not going to return
anything because there's no values
connected to it what I like to do with
this is instead of doing the iocation
which does integers more common is to
come in here and we have our data set
and we're going to do data set dot or
data set. columns and remember that
lists all the columns so if I come in
here let me just Mark that as red and I
print data set.
columns you can see that I have my index
here I have my MPG cylinders everything
and including the brand which we don't
want so the way to get rid of the brand
would be to do data Columns of
Everything But the last one minus one so
now if I print this you'll see the brand
disappears and so I can actually just
take data set columns minus one and I'll
put it right in here for the columns
we're going to look
at and let's unmark this and unmark
this and now if I do an X do head I now
have a new data frame and you can see
right here we have all the different
columns except for the brand at the end
of the year and it turns out when you
start playing with the data set you're
going to get an error later on and it'll
say cannot convert string to uh float
value and that's because for some reason
these things the way they recorded them
must have been recorded as strings so we
have a neat feature in here on pandas to
convert and it is simply convert object
and for this we're going to do convert
oops convert
underscore numeric numeric equals true
and yes I did have to go look that up I
don't have it memorized the convert
numeric in there if I'm working with a
lot of these things I remember them but
um depending on where I'm at what I'm
doing I usually have to look it up and
we run that oops I must have missed
something in here let me double check my
spelling and when I double check my
spelling you'll see I missed the first
underscore in the convert objects when I
run this it now has everything converted
into a numeric value because that's what
we're going to be working with is
numeric values down
here and the next part is that we need
to go through the data and eliminate
null values most people when they're
doing small amounts working with small
data pools discover afterwards that they
have a null value and they have to go
back and do this so you know be aware
whenever we're formatting this data
things are going to pop up and sometimes
you go backwards to fix it and that's
fine that's just part of exploring the
data and understanding what you
have and I should have done this earlier
but let me go ahead and increase the
size of my window one
notch there we go easier to
see so we'll do 4 I in working with x.
columns we'll page through all the
columns and we want to take X of I and
we're going to change that we're going
to alter it and so with this we want to
go ahead and fill in X of I pandis Has
the fill in a and that just fills in any
non-existent missing data and we'll put
my brackets up and there's a lot of
different ways to fill this data if you
have a really large data set some people
just void out that data because if and
then look at it later in a separate
exploration of data one of the tricks we
can do is we can take take our column
and we can find the
means and the means is in our quotation
marks so when we take the columns we're
going to fill in the the non-existing
one with the means the problem is that
returns a decimal float so some of these
aren't decimals certainly need to be a
little careful of doing this but for
this example we're just going to fill it
in with the integer version of this
keeps it on par with the other data that
isn't a decimal point
and then what we also want to do is we
want to double check A lot of times you
do this first part first to double check
then you do the fill and then you do it
again just to make sure you did it right
so we're going to go through and test
for missing data and one of the re ways
you can do that is simply go in here and
take our X of I column so it's going to
go through the x of I column it says is
null so it's going to return any any
place there's a null value it actually
goes through all the rows of each column
is null and then we want to go ahead and
sum that so we take that we add the sum
value and these are all pandas so is
null is a panda command and so is some
and if we go through that and we go
ahead and run
it and we go ahead and take and run that
you'll see that all the columns have
zero null values so we've now tested and
double checked and our data is nice and
clean we have no null values everything
is now a number value we turned it into
numeric
and we've removed the last column in our
data and at this point we're actually
going to start using the elbow method to
find the optimal number of clusters so
we're now actually getting into the SK
learn part uh the K means clustering on
here I guess we'll go ahead and zoom it
up one more notot so you can see what
I'm typing in
here and then from sklearn going to or
sklearn cluster I'm going to import K
means I always forget to capitalize the
K and the M when I do this that's say
capital K capital M K
means and we'll go and create a um array
wcss equals let make it an empty array
if you remember from the elbow method
from our
slide within the sums of squares WSS is
defined as the sum of square distance
between each member of the cluster and
its centroid so we're looking at that
change in differences as far as a square
distance and we're going to run this
over a number of K mean
values in fact let's go for I in range
we'll do 11 of
them range 0
11 and the first thing we're going to do
is we're going to create the actual
we'll do it all lower
case and so we're going create this
object from the K means that we just
imported and the variable that we want
to put into this is in clusters and
we're going to set that equals to I
that's the most important one because
we're looking at how increasing the
number of clusters changes our answer
there are a lot of settings to the K
means our guys in the back did a great
job just kind of playing with some of
them the most common ones that you see
in a lot of stuff is how you init your K
means so we have K means plus plus plus
this is just a tool to let the model
itself be smart how it picks it
centroids to start with its initial
centroids we only want to iterate no
more than 300 times we have a Max
iteration we put in there we have an the
inth of knit the random State equals
zero you really don't need to worry too
much about these when you're first
learning this as you start digging in
deeper you start finding that these
shortcuts that will speed up the process
as far as a setup but the big one that
we're working with is the in clusters
equals I so we're going to literally
train our K means 11 times we're going
to do this process 11 times in if you're
working with uh Big Data you know the
first thing you do is you run a small
sample of the data so you can test all
your stuff on it and you can already see
the problem that if I'm going to iterate
through a terabyte of data 11 times and
then the K means itself is iterating
through the data multiple times that's a
heck of a process so you got to be a
little careful with this a lot of times
though you can find your elbow using the
elbow method find your optimal number on
a sample of data especially if you're
working with larger data sources so we
want to go ahead and take our K means
and we're just going to fit it if you're
looking at any of the SK learn very
common you fit your model and if you
remember correctly our variable we're
using is the capital x and once we fit
this value we go back to the um array we
made and we want to go just toin that
value on the
end and it's not the actual fitware
pinning in there it's like when it
generates it it generates the value
you're looking for is inertia so K
means. inertia will pull that specific
value out that we
need and let's get a visual on this
we'll do our PLT plot and what we're
plotting
here is first the x axis which is range
zero 11 so that will generate a nice
little plot there and the wcss for our Y
axis it's always nice to give our plot a
title and let's see we'll just give it
the elbow method for the title and let's
get some labels so let's go ahead and do
PLT X
label and what we'll do we'll do number
of clusters for that and PLT y
label and for that we can do oops there
we go wcss since that's what we're doing
on the plot on there and finally we want
to go ahead and display our graph which
is simply PLT do
oops. show there we go and because we
have it set to inline it'll appear in
line hopefully I didn't make a type
error on
there and you can see we get a very nice
graph you can see a very nice elbow
joint there at uh two and again right
around three and four and then after
that there's not very much now as a data
scientist if I was looking at this I
would do either three or four and I'd
actually try both of them to see what
the um output look like and they've
already tried this in the back so we're
just going to use three as a setup on
here and let's go ahead and see what
that looks like when we actually use
this to show the different kinds of
cars and so let's go ahead and apply the
K means to the car's data set and
basically we're going to copy the code
that we Loop through up above where K
means equals K means number of clusters
and we're just going to set that number
of clusters to three since that's what
we're going to look for you could do
three and four on this and graph them
just to see how they come up
differently' be kind of curious to look
at that but for this we're just going to
set it to three go ahead and create our
own variable y k means for our answers
and we're going to set that equal to
whoops I double equal there to K means
but we're not going to do a fit we're
going to do a fit predict is the setup
you want to use and when you're using
untrained models you'll see um a
slightly different usually you see fit
and then you see just the predict but we
want to both fit and predict the K means
on this and that's fitcore predict and
then our capital x is the data we're
working
with and before we plot this data we're
going to do a little pandas trick we're
going to take our x value and we're
going to set XS Matrix so we're
converting this into a nice rows and
columns kind of set up but we want the
we're going to have columns equals none
so it's just going to be a matrix of
data in here and let's go ahead and run
that a little warning you'll see These
Warnings pop up because things are
always being updated so there's like
minor changes in the versions and future
versions instead of Matrix now that it's
more common to set ITV values instead of
doing as Matrix but M Matrix works just
fine for right now and you'll want to
update that later on but let's go ahead
and dive in and plot this and see what
that looks like and before we dive into
plotting this data I always like to take
a look and see what I am plotting so
let's take a look at why K means I'm
just going to print that out down here
and we see we have an array of answers
we have 2 1 0 2 one two so it's
clustering these different rows of data
based on the three different spaces it
thinks it's going to be and then let's
go ahead and print X and see what we
have for x and we'll see that X is an
array it's a matrix so we have our
different values in the array and what
we're going to do it's very hard to plot
all the different values in the array so
we're only going to be looking at the
first two or positions zero and
one and if you were doing a full
presentation in front of the board
meeting you might actually do a little
different and and dig a little deeper
into the different aspects because this
is all the different columns we looked
at but we only look at columns one and
two for this to make it easy so let's go
ahead and clear this data out of here
and let's bring up our plot and we're
going to do a scatter plot here so PLT
scatter
and this looks a little complicated so
let's explain what's going on with this
we're going to take the X
values and we're only interested in y of
K means equals zero the first cluster
okay and then we're going to take value
zero for the xaxis and then we're going
to do the same thing here we're only
interested in K means equals zero but
we're going to take the second column so
we're only looking at the first two
columns in our answer or in the data and
then the guys in the back played with
this a little bit to make it
pretty and they discovered that it looks
good with as a size equals 100 that's
the size of the dots we're going to use
red for this one and when they were
looking at the data and what came out it
was definitely the Toyota on this so
we're just going to go ahead and label
it Toyota again that's something you
really have to explore in here as far as
playing with those numbers and see what
looks good we'll go ahead and hit enter
in there and I'm just going to paste in
the next two lines which is the next two
cars and this is our Nissa and Honda and
you'll see with our scatter plot we're
now looking at where Yore K means equals
1 and we want zero column and y k means
equals 2 again we're looking at just the
first two columns zero and one and each
of these rows then corresponds to Nissan
and
Honda and I'll go ahead and hit enter on
there and uh finally let's take a look
and put the centroids on there again
we're going to do a scatter
plot and on the centroids you can just
pull that from our c means the uh model
we created do cluster centers and we're
going to just do um
all of them in the first number and all
of them in the second number which is 0o
one because you always start with zero
and
one and then they were playing with the
size and everything to make it look good
we'll do a size of 300 we're going to
make the color yellow and we'll label
them so it's good to have some good
labels
centroids and then we do want to do a
title PLT
title and pop up there PLT title you
always make want to make your graphs
look pretty and we'll call it clusters
of car
make and one of the features of the plot
library is you can add a legend it'll
automatically bring in it since we've
already labeled the different aspects of
the legend with Toyota Nissan and
Honda and finally we want to go ahead
and show so we can actually see it and
remember it's in line uh so if you're
using a different editor that's not the
Jupiter notebook you'll get a popup of
this and you should have a nice set of
clusters here so we can look at this and
we have a clusters of Honda and green
Toyota and red Nissan and purple and you
can see where they put the centroids to
separate
them now when we're looking at this we
can also plot a lot of other different
data on here as far because we only
looked at the first two columns this is
just column one and two or 0 one as as
you label them in computer scripting but
you can see here we have a nice clusters
of car Mak and we were able to pull out
the data and you can see how just these
two columns form very distinct clusters
of data so if you were exploring new
data you might take a look and say well
what makes these different almost going
in reverse you start looking at the data
and pulling apart the columns to find
out why is the first group set up the
way it is maybe you're doing loans and
you want to go well why is this group
not defaulting on their loans and why is
the last group defaulting on their loans
and why is the middle group 50%
defaulting on their bank loans and you
start finding ways to manipulate the
data and pull out the answers you
want so now that you've seen how to use
K mean for clustering let's move on to
the next topic now let's look into
logistic regression the logistic
regression algorithm is the simplest
classification algorithm used for binary
or multi-classification problems and we
can see we have our little girl from
Canada who's into horror books is back
that's actually really scary when you
think about that with those big eyes in
the previous tutorial we learned about
linear regression dependent and
independent variables so to brush up yal
mx + C very basic algebraic function of
Y and X the dependent variable is the
target class variable we are going to
predict the independent variables X1 all
the way up to xn are the features or
attributes we're going to use to predict
the target class we know what a linear
regression looks like but using the
graph we cannot divide the outcome into
categories it's really hard to
categorize 1.5 3.6 9.8 uh for example a
linear regression graph can tell us that
with increase in number of hours studied
the marks of a student will increase but
it will not tell us whether the student
will pass or not in such cases where we
need the output as categorical value we
will use logistic regression and for
that we're going to use the sigmoid
function so you can see here we have our
marks 0 to 100 number of hours studied
that's going to be what they're
comparing it to in this example and we
usually form a line that says y = mx + C
and when we use the sigmoid function we
have P = 1/ 1 + eus y it generates a
sigmoid curve and so you can see right
here when you take the Ln which is the
natural logarithm I always thought it
should be NL not Ln that's just the
inverse of uh e your e to the minus y
and so we do this we get Ln of p over 1
minus p = m * x + C that's the sigmoid
curve function we're looking for and we
can zoom in on the function and you'll
see that the function as it derives goes
to one or to zero depending on what your
x value is and the probability if it's
greater than 0.5 the value is
automatically round it off to one
indicating that the student will pass so
if they're doing a certain amount of
studying they will probably pass pass
then you have a threshold value at the 0
five it automatically puts that right in
the middle usually and your probability
if it's less than 0.5 the value run it
off to zero indicating the student will
fail so if they're not studying very
hard they're probably going to fail this
of course is ignoring the outliers of
that one student who's just a natural
genius and doesn't need any studying to
memorize everything that's not me
unfortunately have to study hard or
learn new stuff problem statement to
classify whether a tumor is malignant or
be 9 and this is actually one of my
favorite data sets to play with because
it has so many features and when you
look at them you really are hard to
understand you can't just look at them
and know the answer so it gives you a
chance to kind of dive into what data
looks like when you aren't able to
understand the specific domain of the
data but I also want you to remind you
that in the domain of medicine if I told
you that my probability was really good
it classified things at say 90% or 95%
and I'm specifying whether you're going
to have a malignant or a Bine tumor I'm
guessing that you're going to go get it
tested anyways so you got to remember
the domain we're working with so why
would you want to do that if you know
you're just going to go get a biopsy
because you know it's that serious this
is like an all or nothing just
referencing the domain it's important it
might help the doctor know where to look
just by understanding what kind of tumor
it is so it might help them or Aid them
in something they missed from before so
let's go ahead and dive into the code
and I'll come back to the domain part of
it in just a minute so use case and
we're going to do our noral Imports here
we're importing numpy Panda Seaborn the
matplot library and we're going to do
matplot library in line since I'm going
to switch over to Anaconda so let's go
ahead and flip over there and get this
started so I've opened up a new window
in my anaconda Jupiter
notebook by the way jupyter notebook uh
you don't have to use Anaconda for the
Jupiter notebook I just love the
interface and all the tools and Anaconda
brings so we got our import numpy as in
P for our numpy number array we have our
pandas PD we're going to bring in caborn
to help us with our graphs as SNS so
many really nice Tools in both caborn
and matplot library and we'll do our met
plot library. pyplot as PLT and then of
course we want to let it know to do it
in line and let's go and just run that
so it's all set
up and we're just going to call our data
data not creative today uh equals PD and
this happens to be in a CSV file so
we'll use a pd. read CSV and I happen to
name the file I renamed it data for
p2.png local spreadsheet and this is
just a CSV file comma separate variables
we have an ID so I guess they um
categorizes for reference of what id
which test was done the diagnosis M for
malignant B for B9 so there's two
different options on there and that's
what we're going to try to predict is
the m andb and test it and then we have
like the radius mean or average the
texture average perimeter mean area mean
smoothness I don't know about you but
unless you're a doctor in the field most
of the stuff I mean you can guess what
concave means just by the term concave
but I really wouldn't know what that
means and the measurements they're
taking so they have all kinds of stuff
like how smooth it is uh the Symmetry
and these are all float values we just
page through them real quick and you'll
see there's I believe 36 if I remember
correctly in this
one so there's a lot of different values
they take and all these measurements
they take when they go in there and they
take a look at the different growth the
tumorous growth so back in our data and
I put this in the same folder as a code
so I saved this code in that folder
obviously if you have it in a different
location you want to put the full path
in there and we'll just do U
Panda's first five lines of data with
the data. head and we run that we can
see that we have pretty much what we
just looked at we have an ID we have a
diagnosis if we go all the way across
you'll see all the different columns
coming across displayed nicely for our
data and while we're exploring the data
our caborn which we referenced as
SNS makes it very easy to go in here and
do a joint plot you'll notice the very
similar to because it is sitting on top
of the um plot Library so the joint plot
does a lot of work for us and we're just
going to look at the first two columns
that we're interested in the radius mean
and the texture mean we'll just look at
those two columns and data equals data
so that tells it which two columns we're
plotting and that we're going to use the
data that we pulled in let's just run
that and it generates a really nice
graph on here and there's all kinds of
cool things on this graph to look at I
mean we have the texture mean and the
radius mean obviously the axes you can
also
see and one of the cool things on here
is you can also see the histogram they
show that for the radius mean where is
the most commonest radius mean come up
and where the most common texture is
that's so we're looking at the tech the
on each growth its average texture and
on each radius its average uh radius on
there get a little confusing because
we're talking about the individual
objects average and then we can also
look over here and see the the histogram
showing us the median or how common each
measurement is and that's only two
columns so let's dig a little deeper
into Seaborn they also have a heat map
and if you're not familiar with heat
Maps a heat map
just means it's in color that's all that
means heat map I guess the original ones
were plotting heat density on something
and so ever sens it's just called a heat
map and we're going to take our data and
get our corresponding numbers to put
that into the heat map and that's simply
data. C RR for that that's a pandas
expression remember we're working in a
pandas data frame so that's one of the
Cool Tools in pandas for our data and
this just pull that information into a
heat map and see what that looks like
and you'll see that we're now looking at
all the different features we have our
ID we have our texture we have our area
our compactness concave points and if
you look down the middle of this chart
diagonal going from the upper left to
bottom right it's all white that's
because when you compare texture to
texture they're identical so they're
100% or in this case perfect one in
their
correspondance and you'll see that when
you look at say area or right below it
it has almost a black on there when you
compare it to texture so these have
almost no corresponding data They Don't
Really form a linear graph or something
that you can look at and say how
connected they are they're very
scattered data this is really just a
really nice graph to get a quick look at
your data doesn't so much change what
you do but it changes verifying so when
you get an answer or something like that
or you start looking at some of these
individual pieces you might go hey that
doesn't match according to showing our
heat map this should not correlate with
each other and if it is you're going to
have to start asking well why what's
going on what else is coming in there
but it does show some really cool
information on here mean we can see from
the ID there's no real one feature that
just says if you go across the top line
that lights up there's no one feature
that says hey if the area is a certain
size then it's going to be B9 or
malignant it says there's some that sort
of add up and that's a big hint in the
data that we're trying to to ID this
whether it's malignant or B9 that's a
big hint to us as data scientist to go
okay we can't solve this with any one
feature it's going to be something that
includes all the features or many of the
different features to come up with the
solution for it and while we're
exploring the data let's explore one
more area and let's look at data. is
null we want to check for null values in
our data if you remember from earlier in
this tutorial we did it a little
differently where we we added stuff up
and summ them up you can actually with
pandas do it really quickly data. isnull
and Summit and it's going to go across
all the columns so when I run
this you're going to see all the columns
come up with no null
data so we've just just to reash these
last few steps we've done a lot of
exploration we have looked at the first
two columns and seeing how they plot
with the caborn with the joint plot
which both the histogram and the data
plotted on the X Y coordinates and
obviously you can do that more in detail
with different columns and see how they
plot together and then we took and did
the Seaborn heat map the
SNS heat map of the data and you can see
right here where it did a nice job
showing us some bright spots where stuff
correlates with each other and forms of
very nice combination or points of
scattering points and you can also see
areas that don't
and then finally we went ahead and
checked the data is the data null value
do we have any missing data in there
very important step because it'll crash
later on if you forget to do this step
it will remind you when you get that
nice error code that says null values
okay so not a big deal if you miss it
but it it's no fun having to go back
when you're you're in a huge process and
you've missed this step and now you're
10 steps later and you got to go
remember where you were pulling the data
in so we need to go ahead and pull out
our X and our y so we just put that down
here and we'll set the x equal to and
there's a lot of different options here
certainly we could do x equals all the
columns except for the first two because
if you remember the first two is the ID
and the diagnosis so that certainly
would be an option but what we're going
to do is we're actually going to focus
on the worst the worst radius the worst
texture parameter area smoothness
compactness and so so on one of the
reasons to start dividing your data up
when you're looking at this information
is sometimes the data will be the same
data coming in so if I have two
measurements coming into my model it
might overweigh them it might overpower
the other measurements because it's
measur it's basically taking that
information in twice that's a little bit
past the scope of this tutorial I want
you to take away from this though is
that we are dividing the data up into
pieces and our team in the back went
ahead and said hey let's just look at
the worst so I'm going to create a an
array and you'll see this array radius
worst texture worst perimeter worst
we've just taken the worst of the worst
and I'm just going to put that in my X
so this x is still a pandas data frame
but it's just those columns and our y if
you remember correctly is going to be
oops hold on one second it's not X it's
data there we go so x equals data and
then it's a list of the different
columns the worst of the worst and if
we're going to take that then we have to
have our answer for our Y for the stuff
we know and if you remember correctly
we're just going to be looking
at the diagnosis that's all we care
about is what is it diagnosed is it Bine
or malignant and since it's a single
column we can just do diagnosis oh I
forgot to put the brackets the there we
go okay so it's just diagnosis on there
and we can also real quickly do like x.
head if you want to see what that looks
like and Y do head
and run this and you'll see um it only
does the last one I forgot about that if
you don't do print you can see that the
the y. head is just Mmm because the
first ones are all malignant and if I
run this the x. head is just the first
five values of radius worst texture
worst parameter worst area worst and so
on I'll go ahead and take that out so
moving down to the next step we've built
our two data sets our an answer and then
the features we want to look
at in data science it's very important
to test your model so we do that by
splitting the
data and from sklearn model selection
we're going to import train test split
so we're going to split it into two
groups there are so many ways to do this
I noticed in one of the more modern ways
they actually split it into three groups
and then you model each group and test
it against the other groups so you have
all kinds of and there's reasons for
that which is pass the scope of this and
for this particular example isn't
necessary for this we're just going to
split it into two groups one to train
our data and one to test our data and
the sklearn uh. model selection we have
train test split you could write your
own quick code to do this where we just
randomly divide the data up into two
groups but they do it for us
nicely and we actually can almost we can
actually do it in one statement with
this where we're going to generate four
four variables capital x train capital X
test so we have our training data we're
going to use to fit the model and then
we need something to test it and then we
have our y train so we're going to train
the answer and then we have our test so
this is the stuff we want to see how
good it did on our model and we'll go
ahead and take our train test split that
we just
imported and we're going to do X and our
y our two different data that's going in
for our split and then the guys in the
back came up and wanted us to go ahead
and use a test size equals. 3 that's
testore size random State it's always
nice to kind of switch to random State
around but not that important what this
means is that the test size is we're
going to take 30% of the data and we're
going to put that into our test
variables our y test and our X test and
we're going to do 70% into the X train
and the Y train so we're going to use
70% of the data to train our model and
30% to test it let's go ahead and run
that and load those up so now we have
all our stuff split up and all our data
ready to go and now we get to the actual
Logistics part we're going actually
going to do our create our model so
let's go ahead and bring that in from
sklearn we're going to bring in our
linear model and we're going to import
logistic regression that's the actual
model we're using and this we'll call it
log
models there we go model and let's just
set this equal to our logistic
regression that we just imported so now
have a variable log model set to that
class for us to use and with most the uh
models in the SK learn we just need to
go ahead and fix it fit do a fit on
there and we use our X train that we
separated out with our y train and let's
go ahead and run this so once we've run
this we'll have a model that fits this
data that 70% of our training
data uh and of course it prints this out
that tells us all the different
variables that you can set on there
there's a lot of different choices you
can make but for word do we're just
going to let all the defaults sit we
don't really need to mess with those on
this particular example and there's
nothing in here that really stands out
as super important until you start
fine-tuning it but for what we're doing
the basics will work just fine and then
let's we need to go ahead and test out
our model is it working so let's create
a variable y predict and this is going
to be equal to our log model and we want
to do a pred predict again very standard
uh format for the sklearn library is
taking your model and doing a predict on
it and we're going to test y predict
against the Y test so we want to know
what the model thinks it's going to be
that's what our y predict is and with
that we want the capital x x test so we
have our train set and our test set and
now we're going to do our y predict and
let's go ahead and run
that and if we uh
print y
predict let me go ahead and run that
you'll see it comes up and it pred a
prints a nice array of uh B and M for B9
and
malignant for all the different test
data we put in there so it does pretty
good we're not sure exactly how good it
does but we can see that it actually
works and it's functional was very easy
to create you'll always discover with
our data science that as you explore
this you spend a significant amount of
time prepping your data and making sure
your data coming in is good uh there's a
saying good data in good answers out bad
data in bad answers out that's only half
the thing that's only half of it
selecting your models becomes the next
part as far as how good your models are
and then of course fine-tuning it
depending on what model you're using so
we come in here we want to know how good
this came out so we have our y predict
here log model. predict X
test
so for deciding how good our model is
we're going to go from the SK learn.
metrics we're going to import
classification report and that just
reports how good our model is doing and
then we're going to feed it the uh model
data let's just print this out and we'll
take our classification
report and we're going to put into
there our test our actual data so this
is what we actually know is true and our
prediction what our model predicted for
that data on the test side and let's run
that and see what that
does so we pull that up you'll see that
we have um a Precision for B9 and
malignant
B&M and we have a Precision of 93 and 91
a total of 92 so it's kind of the
average between these two of 92 there's
all kinds of different information on
here your F1
score your recall your support coming
through on this and for this I'll go
ahead and just flip back to our slides
that they put together for describing it
and so here we're going to look at the
Precision using the classification
report and you see this is the same
print out I had up above some of the
numbers might be different because it
does randomly pick out which data we're
using so this model is able to predict
the type of tumor with
91% accuracy so when we look back here
that's you will see where we have uh B9
and mland it actually is 92 coming up
here but we're looking about a 92 91%
precision and remember I reminded you
about domain so we're talking about the
domain of a medical domain with a very
catastrophic outcome you know at 91 or
92% Precision you're still going to go
in there and have somebody do a biopsy
on it very different than if you're
investing money and there's a 92% chance
you're going to earn 10% and 8% chance
you're going to lose 8% you're probably
going to bet the money CU at that odds
it's pretty good that you'll make some
money and in the long run you do that
enough you definitely will make money
and also with this domain I've actually
seen them use this to identify different
forms of cancer that's one of the things
that they're starting to use these
models for because then it helps the
doctor know what to investigate so that
wraps up this section we're finally
we're going to go in there and let's
discuss the answer to the quiz asked in
machine learning tutorial part one can
you tell what's happening in the
following cases grouping documents into
different categories B based on the
topic and content of each document this
is an example of clustering where K
means clustering can be used to group
the documents by topics using bag of
words approach so if You' gotten in
there that you're looking for clustering
and hopefully you had at least one or
two examples like K means that are used
for clustering different things then
give yourself a two thumbs up B
identifying handwritten digits and
images correctly this is an example of
classification the traditional approach
to solving this would be to extract
digit dependent features like curvature
of different digits Etc and then use a
classifier like svm to distinguish
between images again if you got the fact
that it's a classification example give
yourself a thumb up and if you're able
to go hey let's use svm or another model
for this give yourself those two thumbs
up on it C behavior of a website
indicating that the site is not working
as designed this is an example of
anomaly detection in this case the
algorithm learns what is normal and what
is not normal usually by observing the
logs of the website give yourself a
thumbs up if you got that one and just
for a bonus can you think of another
example of anomaly detection one of the
ones I use for my own business is
detecting anomalies in stock markets
stock markets are very ficked and they
behave very ertical so finding those
erratic areas and then finding ways to
track down why they're erratic was
something released in social media was
something released you can see we're
knowing where that anomaly is can help
you to figure out what the answer is to
it in another area D predicting salary
of an individual based on his or her
years of experience this is an example
of regression this problem can be
mathematically defined as a function
between independent years of experience
and dependent variables salary of an
individual and if you guess that this
was a regression model give yourself a
thumbs up and if you're able to remember
that it was between independent and
dependent variables and that terms give
yourself two thumbs up summary so to
wrap it up we went over what is K means
and we went through also the chart of
choosing your elbow method and assigning
a random centroid to the Clusters
Computing the distance and then going in
there and figuring out what the minimum
centroids is and Computing the distance
and going through that Loop until it
gets the perfect centroid and we looked
into the elbow method to choose K based
on running our clusters across a number
of variables and finding the best
location for that we did a nice example
of clustering cars with K means even
though we only looked at the first two
columns to make it simple and easy to
graph we can easily extrapolate that and
look at all the different columns and
see how they all fit together and we
looked at what is logistic regression we
discussed the sigmoid function what is
logistic regression and then we went
into an example of classifying tumors
with Logistics I hope you enjoyed part
two of machine learning thank you for
joining us today for more information
visit www.s simply learn.com again my
name is Richard kersner a member of the
simplylearn team get certified get ahead
if you have any questions or comments
feel free to write those down below the
YouTube video or visit us at simply
learn.com we'll be happy to supply you
with the data sets or other information
as
[Music]
requested hi there if you like this
video subscribe to the simply learn
YouTube channel and click here to watch
similar videos to nerd up and get
certified click
here today we're going to cover the K
nearest neighbors a that referred to as
knnn and KNN is really a fundamental
place to start in the machine learning
it's a basis of a lot of other things
and just the logic behind it is easy to
understand and Incorporated in other
forms of machine learning so today
what's in it for you why do we need KNN
what is KNN how do we choose the factor
k
when do we use
knnn how does KNN algorithm work and
then we'll dive into my favorite part
the use case predict whether a person
will have diabetes or not that is a very
common and popular used data set as far
as testing out models and learning how
to use the different models in machine
learning by now we all know machine
learning models make predictions by
learning from the past data available so
we have our input values our machine
learning model Builds on those inputs of
what we already know and then we use
that to create a predicted output is
that a dog little kid looking over there
and watching the black cat cross their
path no dear you can differentiate
between a cat and a dog based on their
characteristics cats cats have sharp
claws uses to climb smaller length of
ears meows and purrs doesn't love to
play around dogs they have dull claws
bigger length of ears barks loves to run
around you usually don't see a cat
running around people although I do have
a cat that does that where dogs do and
we can look at these we can say we can
evaluate the sharpness of the claws how
sharp are their claws and we can
evaluate the length of the ears and we
can usually sort out cats from dogs
based on even those two characteristics
now tell me if it is a cat or a dog odd
question usually little kids know cats
and dogs by now unless they live a place
where there's not many cats or dogs so
if we look at the sharpness of the claws
the length of the ear ears and we can
see that the cat has smaller ears and
sharper claws than the other animals its
features are more like cats it must be a
cat sharp claws length of ears and it
goes in the cat group because KNN is
based on feature similarity we can do
classification using KNN classifier so
we have our input value the picture of
the black cat it goes into our trained
model and it predicts that this is a cat
coming out so what is knnn what is the
K&N algorithm K nearest neighbors is
what that stands for is one of the
simplest supervised machine learning
algorithms mostly used for
classification so we want to know is
this a dog or it's not a dog is it a cat
or not a cat the classifies a data point
based on how its neighbors are
classified KNN stores all available
cases and classifies new cases based on
a similarity measure and here we gone
from cats and dogs right into wine
another favorite of mine K&N stores all
available cases and classifies new cases
based on a similarity measure and here
you see we have a measurement of sulfur
dioxide versus the chloride level and
then the different wines they've tested
and where they fall on that graph based
on how much sulfur dioxide and how much
chloride K and KNN is a perimeter that
refers to the number of nearest
neighbors to include in the majority of
the voting process and so if we add a
new glass of wine there red or white we
want to know what the neighbors are in
this case we're going to put k equal 5
we'll talk about K in just a minute a
data point is classified by the majority
of votes from its five nearest neighbors
here the unknown point would be
classified as red since four out of five
neighbors are red so how do we choose K
how do we know k equals five I mean
that's what the value we put in there so
we're going to talk about it how do we
choose the factor K KN andn algorithm is
based on feature similarity choosing the
right value of K is a process called
parameter tuning and is important for
better accuracy so it k equal 3 we can
classify we have a question mark in the
middle as either a as a square or not is
it a square or is it in this case a
triangle and so if we set k equals to
three we're going to look at the three
nearest neighbors we're going to say
this is a square and if we put k equals
to 7 we classify as a triangle depending
on what the other data is around and you
can see as the K changes depending on
where that point is that drastically
changes your answer and uh we jump here
we go how do we choose the factor of K
you'll find this in all machine learning
choosing these factors that's the face
you get it's like oh my gosh did I
choose the right K did I set it right my
values in whatever machine learning tool
you're looking at so that you don't have
a huge bias in One Direction or the
other and in terms of knnn the number of
K if you choose it too low the bias is
based on it's just too noisy it's it's
right next to a couple things and it's
going to pick those things and you might
get a skewed answer and if your K is too
big then it's going to take forever to
process so you're going to run into
processing issues and resource issues so
what we do the most common use and
there's other options for choosing K is
to use the square root of n so N is a
total number of values you have you take
the square root of it in most cases you
also if it's an even number so if you're
using uh like in this case squares and
triangles if it's even you want to make
your K value odd that helps it select
better so in other words you're not
going to have a balance between two
different factors that are equal so
usually take the square root of N and if
it's even you add one to it or subtract
one from it and that's where you get the
K value from that is the most common use
and it's pretty solid it works very well
when do we use KNN we can use KNN when
data is labeled so you need a label on
it we know we have a group of pictures
with dogs dogs cats cats data is Noise
free and so you can see here when we
have a class and we have like
underweight 140 23 Hello Kitty normal
that's pretty confusing we have a a high
variety of data coming in so it's very
noisy and that would cause an issue data
set is small so we're usually working
with smaller data sets where I you might
get into gig of data if it's really
clean doesn't have a lot of noise
because KNN is a lazy learner I.E it
doesn't learn a discriminative function
from the training set so it's very lazy
so if you have very complicated data and
you have a large amount of it you're not
going to use the KNN but it's really
great to get a place to start even with
large data you can sort out a small
sample and get an idea of what that
looks like using the KNN and also just
using for smaller data sets KNN works
really good how does the KNN algorithm
work consider a data set having two
variables height in centimeters and
weight in kilograms and each point is
classified as normal or underweight so
we can see right here we have two
variables you know true false they're
either normal or they're not they're
underweight on the basis of the given
data we have to classify the below set
as normal or underweight using KNN in so
if we have new data coming in that says
57 kg and 177 cm is that going to be
normal or underweight to find the
nearest neighbors we'll calculate the
ukian distance according to the ukian
distance formula the distance between
two points in the plane with the
coordinates XY and ab is given by
distance D equals the square root of x -
a^ 2 + y - b^ 2 and you can remember
that from the two edges of a triangle
we're Computing the third Edge since we
know the X side and the yide let's
calculate it to understand clearly so we
have our unknowing point and we placed
it there in red and we have our other
points where the data is scattered
around the distance D1 is a square otk
of 170 - 167 2 + 57 - 51 SAR which is
about 6.7 and distance two is about 13
and distance three is about 13.4 similar
Sly we will calculate the ukian distance
of unknown data point from all the
points in the data set and because we're
dealing with small amount of data that's
not that hard to do and it's actually
pretty quick for a computer and it's not
a really complicated Mass you can just
see how close is the data based on the
ukan distance hence we have calculated
the ukian distance of unknown data point
from all the points as showing where X1
and y1 equal 57 and 170 whose class we
have to classify so now we're looking at
that we're saying well here's the ukian
distance who's going to be their closest
neighbors now let's calculate the
nearest neighbor at k equals 3 and we
can see the three closest neighbors puts
them at normal and that's pretty
self-evident when you look at this graph
it's pretty easy to say okay what you
know we're just voting normal normal
normal three votes for normal this is
going to be a normal weight so majority
of neighbors are pointing towards normal
hence as per KNN algorithm the class of
57170 should be normal so recap of knnn
positive integer K is specified along
with a new sample we select the K
entries in our database which are
closest to the new sample we find the
most common classification of these
entries this is the classification we
give to the new sample so as you can see
it's pretty straightforward we're just
looking for the closest things that
match what we got so let's take a look
and see what that looks like in a use
case in Python so let's dive into the
predict diabetes use case so use case
predict diabetes the objective predict
whether a person will be diagnosed with
diabet IES or not we have a data set of
768 people who were or were not
diagnosed with diabetes and let's go
ahead and open that file and just take a
look at that data and this is in a
simple spreadsheet format the data
itself is comma separated very common
set of data and it's also a very common
way to get the data and you can see here
we have columns a through I that's what
one 2 3 4 5 6 78 um eight columns with a
particular tribute and then and the
ninth column which is the outcome is
whether they have diabetes as a data
scientist the first thing you should be
looking at is insulin well you know if
someone has insulin they have diabetes
because that's why they're taking it and
that could cause issue on some of the
machine learning packages but for a very
basic setup this works fine for doing
the KNN and the next thing you notice is
it didn't take very much to open it up
um I can scroll down to the bottom of
the data there's
768 it's pretty much a small data set
you know at 769 I can easily fit this in
to my ram on my computer I can look at
it I can manipulate it and it's not
going to really tax just a regular
desktop computer you don't even need an
Enterprise version to run a lot of this
so let's start with importing all the
tools we need and before that of course
we need to discuss what IDE I'm using
certainly you can use any particular
editor for python but I like to use for
doing uh very basic visual stuff the
Anaconda which is great for doing demos
with the Jupiter notebook and just a
quick view of the Anaconda Navigator
which is the new release out there which
is really nice you can see under home I
can choose my application we're going to
be using python 36 I have a couple
different uh versions on this particular
machine if I go under environments I can
create a unique environment for each one
which is nice and there's even a little
button there where I can install
different packages so if I click on that
button and open the terminal I can then
use a simple pip install to install
different packages I'm working with
let's go ahead and go back under home
and we're going to launch our notebook
and I've already you know kind of like
uh the old cooking shows I've already
prepared a lot of my stuff so we don't
have to wait for it to launch because it
takes a few minutes for it to open up a
browser window in this case I'm going
it's going to open up Chrome because
that's my default that I use and since
the script is pre-done you'll see I have
a number of windows open up at the top
the one we're working in and uh since
we're working on the KNN predict whether
a person will have diabetes or not let's
go and put that title in there and I'm
also going to go up here and click on
Cell actually we want to go ahead and
first insert a cell below and then I'm
going to go back up to the top cell and
I'm going to change the cell type to
markdown that means this is not going to
run as python it's a markdown language
so if I run this first one it comes up
in nice big letters which is kind of
nice remind us what we're working on and
by now you should be familiar with doing
all of our Imports we're going to import
the pandas as PD import numpy as NP
pandas is the pandas data frame and
numpy is a number array very powerful
tools to use in here we have our Imports
so we've brought in our pandas our numpy
our two general python tools and then
you can see over here we have our train
test split by now youed to be familiar
with splitting the data we want to split
part of it for training our thing and
then training our particular model and
then we want to go ahead and test the
remaining data just see how good it is
pre-processing a standard scaler
pre-processor so we don't have a bias of
really large numbers remember in the
data we had like number pregnancies
isn't going to get very large where the
amount of insulin they take and get up
to 256 so 256 versus 6 that will skew
results so we want to go ahead and
change that so they're all uniform
between minus one and one and then the
actual tool this is the K neighbors
classifier we're going to use and
finally the last three are three tools
to test all about testing our model how
good is it let me just put down test on
there and we have our confusion Matrix
our F1 score and our accuracy so we have
our two general pyth on modules we're
importing and then we have our six
modules specific from the sklearn setup
and then we do need to go ahead and run
this so these are actually imported
there we go and then move on to the next
step and so in this set we're going to
go ahead and load the data base we're
going to use pandas remember pandas is
PD and we'll take a look at the data in
Python we looked at it in a simple
spreadsheet but usually I like to also
pull it up so that we can see what we're
doing so here's our data set equals pd.
read CSV that's a pandas command and the
diabetes folder I just put in the same
folder where my IPython script is if you
put in a different folder you'd need the
full length on there we can also do a
quick length of uh the data set that is
a simple python command Len for length
we might even let's go ahead and print
that we'll go print and if you do it on
its own line link. data set in the
jupyter notebook it'll automatically
print it but when you're in most of your
different setups you want to do the
print in front of the and then we want
to take a look at the actual data set
and since we're in pandas we can simply
do data set head and again let's go
ahead and add the print in there if you
put a bunch of these in a row you know
the data set one head data set two head
it only prints out the last one so I
usually always like to keep the print
statement in there but because most
projects only use one data frame Panda's
data frame doing it this way doesn't
really matter the other way works just
fine and you can see when we hit the Run
button we have the 768 lines which we
knew and we have our pregnancies it's
automatically given a label on the left
remember the head only shows the first
five lines so we have zero through four
and just a quick look at the data you
can see it matches what we looked at
before we have pregnancy glucose blood
pressure all the way to age and then the
outcome on the end and we're going to do
a couple things in this next step we're
going to create a list of columns where
we can't have zero there's no such thing
as zero skin thickness or zero blood PR
pressure zero glucose uh any of those
you'd be dead so not a really good
Factor if they don't if they have a zero
in there because they didn't have the
data and we'll take a look at that
because we're going to start replacing
that information with a couple of
different things and let's see what that
looks like so first we create a nice
list as you can see we have the values
talked about glucose blood pressure skin
thickness uh and this is a nice way when
you're working with columns is to list
the columns you need to do some kind of
transformation on very common thing to
do and then then for this particular
setup we certainly could use the there's
some Panda tools that will do a lot of
this where we can replace the na but
we're going to go ahead and do it as a
data set column equals data set column.
replace this is this is still pandas you
can do a direct there's also one that
that you look for your n a lot of
different options in here but the Nan
nump n is what that stands for is is non
doesn't exist so the first thing we're
doing here is we're replacing the zero
with a numpy none there's no data there
that's what that says that's what this
is saying right here so put the zero in
and we're going to replace zeros with no
data so if it's a zero that means the
person's well hopefully not dead
hopefully they just didn't get the data
the next thing we want to do is we're
going to create the mean which is the in
integer from the data set from the
column do mean where we skip Nas we can
do that that is a panda's command there
the skip na so we're going to figure out
the mean of that data set and then we're
going to take that that data set column
and we're going to replace all the
npn with the means why did we do that
and we could have actually just uh taken
this step and gone right down here and
just replace zero and Skip anything
where except you could actually there's
a way to skip zeros and then just
replace all the zeros but in this case
we want to go ahead and do it this way
so you can see that we're switching this
to a non-existent value then we're going
to create the mean well this is the
average person so if we don't know what
it is if they did not get the data and
the data is missing one of the tricks is
you replace it with the average what is
the most common data for that this way
you can still use the rest of those
values to do your computation and it
kind of just brings that particular
value of those missing values out of the
equation let's go ahead and take this
and we'll go ahead and run it doesn't
actually do anything so we're still
preparing our data if you want to see
what that looks like we don't have
anything in the first few lines it's not
going to show up but we certainly could
look at a row let's do that let's go
into our data set with a printed data
set and let's pick in this case let's
just do glucose and if I run this this
is going to print all the different
glucose levels going down and we
thankfully don't see anything in here
that looks like missing data at least on
the ones it shows you can see it skipped
a bunch in the middle because that's
what it does if you have too many lines
in Jupiter notebook it'll skip a few and
and go on to the next in a data set let
me go and remove this and we'll just
zero out that and of course before we do
any process say before proceeding any
further we need to split the data set
into our train and testing data that way
we have something to train it with and
something to test it on and you're going
to notice we did a little something here
with the Panda's database code there we
go my drawing tool we've added in this
right here off the data set and what
this says is that the first one in
pandas this is from the PD pandas it's
going to say within the data set we want
to look at the iocation and it is all
rows that's what that says so we're
going to keep all the rows but we're
only looking at zero column 0 to 8
remember column 9 here it is right up
here we printed in here is outcome well
that's not part of the training data
that's part of the answer yes it's
column nine but it's listed as eight
number eight so 0o to eight is nine
columns so uh eight is the value and
when you see it in here zero this is
actually 0 to 7 it doesn't include the
last one and then we go down here to Y
which is our answer and we want just the
last one just column 8 and you can do it
this way with this particular notation
and then if you remember we imported the
train test split that's part of the SK
learn right there and we simply put in
our X and our y we're going to do random
State equals zero you don't have to
necessarily seed it that's a seed number
I think the default is one when you SE
it I'd have to look that up and then the
test size test size is 0.2 that simply
means we're going to take 20% of the
data and put it aside so that we can
test it later that's all that is and
again we're going to run it not very
exciting so far we haven't had any print
out other than to look at the data but
that is a lot of this is prepping this
data once you prep it the actual lines
of code are quick and easy and we're
almost there with the actual writing of
our KNN we need to go ahead and do a
scale the data if you remember correctly
we're fitting the data in a standard
scaler which means instead of the data
being from you know five to 303 in one
column and the next column is 1 to six
we're going to set that all so that all
the data is between minus1 and one
that's what standard scaler does keeps
it standardized and we only want to fit
the scaler with the training set but we
want to make sure the testing set is the
X test going in is also transformed so
it's processing it the same so here we
go with our standard scaler we're going
to call it scor X for the scaler and
we're going to import the standard
scaler into this variable and then our X
train equals score x. fit transform so
we're creating the scaler on the X X
train variable and then our X test we're
also going to transform it so we've
trained and transformed the XT train and
then the X test isn't part of that
training it isn't part of that of
training the Transformer it just gets
transformed that's all it does and again
we're going to go and run this if you
look at this we've now gone through
these steps all three of them we've
taken care of replacing our zeros for
key columns that shouldn't be zero and
we replace that with the means of those
columns that way that they fit right in
with our data models we've come down
here and we split the data so now we
have our test data and our training data
and then we've taken and we scaled the
data so all of our data going in now no
we don't tra we don't train the Y part
the Y train and Y test that never has to
be trained it's only the data going in
that's what we want to train in there
then Define the model using K neighbors
classifier and fit the train data in the
model so we do all that data a prep and
you can see down here we're only going
to have a couple lines of code where
we're actually building our model and
training it that's one of the cool
things about Python and how far we've
come it's such an exciting time to be in
machine learning because there's so many
automated tools let's see before we do
this let's do a quick length of and
let's do y we want let's just do length
of Y and we get 768 and if we import
math we do math. square root let's do y
train there we go it's actually supposed
to be X train before we do this let's go
ahead and do import math and do math
square root length of Y test and when I
run that we get
12.49 I want to see show you where this
number comes from we're about to use 12
is an even number so if you know if
you're ever voting on things remember
the neighbors all vote don't want to
have an even number of neighbors voting
so we want to do something odd and let's
just take one away we'll make it 11 let
me delete this out of here this one of
the reasons I love Jupiter notebook cuz
you can flip around and do all kinds of
things on the fly so we'll go ahead and
put in our classifier we're creating our
classifier now and it's going to be the
K neighbors classifier n neighbors equal
11 remember we did 12 minus 1 for 11 so
we have an odd number of neighbors P
equals 2 because we're looking for is it
are they diabetic or not and we're using
the ukian metric there are other means
of measuring the distance you could do
like square square means value there's
all kinds of measure this but the ucan's
the most common one and it works quite
well it's important to evaluate the
model let's use the confusion Matrix to
do that and we're going to use the
confusion Matrix wonderful tool and then
we'll jump into the F1 score and finally
accuracy score which is probably the
most commonly used quoted number when
you go into a meeting or something like
that so let's go ahead and paste that in
there and we'll set the cm equal to
confusion Matrix y test y predict so
those are the two values we're going
going to put in there and let me go ah
and run that and print it out and the
way you interpret this is you have the Y
predicted which would be your title up
here we could do uh let's just do p r d
predicted across the top and actual
going down actual it's always hard to to
write in here actual that means that
this column here down the middle that's
the important column and it means that
our prediction said 94 and prediction in
the actual agreed on 94 and 32 this
number here the 13 and the 15 those are
what was wrong so you could have like
three different if you're looking at
this across three different variables
instead of just two you'd end up with
the third row down here and the column
going down the middle so in the first
case we have the the and I believe the
zero is a 94 people who don't have
diabetes the prediction said that 13 of
those people did have diabetes and were
at high risk and the 32 that had
diabetes it had correct but our
prediction said another 15 out of that
15 it classified as incorrect so you can
see where that classification comes in
and how that works on the confusion
Matrix then we're going to go ahead and
print the F1 score let me just run that
and you see we get a 69 in our F1 score
the F1 takes into account both sides of
the balance of false positives where if
we go ahead and just to the accuracy
account and that's what most people
think of is it looks at just how many we
got right out of how many we got wrong
so a lot of people when you're a data
scientist and you're talking to other
data scientists they're going to ask you
what the F1 score the F score is if
you're talking to the general public or
the U decision makers in the business
they're going to ask what the accuracy
is and the accuracy is always better
than the F1 score but the F1 score is
more telling it lets us know that
there's more false positives than we
would like like on here but 82% not too
bad for a quick flash look at people's
different statistics in running an
sklearn and running the KNN the K
nearest neighbor on it so we have
created a model using KNN which can
predict whether a person will have
diabetes or not or at the very least
whether they should go get a checkup and
have their glucose checked regularly or
not the print accurac score we got the
0818 was pretty close to what we got and
we can pretty much round that off and
just say we have an accuracy of 80%
tells us it is a pretty fair fit in the
model the principal component uh
analysis we're going to cover
dimensionality reduction principal
component analysis what is it important
PCA terminologies and you'll see it
abbreviated uh normally as PCA principal
component analysis PCA properties PCA
example and then we'll pull up some
python code in our jupyter notebook and
have some Hands-On demo on the PCA and
how it's used dimensionality reduction
dimensionality reduction refers to the
technique that reduces the number of
input variables in a data
set and so you can see on the table on
the right shows the orders made at an
automobile parts retailer the retailer
sells different automobile parts from
different companies and you can see we
have company uh bpex isomax and they
have the item the tire the axle an order
ID a price number and a quantity in
order to predict the future sell
we find out that using correlation
analysis that we just need three
attributes therefore we have reduced the
number of attributes from five to three
and clearly we don't really care about
the part number I don't think the part
number would have an effect on how many
tires are bought um and even the store
who's buying them probably does not have
an effect on that in this case that's
what they've actually done is remove
those and we just have the item the tire
the price and the quantity one of the
things you should be taking away from
this is in the scheme of things we are
in the descriptive phase we're
describing the data and we're
pre-processing the data what can we do
to clean it up why dimensionality
reduction well number one less
dimensions for a given data set means
less computation or training time that
can be really important if you're trying
a number of different models uh and
you're rerunning them over and over
again and even if you have seven
gigabytes of data that can start taking
days to go through all those different
models so this is huge this is probably
the hugest part as far as reducing um
our data set redundancy is removed after
removing similar entries from the data
set again pre-processing some of our
models like a neural network if you put
into two the same data it might give
them a higher weight than they would if
it was just once we want to get rid of
that
redundancy it also increases the
processing time if you have multiple
data coming in space required to store
the data is
reduced so if we're committing this into
a big data uh pool we might not send the
company that bought it why would we want
to store two whole extra columns when we
added into that pool of data makes the
data easy for plotting in 2D and 3D
plots this is my favorite part very
important you're in your shareholder
meeting you want to be able to give them
a really good um clear answer simplified
version you want to reduce it down to
something people can take in it helps to
find out the most significant features
and skip the rest which also comes in in
postcript that kind of goes with number
four where makes data easy for plotting
you have a better interpretation when
we're looking at it principal component
analysis so what is it uh principle
component analysis is a technique for
reducing the dimensionality of data sets
increasing interpretability but at the
same time minimizing information loss so
we take some very complex data set with
lots of variables we run it through the
PCA we reduce the variables we end up
with a reduced variable
setup this is very confusing to look at
because if you look at the end result we
have the different colors all lined up
so what we're going to take a look at is
let's say we have a picture here uh
let's say you are asked to take a
picture of some Toddlers and you are
deciding which angle would be the best
to take the picture from so if we come
up here we look at this we say okay this
is you know one angle uh we get the back
of a lot of heads not many
faces uh so we'll do it from here we
might get the one person up front
smiling a lot of the people in the class
are missing so we have a huge amount off
to the right of blank space Maybe from
up here again we have the back of
someone's head and uh it turns out that
the best angle to click the picture from
might be this bottom left angle you look
at it and you say hey that makes makes
sense it's a a good um configuration of
all the people in the picture now when
we're talking about data it's not you
really can't do it by what you think is
going to be the best we need to have
some kind of mathematical formula so
it's consistent and so it makes sense in
the back end one of the projects I
worked on many years ago uh has
something similar to the iris and if
you've ever done the iris data set is
probably one of the most common ones out
there where they have the flower and
they're measuring the stammen uh in the
pedals and they have width and they have
length of the
pedal instead of putting through the
width and the length of the petal we
could just as easily do the um width to
length ratio we can divide the width by
the length and you get a single number
where you had two that's the kind of
idea that's going on into this in
pre-processing and looking at what we
can do to bring the data down the very
simplified example on my uh Iris pedal
example example when we look at the
similarity in PCA we find the best
picture or projection of the data points
and so we look down at from one angle
we've drawn a line down there uh we can
see these data points based on in this
case just two variables now keep in mind
we're usually talking about 36 40
variables um almost all of your business
models you usually have about 26 to 27
different variables they're looking at
uh same thing with like a bank loan
model we're talking 26 to 36 different
variables they're looking at that are
going in so what we want to do is we
want to find the best view in this case
we're just looking at the
XY we look down at it and we have our
second um idea PC2 and again we're
looking at the X side this XY this time
from a different direction here for our
ease we can consider that we get two
principal components namely pc1 and
PC2 comparing both the principal
components we find the data points are
sufficiently spaced in
pc1 so if you look at what we got here
we have uh pc1 you can see along the
line how the data points are spaced
versus the spacing in PC2 and that's
what they're coming up with what is
going to give us the best look for these
data points when we combine them and
we're looking at them from just a single
angle whereas in PC2 they are less
spaced which makes the observation and
further calculations much more difficult
there therefore we accept the pc1 and
not the PC2 as the data points are more
spaced now obviously the backend
calculations are a little bit more
complicated when we get into the math of
how they decide what is more
valuable this gives you an idea though
that when we're talking about this we're
talking about the perspective uh which
would help in understanding how PCA
analysis
works we want to go ahead and do is dive
into the important terminologies under
PCA and important terminologies are
views the perspective through which data
points are
observed and so you'll hear that if
someone's talking about a PCA
presentation and they're not taking the
time to reduce it to something that the
average person shareholders can
understand you might hear them refer to
it as the different views what view are
we taking Dimension number of columns in
a data set are called the dimensions of
that data set we talked about you'll
hear features Dimensions um I was
talking about features usually when
you're running a business you're talking
25 26 27 different features minimal and
then you have the principal component
new variables that are constructed as
linear combinations or mixtures of the
initial
variables principal component is very
important it's a combination if you
remember my flower example it would be
the width over the length of the petal
as opposed to putting both width and
length in you just put in the um ratio
instead which is a single number versus
two separate numbers
projections the perpendicular distance
between the principal component and the
data
points and that goes to that line we had
earlier it's that right angle line of
where those Point how those points fall
onto the line important properties
important properties number of principal
components is always less than or equal
to the number of
attributes that just makes Common Sense
uh you're not going to do 10 principal
properties with only three features now
you're trying to reduce them so that's
just kind of goofy but it is important
to remember that people will throw weird
code out there and just randomly do
stuff with instead of really thinking it
through principal components are
orthagonal
and this is what we're talking about
that right angle from the line we when
we do pc1 we're looking at how those
points fall onto that line uh same thing
with PC2 we want to make sure that pc1
does not equal PC2 we don't want to have
the same two principal points uh when we
do two
points the priority of principal
components decreases as their numbers
increase this is important to understand
if you're going to
create uh one
principal component everything is
summarized into that one component as we
go to two components the priority um how
much it holds value
decreases as we go down so if you have
five different points each one of those
points is going to have less value than
just the one point which has everything
summarized in it how PCA works I said
there was more in the back end we talk
about the math this is what we're
talking about is how does it actually
work so now we have understanding that
you're you're looking at a perspective
uh now we want to see how that math side
Works PCA performs the following
operations in order to evaluate the
principal components for a given data
set first we start with the
standardization then we have a
covariance matrix
computation and we use that to generate
our IGN vectors and ige values which is
the feature vector and if you remember
the IGN Vector is like a translation for
um uh moving the data from xal 1 to xal
2 or whatever altering it and the IG
value is a final value that we
generate when we talk about
standardization the main aim of this
step is to standardize the range of the
attributes so that each one of them lie
within similar boundaries this process
involves removal of the mean from the
variable values and scaling the data
with respect to the standard
deviation and you can see here we have Z
equals the variable values minus the
mean over the standard
deviation the co-variance Matrix
computation co-variance Matrix is used
to express the correlation between any
two or more attributes in
multi-dimensional data set the
co-variance Matrix has the entries as
the variance and the co-variance of the
attribute values the variance is denoted
by VAR and the co-variance is denoted by
Cove on the right we can see the
co-variance Matrix for two attributes
and their
values when we do a Hands-On look at the
code we'll do a display of this so you
can see what we're talking about and
what that looks like for now you can
just notice that this is a matrix that
we're generating with the variance and
then the co-variance of x to Y on the
right side we can see the covariance
table for more than two attributes in a
multi-dimensional data
set this is what I was talking about we
usually are looking at uh not just one
feature or two features we're usually
looking at 25 30 features going
on and so if we do a setup like this we
should see all those different features
as the different
variables covariance Matrix tells us how
the two or more variables are related
positive covariant indicate that the
value of one variable is directly
proportional to the other variable
negative covariant indicate that the
value of one variable is inversely
proportional to the other variable that
is always important to note whenever
we're doing any of these matrixes that
we're going to be looking at that
positive and negative whether it's
inverted or not and then we have the ige
value Val and the IG vectors IG values
and IG vectors are the mathematical
value that are extracted from the
covariance table they are responsible
for the generation of a new set of
variables from the old set of variables
which further lead to the construction
of the principal components igene
vectors do not change directions after
linear transformation igene values are
the scalers or the magnitude of the ige
vectors and again this is just Chang
transforming that data so we're going to
change uh the vector B to the B Prime as
denoted on the chart and so when we have
like multiple variables how do we
calculate that new variable and then we
have feature vectors feature vectors is
simply a matrix that has iing vectors of
the components that we decide to keep as
the
columns here we decide whether we must
keep or discard the less significant
principal components that we have
generated in the above steps this
becomes really important as we start
looking at U the back end of this and
we'll do this in the demo uh but one of
the more important steps to
understand and so we have the PCA
example consider Matrix X within rows or
observations and K columns or variables
now for this Matrix we would construct a
variable space with as many dimensions
as the
variable but for our Simplicity let's
consider this three dimensions for now
now now each observation row of the
Matrix X is placed in the K dimensional
variable space such that the rows in the
data table form a swarm of points in
this
space now we find the mean of all the
observations and then place it along the
data points on the
plot the first principal component is a
line the best accounts for the shape of
the point swarm it represents a maximum
variance Direction in the data
each observation may be projected onto
this line in order to get a coordinate
value along the pc1 this value is known
as a
score usually only one principal
component is insufficient to model the
systematic variation for a data set thus
a second principal axis is
created the second principal component
is oriented such that it reflects the
second largest source of variation in
the data while being orthagonal to pc1
PC 2 also passes through the average
Point let's go ahead and pull this up
and just see what that means uh inside
our python scripting I'm going to use
the Anaconda Navigator and I will be in
Python
3.6 for this example I believe there's
even like a 3.9 out I tend to stay in
3.6 because a lot of the models I use
especially with the neural networks are
stable in
and then we open up our uh Jupiter I'm
in Chrome and we go ahead and create a
new Python
3 and for ease of use uh our team in the
back was nice enough to put this
together for me and we'll go and start
with the libraries the first thing I
like to do whenever I'm looking at any
new setup uh well you know what Let's do
let's do the libraries first we're going
to do our basic libraries which is map
plot Library uh the PLT from the M plot
Library pandas our data frame uh PD
numpy our numbers array NP caborn for
graphing SNS that goes with the plot
that actually sits on Matt plot Library
so the caborn sits on there and then we
have our Amber sign because we're in
jupyter Notebook M plot library in line
the newer version actually doesn't
require that um but I put it in there
either anyway just because I'm so used
to
it and then we want to go ahead and take
a look at the
data and in this case we're going to
pull in uh certainly you can have lots
of fun with different data but we're
going to use the cancer data set u one
of the reasons a cancer data set is is
it has like 36 35 different features so
it's kind of fun to use that as our base
for this and we'll go ahead and run this
and look at our
keys and the first thing we notice in
our keys for the cancer data set uh is
we have our data we have our Target our
frame Target names description feature
names and file
name so what we're looking for in all
this is um well let's take a look at the
description let's go in here and pull up
the description on
here I'm not going to spend a huge
amount of time on the description um
because this is we don't want to get
into a medical domain we want to focus
on our PCA setup uh what's important is
you start looking at what the different
attributes are what they mean um if you
were in the medical field you'd want to
note all these different things whether
what they measuring where it's coming
from you can actually see the actual
different um measurements are
taking no missing
attributes we page all the way to the
bottom and you're going to have your
data in this case our
Target and if you dig deep enough to the
Target uh let's actually do this let's
go ahead and print Target
names real quick here I always like to
to just take a look and see what's on
the other end of this uh
Target names run
that and so the target name is is it
malignant or is it B9 um so in other
words is this uh dangerous growth or is
it something we don't have to worry
about that's the bottom line with the
cancer in this
case and then we can go ahead and load
our data and you know what let me go up
a just a notch here for easy of
reading it's hard to get that just right
I guess I'll we have to do uh so let's
go ahead and look at our data uh our our
we're going to use our pandas and we're
going to go ahead and uh do our data
frame it's going to equal cancer data
columns equals cancer feature equals
feature names so remember up here we
already loaded the the U names up of our
of the features in there what is going
to come out of this let me just see if I
can get to
that it's at the top of Target names um
that's just this list of names here in
the
setup and we can go ahead and run this
code and it'll print the head and you
can see here we have the mean radius the
mean texture mean perimeter I don't know
about you this is a Wonder F data set if
you're playing with it because like many
of the data that most of the data that
comes in half the time we don't even
know what we're looking at uh we're just
handed a bunch of stuff as a data
scientist going what the heck is this
and so this is a good place to start
because this has a number of different
features in there and we have no idea
what these feature means or where they
come from we want to just look at the
data and figure that
out and now we actually are getting into
the PCA side of it as we've noticed
before it difficult to visualize High
dimensional data we can use PCA to find
the first two principal components and
visualize the data this new
two-dimensional space with a single
scatter plot uh before we do this we
need to go ahead and scale our
data now I haven't run this to see if
you really have to scale the data on
this um but as just a
general runtime I almost do that as the
first step of any modeling even if it's
pre-modeling as we're doing here um in
neural networks that is so important
with PCA visualization it's already
going to scale it when we do the means
and deviation inside the PCA uh but just
in case it's always good to scale
it and then we're going to take our PCA
with the pyit learn uses very similar
process to other pre-processing
functions that come with pyit learn we
instantiate a PCA object find the
printable components using the fit
method then apply the rotation and
dimensionality reduction by calling
transform we can also specify how many
components we want to keep when creating
the PCA
object and so the code for
this oops getting a little bit
ahead let me go and run this code uh so
the code for
this is from sklearn decomposition
import PCA PCA equals PCA in components
equals 2 and that's really important to
note that um because we're only going to
want to look at two
components I would never go over four
components uh especially if you're going
to demo this with somebody else if
you're showing this to the
shareholders the whole idea is to reduce
it to something people can
see uh and then the PCA fit we're going
to uh is going to take the scale data
that we generated up here and then you
can see we've created our PCA model with
in components equals
2 now whenever I use a new tool I like
to go in there and actually see what I'm
using so let's go to the S kit uh web
page for the
PCA and you can see in here here's our
call statement it describes what all the
different uh setups you have on
there probably the biggest one to look
at would be um well the biggest one is
your components how many components do
you want uh which you have to put in
there pretty much and then you also
might look at the SVD solver it's on
auto right now but you can override that
and do different things with it it does
a pretty good job as it
is and if we go down all the way down
to
um here we go to our methods if you
notice we have fit we have fit transform
nowhere in here is predict because this
is not used for prediction uh it's used
to look at the data again we're in the
describe setup we're fitting the data
we're taking a look at it uh we've
already looked at our minimum maximum
we've already looked at what's in each
quarter we've done a full description of
the data this is part of describing the
data um that's the biggest thing I take
away when I come zooming in here and of
course they have examples of it down
here if you forget
um and the biggest one of course is the
number of components and then uh I mean
the rest you can play with um the actual
solver whether you're doing a full
randomize there's different things it
does pretty good on the
auto and now we can transform this data
to its first two principal
components and so we have our um X
PCA we're going to set that equal to PCA
transform scaled
data uh so there we go there's our first
transformation and let's just go ahead
and print the scaled data shape and the
xpc data
shape and the reason we want to do this
is just to show us uh what's going on
here we've taken 30 features I think I
said 36 or something like that but it's
30 and we've compressed it down to two
features and we decided we wanted two
features and that's where this comes
from uh we still have 569 data sets I
mean data rows not data sets we still
have 569 rows of data but instead of
computing 30 features we're now only
doing our model on two
features so let's go ahead and uh uh
plot these and take a look and see
what's going
on and
uh we're just going to use our PLT
figure we're set the figure size on here
here's our scatter plot um X
PCA xcore PCA of uh of one these are two
different perceptions we're using uh and
then you'll see right here C for color
cancer equals Target and so remember we
have zero we have one and if I remember
correctly zero was malignant one was
B9 uh so everything in the zero column
is going to be one color and the other
color is going to be one and then we're
going to use the plasma map just kind of
telling you what color it is add some
labels first principal component second
principal component we'll go and run
this and you can see here instead of
having a chart one of those heat maps
with 30 different columns in it we can
look at this and say hey this one
actually did a pretty good
job of separating the
data and a couple things when I'm
looking at this that I notice is first
we have a very clear area where it's
clumped together um where it's going to
be benign and we have a huge area it's
still clumped together more spread out
where it's going to be uh malignant or I
think I had that backwards and then in
the middle because we're dealing with
something in this particular case cancer
we would try to separate I would be
exploring how to separate this middle
group out in other where there's an area
where everything overlaps and we're not
going to have a clear result on it uh
just because those are the people you
want to go in there and have extra tests
or treat it differently versus going in
and saying just cutting into the can
into the cancer so the body absorbs it
and it dissipates versus uh actively
going in there removing it testing it
going through chemo and all the
different things that's a big difference
you know as far as what's going to
happen here and that middle line where
they overlap is going to be huge that's
domain specific uh going back to the
data we can see here uh clearly by using
these two components we can easily
separate these two classes so the next
step is what does that mean interpreting
the
components unfortunately with this great
power of dimensionality reduction comes
the cost of not being able to easily
understand what these components
represent I don't know what principal
component one looks represents or second
principle the components correspond to
combinations of original features the
components themselves are stored as an
attribute of the filtered PCA object and
so when we t look at that we can go
ahead and do uh look at the PCA
components this is in our model we built
we've trained it we can run that and you
can see here's the actual components uh
it's the two components have each have
their own
array and within the array you can see
the U what the scores they're using and
these actually give weight to what
features are doing
what so in this numpy Matrix array each
row represents a principal component and
each column relates back to the original
features what's really neat about this
is we can now go in
reverse and drop this onto a heat map
and start seeing uh what this means and
so let me go ahead and just put this
down o so I already got it down
here uh we'll go ahead and put this in
here we're going to use our um DF comp
data frame and we do our PCA
components and I want you to notice how
easy this is uh we're going to set our
columns equal to cancer feature names
that just makes it really easy and we're
dumping it into a data frame what's neat
about a data frame is when we get to
Seaborn it will pull that data frame
apart and uh and set it up for us where
we want and so we're just going to do
the CN the caborn heat map
of our data frame uh composition and
we'll use the plasma
coloring and it creates a nice little
color graph here you can see we have the
mean radius and all the different
features along the bottom on the right
uh we have a scale so we can see we have
the dark colors all the way to the
really light colors which are what's
really shining there this is like the
primary stuff we want to look
at so this heat map in the color bar
basically represent the correlation
between the various features and the
principal component
itself so you know very powerful map to
look at and then you can go in here and
we might notice that the mean radius
look how how on the bottom of the map it
is um on some of this uh so you have
some interesting correlations here that
change the variations on that and what
means what this is more when you get to
uh uh
postribosomal to try to guess as what
these things mean and what you want to
change to get a better result
regularization in machine
learning so our agenda on this one is
fitting the data understanding linear
regression bias and variance what is
overfitting what is underfitting and
those are like the biggest things right
now in data science is overfitting and
underfitting what does that mean and
what is regularization and then we'll do
a quick Hands-On demo to take a look at
this so fitting the data let's start
with fitting the data and we talk about
uh what is data fitting it's a process
of plotting a series of data points and
drawing the best fit line to understand
the relationship between the variables
and this is what we called Data fitting
and you can see here we have a couple of
lines we've drawn on this graph we're
going to go in a little deeper on there
uh so we might have in this case just a
two Dimensions we have an efficiency of
the car and we have the distance
traveled in 1,000
km and so what is data fitting well it's
a linear relationship and a linear
relationship very specifically linear
means line uh the line used to represent
the relationship is a straight line that
passes through the data points and the
variables have linear
relationship linear
regression so let's start with uh how
linear regression Works a linear
regression uh finds the line that best
fits the data point and gives a
relationship between the two
variables and so you can see here we
have the efficiency of the car um versus
the distance traveled and you can see
this nice straight line drawn through
there and when you talk about multiple
variables all you're doing is putting
this instead of a line it now becomes a
plane it gets a little more complicated
with multiple variables but they all
come down to this linear kind of uh
drawing a line through your data and
finding what fits the the data of the
best and so we can consider an example
uh let's say that we want to find the
relationship between the temperature
outside versus the sales of ice cream
and so we start looking at that we're
looking at the how many ice cream cones
we're selling or how much money we sold
in ice cream and we're looking at how
warm it is outside which would hopefully
draw a lot of people into the ice cream
store and suppose we have two lines
we're going to draw L1 and L2 and we're
going to kind of guess which one we
think is the best fit and which claim to
describe the relationship between the
variables and so first we find the
square of the distance between the line
L1 and each data point and add them all
and find the mean
distance and I want you to think about
that when we um uh Square something if
it's a negative or positive number it no
longer matters because a minus 2^2 is 4
2^2 is 4 so we're removing what side of
the line it's on and we're just just
looking for the error in this case the
mean distance of each of the little
dotted lines you see
here this way of calculating the square
of the distance adding them and then
taking the mean is called mean square
error or loss function and we talk about
loss how far off are we that's what
we're really talking about what did we
miss uh and we have a positive distance
and a negative distance and of course
when we Square it it is neither it just
becomes a positive
error and so we take the mean square
error and a lot of times you'll see it
referred to as MSE uh if I look in a
code and I'm going through my python
code and I see msse I know that's a mean
squared error and we take all the dotted
lines and we calculate this error we add
them all together and then we average it
or find the
means and in this case they ran a demo
on this and it was uh 1,1
127.23 uh for our L1 line now we find
the loss function for line L2 in a
similar fashion and we get the mean
square error to be
6,397 and it's computed the same way so
maybe you put this line just way outside
the data range and this is the error you
get by analyzing our results we find
that the loss function or the mean
square error is less for L1 than L2
hence L1 is the best fit
line uh this process describes a lot of
machine learning
processes we're going to keep guessing
and get as close as we can to find the
right answer we have to have some way to
invi to um calculate this and figure out
which one's the best and the mean square
error is one of the better fits to doing
for doing this and most commonly
used we really want to talk about bias
and variance very important terms to
know in machine learning and with linear
regression
so bias bias occurs when an algorithm
has limited flexibility to learn from
data variance defines the algorithm's
sensitivity to specific sets of data
let's start with bias and variance you
can see here we have um the two
different setups uh bias you can think
is very generalized where variance is
very
specific uh and so we talk about bias
such models pay very little attention to
the training data and oversimplify the
model therefore the validation error or
prediction error and training error
follow similar
Trends and uh with bias if you
oversimplify it so much you're going to
miss your um local uh if if you have
like a really good fit you're going to
miss it you're you're going to just kind
of guess what the average is and that's
what your answer is going to
be with variance a model mod with a high
variance pays a lot of attention to
training data and does not generalize
therefore the validation error or
prediction error are far apart from each
other such models always lead to a high
error on training and test data as a
bias does where variance such models
usually perform very well on training
data but have high error rates on test
data and I want you to think about this
um when we're talking about a bias uh
the error is going to be high both when
you're training it and you're testing it
why because we're just kind of getting
an average we're not really fitting it
close with variance we're fitting it so
close that the test data does really
good it's going to nail it every time uh
if you're doing categorical testing
that's a car that's a truck that's a
bicycle um but with variance suddenly a
truck has to have certain features and
it might have to be red uh because you
had so many red pictures so if it has if
it's an 18-wheeler it has to be red if
it's uh blue then it has to be a bicycle
that's a kind of variants we're talking
about where it picks up on something and
it it cannot get the right answer unless
it gets a very specific data and we see
that so that as you're testing it your
models and you programmed it you got to
look for how I trained it what is coming
out and if it's not if it's not looking
good on either bias or or if it's not
looking good on the training or on on
the test data than your bias uh than
your bias in your data if it really
looks good on the training data then
that's going to be your variance you've
overfitted the data and those are very
important things to know when you are
building your models uh in regression of
any kind or any kind of uh setup for
predicting so in dark games if all the
data fall on a particular pointer this
can be considered as a biased throw and
the player aims for the particular
particular score for variance if all the
darts fall on different pointers and no
two darts fall on the same pointer then
this can be considered as a varied throw
and the player aims for various scores
uh again the bias sums everything up in
one point kind of averages it together
where the variance really looks for the
individual uh predictions coming
out so let's go ahead and talk about
overfitting uh when we talk about
overfitting it's a scenario where the
machine learning model tries to learn
from the details along with the noise
and the data tries to fit each data
point on the curve uh you can see that
um if you plug in your coordinates
you're just going to get the whatever is
fited every point on the data stream
there's no average there's no two points
that might have the me know y might have
two different answers because uh if the
wind blows a certain way um and your
efficiency of your car maybe you have a
headwind so your car might alter how
efficient it is as it goes and so
there's going to be this variance on
here and this says no you can't have any
variance what's you know the this is
it's going to be exactly this it can't
be any you can't be the same speed or
the same car and have a slightly
different
efficiency so as the model has very less
flexibility it fails to predict new data
points and thus the model rejects every
new data point during the
prediction uh so you'll get like a
really high error on
here and so uh reasons for overfitting
uh data used for training is not cleaned
and contains noise garbage values in it
you can spend so much time cleaning your
data and it's so important it's so
important that if you have if you have
some kind of something wrong with the
data coming in it needs to be addressed
whether it's a source of the data maybe
they use in medical different measuring
tools uh so you now have to adjust for
data that came in from hospital hit a
versus Hospital b or even off of machine
a and machine B that's testing something
and those those numbers are coming in
wrong the model has a high variance uh
again wind is a good example I was
talking about that with the car you may
have a 100 tests but because the wind's
blowing it's all over the
place uh size of training data used is
not enough so a small amount of data is
going to also cause this problem you
only have a few points and you try to
plot everything the model is too complex
uh this comes up a lot we put too many
pieces together and how they interact
can't even be tracked um and so you have
to go back break it up and find out
actually what correlates and what
doesn't so what is underfitting a
scenario where machine learning models
can neither
learn the relationship between the data
points nor predict or classify a new
data point and you can see here we have
our efficiency of our car and our line
drawn and it's just going to be way off
for both the training and the predicting
data as the model doesn't fully learn
the patterns it accepts every new data
point during the prediction so instead
of looking for a general pattern uh we
just kind of accept
everything data used for training is not
cleaned and contains noise garbage and
values again underfitting and
overfitting same issue you got to clean
your
data the model has a high
bias uh we've seen this in all kinds of
things
from uh the mo the most common is the
driving cars to facial identification or
whatever it is the model itself when
they build it might have a bias towards
one thing and this would be an
underfitted model would have that bias
because it's averaged it out so if you
have um five people from India and 10
people people from um Africa and 20
people from the US you've created a bias
uh because it's looking at the 20 people
and you only have a small amount of data
to work
with size of training data used is not
enough uh that goes with the size I was
just talking about so we have a model
with a high bias we have size of
training data used it's not enough the
model is too
simple again this a one straight line
through all the data when and it need
has a slight shift to it for other
reasons so what is a good fit uh a
linear curve that best fits the data is
neither overfitting or underfitting
models but is just right and of course
we have the nice examples here where we
have overfitting lines going up and down
every Point starting to be include glued
underfitting uh the line really is off
from where the data is and then a good
fit is got to get rid of that minim that
um error coming through regularization
is taking the guesswork out you're
looking at this graph and you're going
oh which one is that really overfit or
is that underfit that's pretty hard to
tell so we talk about
regularization regularization techniques
are used to calibrate the linear
regression models and to minimize the
adjusted loss function and prevent
overfitting or
underfitting so what that means uh in
this case we're going to go ahead and
take a look at a couple different things
we're going to look at regularization
which we'll start with a linear model
we'll look at the Ridge regularization
and the lasso
regularization and these models are just
like uh just like we did the um MLP the
multi-layered positron in the sklearn
module you could bring in the ridge
module and you can bring in the lassle
module so when we talk about um Ridge
regression it modifies the overfitted or
underfitted models by adding the penalty
equivalent to the sum of the squares of
the magnitude of the
coefficients and so we have a cost
function equals loss equals uh Lambda
times the sum of W squared or the
absolute value of w depending on how
you're doing it now remember we talked
about error where we either Square it or
we absolute value it uh because that
removes a plus or minus sign on there
and there's reasons to do it either way
but is more common to square the
value and then we have our uh um in this
case the Lambda is going to be the
penalty for the errors we've thrown in a
Greek character for you just to confuse
everybody and W is the slope of the
curve of the
line so uh we're going to look at this
and we're going to draw a line this is
going to be like a linear regression
model so if you had in sklearn you could
import just a standard linear regression
model uh it would plot this line across
whatever data we're working
on and we look at this and of course
we're just extrapolating this um I know
they use some specific data but don't
want to get into the actual domain and
so for a linear regression line let's
consider two points that are on the
line and we'll go ahead and have a loss
equal zero uh considering the two points
on the line we'll go and do Lambda
equals 1 we'll set our W is going to be
1.4 then the cost function equals 0 + 1
* 1.42 which equal
1.96
uh so really don't get caught up too
much in the math on this other than
understanding um that this is something
that's very easy for a computer to
calculate and if you ever see the loss
plus the plus the Lambda time W the sum
of w
^2 and then let's say we have a ridge uh
regression line and it does this we go
ahead and plot it and we do the
calculations on the data and for the rid
regression let's assume a loss equals
3^2 + 2^ s = .13 so when they put all
the calculations through of the two
points we end up with the 0.0
62 uh so we now had a linear regression
model we now had a ridge regression
model and the ridge regression model
plots a little differently than the
standard linear regression
model and comparing the two models with
all the data points we can see that the
ridge regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression line and I find this true on
a lot of data I work with I'll end up
using either the ridge regression model
or the lasso uh Mars regression model
for fitting um especially dealing with a
lot of like uh stock markets daily um
setup they come out slightly better uh
you get a slightly better um
fit and so we have our lasso we just
talked about lasso coming in
here and the cost function equals uh um
instead of doing a squared we're just
going to do the absolute value and so if
you remember this is where Ridge
regression changes where's my Ridge
regression model uh we're squaring the
value
here and if you look at this we're not
squaring the value we're just finding
the absolute value on here and so the
loss of the of the squared
individuals um and here is
our Lambda symbol again penalty for
errors and W equals the slope of the
curve and comparing the two models with
all the data points we can see that the
lasso regression line fits the model
more accurately than the linear
regression
line and this is like I said I I use
these two models a lot uh the Ridge and
this is important this is this is kind
of the meat of the matter how do you
know which one to use some of it is you
just do it a bunch of times and then you
figure it out uh Ridge regularization is
useful when we have many variables with
relatively smaller data samples the
model does not encourage convergence
towards zero but is likely to make them
closer to zero and prevent
overfitting the Lasser regularization
model is preferred when we are fitting a
linear model with fewer
variables so in the LA in the iris thing
we had four or five variables as they
measured the different Leaf pieces uh
you might be doing the measurements on
the cancer project which has 36
different
variables um so as we get down to the
iris with four variables lassar will
probably uh work pretty good where you
might use the ridge regularization with
more model with if you have something uh
significantly larger and it encourages
the coefficients of the variables to go
toward zero because of the shape of the
constraint which is an absolute
value and with any of this we want to go
ahead and uh do a demo in lasso and
ridge regression so let's take a look
and see what that looks like in our code
and bring up our Jupiter notebook we'll
start with our Imports pandas as PD
import numpy as NP import map plot
Library as PLT um sklearn we're going to
import our data sets it's kind of more
generic um we usually just import one
data set instead of all of them but you
know quick and dirty when you're putting
some of these together uh we have our
sklearn model selection we're going to
import our train test split for
splitting our data up and then we'll
bring in our linear regression
model and we'll go ahead and run these
just to load them up and then load our
data set we're just talking about that
uh you could just um um have imported
the load Boston and Boston data set in
there instead of loading all the data
sets
um and then once we've loaded our data
set we want to go ahead and take a look
at that data and see what we got here
let me just go and pop that down there
and go and run it and so we've gone
ahead and taken our uh Boston uh data
we're going to look we put it into our
pandas data frame um the Boston data set
and then the Boston columns so we want
to see what's going on with them um we
have our Target we have the house price
uh Etc and so our x equals Boston um
iocation now remember in pandas the new
updates to pandas they want iocation if
you're going to pull data we used to be
able to leave this off but it does
something different it creates a slice
versus a direct um setup so make sure
you're using that iocation and the I the
output so this is all just bringing our
data
together and we can see here if we do uh
we print the Boston um Panda's head we
can see here all of our different um
aspects we're looking
for and if you're following the X and
the Y the x is um
everything except for the last column
where Y is uh all the it's that's what
this means all the rows except for the
last column and then Y is all the rows
but just the last column so Y is our
house price and the x is the Crim Zan
industry Chaz Knox and all these other
different um statistics they've
collected for house sales in
Boston there we go oops
control
ah so we'll go ahead and split our data
uh X train and our x uh test YT train y
test equals the train test split which
we imported and we have our Boston um
you could have easily used the X and Y
on here as opposed to Boston um
iocation and we'll create our test size
we're going to take 25% of the data and
put it in as a
test uh and then we'll go ahead and run
this
uh need an extra drink there uh so we
have our train and test and then of
course the print the train data
shape I love doing this kind of thing
whenever I'm working with this data
print out the shape make sure everything
looks correct uh so that we have 127 by
13 and 127 by 1 379 by 13 they should
match and if they're if the the data
sets are not quite matching then you
know something's wrong and you're going
to get all those errors I don't know how
many times I've gone through here and
it's dropped a row on one of them and
not on the other or something weird has
happened when I'm cleaning the data this
is pretty straightforward and simple
because the data comes in a nice
prepackage it's all clean for
you so let's go ahead and apply apply
the multiple linear regression
model and uh we'll call this l r lreg
linear regression and we're going to go
ahead and fit that linear regression
model to X train and Y
train then we'll generate the prediction
on the test Set uh so here's our lre y
predict with our X test going into the
prediction and let's calculate that mean
square error msse I told you you'll see
MSE used a lot um people use it in
variables and things like that it's
pretty common and we get our mean
squared error equals uh this is just the
basic formula we've already been talking
about what's the difference squared
uh then we look for the average of that
we'll go ahead and just run
this and you can see when we get through
the end of this we have our mean square
error on
test we have our total and then we have
each column coming
down and at this point unless you really
know the data you're working with it's
not going to mean a whole lot so if it's
in your domain you might be know what
you're looking at when you see see these
kinds of numbers coming up uh but if
it's not it's just a bunch of numbers
and that's okay at least that's okay for
this demo uh and then we're going to go
ahead and plot these so we can see
what's going on and this is always kind
of fun it's always nice to have a nice
visual of what you're looking at and you
can see here um when we plot the
coefficient scores on here and we the
guys in the back did a great job putting
some pretty colors together making it
look nice and setting up the
columns you can see here
uh your nox has like just a huge
coefficient um when I look at a table
like this I look for what has very
little um different coefficients they're
not using a huge change and what has
huge changes and that Flags you for all
kinds of things as you're working with
the data but it depends so much on the
domain you're working
with these are great things though as a
just a quick look to see what's going on
with your data and what you're looking
for and of course once we look at this
now our motive is to reduce the
coefficient score so now we want to take
these and and uh bring them down as much
as we can and for that we're going to
work with the ridge regression on here
so let's start by going ahead and we're
going to import our Ridge model the rid
regression from the SK learn library or
the
pyit and we're going to go ahead and
train the model so here's our Ridge R
equals Alpha equals 1 and I mentioned
that earlier um when I work with the
ridge model you'll see Alpha equals 1 if
you set Alpha equal to zero that's a
standard linear regression model so you
have Alpha equals 1 2 3 4 and you
usually use 1 2 or 3 four and a standard
integer on there and we'll go ahead and
fit the ridge model on there with our X
train and our YT train data generate a
prediction for that um for our X test
and we'll calculate the mean square
error uh just like we did before this
should all look
familiar and and we'll go ahead and
print that out and we'll look at the uh
Ridge coefficients for our data and see
what that looks
like now if I jump up and down between
these
two you'll get a headache
uh you'll still see the nox value let's
just look at the nox because that was
the biggest value it's a minus 9 here
and if we go back up here the nox value
is a minus 18 so right off the bat I'm
seeing a huge change
um in the biggest coefficient
there uh so if we're going to do that
nice setup we want to go ahead and just
print it and see what that looks
like here we go and we've uh set up our
um plot subplots and again the team put
together some nice colors so it makes it
look good we're doing an xar based on
the
columns and our um regress coefficients
color equals color X spine bottom and so
forth uh so just puts together a nice
little
graph and you're starting to see uh one
this when you compare this if you put on
the same graph as this one up here this
is up here at minus 18 this is at minus
9 and so this graph is half the size of
the graph above uh the same thing with
these values here they might look the
same but they're actually all um almost
half the value on
here and then finally you can do the
same thing for the lasso
regression this it all look uh very
similar as far as what we worked on
before and I'm just going to ahead and
print that on here and run it and again
let's go up to uh KNX look where KNX is
it's all the way down to zero and if we
look at our next biggest coefficient is
minus8 and really here's our
22.73 we go up
here um
16.7 and we go up here and we look at
the same number uh
16.69% 69 is better than 78 uh so from
the very beginning we might start
looking at this first model for
overall
predicting but there's other factors
involved uh we might know that uh the
knocked value is Central and the other
ones aren't quite as good and so we
might start looking at just certain
setups like what is our what is this
particular coefficient because it might
have a certain meaning to us and so
forth and so you got look at all those
different thing um items in there again
but the bottom dollar is our first model
did better than our other two models our
mean square error on the test set um
continues to come down on this we're
going to cover reinforcement learning
today and what's in it for you we'll
start with why reinforcement learning
we'll look at what is reinforcement
learning we'll see what the different
kinds of learning strategies are that
are being used today in computer models
under supervised versus unsupervised
versus
reinforcement we'll cover important
terms specific to reinforcement learning
we'll talk about markov's decision
process and we'll take a look at a
reinforcement learning example well
we'll teach a tic-tac-toe how to play
why reinforcement learning training a
machine learning model requires a lot of
data which might not always be available
to us further the data provided might
not be reliable learning from a small
subset of actions will not help expand
the vast realm of Sol solutions that may
work for a particular problem and you
can see here we have the robot learning
to walk um very complicated setup when
you're learning how to walk and you'll
start asking questions like if I'm
taking one step forward and left what
happens if I pick up a 50 pound object
how does that change how a robot would
walk these things are very difficult to
program because there's no actual
information on it until the it's
actually tried out learning from a small
subset of actions will not help expand
the vast realm of solutions that may
work for a particular
problem and we'll see here it learned
how to walk this is going to slow the
growth that technology is capable of
machines need to learn to perform
actions by themselves and not just learn
off
humans and you see the objective climb a
mountain real interesting point here is
that as human beings we can go into a
very unknown environment and we can
adjust for it and kind of explore FL and
play with it most of the models the
non-reinforcement models in computer um
machine learning aren't able to do that
very well uh there's a couple of them
that can be used or integrated to see
how it goes is what we're talking about
with reinforcement learning so what is
reinforcement learning reinforcement
learning is a subbranch of machine
learning that trains me modeled to
return an Optimum solution for a problem
by taking a sequence of decisions by
itself consider a robot learning to go
from one place to another the robot is
given a scenario and must arrive at a
solution by itself the robot can take
different paths to reach the
destination it will know the best path
by the time taken on each path and might
even come up with a unique solution all
by itself and that's really important is
we're looking for Unique Solutions uh we
want the best solution but you can't
find it unless you try it so we're
looking at uh our different systems or
different model we have supervised
versus unsupervised versus reinforcement
learning and with the supervised
learning that is probably the most
controlled environment uh we have a lot
of different supervised learning models
whether it's linear regression neural
networks um there's all kinds of things
in between decision trees the data
provided is labeled data with output
values specified and this is important
because when we talk about supervised
learning you already know the answer for
all this information you already know
the picture has a motorcycle in it so
you're supervised learning you already
know that um the outcome for tomorrow
for you know going back a week you're
looking at stock you can already have
like the graph of what the next day
looks like so you have an answer for
it and you have labeled data which is
used you have an external supervision
and solves Problems by mapping labeled
input to know one output so very
controlled unsupervised learning and
unsupervised learning is really
interesting because this now taking part
in many other models they start with an
you can actually insert an unsupervised
learning model um in almost either
supervised or reinforcement learning as
part of the system which is really cool
uh data provided is unlabeled data the
outputs are not specified machine makes
its own predictions used to solve
association with clustering problems
unlabeled data is used no supervision
solves Problems by understanding
patterns and discovering output
uh so you can look at this and you can
think um some of these things go with
each other they belong together so it's
looking for what connects in different
ways and there's a lot of different
algorithms that look at this um when you
start getting into those there's some
really cool images that come up of what
unsupervised learning is how it can pick
out say uh the area of a donut one model
will see the area of the dut and the
other one will divide it into three
sections based on its location versus
what's next to it so there's a lot of
stuff that goes in with unsupervised
learning and then we're looking at
reinforcement learning probably the
biggest industry in today's market uh in
machine learning or growing Market it's
very it's very infant stage uh as far as
how it works and what it's going to be
capable of the machine learns from its
environment using rewards and errors
used to solve reward-based problems no
predefined data is used no supervision
follows Trail and error problem solving
approach
uh so again we have a random at first
you start with a random I try this it
works and this is my reward doesn't work
very well maybe or maybe it doesn't even
get you where you're trying to get it to
do and you get your reward back and then
it looks at that and says well let's try
something else and it starts to play
with these different things finding the
best route so let's take a look at
important terms in today's reinforcement
model and this has become pretty
standardized over the last uh few years
so these are really good to know we have
the agent uh agent is the model that is
being trained via reinforcement learning
so this is your actual uh entity that
has however you're doing it whether
you're using a neural network or a q
table or whatever combination thereof
this is the actual agent that you're
using this is the
model and you have your environment uh
the training situation that the model
must optimized to is called its
environment uh and you can see here I
guess we have a robot who's trying to
get uh chest full gyms or whatever and
that's the output and then you have your
action this is all possible steps that
can be taken by the model and it picks
one action and you can see here it's
picked three different uh routes to get
to the chest of diamonds and
gems we have a state the current
position condition returned by the
model and you could look at this uh if
you're playing like a video game this is
the screen you're looking at uh so when
you go back here uh the environment is a
whole game board so if you're playing
one of those mobus games you might have
the whole game board going on uh but
then you have your current position
where are you on that game board what's
around that what's around you um if you
were talking about a robot the
environment might be moving around the
yard where it is in the yard and what it
can see what input it has in that
location that would be the current
position condition return by the model
and then the reward uh to help the model
move in the right direction it is
rewarded points are given to it to
appraise some kind of action so y you
did good or if uh didn't do as good
trying to maximize the reward and have
the best reward
possible and then policy policy
determines how an agent will behave at
any time it acts as a mapping between
action and present State this is part of
the model what what is your action that
you're you're going to take what's the
policy you're using to have an output
from your agent one of of the reasons
they separate uh policy as its own
entity is that you usually have a
prediction um of a different options and
then the policy well how am I going to
pick the best based on those predictions
I'm going to guess at different options
and we'll actually weigh those options
in and find the best option we think
will work uh so it's a little tricky but
the policy thing is actually pretty cool
how it works let's go Ahad and take a
look at a reinforcement learning example
and just in looking at this we're going
to take a look uh consider what a dog um
that we want to train uh so the dog
would be like the agent so you have your
your puppy or whatever uh and then your
environment is going to be the whole
house or whatever it is where you're
training them and then you have an
action we want to teach the dog to
fetch so action equals fetching uh and
then we have a little biscuit so we can
get the dog to perform various actions
by offering incentives such as a dog
biscuit as a
reward the dog will follow a policy to
maximize this reward and hence will
follow every command and might even
learn new actions like begging by itself
uh so you have B you know so we start
off with fetching it goes oh I get a
biscuit for that it tries something else
and you get a handshake or begging or
something like that and it goes oh this
is also reward-based and so it kind of
explores things to find out what will
bring it as biscuit and that's very much
like how a reinforced model goes is it
uh looks for different rewards how do I
find can I try different things and find
a reward that
works the dog also will want to run
around and play and explorers
environment uh this quality of model is
called exploration so there's a little
Randomness going on in
Exploration and explores new parts of
the house climbing on the sofa doesn't
get a reward in fact it usually gets
kicked off the
sofa so let's talk a little bit about
markov's decision process uh markov's
decision process is a reinforcement
learning policy used to map a current
state to an action where the agent
continuously interacts with the
environment to produce new Solutions and
receive rewards and you'll see here's
all of our different uh uh vocabulary we
just went over we have a reward our
state our agent our environment inter
our action and so even though the
environment kind of contains everything
um that you you really when you're
actually writing the program your
environment's going to put out a reward
in state that goes into the agent uh the
agent then looks at this uh state or it
looks at the reward usually um first and
it says okay I got rewarded for whatever
I just did or didn't get rewarded and
then it looks at the state then it comes
back and if you remember from policy the
policy comes in um and then we have a
reward the policy is that part that's
connected at the bottom and so it looks
at that policy it says hey what's a good
action that will probably be similar to
what I did or um sometimes they're
completely random but what's a good
action that's going to bring me a
different
reward so taking the time to just
understand these different pieces as
they go is pretty important in most of
the models today um and so a lot of them
actually have templates based on this
you can pull in and start using um
pretty straightforward as far far as
once you start seeing how it works uh
you can see your environment send says
hey this is the agent did this if you're
a character in a game this happened and
it shoots out a reward in a state the
agent looks at the reward looks at the
new state and then takes a little guess
and says I'm going to try this action
and then that action goes back into the
environment it affects the environment
the environment then changes depending
on what the action was and then it has a
new state and a new reward that goes
back to the agent
so in the diagram shown we need to find
the shortest path between node A and D
each path has a reward associated with
it and the path with the maximum reward
is what we want to choose the nodes AB c
d denote the nodes to travel from node
uh A to B is an action reward is the
cost of each path and policy is each
path
taken and you can see here a can go uh
to b or a can go to C right off the bat
or it can go right to D and if you
explored all three of these uh you would
find that a going to D was a zero reward
um a going to C and D would generate a
different reward or you could go AC b d
there's a lot of options here um and so
when we start looking at this diagram
you start to
realize that even though uh today's
reinforced learning models do really
good uh um finding an answer they end up
trying almost all the different
directions you see and so they take up a
lot of work uh or a lot of processing
time for reinforcement learning they're
right now in their infant stage and
they're really good at solving simple
problems and we'll take a look at one of
those in just a minute in a tic tac toe
game uh but you can see here uh once
it's gone through these and it's
explored it's going to find the
ACD is the best reward it gets a full 30
points for it so let's go ahead and take
a look at a reinforcement learning
demo uh in this demo we're going to use
reinforcement learning to make a tic tac
toe game you'll be playing this game
Against the Machine learning
model and we'll go ahead and we're doing
it in Python so let's go ahead and go
through um I always uh not always
actually have a lot of python tools
let's go through um Anaconda which will
open up a Jupiter notebook seems like a
lot of steps but it's worth it to keep
all my stuff separate and it's also has
a nice display when you're in the
Jupiter notebook for doing
python so here's our Anaconda Navigator
I open up the notebook which is going to
take me to a web page and I've gone in
here and created a new uh python folder
and this case I've already done it and
enabled it to change the name to
tic-tac-toe uh and then for this example
uh we're going to go ahead
and import a couple things we're going
to um import numpy as NP we'll go ahead
and import pickle numpy of course is our
number array and then pickle is just a
nice way sometimes for storing uh
different information uh different
states that we're going to go through on
here uh and so we're going to create a
class called State we're going to start
with
that and there's a lot of lines of code
to this uh class that we're going to put
in here don't let that scare you too
much there's not as much here um it
looks like there's going to be a lot
here but there really is just a lot of
setup going on in the in our class date
and so we have up here we're going to
initialize it um we have we have our
board um it's a tic teac toe board so
we're only dealing with nine spots on
the board uh we have player one player
two uh is in we're going create a board
hash uh we'll look at that in just a
minute we're just going to stir some
information in there symbol of player
equals one um so there's a few things
going on as far as the
initialization uh then something simple
we're just going to get the hash um of
the board we're GNA get the information
from the board on there which is columns
and rows we want to know when a winner
occurs uh so if you get three in a row
that's what this whole section here is
for uh me go ahead and scroll up a
little bit and you can get a copy of
this code if you send a note over to
Simply learn we'll send you over um this
particular file and you can play with it
yourself and see how it's put together I
don't want to spend a huge amount of
time on this uh because this is just
some real General python coding
uh but you can see here we're just going
through um all the rows and you add them
together and if it equals three three in
a row same thing with
columns um diagonal so you got to check
the diagonal that's what all this stuff
does here is it just goes through the
different areas actually let me go ahead
and
put there we
go um and then it comes down here and we
do our sum and it says true uh minus
three just says did somebody win or is
it a tie so you got to add up all the
numbers on there anyway just in case
they're all filled up and next we also
need to know available positions um
these are ones that don't no one's ever
used before this way when you try
something or the computer tries
something uh it's not going to give it
an illegal move that's what the
available positions is doing uh then we
want to update our state and so you have
your position going in we're just
sending in the position that you just
chose and you'll see there's a little
user interface we put in there you can p
pick the row and column in
there and again I mean this is a lot of
code uh so really it's kind of a thing
you'd want to go through and play with a
little bit and just read through it get
a copy of it uh great way to understand
how this works and here is a given
reward um so we're going to give a
reward result equals self winner this is
one of the hearts of what's going on
here uh is we have a result self. winner
so if there's a winner then we have a
result if the result equals one here's
our
feedback uh if it doesn't equal one then
it gets a zero so it only gets a reward
in this particular case if it
wins and that's important to know
because different uh systems of
reinforced learning do rewarding a lot
differently depending on what you're
trying to do this is a very simple
example with a a 3X3 board imagine if
you're playing a video game uh certainly
you only have so many actions but your
environment is huge you have a lot going
on in the environment and suddenly a
reward system like this is going to be
just um it's going to have to change a
little bit it's going to have to have
different rewards and different setup
and there's all kinds of advanced ways
to do that as far as weighing you add
weights to it and so they can add the
weights up depending on where the reward
comes in so it might be that you
actually get a reward in this case
you get the reward at the end of the
game and I'm spending just a little bit
of time on this because this is an
important thing to note but there's
different ways to add up those rewards
it might have like if you take a certain
path um the first reward is going to be
weighed a little bit less than the last
reward because the last reward is
actually winning the game or scoring or
whatever it is so this reward system
gets really complicated on some of the
more advanced uh
setups um in this case though you can
see right here that they give a um a 0.1
and a 0. five
reward um just for getting a picking the
right value and something that's
actually valid instead of picking an
invalid value so rewards again that's
like key it's huge how do you feed the
rewards back in uh then we have a board
reset that's pretty straightforward it
just goes back and resets the board to
the beginning cuz it's going to try out
all these different things while it's
learning it's going to do it by trial
and error so you have to keep resetting
it
and then of course there's the play we
want to go ahead and play uh rounds
equals 100 depends on what you want to
do on here um you can set this different
you obviously set that to higher level
but this is just going to go through and
you'll see in here uh that we have
player one and player two this is this
is the computer playing itself uh one of
the more powerful ways to learn to play
a game or even learn something that
isn't a game is to have two of these
models that are basically trying to beat
each other and so they they keep finding
explore new things this one works for
this one so this one tries new things it
beats this we've seen this in um chess I
think was a big one where they had the
two players in chess with reinforcement
learning uh was one of the ways they
train one of the top um computer chess
playing
algorithms uh so this is just what this
is it's going to choose an action it's
going to try something and the more it
tries stuff
um the more we're going to record the
hash we actually have a board hash where
they self get the hash setup on here
where it stores all the
information and then once you get to a
win one of them wins it gets the reward
uh then we go back and reset and try
again and then kind of the fun part we
actually get down here is uh we're going
to play with a human so we'll get a
chance to come in here and see what that
looks like when you put your own
information in and then it just comes in
here does the same thing it did above it
gives it a reward for its things um or
sees if it wins or ties um looks at
available positions all that kind of fun
stuff and then finally we want to show
the board uh so it's going to print the
board out each
time really um as an integration is not
that exciting what's exciting uh in here
is one looking at this reward system
whoops Play One More up the reward
system is really the heart of this how
do you reward the different uh setup
and the other one is when it's playing
it's got to take an action and so what
it chooses for an action is also the
heart of reinforcement learning how do
we choose that action and those are
really key to right now where
reinforcement learning is um in today's
uh technology is uh figuring this out
how do we reward it and how do we guess
the next best action so so we have our
uh environment and you can see the
environment is we're going to be or the
state uh which is kind of like what's
going on we're going to return the state
depending on what happens and we want to
go ahead and create our agent uh in this
CL our player so each one is go and grab
that and so we look at a class player
um this is where a lot of the magic is
really going on is what how is this
player figuring out how to maneuver
around the board and then the board of
course returns a State uh that it can
look at and a reward uh so we want to
take a look at this we have uh name uh
self State this is class player and when
you say class player we're not talking
about a human player we're talking about
um just a uh the computer players and
this is kind of interesting so remember
I told you depending on what you're
doing there's going to be a Decay gamma
um explore rate uh these are what I'm
talking about is how do we train it um
as you try different moves it getss to
the end the first move is important but
it's not as important as the last one
and so you could say that the last one
has the heaviest weight and then as you
as you get there the first one let's see
the first move gives you a five reward
the second gives you a two reward and
the third one gives you a 10 reward
because that's the final ending you got
it the 10's going to count more than the
first step uh and here's our uh we're
going to you know get the board
information coming in in and then choose
an action this was the second part that
I was talking about that was so
important uh so once you have your
training going on we have to do a little
Randomness and you can see right here is
our NP random um uniform so it's picking
out a random number take a random action
this is going to just pick which row and
which column it is um and so choosing
the action this one you can see we're
just doing random States uh Choice
length of position action position and
then it skips in there and takes a look
at the board uh for p in positions you
get it's actually storing the different
boards each time you go through so it it
has a record of what it did so it can
properly weigh the values and this
simply just depins a hash date what's
the last date Pinn it to the uh um to
our states on here here's our
feedback reward so the reward comes in
and it's going to take a look at this
and say is it none uh what is the reward
and here is that formula remember I was
telling you about up here um that was
important because it has Decay gamma
times the reward this is where as it
goes through each step and this is
really important this is this is kind of
the heart of this of what I was talking
about earlier uh you have step
one and this might have a reward of two
you have step two I should probably
should have done ABC this has AEP step
three uh step
four so on till you get to step in and
this might have a reward of
10 uh so reward of
10 we're going to add that but we're not
adding uh let's say this one right here
uh let's say this reward here right
before 10 was um let's say it's also 10
that just makes the the math easy so we
had 10 and 10 we had 10 this is 10 and
10 in whatever it is but it's time it's
0.9 uh so instead of putting a full 10
here we only do nine that's a 0.9
times
10 and so this
formula um as far as the Decay times the
reward minus the cell State value uh it
basically adds in it says here's one or
here's two I'm sorry I should have done
this ABC would have been easier uh so
the first move goes in here and it puts
two in
here uh then we have our self uh setup
on here you can see how this gets pretty
complicated in the math but this is
really the key is how do we train our
states and we want the the final State
the win to get the most points if you
win you get most points uh and the first
step gets the least amount of points so
you're really training this almost in
reverse you're training you're training
it from the last place where you have
like it says okay this is now where I
where need to sum up my rewards and I
want to sum them up going in reverse and
I want to find the answer in Reverse
kind of an interesting uh uh play on the
mind when you're trying to figure this
stuff
out and of course we want to go ahead
and reset the board down here uh and
save the policy load
policy these are the different things
that are going in between the agent and
the state to figure out what's going on
let's go ahead and load that that up and
then finally we want to go ahead and
create a human
player and the human player is going to
be a little different uh in that uh you
choose an action row and column here's
your action uh if action is if action in
positions meaning positions that are
available uh you return the action if
not it just keeps asking you until you
get the action that actually works and
then we're going to go ahead head and
appin to the hash state which uh we
don't need to worry about because it
Returns the action up
here and feed forward uh again this is
because it's a
human um at the end of the game bat
propagate and update State values this
part isn't being done because it's not
programming uh the model uh the model is
getting its own rewards so we've gone
ahead and loaded this in here uh so
here's all our pieces and the first
thing we want to do
is set up uh P1 player one uh P2 player
two and then we're going to send our
players to our state so now it has P1 P2
and it's going to play and it's going to
play 50,000 rounds now we can probably
do a lot less than this and it's not
going to get the full results in fact
you know what uh let's go ahead and just
do five um just to play with it because
I want to show you something
here oops somewhere in there I forgot to
load
something there we go I must have start
forgot to run this
run oops forgot a reference there for
the board rows and columns
3x3 um there is actually in the state it
references that we just tack it on on
the end it was supposed to be at the
beginning uh so now I've only set this
up with um see where are we going here
I've only set this up to train
five times and the reason I did that is
we're going to uh come in and actually
play it and then I'm going to change
that and we can see how it differs on
there there we go and I didn't make it
through a run and we're going to go
ahead and save the
policy um so now we have our player one
and our player two policy uh the way we
set it up it has two separate policies
loaded up in
there and then we're going to come in
here and we're going to do uh player one
is going to be the computer experience
rate zero load policy one human player
human and we're going to go ahead and
play this and I remember I only went
through it um uh just one round of
training in fact minimal training and so
it puts an X there and I'm going to go
ahead and do row zero column one you can
see this is very uh basic on here and so
I put in my zero and then I'm going to
go zero block it see 0 0 and you can see
right here it let me win uh just like
that I was able to win
zero two and woo human winds so I only
trained it five times we're going to run
this again and this time uh instead of
five let's do 5,000 or 50,000 I think
that's what the guys in the back had and
this takes a while to train it this is
where where reinforcement learning
really falls apart look how simple this
game is we're talking about uh 3x3 set
of
columns and so for me to train it on
this um I could do a q table which would
take which would go much quicker um you
could build a quick Q table with almost
all the different options on there and
uh you would probably get a the same
result much quicker we're just using
this as an example so when we look at
reinforcement learning you need to be
very careful what you apply it to it
sounds like a good deal until you do
like a large neural network where you're
doing um you set the neural network to a
learning increment of one so every time
it goes through it
learns and then you do your action so
you pick from the learning uh setup and
you actually try actions on the learning
setup until you get the what you think
is going to be the best action so you
actually feed what you think is right
back through the neural net networ
there's a whole layer there which is
really fun to play
with and then it has an output well
think of all those processes I mean that
is just a huge amount of work it's going
to do uh let's go ahead and Skip ahead
here give it a moment it's going to take
a a minute or two to go ahead and
run now to train it uh we went ahead and
let it run and it took a while this this
took um I got a pretty powerful
processor and it took about 5 minutes
plus to run it and we'll go ahead and
uh run our player setup on here oops I
brought in the last whoops I brought in
the last round so give me just a moment
to redo the policy save there we go I
forgot to save the policy back in
there and then go ahead and run our
player again so we we've saved the
policy and then we want to go ahead and
load the policy for P1 as the computer
and we can see the computer's gone in
the bottom right corner I'm going to go
ahead and go uh one one which is the
center and it's gone right up the top
and if you have ever played Tic Tac Toe
you know the computer has me uh but
we'll go ahead and play it out row zero
column
two there it is and then it's gone here
and so I'm going to go ahead and go row
01 two no 01 there we go and column zero
that's where I wanted oh and it says I
okay you your action there we go boom uh
so you can see here we've got a didn't
catch the win on this it said Tai um
kind of funny they didn't catch the win
on
there but if we play this a bunch of
times you'll find it's going to win more
and more the more we train it the more
the reinforcement
happens this lengthy training process uh
is really the stopper on reinforcement
learning as this changes reinforcement
learning will be of the more powerful uh
packages evolving over the next decade
or two in fact I would even go as far as
to say it is the most important uh
machine learning tool and artificial
intelligence tool out there as it learns
not only a simple Tic Tac Toe board but
we start learning environments and the
environment would be like in language if
you're translating a language or
something from one language to the other
so much of it is lost if you don't know
the context it's in what's the
environments it's in and so being able
to attach environment and context and
all those things together is going to
require reinforcement learning to
do so again if you want to get a copy of
the Tic Tac Toe board it's kind of fun
to play with uh run it you can test it
out you can do U you know test it for
different uh uh values you can switch
from P1
computer uh where we loaded the policy
one to load the policy 2 and just see
how it varies there's all kinds of
things you can do on there so what is Q
learning Q learning is reinforcement
learning policy which will fill the next
best action given a current state it
chooses this action at random and aims
to maximize the reward and so you can
see here's our standard reinforcement
learning graph um by now if you're doing
any reinforcement learning you should be
familiar with this where you have your
agent your agent takes an action the
action affects the environment and then
the environment sends back the reward or
the feedback and the state it's the new
state the agents in where is it at on
the chessboard where is it at in the
video game um if your robots out there
picking trash up off the side of the
road where is it at on the road consider
an ad recommendation system usually when
you look up a product
online you get ads which will suggest
the same product over and over
again using Q learning we can make an ad
recommendation system which will suggest
related products to our previous
purchase the reward will be if user
click clicks on the suggested
product and again you can see um you
might have a lot of products on uh your
web advertisement or your pages but it's
still not a float number it's still a
set number and that's something to be
aware of when you're using Q learning
and you can see here that if you have a
100 people clicking on ads and you click
on one of the ads it might go in there
and say okay this person clicked on this
ad what is the best set of ads based on
clicking on this ad or these two ads
afterwards based on where they are
browsing so let's go a and take a look
at some important terms when we talk
about Q learning uh we have States the
state s represents the current position
of an agent in an
environment um the action the action a
is the step taken by the agent when it
is particular State rewards for every
action the agent will get a positive or
negative
[Music]
reward and again uh when we talk about
States we're usually not with you're
using a q table you're not usually
talking about float variables you're
talking about true false uh and we'll
take a closer look at that in a second
and episodes when an agent ends up in a
terminating State and can't take a new
action uh this might be if you're
playing a video game your character
stepped in and is now dead or whatever
uh Q values used to determine how good
an action a taken at a particular State
s is q a of s and temporal difference a
formula used to find the Q value by
using the value of the current state and
action and previous state and action and
very I mean there's bellman's equation
which basically is the equation that
kind of uh covers what we just looked at
in all those different terms the Bellman
equation is used to determine the values
of a particular State and deduce how
good it is to be in take that state the
optimal the optimal state will give us
the highest op optimal value Factor
influencing Q values the current state
and action that's your essay so your
current state and your
action uh then you have your previous
date in action which is your s um I
guess Prime I'm not sure how they how
they reference that S Prime a prime so
this is what happened before uh then you
have a reward for Action so you have
your R reward and you have your maximum
expected future
reward and you can see there's also a
learning rate put in there and a
discount rate uh so we're looking at
these just like any other model we don't
want to have an absolute um final value
on here we don't want it to if you do
absolute values instead of taking
smaller steps you don't really have that
approach to the solution you just have
it jump and then pretty soon if you jump
one solution out that's what's going to
be the new solution whichever one jumps
up really high first um kind of ruining
the whole idea of doing a random
selection and I'll go into the random
selection in just a second steps in Q
learning step one create an initial Q
table with all values initialized to
zero again we're looking at 0o one uh so
are you you know here's our action we
start we're an idol we took a wrong
action we took a correct action and int
and then we have our um actions fetching
sitting and running and of course we're
just using the dog example and choose an
action and perform it update values in
the table and of course when we're
choosing an action we're going to kind
of do something random and just randomly
pick one so you start out and you sit
and you have then a um then depending on
that um um action you took you can now
update the value for sitting after you
start from start to
sitting get the value of the reward and
calculate the Val the value Q value
using the Bell Mini equation and so now
we attach a reward to
sitting and when we attach all those
rewards we continue the same until the
table's filled with or an episode
ends and and my IM I was going to come
back to the random side of this and
there's a few different formulas they
use for the random um setup to pick it I
usually let whatever Q model I'm using
do their standard one because someone's
usually gone in and done the math uh for
the optimal uh spread uh but you can
look at this if I I have running has a
reward of 10 sitting has a reward of
seven fetching has a reward of five um
just kind of without doing like a a a
means you know using the bell curve for
the means value and like I said there's
some math you can put in there to pick
um so that you're more like so that
running has even a higher chance um but
even if you were just going to do an
average on this you could do an average
a random number by adding them all
together uh so you get 10 plus 7 plus 5
is 22 you could do 0 to 22 and or 0 to
21 but 1 to 22 one to five would be
fetching uh and so forth you know the
last 10 so you can just look at this as
what percentage are you going to go for
that particular
option um and then that gets your random
setup in there and then as you slowly
increment these up uh you see that uh um
if you're idle um where's one here we go
sitting at the end if you're at the end
of wherever you're you're at sitting
gets a reward of one um where's the good
one on here oh wrong action running for
a wrong action gets almost no reward so
that becomes very very less likely to
happen but it still might happen it
still might have a percentage of coming
up and that's where the random
programming and Q learning comes in the
below table gives us an idea of how many
times an action has been taken and how
positively correct action or negatively
wrong action it is going to affect the
next state so let's ahead and dive in
and pull up a little piece of code and
see what this looks like um in
Python uh in this demo we will use Q
learning to find the shortest path
between two given points if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scaleup by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more if
you seen my videos before um I like to
do it in the uh Anaconda Jupiter
notebook book um setup just because it's
really easy to see and it's a nice demo
uh and so here's my anaconda this one
I'm actually using uh python 36
environment that I set up in here and
we'll go ahead and launch the Jupiter
Notebook on this and once we're in our
Jupiter notebook uh which has the kernel
loaded with Python 3 we'll go ahead and
create a new Python 3 uh folder in
here and we'll call this uh
Q learn in and to start this
demo let's go ahead and import our numpy
array we'll just run that so it's import
it and like a lot of these uh model
programs when you're building them you
spend a lot of time putting it all
together um and then you end up with
this really short answer at the
end uh and we'll we'll take a look at
that as we come into it so we we go
ahead and start with our location to
State uh so we have um L1 L2 these are
are nine locations 1 to nine and then of
course the state is going to be 0 1 2 3
4 it's just a mapping of our location to
a integer on there and then we have our
actions our actions are simply uh moving
from um One
location to another so I can go to I can
go to location zero I can go to location
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 uh so these are my
actions I can choose these are the
locations of our
state
and if you remember earlier I mentioned
uh um that the limitation is that you
you don't want to put in um a
continually growing table because you
can actually create a dynamic Q table
where you continually add in new values
as they
arise because um if you have float
values this just becomes infinite and
then your memory in your computer's gone
or you know does it's not going to work
at the same time you might think well
that kind of really limits the the Q uh
T learning setup but there are ways to
use it in conjunction with other systems
and so you might look
at uh well I do um been doing some work
in stock um and one of the questions
that comes out is to buy or sell the
stock and the state coming in might be
um you might take it create what called
buckets um where anything that you
predict is going to
return more than a certain amount of
money um the error for that stock that
you've had in the past you put those in
buckets and suddenly as you start
putting the creating these buckets you
realize you do have a limited amount of
information coming in you no longer have
a float number you now have um bucket
one two three and four and then you can
take those buckets put them through a a
q learning table and come up with the
best action which stock should I buy
it's like gambling stock is is pretty
much gambling if you're doing day
trading you're not doing long-term um
Investments and so you can start looking
at it like that a lot of the um current
feeds say that the best algorithms used
for day Traders where you're doing it on
your own is really to ask the question
do I want to trade the stock yes or no
and now you have it in a q learning
table and now you can take it to that
next level and you can see where that
can be a really powerful tool at the end
of doing a basic linear regression model
or something uh what is the best
investment and you start getting the
best reward on
there uh and so if we're going to have
rewards these rewards we just create um
it says uh if basically if you're uh
this should match our Q table because
it's going to be uh you have your state
and you have your action across the top
if you remember from the dog and so we
have whatever state we're in going down
and then the next action and what the
reward is for it um and of course if you
were actually doing a a um something
more connected your reward would be
based on um the actual environment it's
in and then we want to go ahead and
create a state to location uh so we can
map the indexes so just like we defined
our rewards uh we're going to go and do
state to location um and you can see
here it's a a dictionary setup for
location State and location to state
with
items and we also need to um
Define what we want for learning rates
uh you remember we had our two different
rates um as far as like learning from
the past and learning from the current
so we'll go ahead and set those to uh 75
and the alpha set to 0.9 and we'll see
that when we do the formula and of
course any of this code uh send a note
to our simply learn team they'll get you
a copy of this code on here let's go
ahead and
pull there we go
the new next two
sections um since we're going to keep it
short and
sweet here we go so let's go ahead and
create our agent um so our agent is
going to have our initialization where
we sended all the information uh we'll
Define our s gamma equals gamma we could
have just set the gamma rate down here
instead of uh submitting it it's kind of
nice to keep them separate because you
can play with these numbers uh our self
Alpha
um then we have our location State we'll
set that in here uh we have our choice
of actions um we're going to go ahead
and just embed the rewards right into
the agent so obviously this would be
coming from somewhere else uh instead of
from uh self-generated and then a self
state to location equals our state to
location uh dictionary and we go ahead
and create a q learning table and I went
ahead and just set the Q learning table
up to um uh 0 to zero what what what the
setup is uh location to State how many
of them are there uh this just creates
an array of zero to zero setup on
there and then the big part is the
training we have our rewards new equals
a copy of self.
rewards ending State equals the self
location state in location so this is
whatever we end up at rewards new equals
ending State plus ending State equals
999 just kind of goes to a dead end and
we start going through
iterations and we'll go ahead um let's
do this uh so this we're going to come
back and we're going to call call it on
here uh let me just erase that switch it
to an
arrow there we go uh so what we're doing
is we're going to send in here to train
it we're going to say hey um I want to
iterate through this a thousand times
and see what happens now this part would
actually be instead of iterating you
might have your external environment and
they're going back and forth and you
iterate through outside of here uh but
just for ease of use our agent's going
to come in here and iterate through this
sometimes I'll put this iteration in
here and I'll have it call the
environment and say hey this is what I
did what's the next state and the
environment does its thing right in here
as I iterate through
it uh and then we want to go ahead and
pick a random state to start with that's
what's going on here you have to start
somewhere um and then you have your
playable actions we're going to start
with just an empty thing for playable
actions and we'll fill that up so that's
what choices I have and so we're going
to iterate through the rewards Matrix to
get the states uh directly reachable
from the randomly chosen current state
assign those states to a list named
playable
actions and so you can see here we have
uh range nine I usually use length of
whatever I'm looking at which is our
locations or States as they are uh we
have a reward so we want to look at the
current the rewards uh the new
reward is our uh is in our chart here of
rewards underscore new uh current state
um plus J uh J being what is the next
date we want to try and so we go Ahad
and do our playable actions and we
append J
and so we're doing is we're randomly
trying different things in here to see
what's going to generate a better
reward and then of course we go ahead
and choose our next State uh so we have
our random Choice playable actions and
if you remember I mentioned on this let
me just go ahead and uh whoops let's do
a free form when we were talking about
the next State uh this right here just
does a random selection instead of a
random uh SE selection you might do
something where uh whatever the best
selection is which might be option three
here and then so you can see that it
might use a bell curve and then option
two over here might have a bell curve
like this oops and we start looking at
these averages and these spreads um or
we can just add them all together and
pick the one that kind of goes in all of
those uh so those are some of the
options we have in here we just go with
a r random Choice uh that's usually
where you start play with it um and then
we have our reward section down here and
so we want to go ahead and find well in
this case a temporal difference uh so
you have your rewards new plus the self
gamma and this is the formula we were
looking at this is bellman's equation
here uh so we have our current value our
learning rate our discount rate involved
in there the reward system coming in for
that um and we can add it all together
this is of course our uh uh maximum
expected future setup in here uh so this
is all of our our bellman's equation
that we're looking at here and then we
come up in here and we update our Q
table that's all this is on this one
that's right here we have um self Q
current state next state and we add in
our um Alpha because we don't want to we
don't want to train all of it at once in
case there's slight differenes coming in
there we want to slowly approach the
answer uh and then we have our route
equals a start
location and next location equals start
location so we're just incrementing we
took a step forward and then finally
remember I was telling you how uh we're
going to do all this and just have some
simple thing at the end or just
generates a simple path we're going to
go ahead and and get the optimal route
we want to find the best route in here
and so we've created a definition for
the optimal route down here scroll down
for that and we get the optimal route we
go ahead and put the information in
including the Q table self uh start
location in location next location route
q and it says while next location is not
equal to in location so while we can
still go our start location equals self
location to State start location so we
already have our best value for the
start
location uh the next state looks at the
Q table and says hey what's the next one
with the best value and then the next
location we go ahead and pull that that
in and we just append it that's what's
going on down
here and then our start location equals
the next location and we just go through
all the steps and we'll go ahead and run
this and now that we have our Q table
our um Q agent loaded we're going to go
ahead and uh take our Q agent load them
up with our Alpha Gamma that we set up
above um along with the location step
action reward state to
location and uh our goal is to plot a
course between L9 and
L1 and we're going to go through a 100 a
thousand iterations on here and so when
I run that it runs pretty quick uh why
is this so fast um if youve been running
neural networks and you've been doing
all these other models you sit here and
wait a long time well we're a very small
amount of data these are all integers
these aren't float values there's not a
the math is not heavy on the on the
processing end and this is where Q
tables are so powerful if you have a
small amount of information coming in
you very quickly uh get an answer off of
this even though we went through it a
thousand times to train it and you'll
see here we have l985 2 and one and
that's based on our reward table we had
set up on there and this is the shortest
path going between these different uh
setups in here and if you remember on
our reward table uh you can see that if
you start here you can go to here
there's places you can't go that's how
this reward table was set up so I can
only go to certain
places uh so kind of a little maze setup
in there and you can play with it this
is really fun uh setup to play with uh
and you can see how you can take this
whole code and you can like I was saying
earlier you can embed it into another
setup in model and predictions where you
put things into buckets and you're
trying to guess the best investment the
best course of action long as you can
take that course of action and and uh
uh reduce it down to a yes no um or if
you're using text you can use a one hot
encoder which word is next there's all
kinds of things you can do with a Q
table uh depending on just how much
information you're putting in there so
that wraps up our demo in this demo
we've uh found the shortest distance
between two paths based on whatever
rules or state rewards we have to get
from point A to point B and what
available actions there are hello and
welcome to this tutorial on deep
learning my name is moan and in the next
about 1 one and a half hours I will take
you through what is deep learning and
into tensorflow environment to show you
an example of deep learning now there
are several applications of deep
learning really very interesting and
Innovative applications and one of them
is identifying the geographic location
based on a picture and how does this
work the way it works is pretty much we
train an artificial neural network with
millions of images which are tagged
their geolocation is tagged and then
when we feed a new picture it will be
able to identify the geolocation of this
new image for example you have all these
images especially with maybe some
significant monuments or or U
significant locations and you train with
millions of such images and then when
you feed another image it need not be
exactly one of those that you have
trained it can be completely different
that is the whole idea of training it
will be able to recognize for example
that this is a picture from Paris
because it is able to recognize the iar
so the way it works internally if we
have to look a little bit under the H is
these images are nothing but this is
digital information in the form of
pixels so each image could be a certain
size it can be 256 x 256 pixel kind of
resolution and then each pixel is either
having a certain grade of color and all
that is fed into the neural network and
it then gets trained in and it's able to
based on these pixels pixel information
it is able to get trained and able to
recognize the features and extract the
features and thereby it is able to
identify these images and the location
of these images and then when you feed a
new image it kind of based on the
training it will be able to figure out
where this image is from so that's the
way a little bit under the hood how it
works so what are we going to do in this
tutorial we will see what is deep
learning and what do we need for deep
learning and one of the main components
of deep learning is neural network so we
will see what is neural network what is
a perceptron and how to implement logic
gates like and or nor and so on use
perceptrons the different types of
neural networks and then applications of
deep learning and we will also see how
neural networks works so how do we do
the training of neural networks and at
the end we will end up with a small demo
code which will take you through
intensive flow now in order to implement
deep learning code there are multiple
libraries or development environments
that are available and T flow is one of
them so the focus at the end of this
would be on how to use tensor flow to
write a piece of code using python as a
programming language and we will take up
a an example which is a very common one
which is like the hollow world of deep
learning the handwriting number
recognition which is a mnist commonly
known as mnist database so we will take
a look at M's database and how we can
train a neural network to recognize
handwritten numbers so that's what you
will see in this particular video so
let's get started what is deep learning
deep learning is like a subset of what
is known as a highlevel concept called
artificial intelligence you must be
already familiar must have heard about
this term artificial intelligence so
artificial intelligence is like the high
level concept if you will and in order
to implement artificial intelligence
applications we we use what is known as
machine learning and within machine
learning a subset of machine learning is
deep learning machine learning is a
little bit more generic concept and deep
learning is one type of machine learning
if you will and we will see a little
later in maybe the following slides a
little bit more in detail how deep
learning is different from traditional
machine learning but to start with we
can mention here that deep learning uses
one of the differentiators between deep
learning and traditional machine
learning is that deep learning uses
neural networks and we will talk about
what are neural networks and how we can
Implement neural networks and so on and
so forth as a part of this tutorial so a
little deeper into deep learning deep
learning primarily involves working with
complicated unstructured data compared
to traditional machine learning with
where we normally use structured data in
deep learning the data would be
primarily images or Voice or maybe text
file so and it is large amount of data
as well and deep learning can handle
complex operations it involves complex
operations and the other difference
between traditional machine learning and
deep learning is that the feature
extraction happens pretty much
automatically in traditional machine
learning feature engineering is done
manually the data scientists we data
scientists have to do feature
engineering feature extraction but in
deep learning that happens automatically
and of course deep learning for large
amounts of data complicated unstructured
data deep learning gives very good
performance now as I mentioned one of
the secret sources of deep learning is
neural networks let's see what neural
networks is neural networks is based on
our biological neurons the whole concept
of deep learning and artificial
intelligence is based on human brain and
human brain consists of billions of tiny
stuff called neurons and this is how a
biological neuron looks and this is how
an artificial neuron looks so neural
networks is like a simulation of our
human brain human brain has billions of
biological neurons and we are trying to
simulate the human brain using
artificial neurons this is how a
biological neuron looks it has dendrites
and the corresponding component with an
artificial neural network is or an
artificial neuron are the inputs they
receive the inputs through dendrites and
then there is the cell nucleus which is
basically the processing unit in a way
so in artificial neuron also there is a
piece which is an equivalent of this
cell nucleus and based on the weights
and biases we will see see what exactly
weights and biases are as we move the
input gets processed and that results in
an output in a biological neuron the
output is sent through a synapse and in
an artificial neuron there is an
equivalent of that in the form of an
output and biological neurons are also
interconnected so there are billions of
neurons which are interconnected in the
same way artificial neurons are also
interconnected so this output of this
neuron will be fed as an input to
another neuron and so on
now in neural network one of the very
basic units is a perceptron so what is a
perceptron A perceptron can be
considered as one of the fundamental
units of neural networks it can consist
at least one neuron but sometimes it can
be more than one neuron but you can
create a perceptron with a single neuron
and it can be used to perform certain
functions it can be used as a basic
binary classifier it can be trained to
do some basic binary classification and
this is how a basic perceptron looks
like and this is nothing but a neuron
you have inputs X1 X2 X to xn and there
is a summation function and then there
is what is known as an activation
function and based on this input what is
known as the weighted sum the activation
function either gets gives an output
like a zero or a one so we say the
neuron is either activated or not so
that's the way it works so you get the
inputs these inputs are each of the
inputs are multiplied by a weight and
there is a bias that gets added and that
whole thing is fed to an activation
function and then that results in an
output and if the output is correct it
is accepted it is wrong if there is an
error then that error is fed back and
the neuron then adjust the weights and
biases to give a new output and so on
and so forth forth so that's what is
known as the training process of a
neuron or a neural network there's a
concept called perceptron learning so
perceptron learning is again one of the
very basic learning processes the way it
works is somewhat like this so you have
all these inputs like X1 to xn and each
of these inputs is multiplied by a
weight and then that sum this is the
formula of the equation so that sum wi
ixi Sigma of that which is the sum of
all these product of X and W is added up
and then a bias is added to that the
bias is not dependent on the input but
or the input values but the bias is
common for one neuron however the bias
value keeps changing during the training
process once the training is completed
the values of these weights W1 W2 and so
on and the value of the bias gets fixed
so that is basically the whole training
in process and that is what is known as
the perceptron training so the weights
and biases keep changing till you get
the accurate output and the summation is
of course passed through the activation
function as you see here this wixi
summation plus b is passed through
activation function and then the neuron
gets either fired or not and based on
that there will be an output that output
is compared with the actual or expected
value which is also known as labeled
information this is the process of
supervised learning so the output is
already known and um that is compared
and thereby we know if there is an error
or not and if there is an error the
error is fed back and the weights and
biases are updated accordingly till the
error is reduced to the minimum so this
iterative process is known as perceptron
learning or perceptron learning Rule and
this error needs to be minimized so till
the error is minimized this iteratively
the weights and biases keep changing and
that is what is the training process so
the whole idea is to update the weights
and the bias of the perceptron till the
error is minimized the error need not be
zero the error may not ever reach zero
but the idea is to keep changing these
weights and bias so that the error is
minimum the minimum possible that it can
have so this whole process is an
iterative process and this is the
iteration continues till either the
error is zero which is uh unlikely
situation or it is the minimum possible
Within These given conditions now in
1943 two scientists Warren mik and
Walter Pitts came up with an experiment
where they were able to implement the
logical functions like and or and nor
using neurons and that was a significant
breakthrough in a sense so they were
able to come up with the most common
logical Gates they were able to
implement some of the most common
logical Gates which could take two
inputs Like A and B and then give a
corresponding result so for example in
case of an and gate A and B and then the
output is a in case of an R gate it is a
plus b and so on and so forth and they
were able to do this using a single
layer perceptron now most of these gats
it was possible to use single layer
perceptron except for XR and we will see
why that is in a little bit so this is
how an and gate works the inputs A and B
the output should be fired or the neuron
should be fired only when both the
inputs are one so if you have 0 0 the
output should be zero for 0 1 it is
again 0 1 0 again 0 and 1 one the output
should be one so how do we implement
this with a neuron so it was found that
by changing the values of Weights it is
possible to achieve this logic so for
example if we have equal weights like 7
7 and then if we take the sum of the
weighted product so for example 7 into 0
and then 7 into 0 will give you 0 and so
on and so forth and in the last case
when both the inputs are one you get a
value which is greater than one which is
the threshold so only in this case the
neuron gets activated and the output is
there is an output in all the other
cases there is no output because the
threshold value is one so this is
implementation of an and gate using a
single perceptron or a single neuron
similarly an orgate in order to
implement an orgate in case of an orgate
the output will be one if either of
these inputs is one so for example 01
will result in one or other in all the
cases it is one except for 0 0 so how do
we implement this using a perceptron
once again if you have a perceptron with
weights for example 1.2 now if you see
here if in the first case when both are
zero the output is zero in the second
case when it is 0 and 1 1.2 into 0 is 0
and then 1.2 into 1 is one and in the
second case similarly the output is 1.2
in the last case when both the inputs
are one the output is 2.4 so during the
training process these weights will keep
changing and then at one point where the
weights are equal to W1 is equal to 1.2
and W2 is equal to 1.2 the system learns
that it gives the correct output so that
is implementation of orgate using a
single neuron or a single layer
perceptron now Exar gate this was one of
the challenging ones they tried to
implement an Exar gate with a single
level perceptron but it was not possible
and therefore in order to implement an
XR so this was like a a roadblock in the
progress of U neural network however
subsequently they realize that this can
be implemented an exr gate can be
implemented using a multi-level
perceptron or MLP so in this case there
are two layers instead of a single layer
and this is how you can Implement an XR
gate so you will see that X1 and X2 are
the inputs and there is a hidden layer
and that's why it is denoted as H3 and
H4 and then you take the output of that
and feed it to the output at 05 and
provide a threshold here so we will see
here that this is the numerical
calculation so the weights are in this
case for X1 it is 20 and Min - 20 and
once again 20 and minus 20 so these
inputs are fed into H3 and H4 so you'll
see here for H3 the input is 01 1 1 and
for H4 it is 1 1 1 and if you now look
at the output final output where the
threshold is taken as one if we use a
sigmoid with the threshold one you will
see that in these two cases it is zero
and in the last two cases it is one so
this is a implementation of XR in case
of XR only when one of the inputs is one
you will get an output so that is what
we are seeing here if we have either
both the inputs are one or both the
inputs are zero then the output should
be zero so that is what is an exclusive
or gate so it is exclusive because only
one of the inputs should be one and then
only you'll get an output of one which
is Satisfied by this condition so this
is a special implementation XR gate is a
special implement mation of perceptron
now that we got a good idea about
perceptron let's take a look at what is
the neural network so we have seen what
is a perceptron we have seen what is a
neuron so we will see what exactly is a
neural network so neural network is
nothing but a network of these neurons
and they are different types of neural
networks there are about five of them
these are artificial neural network
convolutional neural network then
recursive neural network or recurrent
neural Network deep neural network and
deep belief Network so and each of these
types of neural networks have a special
you know they can solve special kind of
problems for example convolutional
neural networks are very good at
performing image processing and image
recognition and so on whereas RNN are
very good for speech recognition and
also text analysis and so on so each
type has some special characteristics
and they can they are good at performing
certain special kind of tasks what are
some of the applications of deep
learning deep learning is today used
extensively in gaming you must have
heard about alphao which is a game
created by a startup called Deep Mind
which got acquired by Google and alphago
is an AI which defeated the human world
champion leas at all in this game of Go
so gaming is an area where deep learning
is being extensively used and a lot of
research happens in the area of gaming
as well in addition to that nowadays
there are neural networks or special
type called generative adversarial
networks which can be used for
synthesizing either images or music or
text and so on and they can be used to
compose music so the neural network can
be trained to compose a certain kind of
music and autonomous cars you must be
familiar with Google Google's
self-driving car and today a lot of
Automotive companies are investing in
this space and uh deep learning is a
core component of this autonomous Cars
the cars are trained to recognize for
example the road the the lane markings
on the road signals any objects that are
in front any obstruction and so on and
so forth so all this involves deep
learning so that's another major
application and robots we have seen
several robots including Sofia you may
be familiar with sopia who was given a
citizenship by Saudi Arabia and there
are several such robots which are very
humanlike and the underlying technology
in many of these robots is deep learning
medical Diagnostics and Health Care is
another major area where deep learning
is being used and within Healthcare
Diagnostics again there are multiple
areas where deep learning and image
recognition image processing can be used
for example for cancer detection as you
may be aware if cancer is detected early
on it can be cured and one of the
challenges is in the availability of
Specialists who can diagnose cancer
using these diagnostic images and
various scans and and so on and so forth
so the idea is to train neural network
to perform some of these activities so
that the load on the cancer specialist
doctors or oncologist comes down and
there is a lot of research happening
here and there are already quite a few
applications that are claimed to be
performing better than human beings in
this space can be lung cancer it can be
breast cancer and so on and so forth so
Healthcare is a major area where deep
learning is being applied let's take a
look at the inner working of a neural
network so how does an artificial neural
network let's say identify can we train
a neural network to identify the shapes
like squares and circles and triangles
when these images are fed so this is how
it works any image is nothing but it is
a digital information of the pixels so
in this particular case let's say this
is an image of 28x 28 pixel and this is
an image of a square there's a certain
way in which the pixels are lit up and
so these pixels have a certain value
maybe from 0 to 256 and 0 indicates that
it is black or it is dark and 256
indicates it is completely it is white
or lit up so that is like an indication
or a measure of the how the pixels are
lit up and so this is an image is let's
say consisting of information
of 784 pixels so all the information
what is inside this image can be kind of
compressed into the 784 pixels the way
each of these pixels is lit up provides
information about what exactly is the
image so we can train neural networks to
use that information and identify the
images so let's take a look how this
works so each neuron the value if it is
close to one that means it is white
whereas if it is close to zero that
means it is black now this is a an
animation of how this whole thing works
so these pixels one of the ways of doing
it is we can flatten this image and take
this complete 784 pixels and feed that
as input to our neural network the
neural network can consist of probably
several layers there can be a few hidden
layers and then there is an input layer
and an output layer now the input layer
take the 784 pixels as input the values
of each of these pixels and then you get
an output which can be of three types or
three classes one can be a square a
circle or a triangle now during the
training process there will be initially
obviously you feed this image and it
will probably say it's a circle or it
will say it's a triangle so as a part of
the training process we then send that
error back and the weights and the
biases of these neurons are adjusted
till it correctly identifies that this
is a square that is the whole training
mechanism that happens out
here now let's take a look at a circle
same way so you feed these 784 pixels
there is a certain pattern in which the
pixels are lit up and and the neural
network is trained to identify that
pattern and during the training process
once again it would probably initially
identify it incorrectly saying this is a
square or a triangle and then that error
is fed back and the weights and biases
are adjusted finally till it finally
gets the image correct so that is the
training process so now we will take a
look at same way a
triangle so now if you feed another
image which is consisting of triangles
so this is the training process now we
have trained our neural network to
classify these images into a triangle or
a circle and a square so now this neural
network can identify these three types
of objects now if you feed another image
and it will be able to identify whether
it's a square or a triangle or a circle
now what is important to be observed is
that when you feed a new image it is not
necessary that the image or the the
triangle is exactly in this position now
the neural network actually identifies
the patterns so even if the triangle is
let's say positioned here not exactly in
the middle but maybe at the corner or in
the side it would still identify that it
is a triangle and that is the whole idea
behind pattern recognition so how does
this training process work this is a
quick view of how the training process
works so we have seen that a neuron
consists of inputs it receives inputs
and then there is a weighted sum which
is nothing but this XI wi summation of
that plus the bias and this is then fed
to the activation function and that in
turn gives us a output now during the
training process initially obviously
when you feed these images when you send
maybe a square it will identify it as a
triangle and when you maybe feed a
triangle it will identify as a square
and so on so that error information is
fed back and initially these weights can
be random maybe all of them have zero
values and then it will slowly keep
changing so the as a part of the
training process the values of these
weights W1 W2 up to WN keep changing in
such a way that towards the end of the
training process it should be able to
identify these images correctly so till
then the weights are adjusted and that
is known as the training process so and
these weights are numeric values could
be
0.525 35 and so on it could be positive
or it could be negative and the value
that is coming here is the pixel value
as we have seen it can be anything
between 0 to 1 you can scale it between
0 to 1 or 0 to 256 whichever way 0 being
black and 256 being white white and then
all the other colors in between so that
is the input so these are numerical
values this multiplication or the
product w i XI is a numerical value and
the bias is also a numerical value we
need to keep in mind that the bias is
fixed for a neuron it doesn't change
with the inputs whereas the weights are
one per input so that is one important
point to be noted so but the bias also
keeps changing initially it will again
have a random value but as a part of the
training process the weights the values
of the weights W 1 W2 WN and the value
of B will change and ultimately once the
training process is complete these
values are fixed for this particular
neuron W1 W2 up to WN and plus the value
of the B is also fixed for this
particular neuron and in this way there
will be multiple neurons and each there
may be multiple levels of neurons here
and that's the way the training process
works so this is another example example
of multi-layer so there are two hidden
layers in between and then you have the
input layer values coming from the input
layer then it goes through multiple
layers hidden layers and then there is
an output layer and as you can see there
are weights and biases for each of these
neurons in each layer and all of them
gets keeps changing during the training
process and at the end of the training
process all these weights have a certain
value and that is a trained model
and those values will be fixed once the
training is completed all right then
there is something known as activation
function neural networks consists of one
of the components in neural networks is
activation function and every neuron has
an activation function and there are
different types of activation functions
that are used it could be a relu it
could be sigmoid and so on and so forth
and the activation function is what
decides whether a neuron should be fired
or not so whether the output should be
zero or one is decided by the activation
function and the activation function in
turn takes the input which is the
weighted sum remember we talked about
wixi + B that weighted sum is fed as a
input to the activation function and
then the output can be either a zero or
a one and there are different types of
activation functions which are covered
in an earlier video you might want to
watch all right so as a part of the
training process we feed the inputs the
lay data or the training data and then
it gives an output which is the
predicted output by the network which we
indicate as y hat and then there is a
labeled data because we for supervised
learning we already know what should be
the output so that is the actual output
and in the initial process before the
training is complete obviously there
will be error so that is measured by
what is known as a cost function so the
difference between the predicted output
and the actual output is the error ER
and the cost function can be defined in
different ways there are different types
of cost functions so in this case it is
like the average of the squares of the
error so and then all the errors are
added which can sometimes be called as
sum of squares sum of square errors or
ssse and that is then fed as a feedback
in what is known as backward propagation
or back propagation and that helps in
the network adjusting the weights and
biases and so the weights and biases get
updated till this value the error value
or the cost function is minimum now
there is a optimization technique which
is used here called gradient desent
optimization and this algorithm Works in
a way that the error which is the cost
function needs to be minimized so
there's a lot of mathematics that goes
behind us for example the find the uh
local Minima the global Minima using the
differentiation and so on and so forth
but the idea is this so as a training
process as the as a part of training the
whole idea is to bring down the error
which is like let's say this is the
function the cost function at certain
levels it is very high the cost value of
the cost function the output of the cost
function is very high so the weights
have to be adjusted in such a way and
also the bias of course that the cost
function is minimized so there is this
optimization technique called gradient
descent that is used and this is known
as the learning rate now gradient
descent you need to specify what should
be the learning rate and the learning
rate should be optimal because if you
have a very high learning rate then the
optimization will not converge because
at some point it will cross over to the
side on the other hand if you have very
low learning rate then it might take
forever to convert so you need to come
up with the optimum value of the
learning rate and once that is done
using the gradient descent optimization
the error function is reduced and that's
like the end of the training process all
right so this is another view of
gradient descent so this is how it looks
this is your cost function the output of
the cost function and that has to be
minimized using gradient descent
algorithm and these are like the
parameters and weight could be one of
them so initially we start with certain
random values so cost will be high and
then the weights keep changing and in
such a way that the cost function needs
to come down and at some point it may
reach the minimum value and then it may
increase so that is where the gradient
desent algorithm decides that okay it
has reached the minimum value and and it
will kind of try to stay here this is
known as the global Minima now sometimes
these curves may not be just for
explanation purpose this has been drawn
in a nice way but sometimes these curves
can be pretty erratic there can be some
local Minima here and then there is a
peak and then and so on so the whole
idea of gradient descent optimization is
to identify the global Minima and to
find the weights and the bias at that
particular point so that's what is
gradient descent and then this is
another example so you can have these
multiple local minimum so as you can see
at this point when it is coming down it
may appear like this is a minimum value
but then it is not this is actually the
global minimum value and the gradient
desent algorithm will make an effort to
reach this level and not get stuck at
this point so the algorithm is already
there and it knows how to identify this
Global minimum and that's what it does
during the training process now in order
to implement deep learning there are
multiple platforms and languages that
are available but the most common
platform nowadays is tensor flow and so
that's the reason we have uh this
tutorial we've created this tutorial for
tensorflow so we will take you through a
quick demo of how to write a tensorflow
code using Python and denlow is uh an
open source platform created by Google
so let's just take a look at the details
of tens ofl and so this is a a library a
python Library so you can use python or
any other languages it's also supported
in other languages like Java and R and
so on but python is the most common
language that is used so it is a library
for developing deep learning
applications especially using neural
networks and it consists of primarily
two parts if you will so one is the
tensors and then the other is the graphs
or the flow that's the way the name
that's the reason for this kind of a
name called tensor flow so what are
tensors tensors are like
multi-dimensional arrays if you will
that's one way of looking at it so
usually you have a onedimensional array
so first of all you can have what is
known as a scalar which means a number
and then you have a one dimensional
array something like this which means
this is like a set of numbers so that is
a onedimensional array then you can have
a two-dimensional array which is like a
matrix and beyond that sometimes it gets
difficult so this is a three-dimensional
array but tens of flow can handle many
more Dimensions so it can have
multi-dimensional arrays that is the
strength of tensor flow and which makes
computation deep learning computation
much faster and that's the reason why
tensor flow is used for developing deep
learning applications so tensor flow is
a deep learning tool and this is the way
it works so the data basically flows in
the form of tensors and the way the
programming works as well is that you
first create a graph of how to execute
it and then you actually execute that
particular graph in the form of what is
known as a session we will see this in
the tensor flow code as we move forward
so all the data is managed or
manipulated in tensors and then the
processing happens using this graphs
there are certain terms called like for
example ranks of a tensor the rank of a
tensor is like a dimensional
dimensionality in a way so for example
if it is scalar so there is just a
number just one number the rank is
supposed to be zero and then it can be a
one-dimensional vector in which case the
rank is supposed to be one and then you
can have a
two-dimensional Vector typically like a
matrix then in the that case we say the
rank is two and then if it is a
three-dimensional array then it rank is
three and so on so it can have more than
three as well so it is possible that you
can store multi-dimensional arrays in
the form of tensors so what are some of
the properties of tensor flow I think
today it is one of the most popular
platform tensorflow is the most popular
deep learning platform or Library it is
open source it's developed by Google
developed and maintained by Google but
it is open source one of the most
important things about tensorflow is
that it can run on CPUs as well as gpus
GPU is a graphical Processing Unit just
like CPU is central processing unit now
in earlier days GPU was used for
primarily for graphics and that's how
the name has come and one of the reasons
is that it cannot perform generic
activities very efficiently like CPU but
it can perform iterative actions or
computations extremely fast and much
faster than a CPU so they are really
good for computational activities and in
deep learning there is a lot of
iterative computation that happens so in
the form of matrix multiplication and so
on so gpus are very well suited for this
kind of computation and tensorflow
supports both GPU as well as CPU and
there's a certain way of writing code in
tensorflow we will see as we into the
code and of course tensorflow can be
used for traditional machine learning as
well but then that would be an Overkill
but just for understanding it may be a
good idea to start writing code for a
normal machine learning use case so that
you get a hang of how tensorflow code
works and then you can move into neural
networks so that is um just a suggestion
but if you're already familiar with how
tensorflow works then probably yeah you
can go straight into the neural networks
part so in this tutorial we will take
the use case of recognizing handwritten
digits this is like a hollow world of
deep learning and this is a nice little
amness database is a nice little
database that has images of handwritten
digits nicely formatted because very
often in deep learning and neural
networks we end up spending a lot of
time in preparing the data for training
and with amness database we can avoid
that you already have the data in the
right format which can be directly used
for training and amnest also offers a
bunch of built-in utility functions that
we can straight away use and call those
functions without worrying about writing
our own functions and that's one of the
reasons why mes database is very popular
for training purposes initially when
people want to learn about deep learning
and tensor flow this is the database
that is used and it has a collection of
70,000 handwritten digits and a large
part of them are for training then you
have test just like in any machine
learning process and then you have
validation and all of them are labeled
so you have the images and their label
and these images they look somewhat like
this so they are handwritten images
collected from a lot of IND uals people
have these are samples written by human
beings they have handwritten these
numbers these numbers going from 0 to 9
so people have written these numbers and
then the images of those have been taken
and formatted in such a way that it is
very easy to handle so that is mes
database and the way we are going to
implement this in our tensor flow is we
will feed this data especially the
training data along with with the label
information and uh the data is basically
these images are stored in the form of
the pixel information as we have seen in
one of the previous slides all the
images are nothing but these are pixels
so an image is nothing but an
arrangement of pixels and the value of
the pixel either it is lit up or it is
not or in somewhere in between that's
how the images are stored and that is
how they are fed into the neural network
and for training one once the network is
trained when you provide a new image it
will be able to identify within a
certain error of course and for this we
will use one of the simpler neural
network configurations called softmax
and for Simplicity what we will do is we
will flatten these pixels so instead of
taking them in a two-dimensional
arrangement we just flatten them out so
for example it starts from here it is a
28 by 28 so there are
7484 pixels so pixel number one starts
here it goes all the way up to 28 then
29 starts here and goes up to 56 and so
on and the pixel number 784 is here so
we take all these pixels flatten them
out and feed them like one single line
into our neural network and this is a
what is known as a softmax layer what it
does is once it is trained it will be
able to identify what digit this is so
there are in this output layer there are
10 neurons each signifying a digit and
at any given point of time when you feed
an image only one of these 10 neurons
gets activated so for example if this is
strained properly and if you feed a
number nine like this then this
particular neuron gets activated it so
you get an output from this neuron let
me just use uh a pen or a laser to show
you here okay so you're feeding a number
nine let's say this has been trained and
now if you're feeding a number nine this
will get activated now let's say you
feed one to the trained Network then
this neuron will get activated if you
feed two this neuron will get activated
and so on I hope you get the idea so
this is one type of of a neural network
or an activation function known as
softmax layer so that's what we will be
using here this is one of the simpler
ones for quick and easy understanding so
this is how the code would look we will
go into our lab environment in the cloud
and uh we will show you there directly
but very quickly this is how the code
looks and uh let me run you through
briefly here and then we will go into
the Jupiter notebook where the actual
code is and we will run run that as well
so as a first step first of all we are
using python here and that's why the
syntax of the language is uh Python and
the first step is to import the
tensorflow library so and we do this by
using this line of code saying import
tensor flow as TF TF is just for
convenience so you can name give any
name and once you do this TF is tens
flow is available as an object in the
name of TF and then you can run its uh
method and accesses its attributes and
so on and so forth and Mist database is
actually an integral part of tensorflow
and that's again another reason why we
as a first step we always use this
example mnist database example so you
just simply import mnist database as
well using this line of code and you
slightly modify this so that the labels
are in this format what is known as one
hot true which means that the label
information is stored like an array and
uh let me just uh use the pen to show
what exactly it is so when you do this
one hot true what happens is each label
is stored in the form of an array of 10
digits and let's say the number is uh 8
okay so in this case all the remaining
values there will be a bunch of zeros so
this is like array at position Z 0 this
is at position one position two and so
on and so forth let's say this is
position 7 then this is position 8 that
will be one because our input is eight
and again position 9 will be zero okay
so one hot encoding this one H encoding
true will kind of load the data in such
a way that the labels are in such a way
that only one of the digits has a value
of one and that indicates So based on
which digit is one we know what is the
label so in this case the eighth
position is one therefore we know this
sample data the value is eight similarly
if you have a two here let's say then
the labeled information will be somewhat
like this so you have your labels so you
have this as zero the zeroth position
the first position is also zero the
second position is one because this
indicates number two and then you have
third as zero and so on okay so that is
the significance of this one hot true
all right and then we can check how the
data is uh looking by displaying the the
data and as I mentioned earlier this is
pretty much in the form of digital form
like numbers so all these are like pixel
values so you will not really see an
image in this format but there is a way
to visualize that image I will show you
in a bit and uh this tells you how many
images are there in each set so the
training there are 55,000 images in
training and in the test set there are
10,000 and then validation there are
5,000 so altogether there are 70,000
images all right so let's uh move on and
we can view the actual image by uh using
the matplot clip library and this is how
you can view this is the code for
viewing the images and you can view them
in color or you can view them in Gray
scale so the cmap is what tells in what
way we want to view it and what are the
maximum values and the minimum values of
the pixel values so these are the Max
and minimum values so of the pixel
values so maximum is one because this is
a scaled value so one means it is uh
White and zero means it is black and in
between is it can be anywhere in between
black and white
and the way to train the model there is
a certain way in which you write your
tensorflow code and um the first step is
to create some placeholders and then you
create a model in this case we will use
the softmax model one of the simplest
ones and um placeholders are primarily
to get the data from outside into the
neural network so this is a very common
mechanism that is used and uh then of
course you will have variables which are
your remember these are your weights and
biases so for in our case there are 10
neurons and each neuron actually has 7
and 84 because each neuron takes all the
inputs if we go back to our slide here
actually every neuron takes all the 784
inputs right this is the first neuron it
has it receives all the 784 this is the
second neuron this also receives all the
78 so each of these inputs needs to be
multiplied with the weight and that's
what we are talking about here so these
are this is a a matrix of
784 values for each of the neurons and
uh so it is like a 10 by 784 Matrix
because there are 10 neurons and uh
similarly there are biases now remember
I mentioned biases only one per neuron
so it is not one per input unlike the
weights so therefore there are only 10
biases because there are only 10 neurons
in this case so that is what we are
creating a variable for biases so this
is something little new in tensor flow
you will see unlike our regular
programming languages where everything
is a variable here the variables can be
of three different types you have
placeholders which are primarily used
for feeding data you have variables
which can change during the course of
computation and then a third type which
is not shown here are constants so these
are like fixed numbers all right so in a
regular programming language you may
have everything as variables or at the
most variables and constants but in tens
oflow you have three different types
placeholders variables and constants and
then you create what is known as a graph
so tensorflow programming consists of
graphs and tensors as I mentioned
earlier so this can be considered
ultimately as a tensor and then the
graph tells how to execute the whole
implementation so that the execution is
stored in the form of a graph and in
this case what we are doing is we are
doing a multiplication TF you remember
this TF was created as a tensorflow
object here one more level one more so
TF is available here now tensor flow has
what is known as a matrix multiplication
or matal function so that is what is
being used here in this case so we are
using the matrix multiplication of
tensor flow so that you multiply your
input values x with W right this is what
we were doing x w + B you just adding B
and this is in very similar to one of
the earlier slides where we saw Sigma XI
wi so that's what we are doing here
matrix multiplication is multiplying all
the input values with the corresponding
weights and then adding the bias so that
is the graph we created and then we need
to Define what is our loss function and
what is our Optimizer so in this case we
again use the tensor flows apis so tf.
NN softmax cross entropy with logits is
the uh API that we will use and reduce
mean is what is like the mechanism
whereby which says that you reduce the
error and Optimizer for doing deduction
of the error what Optimizer are we using
so we are using gradient descent
Optimizer we discussed about this in
couple of slides uh earlier and for that
you need to specify the learning rate
you remember we saw that there was a a
slide somewhat like this and then you
define what should be the learning rate
how fast you need to come down that is
the learning rate and this again needs
to be tested and tried and to find out
the optimum level of this learning rate
it shouldn't be very high in which case
it will not converge or shouldn't be
very low because it will in that case it
will take very long so you define the
optimizer and then you call the method
minimize for that Optimizer and that
will kickart the training process and so
far we've been creating the graph and in
order to actually execute that graph we
create what is known as a session and
then we run that session and once the
training is completed we specify how
many times how many iterations we want
it to run so for example in this case we
are saying Thousand Steps so that is a
exit strategy in a way so you specify
the exit condition so training will run
for th000 iterations and once that is
done we can then evaluate the model
using some of the techniques shown here
so let us get into the code quickly and
see how it works so this is our Cloud
environment now you can install
tensorflow on your local machine as well
I'm showing this demo on our existing
Cloud but you can also install denslow
on your local machine and uh there is a
separate video on how to set up your
tensorflow environment you can watch
that if you want to install your local
environment or you can go for other any
cloud service like for example Google
Cloud Amazon or Cloud Labs any of these
you can use and uh run and try the code
okay so it has got started
we will log
in all right so this is our deep
learning tutorial uh code and uh this is
our tensorflow
environment and uh so let's get started
the first we have seen a little bit of a
code walk through uh in the slides as
well now you will see the actual code in
action so the first thing we need to do
is import tensor flow and then we will
import the data and we need to adjust
the data in such a way that
the one hot is encoding is set to True
one hot encoding right as I explained
earlier so in this case the label values
will be shown appropriately and if we
just check what is the type of the data
so you can see that this is a data sets
python data sets and if we check the
number of images is the way it looks so
this is how it looks it is an array of
type float 32
similarly the number if you want to see
what is the number
of training images there are 55,000 then
there are test images 10,000 and then
validation images 5,000 now let's take a
quick look at the data itself
visualization so we will use um matte
plot clip for this and um if we take a
look at the shape now shape gives us
like the dimension of the tensors or or
or the arrays if you will so in this
case the training data set if we see the
size of the training data set using the
method shape it says there are 55,000
and 55,000 by 784 so remember this 784
is nothing but the 28 by 28 28 into 28
so that is equal to 784 so that's what
it is uh showing now we can take just
one image and just see what is the the
first image and see what is the shape so
again size obviously it is only 784
similarly you can look at the image
itself the data of the first image
itself so this is how it it shows so
large part of it will probably be zeros
because as you can imagine in the image
only certain areas are written rest is U
black so that's why you will mostly see
zeros either it is black or white but
then there are these values are so the
values are actually they are scaled so
the values are between 0o and one okay
so this is what you're seeing so certain
locations there are some values and then
other locations there are zeros so that
is how the data is stored and loaded if
we want to actually see what is the
value of the handwritten image if you
want to view it this is how you view it
so you create like do this reshape and
um matplot lib has this um feature to
show you these images so we will
actually use the function called um IM
am show and then if you pass this
parameters appropriately you will be
able to see the different images now I
can change the values in this position
so which image we are looking at right
so we can say if I want to see what is
there in maybe
5,000 right
so 5,000 has three similarly you can
just say five what is in five five as
eight what is in
50 again eight so basically by the way
if you're wondering uh how I'm executing
this code shift enter in case you're not
familiar with Jupiter notebooks shift
enter is how you execute each cell
individual cell and if you you want to
execute the entire program you can go
here and say run all so that is
how this code gets executed and um here
again we can check what is the maximum
value and what is the minimum value of
this pixel values as I mentioned this is
it is scaled so therefore it is between
the values lie between 1 and zero now
this is where we create our
model the first thing is to create the
required placeholder ERS and variables
and that's what we are doing here as we
have seen in the slides so we create one
placeholder and we create two variables
which is for the weights and biases
these two variables are actually
matrices so each variable has 784 by 10
values okay so one for this 10 is for
each neuron there are 10 neurons and 784
is for the pixel value vales inputs that
are given which is 28 into 28 and the
biases as I mentioned one for each
neuron so there will be 10 biases they
are stored in a variable by the name b
and this is the graph which is basically
the multiplication of these matrix
multiplication of X into W and then the
bias is added for each of the neurons
and the whole idea is to minimize the
error so let me just execute I think
this code is is executed then we Define
what is our the Y value is basically the
label value so this is another
placeholder we had X as one placeholder
and Yore true as a second placeholder
and this will have values in the form of
uh 10 digigit 10 digigit uh arrays and
uh since we said one hot encoded the
position which has a one value indicates
what is the L label for that particular
number all right then we have cross
entropy which is nothing but the loss
loss function and we have the optimizer
we have chosen gradient descent as our
Optimizer then the training process
itself so the training process is
nothing but to minimize the cross
entropy which is again nothing but the
loss function so we Define all of this
in the form of a graph so up to here
remember what we have done is we have
not exactly executed any tensorflow code
till now we are just preparing the graph
the execution plan that's how the
tensorflow code works so the whole
structure and format of this code will
be completely different from how we
normally do programming so even with
people with programming experience may
find this a little difficult to
understand it and it needs quite a bit
of practice so you may want to view this
uh video also maybe a couple of times to
understand this flow because the way
tensorflow programming is done is
slightly different from the normal
programming some of you who let's say
have done uh maybe spark programming to
some extent will be able to easily
understand this uh but even in spark the
the programming the code itself is
pretty straightforward behind the scenes
the execution happens slightly
differently but in tens oflow even the
code has to be written in a completely
different way so the code doesn't get
executed uh in the same way as you have
written so that that's something you
need to understand and a little bit of
practices needed for this so so far what
we have done up to here is creating the
variables and feeding the variables and
um or rather not feeding but setting up
the variables and uh the graph that's
all defining maybe the uh what kind of a
network you want to use for example we
want to use softmax and so on so you
have created the variables have to load
the data loaded the data viewed the data
and prepared everything but you have not
yet executed anything in tens of flow
now the next step is the execution in
tens of flow so the first step for doing
any execution in tensor flow is to
initialize the variable so anytime time
you have any variables defined in your
code you have to run this piece of code
always so you need to basically create
what is known as a a node for
initializing so this is a node you still
are not yet executing anything here you
just created a node for the
initialization so let us go ahead and
create that and here onwards is where
you will actually execute your code uh
in tensive flow and in order to execute
the code what you will need is a session
tensor flow session so tf. session will
give you a session and there are a
couple of different ways in which you
can do this but one of the most common
methods of doing this is with what is
known as a with Loop so you have a with
tf. session as sess and with a uh colon
here and this is like a block starting
of the block and these indentations tell
how far this block goes and this session
is valid till this block gets executed
so that is the purpose of creating this
width block this is known as a width
block so with tf. session as says you
say cs. run in it now cs. run will
execute a node that is specified here so
for example here we are saying CES do
run cess is is basically an instance of
the session right so here we are saying
tf. session so an instance of the
session gets created and we are calling
that cess and then we run a node within
that one of the nodes in the graph so
one of the nodes here is in it so we say
run that particular node and that is
when the initialization of the variables
happens now what this does is if you
have any variables in your code in our
case we have W is a variable and B is a
variable so any variables that we
created you have to run this code you
have to run the initialization of these
variables otherwise you will get an
error okay so that is the that's what
this is doing then we within this width
block we specify a for Loop and we are
saying we want the system to iterate for
thousand steps and perform the training
that's what this for Loop does run
training for thousand
iterations and what it is doing
basically is it is fetching the data or
these images remember there are about
50,000 images but it cannot get all the
images in one shot because it will take
up a lot of memory and performance
issues will be there so this is a very
common way of Performing deep learning
training you always do in batches so we
have maybe 50,000 images but you always
do it in batches of 100 or maybe 500
depending on the size of your system and
so on and so forth so in this case we
are saying okay get me 100 uh images at
a time and get me only the training
images remember we use only the training
data for training purpose and then we
use test data for test purpose you must
be familiar with machine learning so you
must be aware of this but in case you
are not in machine learning also not
this is not specific to deep learning
but in machine learning in general you
have what is known as training data set
and test data set your available data
typically you will be splitting into two
parts and using the training data set
for training purpose and then to see how
well the model has been trained you use
the test data set to check or test the
validity or the accuracy of the model so
that's what we are doing here and You
observe here that we are actually
calling an mnist function here so we are
saying mnist train. nextt batch right so
this is the advantage of using mnes
database because they have provided some
very nice helper functions which are
readily available otherwise this
activity itself we would have had to
write a piece of code to fetch this data
in batches that itself is a a lengthy
exercise so we can avoid all that if we
are using amness database and that's why
we use this for the initial learning
phase okay so when we say fetch what it
will do is it will fetch the images into
X and the labels into Y and then you use
this batch of 100 images and you run the
training so cs. run basically what we
are doing here is we are running the
training mechanism which is nothing but
it passes this through the neural
network passes the images through the
neural network finds out what is the
output and if the output obviously the
initially it will be wrong so all that
feedback is given back to the neural
network and thereby all the W's and B's
get updated till it reaches th
iterations in this case the exit
criteria is th000 but you can also
specify probably accuracy rate or
something like that for the as an exit
criteria so here it is it just says that
okay this particular image was wrongly
predicted
so you need to update your weights and
biases that's the feedback given to each
neuron and that is run for th000
iterations and typically by the end of
this thousand iterations the model would
have learned to recognize these
handwritten images obviously it will not
be 100% accurate okay so once that is
done after so this happens for thousand
iterations once that is done you then
test the accuracy of these models by
using the test data set right so this is
what we are trying to do here the code
may appear a little complicated because
if you're seeing this for the first time
you need to understand uh the various
methods of tensor flow and so on but it
is basically comparing the output with
what has been what is actually there
that's all it is doing so you have your
test data and uh you're trying to find
out what is the actual value and what is
the predicted value and see seeing
whether they are equal or not TF do
equal right and how many of them are
correct and so on and so forth and based
on that the accuracy is uh calculated as
well so this is the accuracy and uh that
is what we are trying to see how
accurate the model is in predicting
these uh numbers or these digits okay so
let us run this this entire thing is in
one cell so we will have to just run it
in one shot it may take a little while
let us see
and uh not bad so it has finished the
thousand iterations and what we see here
as an output is the accuracy so we see
that the accuracy of this model is
around
91% okay now which is pretty good for
such a short exercise within such a
short time we got 90% accuracy however
in real life this is probably not
sufficient so there are other ways in to
increase the accuracy we will see
probably in some of the later tutorials
how to improve this accuracy how to
change maybe the hyper parameters like
number of neurons or number of layers
and so on and so forth and uh so that
this accuracy can be increased Beyond
90% hello and welcome to the tensorflow
object detection API tutorial in this
video I will walk you through the
tensorflow code to perform object
detection in a video so let's get
started this part is basically you're
importing all the libraries we need a
lot of these libraries for example lpai
we need image IO datetime and pill and
so on and so forth and of course ma plot
lib so we import all these libraries and
then there are a bunch of variables
which have some paths for the files and
folders so this is regular stuff let's
keep moving then we import the Mac plot
lib and make it in line and uh a few
more Imports all right and then these
are some warnings we can just ignore
them so if I run this code once again
it'll go away all right and then here
onwards we do the model preparation now
what we're going to do is we're going to
use an existing neural network model so
we are not going to train a new one
because that really will uh take a long
time and uh it needs a lot of uh
computation resources and so on and it
is really not required there are already
models that have been trained and in
this case it is the SSD with mobile net
that's the model that we are going to
use and uh this model is trained to
detect objects and uh it is readily
available as open source so we can
actually use this and if you want to use
other models there are a few more models
available so you can click on this link
here and uh let me just take you there
there are a few more models but we have
chosen this particular one because this
is faster it may not be very accurate
but that is one of the faster models but
on this link you will see a lot of other
models that are readily available these
are trained models some of them would
take a little longer but they may be
more accurate and so on so you can
probably play around with these other
models okay so we will be using that
model so this piece of code this line is
basically importing that model and this
is also known as uh Frozen model the
term we use is frozen model so we import
download and import that and then we
will actually use that model in our code
all right so these two cells we have
downloaded and imported the model and
then once it is available locally we
will then load this into our program all
right so we are loading this into memory
and uh you need to perform a couple of
additional steps which is basically we
need to to map the numbers to text as
you may be aware when we actually build
the model and when we run predictions
the model will not give a text the
output of the model is usually a number
so we need to map that to a text so for
example if the network predicts that the
output is five we know that five means
it is an airplane things like that so
this mapping is done in this next cell
all right so let's keep moving and then
we have a helper code which will
basically load the data or load the
images and transform into numpy arrays
this is also used in doing object
detection in images so we are actually
going to reuse because video is nothing
but it consists of frames which in turn
are images so we are going to pretty
much use reuse the same code which we
used for doing object detection in
images so this is where the actual
detection starts so here this is the
path for where the images are stored so
this is here once again we are reusing
the code which we wrote for detecting
objects in an image so this is the path
where the images were stored and this is
the extension and this was done for
about two or three images so we will
continue to use this and uh if we go
down I'll skip this section so this is
the cell where we are actually loading
the video and converting it into frames
and then using frame by frame we are
detecting the objects in the image so in
this code what we are doing basically is
there a few lines of code what they do
is basically once they find an object a
box will be drawn around those uh each
of those objects and the input file the
name of the input video file is uh
traffic it is the extension is MP4 and
uh we have this video reader it's a
excellent object which is basically part
of this class called image IO so we can
read and write videos using that and uh
the video that we are going to use is
traffic. MP4 you can use any mp4 file
but in our case I picked up video which
has uh like car so let me just show you
so this is in this object detection
folder I have this mp4 file I'll just
quickly play this video it's a little
slow yeah okay so here we go this is the
video it's a short one relatively small
video so that for this particular demo
and what it will do is once we run our
code it will detect each of these cars
and it will annotate them as cars so in
this particular video we only have cars
we can later on see with another video I
think I have cat here so we can also try
with that but let's first check with
this uh traffic video so let me go back
so we will be reading this frame by
frame and um no actually we will be
reading the video file but then we will
be analyzing it frame by frame and we
will be reading them at 10 frames per
second that is the rate we are
mentioning here and analyzing it and
then annotating and then writing it back
so you will see that we will have a
video file named something like this
traffic annotated and um we will see the
annotated video so let's go back and run
through this piece of code and then we
will come back and see the annotated uh
video this might take a little while so
I will pause the video after running
this particular cell and then come back
to show you the results all right so
let's go ahead and run it so it is
running now and it is also important
that at the end you close the video
writer so that it is similar to a file
pointer when you open a file you should
also make sure you close it so that it
doesn't hog the resources so it's very
similar at the end of it the last piece
or last line of code should be video
writer. close all right so I'll pause
and then I'll come back okay so I will
see you in a little bit all right so now
as you can see here the processing is
done the our glass has disappeared that
means the video has been processed so
let's go back and check the annotated
video we go back to my file manager so
this was the original traffic. MP4 and
now you have here traffic annotated
before so let's go and run this and see
how it
looks you see here it just got each of
these cars are getting detected let me
pause and show you so we pause here it
says car 70% let us allow it to go a
little further it detects something on
top what is that truck okay so I think
because of the board on top it somehow
thinks there is a truck let's lay some
more and see if it detects anything else
so this is again a car looks like so let
us yeah so this is a car and it has
confidence level of 69% okay this is
again a car all right so basically till
the end it goes and detects each and
every car that is passing by now we can
quickly repeat this process for another
video let me just show you the other
video which is a cat again there is uh
this cat is not really moving or
anything but it is just just standing
there staring and moving a little slowly
and uh our application will our network
will detect that this is a cat and uh
even when the cat moves a little bit in
the other direction it'll continue to
detect and show that it is a cat Okay so
yeah so this is how the original video
is let's go ahead and change our code to
analyze this one and see if it detects
our Network detects this cat close this
here we go and I'll go back C my code
all we need to do is change this traffic
to cat the extension it will
automatically pick up because it is
given here and then it will run through
so very quickly once again what it is
doing is this video reader video reader
has a a neat little feature or interface
whereby you can say for frame in video
reader so it will basically provide
frame by frame so you are in a loop
frame by frame and then you take that
each frame that is given to you you take
it and analyze it as if it is an image
individual image so that's the way it
works so it is very easy to handle this
all right so now let's once again run
just this cell rest of the stuff Remains
the Same so I will run this cell again
it will take a little while so the our
classes come back I will pause and then
come back in a little while all right so
the processing is done let's go and
check the annotated video go here so we
have cat annotated
MP4 let's play this all right so you can
see here it is detecting the cat and in
the beginning you also saw it detected
something else here there looks like it
detected one more object so let's just
go back and see what it has detected
here let's see yes so what is it trying
to show here it's too small not able to
see but uh it is trying to detect
something I think it is saying it is a
car I don't know all right okay so in
this video there's only pretty much only
one object which is the cat and uh let's
wait for some time and see if it
continues to detect it when the cat
turns around and moves as well just in a
little bit that's going to happen and we
will see there we go and in spite of
turning the other way I think our
network is able to detect that it is a
cat so let me freeze and then show here
it is actually still continues to detect
it as a cat all right so that's that's
pretty much it I think that's the only
object that it detects in this
particular video okay so close this so
that's pretty much it thank you very
much for watching this video and you
have a great day and in case you have
any questions please uh put them below
the video here and we will be more than
happy to get back to you and make sure
you put your email ID so that we can
contact you in case you have any
questions thank you once again bye-bye
today we're going to be covering the
convolutional neural network tutorial do
you know how deep learning recognizes
the objects in an image and really this
particular neural network is how image
recognition works it's very Central one
of the biggest building blocks for image
recognition it does it using convolution
neural network and we over here we have
the basic picture of a u hummingbird
pixels of an image fed as input you have
your input layer coming in so it takes
that graphic and puts it into the input
layer you have all your hidden layers
and then you have your output layer and
your output layer one of those is going
to light up and say oh it's a bird we're
going to go into depth we're going to
actually go back and forth on this a
number of times today so if you're not
catching all the image um don't worry
we're going to get into the details so
we have our input layer accepts the
pixels of the image as input in the form
of arrays and you can see up here where
they've actually um labeled each block
of the bird in different arrays so we'll
dive into deep as to how that looks like
and how those matrixes are set up your
hidden layer carry out feature
extraction by performing certain
calculations and manipulation so this is
the part that kind of reorganizes that
picture multiple ways until we get some
data that's easy to read for the neural
network this layer uses a matrix filter
and performs convolution operation to
detect patterns in the image and if you
remember that convolution means to coil
or to twist so we're going to twist the
data around and alter it and use that
operation to d a new pattern there are
multiple hidden layers like convolution
layer real U is how that is pron
announced and that's the rectified
linear unit that has to do with the
activation function that's used pooling
layer also uses multiple filters to
detect edges corners eyes feathers beak
Etc and just like the term says pooling
is pooling information together and
we'll look into that a lot closer here
so if you're if it's a little confusing
now we'll dig in deep and try to get you
uh squared away with that and then
finally there is a fully connected layer
that identifies the object in the image
so we have these different layers coming
through in the hidden layers and they
come into the final area and that's
where we have say one node or one neural
network entity that lights up that says
it's a bird what's in it for you we're
going to cover an introduction to the
CNN what is convolution neural network
how CNN recognizes images we're going to
dig deeper into that and really look at
the individual layers in the
convolutional neural network and finally
we do a use case implementation using
the CNN we'll begin our introduction to
the CNN by ining a pioneer of
convolutional neural network Yan leun he
was the director of Facebook AI research
group built the first convolutional
neural network called lenette in
1988 so these have been around for a
while and have had a chance to mature
over the years it was used for character
recognition tasks like reading zip code
digits imagine processing mail and
automating that process CNN is a feed
forward neural network that is generally
used to analyze visual images by
producing data with a grid-like topology
a CNN is also known as a convet and very
key to this is we are looking at images
that was what this was designed for and
you'll see the different layers as we
dig in Mirror some of the other some of
them are actually now used since we're
using uh tensorflow and carass in our
code later on you'll see that some of
those layers appear in a lot of your
other neural network Frameworks uh but
in this case this is very Central to
processing images and doing so in a
variety that captures multiple images
and really drills down into their
different features in this example here
you see flowers of two varieties Orchid
and a rose I think the Orchid is much
more dainty and beautiful and the rose
smells quite beautiful I have a couple
rose bushes in my yard uh they go into
the input layer that data is in sent to
all the different nodes in the next
layer one of the Hidden layers based on
its different weights and its setup it
then comes out and gives those a new
value those values then are multiplied
by their weights and go to the next
hidden layer and so on and then you have
the output layer and one of those notes
comes out and says it's an orchid and
the other one comes out and says it's a
rose depending on how was well it was
trained what separates the CNN or the
convolutional neural network from other
neural networks is a convolutional
operation forms a basis of any
convolutional neural network in a CNN
every image is represented in the form
of arrays of pixel values so here we
have a real image of the digit 8 uh that
then gets put onto its pixel values
represented in the form of an array in
this case you have a two-dimensional
array and then you can see in the final
in form we transform the digit 8 into
its representational form of pixels of
zeros and one where the ones represent
in this case the black part of the eight
and the zeros represent the white
background to understand the convolution
neural network or how that convolutional
operation Works we're going to take a
side step and look at matrixes in this
case we're going to simplify it we're
going to take two matrices A and B of
one dimension now kind of separate this
from your thinking as we learned that
you want to focus just on the Matrix
aspect of this and then we'll bring that
back together and see what that looks
like when we put the pieces for the
convolutional operation here we've set
up two arrays we have uh in this case
there a single Dimension Matrix and we
have a = 5
37597 and we have Bal 1 23 so in the
convolution as it comes in there it's
going to look at these two and we're
going to start by doing multiplying them
a * B and so we multiply the arrays
element wise and we get 5
66 where five is the 5 * 1 6 is 3 * 2
and then the other six is 2 * 3 and
since the two arrays aren't the same
size they're not the same setup we're
going to just truncate the first one and
we're going to look at the second array
multiplied just by the first three
elements of the first array now that
going to be a little confusing remember
a computer gets to repeat these
processes hundreds of times so we're not
going to just forget those other numbers
later on we'll see we'll bring those
back in and then we have the sum of the
product in this case 5 + 6 + 6 equal 17
so in our a * B our very first digit in
that Matrix of a * B is 17 and if you
remember I said we're not going to
forget the other digits so we now have
325 we move one set over and we take 325
and we multiply that * B and you'll see
that 3 * 1 is 3 2 * 2 is 4 and so on and
so on we sum it up so now we have the
second digit of our a * B product in The
Matrix and we continue on with that same
thing so on and so on so then we would
go from uh 375 to 759 to 597 this short
Matrix that we have for a we've now
covered all the different entities in a
that match three different levels of B
now in a little bit we're going to cover
where we use this math at this
multiplying of matrixes and how that
works uh but it's important to
understand that we're going through the
Matrix and multiplying the different
parts to it to match the smaller Matrix
with the larger Matrix I know a lot of
people get lost at is you know what's
going on here with these matrixes uh oh
scary math not really that scary when
you break it down we're looking at a
section of a and we're comparing it to B
so when you break that down your mind
like that you realize okay so I'm I'm
just taking these two matrixes and
comparing them and I'm bringing the
value down into one Matrix a * B we're
producing that information in a way that
will help the computer see different
aspects let's go ahead and flip over
again back to our images here we are
back to our images talking about going
to the most basic two-dimensional image
you can get to consider the following
two images the image for the symbol
backs slash when you press the back
slash the above image is processed and
you can see there for the image for the
forward slash is the opposite so when we
click the forward slash button that
flips uh very basic we have four pixels
going in can't get any more basic than
that here we have a little bit more
complicated picture we take a real image
of a smiley face um then we represent
that in the form of black and white
pixels so if this was an image in the
computer it's black and white and like
we saw before we convert this into the
zeros and one so where the other one
would have just been a matrix of just
four dots now we have a significantly
larger image coming in so don't worry
we're going to bring this all together
here in just a little bit layers in
convolutional neural network when we're
looking at this we have our convolution
layer and that really is the central
aspect of processing images in the
convolutional neural network that's why
we have it and then that's going to be
feeding in and you have your reu layer
which is you know as we talked about the
rectified linear unit we'll talk about
that a little bit later the reu is an
how it Act is how that layer is
activated is the math behind it what
makes the neurons fire you'll see that
in a lot of other neural networks when
you're using it just by itself it's for
proc processing smaller amounts of data
where you use the atom activation
feature for large data coming in now
because we're processing small amounts
of data in each image the reu layer
works great you have your pooling layer
that's where you're pulling the data
together pooling is a neural network
term it's very commonly used I like to
use a term reduce so if you're coming
from the map and reduce side you'll see
that we're mapping all this data through
all these networks and then we're going
to reduce it we're going to pull it
together and then finally we have the
fully connected layer that's where our
output's going to come out so we have
started to look at matrixes we've
started to look at the convolutional
layer and where it fits in and
everything we've taken a look at images
so we're going to focus more on the
convolution layer since this is a
convolutional neural network a
convolution layer has a number of
filters and perform convolution
operation every image is considered as a
matrix of pixel values consider the
following 5x5 image whose pixel values
are only zero and one now obviously when
we're dealing with color there's all
kinds of things that come in on color
processing but we want to keep it simple
and just keep it black and white and so
we have our image pixels uh so we're
sliding the filter Matrix over the image
and Computing the dot product to detect
the patterns and right here you're going
to ask where does this filter come from
this is a bit confusing because the
filter is going to be derived uh later
on we build the filters when we program
or train our model so you don't need to
worry what the filter actually is what
you do need to understand how a
convolution layer works is what is the
filter doing filter and you'll have many
filters you don't have just one filter
you'll have lots of filters that are
going to look for different aspects and
so the filter might be looking for just
edges it might be looking for different
parts we'll cover that a little bit more
detail in a minute right now we're just
focusing on how the filter works as a
matrix remember earlier we talked about
multiplying matrixes together and here
we have our two-dimensional Matrix and
you can see we take the filter and we
multiply it in the upper left image and
you can see right here 1 * 1 1 * 0 1 * 1
we multiply those all together then sum
them and we end up with a convolved
feature of four we're going to take that
and sliding the filter Matrix over the
image and Computing the dot product to
detect patterns so we're just going to
slide this over we're going to predict
the first one and slide it over one
notch predict the second one and so on
and so on all the way through until we
have a new Matrix and this Matrix which
is the same size as a fil filter has
reduced the image and whatever filter
whatever that's filtering out it's going
to be looking at just those features
reduced down to a smaller uh Matrix so
once the feature maps are extracted the
next step is to move them to the ru
layer so the realu layer The Next Step
first is going to perform an element
wise operation so each of those Maps
coming in if there's negative pixels so
it says all the negative pixels to zero
um and you can see this nice graph where
it just zeros out the negatives and then
you have a value that goes from zero up
to whatever value is coming out of the
Matrix this introduces nonlinearity to
the network uh so up until now we have a
we say linearity we're talking about the
fact that the feature has a value so
it's a linear feature this feature um
came up and it has let's say the feature
is the edge of the beak you know it's
like or the backslash that we saw um
you'll look at that and say okay this
feature has a value from -10 to 10 10 in
this case um if it was one and say yeah
this might be a beak it might not might
be an edge right there a minus 5 means
no we're not even going to look at it to
zero and so we end up with an output and
the output takes all these feature all
these filtered features remember we're
not just running one filter on this
we're running a number of filters on
this image and so we end up with an
rectified feature map that is looking at
just the features coming through and how
they weigh in from our filters so here
we have an input of a looks like a
twocan
bird very exotic looking real image is
scanned in multiple convolution and the
reu layers for locating features and you
can see up here is turned it into a
black and white image and in this case
we're looking in the upper right hand
corner for a feature and that box scans
over a lot of times it doesn't scan one
pixel at a time a lot of times it will
Skip by two or three or four pixels uh
to speed up the process that's one of
the ways you can compensate if you don't
have enough resources on your
computation for large images and it's
not just one filter slowly goes across
the image uh you have multiple filters
that been programmed in there so you're
looking at a lot of different filters
going over the different aspects of the
image and just sliding across there and
forming a new Matrix one more aspect to
note about the reu layer is we're not
just having one reu coming in uh so not
only do we have multiple features going
through but we're generating multiple
reu layers for locating the feature
that's very important to note you know
so we have a quite a bundle we have
multiple filters multiple railu uh which
brings us to the next step forward
propagation now we're going to look at
the pooling layer the rectified feature
map now goes through a pooling layer
pooling is a down sampling operation
that reduces the dimensionality of the
feature map that's all we're trying to
do we're trying to take a huge amount of
information and reduce it down to a
single answer this is a specific kind of
bird this is an iris this is a rose so
you have a rectified feature map and you
see here we have a rectified feature map
coming in um we set the max pooling with
a 2x2 filters and a stride of Two And if
you remember correctly I talked about
not going one pixel at a time uh well
that's where the stride comes in we end
up with a 2X two pulled feature map but
instead of moving one over each time and
looking at every possible combination we
skip a we skip a few there we go by two
we skip every other pixel and we just do
every other one um and this reduces is
our rectified feature map which as you
can see over here 16x 16 to a 4x4 so
we're continually trying to filter and
reduce our data so that we can get to
something we can manage and over here
you see that we have the Max uh 34 one
and two and in the max pooling we're
looking for the max value a little bit
different than what we were looking at
before so coming from the rectified
feature we're now finding the max value
and then we're pulling those features
together so instead of to think of this
as image of the map think of this as how
valuable is a feature in that area how
much of a feature value do we have and
we just want to find the best or the
maximum feature for that area they might
have that one piece of the filter of the
beak said oh I see a one in this beak in
this image and then it skips over and
says I see a three in this image and
says oh this one is rated as a four we
don't want to sum it together cuz then
you know you might have like five ones
and I'll say ah five but you might have
uh four zeros and one 10 and that tin
says well this is definitely a beak
where the ones will say probably not a
beak a little strange analogy since
we're looking at a bird but you can see
how that pulled feature map comes down
and we're just looking for the max value
in each one of those matrixes pooling
layer uses different filters to identify
different parts of the image like edges
corners body feathers eyes beak Etc um I
know I focus mainly on the beak but
obviously uh each feature could be each
a different part of the bird coming in
so let's take a look at at what that
looks like structure of a convolution
neural network so far this is where
we're at right now we have our input
image coming in and then we use our
filters and there's multiple filters on
there that are being developed to kind
of twist and change that data and so we
multiply the matrixes we take that
little filter maybe it's a 2 by two we
multiply it by each piece of the image
and if we step two then it's every other
piece of the image that generates
multiple convolution layers so we have a
number of convolution layers we have um
set up in there is looking at that data
we then take those convolution layers we
run them through the reu setup and then
once we've done through the reu setup
and we have multiple reu going on
multiple layers that are reu then we're
going to take those multiple layers and
we're going to be pooling them so now we
have the pooling layers or multiple
poolings going on up until this point
we're dealing with uh sometimes it's
multiple Dimensions you can have three
dimensions some strange data setups that
aren't doing images but looking at other
things they can have four five six seven
dimensions uh so right now we're looking
at 2D image Dimensions coming in into
the pooling layer so the next step is we
want to reduce those Dimensions or
flatten them so flattening flattening is
a process of converting all of the
resultant two-dimensional arrays from
pulled feature map into a single long
continuous linear Vector so over here
you see where we have a pulled feature
map maybe that's the bird wing and it
has values 6847 and we want to just
flatten this out and turn it into 6847
or a single linear vector and we find
out that not only do we do each of the
pulled feature Maps we do all of them
into one long linear Vector so now we've
gone through our convolutional neural
network part and we have the input layer
into the next setup all we've done is
taken all those different pooling layers
and we flatten them out and combine them
into a single linear Vector going in so
after we've done the flattening we have
a just a quick recap because we've
covered so much so it's important to go
back and take a look at each of the
steps we've gone through the structure
of the network so far is we have our
convolution where we twist it and we
filter it and multiply the matrixes we
end up with our convolutional layer
which uses the reu to figure out the
values going out into the pooling and
you have numerous convolution layers
that then create numerous pooling layers
pooling that data together which is the
max value which one we want to send
forward we want to send the best value
and then we're going to take all of that
from each of the pooling layers and
we're going to flatten it and we're
going to combine them into a single
input going into the final layer once
you get to that step you might be
looking at that going boy that looks
like the normal into it to most neural
network and you're correct it is so once
we have the flattened Matrix from the
pooling layer that becomes our input so
the pooling layer is fed as an input to
the fully connected layer to classify
the image and so you can see as our
flattened Matrix comes in in this case
we have the pixels from the flatten
Matrix fed as an input back to our
twocan or whatever that kind of bird
that is um I need one of these to
identify what kind of bird that is it
comes into our Ford propagation network
uh and that will then have the different
weights coming down across and then
finally it selects that that's a bird
and that it's not a dog or a cat in this
case even though it's not labeled the
final layer there in red is our output
layer our final output layer that says
bird cat or dog so quick recap of
everything we've covered so far we have
our input image which is twisted and M
multiply the filters are multiplied
times the matri the two matrixes
multiplied all the filters to create our
convolution layer our convolution layers
there's multiple layers in there because
it's all building multiple layers off
the different filters then goes through
the reu as say activation and that
creates our pooling and so once we get
into the pooling layer we then in the
pooling look for who's the best what's
the max value coming in from our
convolution and then we take that layer
and we flatten it and then it goes into
a fully connected layer our fully
connected neural network and then to the
output and here we can see the entire
process how the CNN recognizes a bird
this is kind of nice because it's
showing the little pixels and where
they're going you can see the filter is
generating this convolution network and
that filter shows up in the bottom part
of the convolution network and then
based on that it uses the relo for the
pooling the pooling then find out which
one's the best and so on all the way to
the fully connected layer at the end or
the classification and the output layer
so that'd be a classification neural
network at the end so we covered a lot
of theory up till now and you can
imagine each one of these steps has to
be broken down in code so putting that
together can be a little complicated not
that each step of the process is overly
complicated but because we have so many
steps uh we have 1 two three four five
different steps going on here with
substeps in there we're going to break
that down and walk through that in code
so in our use case implementation using
the CNN we'll be using the CFR 10 data
set from Canadian Institute for advanced
research for classifying images across
10 categories Unfortunately they don't
let me know whether it's going to be a
toucan or some other kind of bird but we
do get to find out whether it can
categorize between a ship a frog deer
bird airplane automobile cat dog horse
truck so that's a lot of fun and if
you're looking anything in the news at
all of our automated cars and everything
else you can see where this kind of
processing is so important in today's
world and Cutting Edge as far as what's
coming out in the commercial deployment
I mean this is really cool stuff we're
starting to see this just about
everywhere in Industry uh so great time
to be playing with this and figuring it
all out let's go ahead and dive into the
code and see what that looks like when
we're actually writing our script before
we go on let's do uh one more quick look
at what we have here let's just take a
look at data batch one keys and remember
in Jupiter notebook I can get by with
not doing the print statement if I put a
variable down there it'll just display
the variable and you can see under data
batch one for the keys since this is a
dictionary we have the batch one label
data and file names uh so you can
actually see how it's broken up in our
data set so for the next step or step
four as we're calling it uh we want to
display the image using Matt plot
Library there's many ways to display the
images you could even uh well there's
other ways to drill into it but map plot
library is really good for this and
we'll also look at our first reshape uh
setup or shape the data so you can have
a little glimpse into what that means uh
so we're going to start by importing our
map plot and of course since I am doing
jupyter notebook I need to do the
matplot inline command so it shows up on
my page so here we go we're going to
import matplot library. pipot is PLT and
if you remember map plot Library the P
plot is like a canvas that we paint
stuff onto and there's my percentage
sign map plot library in line so it's
going to show up in my notebook and then
of course we're going to import ort
numpy as NP for our numbers python array
setup and let's go ahead and set u x
equals to data batch one so this will
pull in all the data going into the x
value and then because this is just a
long stream of binary data uh we need to
go a little bit of reshaping so in here
we have to go ahead and reshape the data
we have 10,000 images okay that looks
correct and this is kind of an
interesting thing it took me a little
bit to I had to go research this myself
to figure out what's going on with this
data and what it is is it's a 32x 32
picture and let me do this let me go
ahead and do a drawing pad on here uh so
we have 32 bits by 32 bits and it's in
color so there's three bits of color now
I don't know why the data is
particularly like this it probably has
to do with how they originally encoded
it but most pictures put the three
afterward so what we're doing here is
we're going to take uh the shape we're
going to take the data which is just a
long stream of information and we're
going to break it up into 10,000 pieces
and those 10,000 pieces then are broken
into three pieces each and those three
pieces then are 32x 32 you could look at
this like an oldfashioned projector
where they have the red screen or the
red projector the blue projector and the
green projector and they add them all
together and each one of those is a 32x
32 bit so that's probably how this was
originally formatted was in that kind of
Ideal things have changed so we're going
to transpose it and we're going to take
the three which was here and we're going
to put it at the end so the first part
is reshaping the data from a single line
of bit data or whatever format it is
into 10,000 by 3x 32x 32 and then we're
going to transpose the color factor to
the last place so it's the image then
the 32x 32 in the middle that's this
part right here and then finally we're
going to take this uh which is three
bits of data and put it at the end so
it's more like we do we process images
now and then as type this is really
important that we're going to use an
integer 8 you can come in here and
you'll see a lot of these they'll try to
do this with a float or a float 64 what
you got to remember though is a float
uses a lot of memory so once you switch
this into uh something that's not
integer 8 which is goes up to 128 you
are just going to the the amount of ram
let me just put that in here is going to
go way up the amount of RAM that it
loads uh so you want to go ahead and use
this you can try the other ones and see
what happens if you have a lot of RAM on
your computer but for this exercise this
will work just fine and let's go ahead
and take that and run this so now our X
variable is all loaded and it has all
the images in it from the batch one data
batch one and just to show we were
talking about with the as type on there
if we go ahead and take x0 and just look
for its max value let me go ahead and
run that uh you'll see it doesn't oops I
said 128 it's 255 uh you'll see it
doesn't go over 255 because it's an
basically an asky character is what
we're keeping that down to we're keeping
those values down so they're only 255 0
to 255 versus a float value which would
bring this up um exponentially in size
and since we're using the map plot
Library we can do um oops that's not
what I wanted since we're using the map
plot Library we can take our canvas and
just do a PLT do IM for image show and
let's just take a look at what x0 looks
like and it comes in I'm not sure what
that is but you can see it's a very low
grade image uh broken down to the
minimal pixels on there and if we did
the same thing oh let's do uh let's see
what one looks like hopefully it's a
little easier to see run on there not
enter let's hit the run on that uh and
we can see this is probably a semi
that's a good guess on there and I can
just go back up here instead of typing
the same line in over and over and we'll
look at three uh that looks like a dump
truck unloading uh and so on you can do
any of the 10,000 images we can just
jump to 55 uh looks like some kind of
animal looking at us there probably a
dog and just for fun let's do just one
more uh uh run on there and we can see a
nice car for image number four uh so you
can see we past through all the
different images and it's very easy to
look at them and they've been reshaped
to fit our view and what the uh matap
plot Library uses for its format so the
next step is we're going to start
creating some helper functions we will
start by a one hot encoder to help us
we're processing the data remember that
your labels they can't just be words
they have to switch it and we use the
one hot encoder to do that and then
we'll also create a uh class uh CFR
helper so it's going to have a knit and
a setup for the images and then finally
we'll go ahead and run that code so you
can see what that looks like and then we
get into the fun part where we're
actually going to start creating our
model our actual neural network model so
let's start by creating our one H
encoder we're going to create our own
here uh and it's going to return an out
and we'll have our Vector coming in and
our values equal 10 what this means is
that we have the 10 values the 10
possible labels and remember we don't
look at the labels as a number cuz a car
isn't one more than a horse that'd be
just kind of bizarre to have horse
equals zero car equals 1 plane equals 2
cat equals three so a cat plus a car
equals what uh so instead we create a
numpy aray of zeros and there's going to
be 10 values so we have 10 different
values in there so you have uh zero or
one one means it's a cat zero means it's
not a cat um in the next line it might
be that uh one means it's a car zero
means it's not a car so instead of
having one output with a value of 0 to
10 you have 10 outputs with the values
of 0 to one that's what the one hot
incoder is doing here and we're going to
utilize this in code in just a minute so
let's go ahead and take a look at the
next helpers we have a few of these
helper functions we're going to build
and when you're working with a very
complicated python project dividing it
up into separate definitions in classes
is very important otherwise it just
becomes really ungainly to work with so
let's go ahead and put in our next
helper uh which is a class and this is a
lot in this class so we we'll break it
down here let's just start uh oop we put
a space right in there there we go that
is a little bit more readable at a
second space so we're going to create
our class the cipher Helper and we'll
start by initializing it now there's a
lot going on in here so let's start with
the uh nit part uh self. I equal zero
that'll come in in a little bit we'll
come back to that in the lower part we
want to initialize our training batches
so when we went through this there was
like a meta batch we don't need the meta
batch but we do need the data batch 1 2
3 4 five and we do not want the testing
batch in here this is just the self all
train batches so we're going to come
make an array of of all those different
images and then of course we left the
test batch out so we have our self. test
batch uh we're going to initialize the
training images and the training labels
and also the test images and the test
labels so these are just this is just to
initialize these variables in here then
we create another definition down here
and this is going to set up the images
let's just take a look and see what's
going on in there now we could have all
just put this as part of the uh init
part uh since this is all just helper
stuff but breaking it up again makes it
easier to read it also makes it easier
when we start executing the different
pieces to see what's going on so that
way we have a nice print statement to
say hey we're now running this and this
is what's going on in here we're going
to set up these self trining images at
this point and that's going to go to a
numpy array vstack and in there we're
going to load up uh in this case the
data for D and S all train batches again
that points right up to here so we're
going to go through each one of these uh
files or each one of these data sets CU
they're not a file anymore we've brought
them in data batch one points to the
actual data and so our self-training
images is going to stack them all into
our into a numpy array and then it's
always nice to get the training length
and that's just a total number of uh
self-training images in there and then
we're going to take the selft trining
images and let me switch marker colors
CU I am getting a little too much on the
markers up here oops there we go bring
down our marker change so we can see it
a little better and at this point this
should look familiar where did we see
this well when we wanted to uh uh look
at this above and we wanted to look at
the images in the matplot library we had
to reshape it so we're doing the same
thing here we're taking our
self-training images and uh based on the
training length total number of images
because we stacked them all together so
now it's just one large file of images
we're going to take and look at it as
our our three video cameras that are
each displaying uh 30 32x 32 we're going
to switch that around so that now we
have um each of our images that stays
the same place and then we have our 32x
32 and then by our three our last our
three different values for the color and
of course we want to go ahead and uh
they run this where you say divide by
255 that was from earlier it just brings
all the data into 0 to one that's what
this is doing so we're turning this into
a 0 to one array which is uh all the
pictures 32x 32x 3 and then we're going
to take the self-training labels and
we're going to pump those through our
one hot encoder we just made and we're
going to stack them together and uh
again we're converting this into an
array that goes from uh instead of
having horse equals 1 dog equals 2 and
then horse plus dog would equal three
which would be cat no it's going to be
uh you know an array of 10 where each
one is 0o to one then we want to go
ahead and set up our test imag and
labels and uh when we're doing this
you're going to see it's the same thing
we just did with the rest of it let me
just change colors right here this is no
different than what we were doing up
here with our training Set uh we're
going to stack the different uh images
uh we're going to get the length of them
so we know how many images are in there
uh you certainly could add them by hand
but it's nice to let the computer do it
especially if it ever changes on the
other end and you're using other data
and again we reshape them and transpose
them and we also do the one hot encoder
same thing we just did on our training
images so now our test images are in the
same format so now we have a definition
which sets up all our images in there
and then the next step is to go ahead
and batch them or next batch and let's
do another breakout here for batches
because this is really important to
understand T to throw me for a little
Loop when I'm working with tensor flow
or carass or a lot of these we have our
data coming in if you remember we had
like 10,000 photos let me just put
10,000 down here we don't want to run
all 10,000 at once so we want to break
this up into batch sizes and you also
remember that we had the number of
photos and this case uh length of test
or whatever number is in there uh we
also have 32 by 32 by 3 so when we're
looking at the batch size we want to
change this from 10,000 to um a batch of
in this case I think we're going to do
batches of 100 so we want to look at
just 100 the first 100 of the photos and
if you remember we set selfi equal to
zero uh so what we're looking at here is
we're going to create X we're going to
get the next batch from the very
initialized we've already initialized it
for zero so we're going to look at X
from zero to batch size which we set to
100 so just the first 100 images and
then we're going to reshape that into uh
and this is important to let the data
know that we're looking at 100x 32x 32x
3 now we've already formatted it to the
32x 32x 3 this just sets everything up
correctly so that X has the data in
there in the correct order and the
correct shape and then the Y just like
the X uh is our labels so our training
labels again they go from zero to batch
size in this case they do selfi plus
batch size because the selfi is going to
keep changing and then finally we
increment the selfi because we have zero
so we so the next time we call it we're
going to get the next batch size and so
basically we have X and Y X being the
photograph data coming in and Y being
the label and that of course is labeled
through one hot encoder so if you
remember correctly if it was say horse
is equal to zero it would be um one for
the zero position since this is the
horse and then everything else would be
zero in here just put lines through
there there we go there's our array hard
to see that array so let's go ahead and
take that and uh we're going to finish
loading it since this is our class and
now we're armed with all this um uh our
setup over here let's go ahead and load
that up and so we're going to create a
variable CH with the CFR helper in it
and then we're going to do ch. setup
images uh now we could have just put all
the setup images under the init but by
breaking this up into two parts it makes
it much more readable and um also if
you're doing other work there's reasons
to do that as far as the setup let's go
ahead and run that and you can see where
it says uh setting up training images
and labels setting up test images and
that's one of the reasons we broke it up
is so that if you're testing this out
you can actually have print statements
in there telling you what's going on
which is really nice uh they did a good
job with this setup I like the way that
it was broken up in the back and then
one quick note you want to remember that
batch to set up the next batch so we
have to run uh batch equals CH next
batch of 100 because we're going to use
the 100 size uh but we'll come back to
that we're going to use that just
remember that that's part of our code
we're going to be using in a minute from
the definition we just made so now we're
ready to create our model first thing we
want to do is we want to import our
tensor flow as TF I'll just go ahead and
run that so it's loaded up and you can
see we got a a warning here uh that's
because they're making some changes it's
always growing and they're going to be
depreciating one of the uh values from
float 64 to float type or it's treated
as an NP float 64 uh nothing to really
worry about CU this doesn't even affect
what we're working on because we've set
all of our stuff to a 255 value or 0o to
one and do keep in mind that 0o to one
value that we converted to 255 is still
a float value but it'll easily work with
either the numpy float 64 or the numpy
dtype float it doesn't matter which one
it goes through so the depreciation
would not affect our code as we have it
and in our tensor flow uh we'll go ahead
let me just increase the size in there
just a moment so you can get better view
of the um what we're typing in uh we're
going to set a couple placeholders here
and so we have we're going to set x
equals TF placeholder TF float 32 we
just talked about the float 64 versus
the numpy float we're actually just
going to keep this at float 32 more than
a significant number of decimals for
what we're working with and since it's a
placeholder we're going to set the shape
equal to and we've set it equal to none
because at this point we're just holding
the place on there we'll be setting up
as we run the batches that's what the
first value is and then 32x 32x 3 that's
what we reshaped our data to fit in and
then we have our y true equals
placeholder T of float 32 and the shape
equals none comma 10 10 is the 10
different labels we have so it's an
array of 10 and then let's create one
more placeholder we'll call this a hold
prob or hold probability and we're going
to use this we don't have to have a
shape or anything for this this
placeholder is for what we call Dropout
if you remember from our Theory before
we drop out so many nodes is looking at
or the different values going through
which helps decrease bias so we need to
go ahead and put a a placeholder for
that also and we'll run this so it's all
loaded up in there so we have our three
different placeholders and since we're
in tensor flow when you use carass it
does some of this automatically but
we're in tensor flow direct sits on
tensor flow we're going to go ahead and
create some more helper functions we're
going to create something to help us
initialize the weights initialize our
bias if you remember that each uh layer
has to have a bias going in we're going
to go ahead and work on our our
conversional 2D our Max pool so we have
our pooling layer our convolutional
layer and then our normal full layer so
we're going to go ahead put those all
into definitions and let's see what that
looks like in code and you can also grab
some of these helper functions from the
MN the uh nist setup let me just put
that in there if you're under the tensor
flow so a lot of these are already in
there but we're going to go ahead and do
our own and we're going to create our uh
a knit weight and one of the reasons
we're doing this is so that you can
actually start thinking about what's
going on in the back end so even though
there's ways to do this with an
automation sometimes these have to be
tweaked and you have to put in your own
setup in here uh now we're not going to
be doing that we're just going to
recreate them for our code and let's
take a look at this we have our weights
and so what comes in is going to be the
shape and what comes out is going to be
uh random numbers so we're going to go
ahead and just knit some random numbers
based on the shape with a standard
deviation of 0.1 kind of a fun way to do
that and then the TF variable uh in nit
random distribution so we're just
creating a random distribution on there
that's all that is for the weights now
you might change that you might have a a
higher standard deviation in some cases
you actually load preset weights that's
pretty rare usually you're testing that
against another model or something like
that and you want to see how those
weights configure with each other uh now
remember we have our bias so we need to
go ahead and initialize the bias with a
constant uh in this case we're using 0.1
a lot of times the bias is just put in
as one and then you have your weights to
add on to that uh but we're going to set
this as 0.1 uh so we want to return a
convolutional 2d in this case a neural
network this is uh would be a layer on
here what's going on on with the con 2D
is we're taking our data coming in uh
we're going to filter it strides if you
remember correctly strides came from
here's our image and then we only look
at this picture here and then maybe we
have a stride of one so we look at this
picture here and we continue to look at
the different filters going on there the
other thing this does is that we have
our data coming in as
32 by 32 by three and we want to change
this so that it's just this is three
dimensions and it's going to reformat
this as just two Dimensions so it's
going to take this number here and
combine it with the 32x 32 so this is a
very important layer here CU it's
reducing our data down using different
means and it connects down I'm just
going to jump down one here uh it goes
with the convolutional layer so you have
your your kind of your pre- formatting
and the setup and then you have your
actual convolution layer that goes
through on there and you can see here we
have a nit weights by the shape a knit
bias shape of three because we have the
three different uh here's our three
again and then we return the tfnn relu
with the convention 2D so this
convolutional uh has this feeding into
it right there it's using that as part
of it and of course the input is the XY
plus b the bias so that's quite a
mouthful but these two are the are the
keys here to creating the convolutional
layers there the convolutional 2D coming
in and then the convolutional layer
which then steps through and creates all
those filters we saw then of course we
have our pooling uh so after each time
we run it through the convectional layer
we want to pull the data uh if you
remember correctly on the on the pool
side and let me just get rid of all my
marks it's getting a little crazy there
and in fact let's go ahead and jump back
to that slide let's just take a look at
that slide over here uh so we have our
image coming in we create our
convolutional layer with all the filters
remember the filters go um you know the
filter is coming in here and it looks at
these four boxes and then if it's a step
let's say step two and then goes to
these four boxes and then the next step
and so on uh so we have our
convolutional layer that we generate or
convolutional layers they use the uh reu
function um there's other functions out
there for this though the reu is the uh
most the one that works the best at
least so far I'm sure that will change
then we have our pooling now if you
remember correctly the pooling was Max
uh so if we had the filter coming in and
they did the multiplication on there and
we have a one and maybe a two here and
another one here and a three here three
is the max and so out of all of these
you then create an array that would be
three and if the max is over here two or
whatever it is that's what goes into the
pooling of what's going on in our
pooling uh so again we're reducing that
data down we're reducing it down as
small as we can and then finally we're
going to flatten it out into a single
array and that goes into our fully
connected layer and you can see that
here in the code right here we're going
to create our normal full layer um so at
some point we're going to take from our
pooling layer this will go into some
kind of flattening process and then that
will be fed into the full the different
layers going in down here um and so we
have our input size you'll see our input
layer get shape which is just going to
get the shape for whatever is coming in
uh and then input size initial weights
is also based on uh the input layer
coming in and the input size down here
is based on the input layer shape so
we're just going to already use the
shape and already have our size coming
in and of course uh you have to make
sure you init the bias always put your
bias on there and we'll do that based on
the size so this will return tf. matmo
input layer w+b this is just a normal
full layer that's what this means right
down here that's what we're going to
return so that was a lot of steps we
went through let's go ahead and run that
so those are all loaded in there and
let's go ahead and uh create the layers
let's see what that looks like now that
we've done all the heavy lifting and
everything uh we get to do all the easy
part let's go ahead and create our
layers we'll create a convolution layer
one and two two different convolutional
layers and then we'll take that and
we'll flatten that out create a a
reshape pooling in there for our reshape
and then we'll have our full uh layer at
the end so let's start by creating our
first uh convolutional layer then we
come in here and let me just run that
real quick and I want you to notice on
here the three and the 32 this is
important because coming into this
convolutional layer we have three
different channels and 32 pixels each uh
so that has to be in there the four and
four you can play with this is your
filter size so if you remember you have
a filter and you have your image and the
filter slowly steps over and filters out
this image depending on what your step
is for this particular setup 44 is just
fine that should work pretty good for
what we're doing and for the size of the
image and then of course at the end once
you you have your convolutional layer
set up you also need to pull it and
you'll see that the pooling is
automatically set up so that it would
see the different shape based on what's
coming in so here we have Max Two by 2
by two and we put in the convolutional
one that we just created the
convolutional layer we just created goes
right back into it and that right up
here as you can see is the X it's coming
in from here so it knows to look at the
first model and set the the data
accordingly set that up so it matches
and we went ahead and ran this already I
think I ran it let me go and run it
again and if we're going to do one layer
let's go ahead and do a second layer
down here and it's uh we'll call it
convo 2 it's also a convolutional layer
on this and you'll see that we're
feeding convolutional one in the pooling
so it goes from convolutional one into
convolutional one pooling from
convolutional one pooling into
convolutional two and then from
convolutional two into convolutional 2
pooling and we'll go ahead and take this
and run this so these variables are all
loaded into memory and for our flattened
layer uh let's go ahead and we'll do uh
since we have 64 coming out of here and
we have a 4x4 going in let's do 8X 8 by
64 so let's do
4,096 this is going to be the flat layer
so that's how many bits are coming
through on the flat layer and we'll
reshape this so we'll reshape our convo
two pooling and that will feed into here
the convo two pooling and then we're
going to set it up as a single layer
that's four 96 in size that's what that
means there we'll go ahead and run this
so we've now created this variable the
convo two flat and then we have our
first full layer this is the final uh
neural network where we have the flat
layer going in and we're going to again
use the uh reu for our uh setup on there
on a neural network for evaluation and
you'll notice that we're going to create
our first full layer our normal full
layer that's our definition so we
created that that's creating the normal
full layer and our input for the data
comes right here from the this goes
right into it uh the convo to flat so
this tells it how big the data is and
we're going to have it come out it's
going to have uh 1024 that's how big the
layer is coming out we'll go ahead and
run this so we now we have our full
layer one and with the full layer one we
want to also Define the full one Dropout
to go with that so our full layer one
comes in uh keep probability equals hold
probability remember we created that
earlier and the full layer one is what's
coming into it and this is going
backwards and training the data we're
not training every weight we're only
training a percentage of them each time
which helps get rid of the bias so let
me go ahead and run that and uh finally
we'll go ahead and create a y predict
which is going to equal the normal full
one Dropout and 10 cuz we have 10 labels
in there now in this neural network we
could have added additional layers that
would be another option to play with you
can also play with instead of 1024 you
can use other numbers for the way that
sets up and what's coming out going into
the next one we're only going to do just
the one layer and the one layer Dropout
and you can see if we did another layer
it' be really easy just to feed in the
full one Dropout into full layer two and
then full Layer Two Dropout would have
full Layer Two feed into it and then
you'd switch that here for the Y
prediction for right now this is great
this particular data set is tried and
true and we know that this will work on
it and if we just type in y predict and
we run that uh we'll see the this is a
tensor object uh shape question mark 10
dtype 32 a quick way to double check
what we're working on so now we've got
all of our uh we've done a setup all the
way to the Y predict which we just did
uh we want to go ahead and apply the
loss function and make sure that's set
up in there uh create the optimizer and
then uh train our Optimizer and create a
variable to initialize all the global TF
variables so before we dive into the um
loss function let me point out one quick
thing or just kind of a rehap over a
couple things and that is when we're
playing with this these setups um we
pointed out up here we can change the 44
and use different numbers there they
change your outcome so depending on what
numbers you use here will have a huge
impact on how well your model fits and
that's the same here of the 1024 also
this is also another number that if you
continue to raise that number you'll get
um possibly a better fit you might over
fit and if you lower that number you'll
use less resources and generally you
want to use this in um the exponential
growth an exponential being 2 4 8 16 and
in this case the next one down would be
512 you can use any number there but
those would be the ideal numbers uh when
you look at this data so the next step
in all this is we need to also create uh
a way of tracking how good our model is
and we're going to call this a loss
function and so we're going to create a
cross entropy loss function and so
before we discuss exactly what that is
let's take a look and see what we're
feeding it uh we're going to feed it our
labels and we have our true labels and
our prediction labels uh so coming in
here is where're the two different uh
variables we're sending in or the two
different probability distributions is
one that we know is true and what we
think it's going to be now this function
right here when they talk about cross
entropy uh in information Theory the
cross entropy between two probability
distributions over the same underlying
set of events measures the average
number of bits needed to identify an
event drawn from the set that's a
mouthful uh really we're just looking at
the amount of error in here how many of
these are correct and how many of these
um are incorrect so how much of it
matches and we're going to look at that
we're just going to look at the average
that's what the mean the reduced to the
mean means here so we're looking at the
average error on this and so the next
step is we're going to take the error we
want to know our cross entropy or our
loss function how much loss we have
that's going to be part of how we train
the model so when you know what the loss
is and we're training it you feed that
back into the back propagation setup and
so we want to go ahead and optimize that
here's our Optimizer we're going to
create the optimizer using an atom
Optimizer remember there's a lot of
different ways of optimizing the data
atoms the most popular used uh so our
Optimizer is going to equal the TF train
atom Optimizer if you don't remember
what the learning rate is let me just
pop this back into here here our
learning rate when you have your weights
you have all your weights and your
different nodes that are coming out
here's our node coming out um and it has
all its weights and then the error is
being prop sent back through in reverse
on our neural network so we take this
error and we adjust these weights based
on the different formulas in this case
the atom formula is what we're using we
don't want to just adjust them
completely we don't want to change this
weight so it exactly fits the data
coming through because if we made that
kind of adjustment it's going to be
biased to whatever the last data we sent
through is instead we're going to
multiply that by 0.001 and make a very
small shift in this weight so our Delta
W is only 0.001 of the actual Delta W of
the full change we're going to compute
from the atom and then we want to go
ahead and train it so our training or
set up a training uh uh variable or
function and this is going to equal our
Optimizer minimize cross entropy and we
make sure we go ahead and run this so
it's loaded in there and then we're
almost ready to train our model but
before we do that we need to create one
more um variable in here and we're going
to create a variable to initialize all
the global TF variables and when we look
at this um the TF Global variable
initializer this is a tensor flow um
object it goes through there and it
looks at all our different setup that we
have going under our tensor flow and
then initializes those variables uh so
it's kind of like a magic W because it's
all hidden in the back end of tensor
flow all you need to know about this is
that you have have to have the
initialization on there which is an
operation um and you have to run that
once you have your setup going so we'll
go ahead and run this piece of code and
then we're going to go ahead and train
our data so let me run this so it's
loaded up there and so now we're going
to go ahead and run the model by
creating a graph session graph session
is a tener flow term so you'll see that
coming up it's one of the things that
throws me because I always think of
graphx and Spark and graph as just
general graphing uh but this talk about
a graph session so we're going to go
ahead and run the model and let's go
ahead and walk through this uh what's
going on here and let's paste this data
in here and here we go so we're going to
start off with the with the TF session
as sess so that's our actual TF session
we've created uh so we're right here
with the TF uh session our session we're
creating we're going to run TF Global
variable initializer so right off the
bat we're initializing our variables
here uh and then we have for I and range
500 so what's going on here remember 500
we're going to break the data up and
we're going to batch it in at 500 points
each we've created our session run so
we're going to do with TF session as
session right here we've created our
variable session uh and then we're going
to run we're going to go ahead and
initialize it so we have our TF Global
variables initializer that we created um
that initializes our our session in here
the next thing we're going to do is
we're going to go for I in range of 500
batch equals ch. nextt batch so if you
remember correctly this is loading up um
100 pictures at a time and uh this is
going to Loop through that 500 times so
we are literally doing uh what is that
uh 500 time 100 is uh 50,000 so that's
50,000 pictures we're going to process
right there in the first process is
we're going to do a session run we're
going to take our train we created our
train variable or Optimizer in there
we're going to feed it the dictionary uh
we had our feed Di AR that you created
and we have x equal batch 0 coming in y
true batch one hold the probability
05 and then just so that we can keep
track of what's going on we're going to
every uh 100 steps we're going to run a
print So currently onstep format C
accuracy is um and we're going to look
at matches equals tf. equal TF argument
y prediction one tf. AR Max y true comma
1 so we're going to look at this this is
how many matches it has and here our ACC
uh all we're doing here is we're going
to take the matches how many matches
they have it creates it generates a
chart we're going to convert that to
float that's what the TF cast does and
then we just want to know the average we
just want to know the average of the um
accuracy and then we'll go ahead and
print that out uh print session run
accuracy feed dictionary so it takes all
this and it prints out our accuracy on
there so let's go ahead and take this
oops screens there let's go ahead and
take this and let's run it and this is
going to take a little bit to run uh so
let's see what happens on my old laptop
and we'll see here that we have our
current uh we're currently on Step Zero
it takes a little bit to get through the
accuracy and this will take just a
moment to run we can see that on our
Step Zero it has an accuracy of 0.1 or
0.128 um and as it's running we'll go
ahead you don't need to watch it run all
the way but uh this accuracy is going to
change a little bit up and down so we've
actually lost some accuracy during our
step two
um but we'll see how that comes out
let's come back after we run it all the
way through and see how the different
steps come out I was actually reading
that backwards uh the way this works is
the closer we get to one the more
accuracy we have uh so you can see here
we've gone from a 01 to
a039 um and we'll go ahead and pause
this and come back and see what happens
when we're done with the full run all
right now that we've uh prepared the
meal got it in the oven and pulled out
my finished dish here if you've ever
watched uh any of the old cooking shows
let's discuss a little bit about this
accuracy going on here and how do you
interpret that we've done a couple
things first we've defined accuracy um
the reason I got it backwards before is
you have uh loss or accuracy and with
loss you'll get a graph that looks like
this it goes oops that's an S by the way
there we go you get a graph that curves
down like this and with accuracy you get
a graph that curves up this is how good
it's doing now in this case uh one is
supposed to be really good accuracy that
mean it gets close to one but it never
crosses one so if you have an accuracy
of one that is phenomenal um in fact
that's pretty much un you know unheard
of and the same thing with loss if you
have a loss of zero that's also unheard
of the zero is actually on this this
axes right here as we go in there so how
do we interpret that because you know if
I was looking at this and I go oh 0.51
that's uh 51% you're doing 5050 no this
is not percentage let me just put that
in there it is not not percentage uh
this is log rithmic what that means is
that 0. 2 is twice as good as1 and uh
when we see 0. 4 that's twice as good
as. 2 real way to convert this into a
percentage you really can't say this is
is a direct percentage conversion what
you can do though is in your head if we
were to give this a percentage uh we
might look at this as uh 50% we're just
guessing equals .1 and if 50% roughly
equals 0.1 that's where we started up
here at the top remember at the top here
here's our 0.128 the accuracy of 50%
then 75% is about 0.2 and so on and so
on don't quote those numbers because
that doesn't work that way they say that
if you have
.95 that's pretty much saying 100% And
if you have uh anywhere between you'd
have to go look this up let me go and
remove all my drawings there uh so the
magic number is 0.5 we really want to be
over a 0. five in this whole thing and
we have uh both 0504 remember this is
accuracy if we were looking at loss then
we'd be looking the other way but 0.0
you know instead of how high it is we
want how low it is uh but with accuracy
being over a 0 five is pretty valid that
means this is pretty solid and if you
get to a0 95 then it's a direct
correlation that's what we're looking
for here in these numbers you can see we
finished with this model at 5135 so
still good um and if we look at uh when
they ran this in the other end remember
there's a lot of Randomness that goes
into it when we see the weights uh they
got 05251 so a little better than ours
but that's fine you'll find your own uh
comes up a little bit better or worse
depending on uh just that Randomness and
so we've gone through the whole model
we've created we trained the model and
we've also gone through on every 100th
run to test the model to see how
accurate it is welcome to the the RNN
tutorial that's the recurrent neural
network so we talk about a feed forward
neural network in a feed forward neural
network information flows only in the
forward direction from the input nodes
through the hidden layers if any and to
the output nodes there are no Cycles or
Loops in the network and so you can see
here we have our input layer I was
talking about how it just goes straight
forward into the hidden layers so each
one of those connects and then connects
to the next hidden layer connects to the
output layer and of course we have a
nice simplified version where it has a
predicted output and the to the input as
x a lot of times and the output as y
decisions are based on current input no
memory about the past no future scope
why recurrent neural network issues in
feed forward neural network so one of
the biggest issues is because it doesn't
have a scope of memory or time a feed
forward neural network doesn't know how
to handle sequential data uh it only
considers only the current input so if
you have a series of things and because
three points back affects what's
happening now and what you're your
output affects what's happening that's
very important so whatever I put as an
output is going to affect the next one
um a feed forward doesn't look at any of
that it just looks at this is what's
coming in and it cannot memorize
previous inputs so it doesn't have that
list of inputs coming in solution to
feed forward neural network you'll see
here where it says recurrent neural
network and we have our X on the bottom
going to H going to Y that's your feed
forward uh but right in the middle it
has a value C so it's a whole another
process so it's memorizing what's going
on in the hidden layers and the hidden
layers as they produce data feed into
the next one so your hidden layer might
have an output that goes off to Y uh but
that output goes back into the next
prediction coming in what this does is
this allows it to handle sequential data
it considers the current input and also
the previously received inputs and if
we're going to look at General drawings
and um Solutions we should also look at
applications of the RNN image captioning
RNN is used to caption an image by
analyzing the activities present in it a
dog catching a ball in midair uh that's
very tough I mean you know we have a lot
of stuff that analyzes images of a dog
and the image of a ball but it's able to
add one more feature in there that's
actually catching the ball in midair
time series prediction any time series
problem like predicting the prices of
stocks in a particular month can be
solved using RNN and we'll dive into
that in our use case and actually take a
look at some stock one of the things you
should know about analyzing stock today
is that it is very difficult and if
you're analyzing the whole stock the
stock market at the New York Stock
Exchange in the US produces somewhere in
the neighborhood if you count all the
individual trades and fluctuations by
the second um it's like three terabytes
a day of data so we're only going look
at one stock just analyzing One stock is
really tricky in here we'll give you a
little jump on that so that's exciting
but don't expect to get rich off of it
immediately another application of the
RNN is natural language processing text
Mining and sentiment analysis can be
carried out using RNN for natural
language processing and you can see
right here the term natural language
processing when you stream those three
words together is very different than I
if I said processing language natural Le
so the time series is very important
when we're analyzing sentiments it can
change the whole value of a sentence
just by switching the words around or if
you're just counting the words you might
get one sentiment where if you actually
look at the order they in you get a
completely different sentiment when it
rains look for rainbows when it's dark
look for star s both of these are
positive sentiments and they're based
upon the order of which the sentence is
going in machine translation given an
input in one language RNN can be used to
translate the input into a different
languages as output I myself very
linguistically challenged but if you
study languages and you're good with
languages you know right away that if
you're speaking English you would say
big cat and if you're speaking Spanish
you would say cat big so that
translation is really important to get
the right order to get uh there's all
kinds of parts of speech that are
important to know by the order of the
words here this person is speaking in
English and getting translated and you
can see here a person is speaking in
English in this little diagram I guess
that's denoted by the flags I have a
flag I own it no um but they're speaking
in English and it's getting translated
into Chinese Italian French German and
Spanish languages some of the tools
coming out are just so cool so somebody
like myself who's very linguistic
challenged I can now travel into Worlds
I would never think of because I can
have something translate my English back
and forth readily and I'm not stuck with
a communication gap so let's dive into
what is a recurrent neural network
recurrent neural network works on the
principle of saving the output of a
layer and feeding this back to the input
in order to predict the output of the
layer sounds a little confusing when we
start breaking it down it'll make more
sense and usually we have a propagation
forward neural network with the input
layers the hidden layers the output
layer with the recurrent neural network
we turn that on its side so here it is
and now our X comes up from the bottom
into the hidden layers into Y and they
usually draw it very simplified X to H
with c as a loop a to Y where a B and C
are the perimeters a lot of times you'll
see this kind of drawing in here digging
closer and closer into the H and how it
works going from left to right you'll
see that the C goes in and then the X
goes in so the x is going Upward Bound
and C is going to the right a is going
out and C is also going out that's where
it gets a little confusing so here we
have xn uh CN and then we have y out and
C out and C is based on HT minus one so
our value is based on the Y and the H
value are connected to each other
they're not necessarily the same value
because H can be its own thing and
usually we draw this or we represent it
as a function h of T equals a function
of C where H of T minus one that's the
last h H output and x a t going in so
it's the last output of H combined with
the new input of x uh where HT is the
new state FC is a function with the
parameter C that's a common way of
denoting it uh HT minus one is the Old
State coming out and then xit T is an
input Vector at time of Step T well we
need to cover types of recurrent neural
networks and so the first one is the
most common one which is a one: one
single output one: one neural network is
usually known as a vanilla neural
network used for regular machine
learning problems why because vanilla is
usually considered kind of a just a real
basic flavor but because it's a very
basic a lot of times they'll call it the
vanilla neural network uh which is not
the common term but it is you know kind
of a slang term people will know what
you're talking about usually if you say
that then we run one to mini so you have
a single input and you might have a
multiple outputs in this case uh image
captioning as we looked at earlier where
we have not just looking at it as a do
but a dog catching a ball in the air and
then you have many to1 Network takes in
a sequence of inputs examples sentiment
analysis where a given sentence can be
classified as expressing positive or
negative sentiments and we looked at
that as we were discussing if it rains
look for a rainbow so positive sentiment
where rain might be a negative sentiment
if you were just adding up the words in
there and then of course if you're going
to do a one to one many to one one to
many there's many to many networks takes
in a sequence of input and generates a
sequence of outputs example machine
translation so we have a lengthy
sentence coming in in English and then
going out in all the different languages
uh you know just a wonderful tool very
complicated set of computations you know
if you're a translator you realize just
how difficult it is to translate into
different languages one of the biggest
things you need to understand when we're
working with this neural network is
what's called The Vanishing gradient
problem while training an RNN your slope
can be either too small or very large
and this this makes training difficult
when the slope is too small the problem
is known as Vanishing gradient and
you'll see here they have a nice U image
loss of information through time so if
you're pushing not enough information
forward that information is lost and
then when you go to train it you start
losing the third word in the sentence or
something like that or it doesn't quite
follow the full logic of what you're
working on exploding gradient problem Oh
this is one that runs into everybody
when you're working with this particular
neural network when the SL tends to grow
exponentially instead of decaying this
problem is called exploding gradient
issues in gradient problem long tring
time poor performance bad accuracy and
I'll add one more in there uh your
computer if you're on a lower-end
computer testing out a model will lock
up and give you the memory error
explaining gradient problem consider the
following two examples to understand
what should be the next word in the
sequence the person who took my bike and
blank a thief the students who got got
into engineering with blank from Asia
and you can see in here we have our x
value going in we have the previous
value going forward and then you back
propagate the error like you do with any
neural network and as we're looking for
that missing word maybe we'll have the
person took my bike and blank was a
thief and the student who got into
engineering with a blank were from Asia
consider the following example the
person who took the bike so we'll go
back to the person who took the bike was
blank a thief in order to understand
what would be the next word in the
sequence the RNN must memorize the
previous context whether the subject was
singular noun or a plural noun so was a
thief is singular the student who got
into engineering well in order to
understand what would be the next word
in the sequence the RNN must memorize
the previous context whether the subject
was singular noun or a plural noun and
so you can see here the students who got
into engineering with blank were from
Asia it might be sometimes difficult for
the era to back propagate to the
beginning of the sequence to predict
what should be the output so when you
run into the gradient problem we need a
solution the solution to the gradient
problem first we're going to look at
exploding gradient where we have three
different solutions depending on what's
going on one is identity initialization
so the first thing we want to do is see
if we can find a way to minimize the
identities coming in instead of having
it identify everything just the
important information we're looking at
next is to truncate the back propagation
so instead of having uh whatever
information it's sending to the next
series we can truncate what it's sending
we can lower that particular uh set of
layers make those smaller and finally is
a gradient clipping so when we're
training it we can clip what that
gradient looks like and uh narrow the
training model that we're using when you
have a Vanishing gradient the OPA
problem uh we can take a look at weight
initialization very similar to the
identity but we're going to add more
weights in there so it can identify
different aspects of what's coming in
better choosing the right activation
function that's huge so we might be
activating based on one thing and we
need to limit that we haven't talked too
much about activation functions so we'll
look at that just minimally uh there's a
lot of choices out there and then
finally there's long short term memory
networks the
lstms and we can make adjustments to
that so just like we can clip the
gradient as it comes out we can also um
expand on that we can increase the
memory Network the size of it so it
handles more information and one of the
most common problems in today's uh setup
is what they call longterm dependencies
suppose we try to predict the last word
in the text the clouds are in the and
you probably said sky here we do not
need any further context it's pretty
clear that the last word is going to be
Sky suppose we try to predict the last
word in the text I have been staying in
Spain for the last 10 years I can speak
fluent maybe you said Portuguese or
French no you probably said Spanish the
word we predict will dep depend on the
previous few words in context here we
need the context of Spain to predict the
last word in the text it's possible that
the gap between the relevant information
and the point where it is needed to
become very large
lstms help us solve this problem so the
lstms are a special kind of recurrent
neural network capable of learning
long-term dependencies remembering
information for long periods of time is
their default Behavior All recurrent
neural networks have the form of a chain
of repeating modules of neural network
connections in standard rnns this
repeating module will have a very simple
structure such as a single tangent H
layer lstm s's also have a chain-like
structure but the repeating module has a
different structure instead of having a
single neural network layer there are
four interacting layers communicating in
a very special way lstms are a special
kind of recurrent neural network capable
of learning long-term dependencies
remembering information for long periods
of time is their default Behavior LST
tms's also have a chain-like structure
but the repeating module has a different
structure instead of having a single
neural network layer there are four
interacting layers communicating in a
very special way as you can see the
deeper we dig into this the more
complicated the graphs kit in here I
want you to note that you have X of T
minus one coming in you have x a t
coming in and you have x a t + one and
you have H of T minus one and H of T
coming in and H of t+1 going out and of
course uh on the other side is the
output a um in the middle we have our
tangent H but it occurs in two different
places so not only when we're Computing
the x of t+ one are we getting the
tangent H from X of T but we're also
getting that value coming in from the X
of T minus one so the short of it is as
you look at these layers not only does
it does the propagate through the first
layer goes into the second layer back
into itself but it's also going into the
third layer so now we're kind of
stacking those up and this can get very
complicated as you grow that in size it
also grows in memory too and in the
amount of resources it takes uh but it's
a very powerful tool to help us address
the problem of complicated long
sequential information coming in like we
were just looking at in the sentence and
when we're looking at our long shortterm
memory network uh there's three steps of
processing in the lstms that we look at
the first one is we want to forget
irrelevant parts so the previous state
you know a lot of times like you know is
as in a unless we're trying to look at
whether it's a plural noun or not they
don't really play a huge part in the
language so we want to get rid of them
then selectively update cell State
values so we only want to update the
cell State values that reflect what
we're working on and finally we want to
put only output certain parts of the
cell state so whatever is coming out we
want to limit what's going out too and
let's dig a little deeper into this
let's just see what this really looks
like like uh so step one decides how
much of the past it should remember
first step in the lstm is to decide
which information to be omitted in from
the cell in that particular time step it
is decided by the sigmoid function it
looks at the previous state h of T minus
one and the current input xit T and
computes the function so you can see
over here we have a function of T equals
the sigmoid function of the weight of f
the H at T minus one and then xit plus
of course you have a bias in there with
any of your neural network so we have a
bias function so F of equals forget gate
decides which information to delete that
is not important from the previous time
step considering an L STM is fed with
the following inputs from the previous
and present time step Alice is good in
physics Jon on the other hand is good in
chemistry so previous output JN plays
football well he told me yesterday over
the phone that he had served as a
captain of his college football team
that's our current input so as we look
look at this the first step is the
forget gate realizes there might be a
change in context after en counting the
First full stop Compares with the
current input sentence of exit so we're
looking at that full stop and then
Compares it with the input of the new
sentence the next sentence talks about
John so the information on Alice is
deleted okay that's important to know so
we have this input coming in and if
we're going to continue on with John
then that's going to be the primary
information we're looking at the
position of the subject is is vacated
and is assigned to JN and so in this one
we've seen that we've weeded out a whole
bunch of information and we're only
passing information on JN since that's
now the new topic so step two is in to
decide how much should this unit add to
the current state in the second layer
there are two parts one is a sigmoid
function and the other is a tangent H in
the sigmoid function it decides which
values to let through zero or one
tangent H function gives the weightage
to the values which are passed deci
setting their level of importance -1 to
1 and you can see the two formulas that
come up uh the I of T equals the sigmoid
of the weight of I a to t minus1 x of t
plus the bias of I and the C of T equals
the tangent of H of the weight of C of H
of T minus one X of t plus the bias of C
so our I of T equals the input gate
determines which information to let
through based on its significance in the
current time step if this seems a little
complicated don't worry cuz a lot of the
programming is already done when get to
the case study understanding though that
this is part of the program is important
when you're trying to figure out these
what to set your settings at you should
also note when you're looking at this it
should have some semblance to your
forward propagation neural networks
where we have a value assigned to a weit
plus a bias very important steps than
any of the neural network layers whether
we're propagating into them the
information from one to the next or
we're just doing a straightforward
neural network propagation let's take a
quick look at this what it looks like
from the human standpoint um as I step
out in my suit again consider the
current input at xft John plays football
well he told me yesterday over the phone
that he had served as a captain of his
college football team that's our input
input gate analysis the important
information John plays football and he
was a captain of his college team is
important he told me over the phone
yesterday is less important hence it is
forgotten this process of adding some
new information can be done via the
input gate now this example is as a
human form and we'll look at training
this stuff in just a minute uh but as a
human being if I wanted to get this
information from a conversation maybe
it's a Google Voice listening in on you
or something like that um how do we weed
out the information that he was talking
to me on the phone yesterday well I
don't want to memorize that he talked to
me on the phone yesterday or maybe that
is important but in this case it's not I
want to know that he was the captain of
the football team I want to know that he
sered I want to know that John plays
football and he was a captain of the the
college football team those are the two
things that I want to take away as a
human being again we measure a lot of
this from the human Viewpoint and that's
also how we try to train them so we can
understand these neural networks finally
we get to step three decides what part
of the current cell State makes it to
the output the third step is to decide
what will be our output first we run a
sigmoid layer which decides what parts
of the cell State make it to the output
then we put the cell State through the
tangent H to push the values to be
between minus one and one and multip it
by the output of the sigmoid gate so
when we talk about the output of T we
set that equal to the sigmoid of the
weight of zero of the H of T minus one
you back One Step in Time by the x of t
plus of course the bias the H of T
equals the out of T times the tangent of
the tangent h of c a t so our o t equals
the output gate allows the past in
information to impact the output in the
current time step let's consider the
example to predicting the next word in
the sentence johon played tremendously
well against the opponent and won for
his team for his contributions Brave
blank was awarded player of the match
there could be a lot of choices for the
empty space current input Brave is an
adjective adjectives describe a noun JN
could be the best output after Brave
thumbs up for JN awarded player of the
match and if you were to pull just the
nouns out of the sentence team doesn't
look right because that's not really the
subject we're talking about
contributions uh you know Brave
contributions or Brave team Brave player
Brave match um so you look at this and
you can start to train this these this
neural network so it starts looking at
and goes oh no JN is what we're talking
about so brave is an adjective Jon's
going to be the best output and we give
John a big thumbs up and then of course
we jump into my favorite part the case
study use case implementation of lstm
let's predict the prices of stocks using
the lstm network based on the stock
price data between 2012 2016 we're going
to try to predict the stock prices of
2017 and this will be a narrow set of
data we're not going to do the whole
stock market it turns out that the New
York Stock Exchange generates roughly
three terabytes of data per day that's
all the different trades up and down of
all the different stocks going on and
each individual one uh second to second
or nanc to nanc uh but we're going to
limit that to just some very basic
fundamental information so don't think
you're going to get rich off this today
but at least you can give an a you can
give a step forward in how to start
processing something like stock prices a
very valid use for machine learning in
today's markets use case implementation
of
lstm let's dive in we're going to import
our libraries we're going to import the
training set and uh get the scaling
going um now if you watch any of our
other tutorials a lot of these pieces
just start to look very familiar cuz
it's very similar setup but let's take a
look at that and um just a reminder
we're going to be using Anaconda the
Jupiter notebook so here I have my
anaconda Navigator when we go under
environments I've actually set up a
carass python 36 I'm in Python 36 and U
nice thing about Anaconda especially the
newer version remember a year ago
messing with anaconda in different
versions of python and different
environments um Anaconda now has a nice
interface um and I have this installed
both on a Ubuntu Linux Ma machine and on
windows so it works fine on there and
you can go in here and open a terminal
window and then in here once you're in
the terminal window this is where you're
going to start uh installing using pip
to install your different modules and
everything now we've already
pre-installed them so we don't need to
do that in here uh but if you don't have
them installed on your particular
environment you'll need to do that and
of course you don't need to use the
anaconda or the Jupiter you can use
whatever favorite python ID you like I'm
just a big fan of this because it keeps
all my stuff separate you can see on
this machine I have specifically
installed one for carass since we're
going to be working with carass under
tensor flow when we go back to home I've
gone up here to application and that's
the environment I've loaded on here and
then we'll click on the launch Jupiter
notebook now I've already in my Jupiter
notebook um have set up a lot of stuff
so that we're ready to go kind of like
uh Martha Stewarts in the old cooking
shows we want to make sure we have all
our tools for you so you're not waiting
for them to load and uh if we go up here
to where it says new you can see where
you can and um create a new Python 3
that's what we did here underneath the
setup so it already has all the modules
installed on it and I'm actually rename
this if you go under file you can rename
it we I'm calling it RNN stock and let's
just take a look at start diving into
the code let's get into the exciting
part now we've looked at the tool and of
course you might be using a different
tool which is fine uh let's start
putting that code in there and seeing
what those Imports and uploading
everything looks like now first half is
kind of boring when we hit the rum
button cuz we're going to be importing
numpy as NP that's uh uh the number
python which is your numpy array and the
matap plot Library CU we're going to do
some plotting at the end and our pandas
for our data set our pandas is PD and
when I hit run uh it really doesn't do
anything except for load those modules
just a quick note let me just do a quick
uh draw here oops shift alt there we go
you'll notice when we're doing this
setup if I was to divide this up oops
I'm going to actually um let's overlap
these here we
go
uh this first part that we're going to
do
is our
data prep a lot of prepping
involved um in fact depending on what
your system in since we're using carass
I put an overlap here uh but you'll find
that almost maybe even half of the code
we do is all about the data prep and the
reason I overlap this with uh carass me
just put that down because that's what
we're working in uh is because carass
has like their own preset stuff so it's
already pre-built in which is really
nice so there's a couple Steps A lot of
times that are in the Kass setup uh
we'll take a look at that to see what
comes up in our code as we go through
and look at stock and then the last part
is to evaluate and if you're working
with um shareholders or uh you know
classroom whatever it is you're working
with uh the evaluate is the next biggest
piece um so the actual code here cross
is a little bit more but when you're
working with with uh some of the other
packages you might have like three lines
that might be it all your stuff is in
your pre-processing in your data since
carass has is is Cutting Edge and you
load the individual layers you'll see
that there's a few more lines here and
cross is a little bit more robust and
then you spend a lot of times uh like I
said with the evaluate you want to have
something you present to everybody else
to say hey this is what I did this is
what it looks like so let's go through
those steps this is like a kind of just
general overview and let's just take a
look and see what the next set of code
looks like and in here we have a data
set train and it's going to be read
using the PD or pandas read CSV and it's
a Google stock pric train.csv and so
under this we have training set equals
data set train. iocation and we've kind
of sorted out part of that so what's
going on here let's just take a look at
let's let's look at the actual file and
see what's going on there now if we look
at this ignore all the extra files on
this um I already have a train and a set
where it's sorted out this is important
to notice because a lot of times we do
that as part of the pre-processing of
the data we take 20% of the data out so
we can test it and then we train the
rest of it that's what we use to create
our neural network that way we can find
out how good it is uh but let's go ahead
and just take a look and see what that
looks like as far as the file itself and
I went ahead and just opened this up in
a basic word pad at text editor just so
we can take a look at it certainly you
can open up an Excel or any other kind
of spreadsheet um and we we note that
this is a comma separated variables we
have a date uh open high low close
volume this is the standard stuff that
we import into our stock one of the most
basic set of information you can look at
in stock it's all free to download um in
this case we downloaded it from uh
Google that's why we call it the Google
stock price um and it specifically is
Google this is the Google stock values
from uh as you can see here we started
off at 13
20102 so when we look at this first
setup up here uh we have a data set
train equals pdor CSV and if you noticed
on the original frame um let me just go
back there they had it set to home
Ubuntu downloads Google stock price
train I went ahead and changed that
because we're in the same file where I'm
running the code so I've saved this
particular python code and I don't need
to go through any special paths or how
the full path on there and then of
course we want to take out um certain
values in here and you're going to
notice that we're using um our data set
and we're now in pandas uh so pandas
basically it looks like a spreadsheet um
and in this case we're going to do I
location which is going to get specific
locations the first value is going to
show us that we're pulling all the rows
in the data and the second one is we're
only going to look at columns one and
two and if you remember here from our
data as we switch back on over columns
we always start with zero
which is the date and we're going to be
looking at open and high which would be
one and
two I'll just label that right there so
you can see now when you go back and do
this you certainly can extrapolate and
do this on all the columns um but for
the example let's just limit a little
bit here so that we can focus on just
some key aspects of
stock and then we'll go up here and run
the code and uh again I said the first
half is very boring when whenever we hit
the Run button it doesn't do anything
cuz we're still just loading the data
and setting it up now that we've loaded
our data we want to go ahead and scale
it we want to do what they call feature
scaling and in here we're going to pull
it up from the sklearn or the SK kit
pre-processing import min max scaler and
when you look at this you got to
remember that um biases in our data we
want to get rid of that so if you have
something that's like a really high
value um let's just draw a quick graph
and I have something here like the maybe
the stock has a value One stock has a
value of 100 and another stock has a
value of
five um you start to get a bias between
different stocks and so when we do this
we go ahead and say okay 100's going to
be the Max and five is going to be the
Min and then everything else goes and
then we change this so we just squish it
down I like the word squish so it's
between one and zero so 100 = 1 or 1 =
100 and 0 = 5 and you can just multiply
it's usually just a simple
multiplication we're using uh
multiplication so it's going to be uh
minus5 and then 100 divided or 95
divided by 1 so or whatever value is is
divided by
95 and uh once we've actually created
our scale we've toing it's going to be
from 0 to one we want to take our
training set and we're going to create a
training set scaled and we're going to
use our scaler SC and we're going to fit
we're going to fit and transform the
training Set uh so we can now use the SC
this this particular object we'll use it
later on our testing set because
remember we have to also scale that when
we go to test our uh model and see how
it works and we'll go ahead and click on
the run again uh it's not going to have
any output yet because we're just
setting up all the
variables okay so we pasted the data in
here and we're going to create the data
structure with the 60 time steps and
output first note we're running 6 time
steps and that is where this value here
also comes in so the first thing we do
is we create our X train and YT train
variables we set them to an empty python
array very important to remember what
kind of array we're in and what we're
working with and then we're going to
come in here we're going to go for I in
range 60 to 1258 there's our 60 60 time
steps and the reason we want to do this
is as we're adding the data in there
there's nothing below the 60 so if we're
going to use 60 time steps uh we have to
start at 60 because it includes
everything underneath of it otherwise
you'll get a pointer error and then
we're going to take our X train and
we're going to append training set
scaled this is a scaled value between
zero and one and then as I is equal to
60 this value is going to be um 60 minus
60 is 0o so this actually is 0 to I so
it's going to be 0 to 60 1 to 61 let me
just circle this part right here 1 to 61
1 uh 2 to 62 and so on and so on and if
you remember I said 0 to 60 that's
incorrect because it does not count
remember it starts at zero so this is a
count of 60 so it's actually 59
important to remember that as we're
looking at this and then the second part
of this that we're looking at so if you
remember correctly here we go we go from
uh 0 to 59 of I and then we have a comma
a zero right here and so finally we're
just going to look at the open value now
I know we did put it in there for one to
two um if you remember correctly it
doesn't count the second one so it's
just the open value we're looking at
just open um and then finally we have y
train. append training set I to zero and
if you remember correctly I2 or I comma
0 if you remember correctly this is 0 to
59 so there's 60 values in it uh so when
we do I down here this is number 60 so
we're going to do this is we're creating
an array and we have 0 to
59 and over here we have number 60 which
is going into the Y train it's being a
pined on there and then this just goes
all the way up so this is down here is a
uh 0 to 59 and we'll call it 60 since
that's the value over here and it goes
all the way up to 12 58 that's where
this value here comes in that's the
length of the data we're loading so
we've loaded two arrays we've loaded one
array that has uh which is filled with
arrays from 0 to 59 and we loaded one
array which is just the value and what
we're looking at you want to think about
this is a Time sequence uh here's my
open open open open open open what's the
next one in the series so we're looking
at the Google stock and each time it
opens we want to know what the next one
uh 0 through 59 what's 60 1 through 60
what's 61 2 through 62 what 62 and so on
and so on going up and then once we've
loaded those in our for Loop we go ahead
and take X train and YT train equals np.
array XT tr. NP array YT train we're
just converting this back in a numpy
array that way we can use all the cool
tools that we get with numpy array
including reshaping so if we take a look
and see what's going on here we're going
to take our X
train we're going to reshape it wow what
the heck does reshape mean uh that means
we have an array if you remember
correctly um so many numbers by
60 that's how wide it is and so we're
when you when you do xtrain do shape
that gets one of the shapes and you get
um XT tr. shape of one gets the other
shape and we're just making sure the
data is formatted correctly and so you
use this to pull the fact that it's 60
by um in this case where's that value 60
by
1199 1258 - 60 1199 and we're making
sure that that is shaped correctly so
the data is grouped into to uh
11.99 by 60 different arrays and then
the one on the end just means at the end
because this when you're dealing with
shapes and numpy they look at this as
layers and so the in layer needs to be
one value that's like the leaf of a tree
where this is the branch and then it
branches out some more um and then you
get the Leaf np. reshaped comes from and
using the existing shapes to form it
we'll go ahead and run this piece of
code again there's no real output and
then we'll import our different carass
modules that we need so from carass
Models we're going to import the
sequential model we're dealing with
sequential data we have our dense layers
we have actually three layers we're
going to bring in our dense our lstm
which is what we're focusing on and our
Dropout and we'll discuss these three
layers more in just a moment but you do
need the with the lstm you do need the
Dropout and then the final layer will be
the dents but let's go ahead and run
this and that'll bring Port our modules
and you'll see we get an error error on
here and if you read it closer it's not
actually an error it's a warning what
does this warning mean these things come
up all the time when you're working with
such Cutting Edge modules that are
completely being updated all the time
we're not going to worry too much about
the warning all it's saying is that the
h5py module which is part of carass is
going to be updated at some point and uh
if you're running new stuff on carass
and you start updating your carass
system you better make sure that your H5
Pi is updated too otherwise you're going
to have an error later on and you can
actually just run an update on the H5 Pi
now if you wanted to not a big deal
we're not going to worry about that
today and I said we were going to jump
in and start looking at what those
layers mean I meant that and uh we're
going to start off with initializing the
RNN and then we'll start adding those
layers in and you'll see that we have
the lstm and then the Dropout lstm then
Dropout lstm then Dropout what the heck
is that doing so let's explore that
we'll start by initializing the RNN
regressor equals sequential because
we're using the sequential model and
we'll run that and load that up and then
we're going to start adding our lstm
layer and some Dropout regularization
and right there should be the Q Dropout
regularization and if we go back here
and remember our exploding gradient well
that's what we're talking about the uh
Dropout drops out unnecessary data so
we're not just shifting huge amounts of
data through um the network so and so we
go in here let's just go ahead and add
this in I'll go ahead and run this and
we had three of them so let me go and
put all three of them in and then we can
go back over them there's the second one
and let's put one more in let's put that
in and we'll go and put two more in I
meant to put I said one more in but it's
actually two more in and then let's add
one more after that and as you can see
each time I run these they don't
actually have an output so let's take a
closer look and see what's going on here
so we're going to add our first lstm
layer in here we're going to have units
50 the units is the positive integer and
it's the dimensionality of the output
space this is what's going out into the
next layer so we might have 60 coming in
but we have 50 going out we have a
return sequence because it is a sequence
data so we want to keep that true and
then you have to tell it what shape it's
in well we already know the shape by
just going in here and looking at xtrain
shape so input shape equals the XT train
shape of one comma one makes it really
easy you don't have to remember all the
numbers that put in 60 or whatever else
is in there you just let it tell the
regressor what model to use and so we
follow our STM with a Dropout layer now
understanding the Dropout layer is kind
of exciting because one of the things
that happens is we can overtrain our
Network that means that our neural
network will memorize such specific data
that it has trouble predicting anything
that's not in that specific realm to fix
for that each time we run through the
training mode we're going to take 02 or
20% of our neurons and just turn them
off so we're only going to train on the
other ones and it's going to be random
that that way each time we pass through
this we don't overtrain these nodes come
back in in the next training cycle we
randomly pick a different 20 and finally
they see a big difference as we go from
the first to the second and third and
fourth the first thing is we don't have
to input the shape because the shape's
already the output units is 50 here this
Auto The Next Step automatically knows
this layer is putting out 50 and because
it's a next layer it automatically sets
that and says oh 50 is coming out from
our last layer it's coming out you know
goes into the regress and of course we
have our Dropout and that's what's
coming into this one and so on and so on
and so the next three layers we don't
have to let it know what the shape is it
automatically understands that and we're
going to keep the units the same we're
still going to do 50 units it's still a
sequence coming through 50 units and a
sequence now the next piece of code is
what brings it all together let's go
ahead and take a look at that and we
come in here we put the output layer the
dense layer and if you remember up here
we had the three layers we had uh lstm
Dropout and D d uh D just says we're
going to bring this all down into one
output instead of putting out a sequence
we just know want to know the answer at
this point and let's go ahead and run
that and so in here you notice all we're
doing is setting things up one step at a
time so far we've brought in our way up
here we brought in our data we brought
in our different modules we formatted
the data for training it we set it up
you know we have our y x train and our y
train we have our source of data and the
answers we're we know so far that we're
going to put in there we've reshaped
that we've come in and built our carass
we've imported our different layers and
we have in here if you look we have what
uh five total layers now carass is a
little different than a lot of other
systems because a lot of other systems
put this all in one line and do it
automatic but they don't give you the
options of how those layers interface
and they don't give you the options of
how the data comes in carass is Cutting
Edge for this reason so even though
there's a lot of extra steps in building
the model this has a huge impact on the
out output and what we can do with this
these new models from carass so we
brought in our dents we have our full
model put together our regressor so we
need to go ahead and compile it and then
we're going to go ahead and fit the data
we're going to compile the pieces so
they all come together and then we're
going to run our training data on there
and actually recreate our regressor so
it's ready to be used so let's go ahead
and compile that and I can go ahead and
run that and uh if you've been looking
at any of our other tutorials on neural
networks you'll see we're going to use
the optimize user adom Adam is optimized
for Big Data there's a couple other
optimizers out there beyond the scope of
this tutorial but certainly Adam will
work pretty good for this and loss
equals mean squared value so when we're
training it this is what we want to base
the loss on how bad is our error we're
going to use the mean squared value for
our error and the atom Optimizer for its
differential equations you don't have to
know the math behind them but certainly
it helps to know what they're doing and
where they fit into the bigger models
and then finally we're going to do our
fit fitting the RN into the training set
we have the regressor do fit XT Trin y
train epics and batch size so we know
where this is this is our data coming in
for the X train our y train is the
answer we're looking for of our data our
sequential input epex is how many times
we're going to go over the whole data
set we created a whole data set of XT
train so this is each each of those rows
which includes a Time sequence of 60 and
badge size another one of those things
where carass really shines is if you
were pulling this save from a large file
instead of trying to load it all into
RAM it can now pick smaller batches up
and load those indirectly we're not
worried about pulling them off a file
today this isn't big enough to uh cause
the computer too much of a problem to
run not too straining on the resources
but as we run this you can imagine what
would happen if I was doing a lot more
than just one column in one set of stock
in this case Google stock imagine if I
was doing this across all the stocks and
I had instead of just the open I had
open close high low and you can actually
find yourself with about 13 different
variables times 60 cuz it's a Time
sequence suddenly you find yourself with
a gig of memory you're loading into your
RAM which will just completely you know
if it's just if you're not on multiple
computerss or cluster you're going to
start running into resource problems but
for this we don't have to worry about
that so let's go ahead and run this and
this will actually take a little bit on
my computer it's an older laptop and
give it a second to kick in there there
we go all right so we have epic so this
is going to tell me it's running the
first run through all the data and as
it's going through it's batching them in
32 pieces so 32 lines each time and
there's 1198 I think I said 1199 earlier
but it's 1198 I was off by one and each
one of these is 13 seconds so you can
imagine this is roughly 20 to 30 minutes
runtime on this computer like I said
it's an older laptop running at uh 0.9
GHz on a dual processor and that's fine
what we'll do is I'll go ahead and stop
go get a drink of coffee and come back
and let's see what happens at the end
and where this takes us and like any
good cooking show I've kind of gotten my
latte I also had some other stuff
running in the background so you'll see
these numbers jumped up to like 19
seconds 15 seconds which you can scroll
through and you can see we've run it
through 100 steps or 100 epics so the
question is what is all this mean one of
the first things you'll notice is that
our loss can is over here it kind of
stopped at 0.14 but you can see it kind
of goes down until we hit about 014
three times in a row so we guessed our
epic pretty close since our loss has
remain the same on there so to find out
what we're looking at we're going to go
ahead and load up our test data the test
data that we didn't process yet and uh
real stock price data set test iocation
this is the same thing we did when we
prepped the data in the first place so
let's go ahead and go through this code
and you see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
from our test CSV you see I've changed
the path on it for my computer and uh
then we'll we call it the real stock
price and again we're doing just the one
column here and the values from iocation
so it's all the rows and just the values
from these that one location that's the
open Stock open let's go ahead and run
that so that's loaded in there and then
let's go ahead and uh create we have our
inputs we're going to create inputs here
and this should all look familiar this
is the same thing we did before we're
going to take our data set total we're
going to do a little Panda concat from
the data State train now remember the
end of the data set train is part of the
data going in and let's just visualize
that just a little bit here's our train
data let me just put TR for train and it
went up to this value here but each one
of these values generated a bunch of
columns it was 60 across and this value
here equals this one and this value here
equals this one and this value here
equals this one and so we need these top
60 to go into our new data so to find
out we're looking at we're going to go
ahead and load up our test data the test
data that we didn't process yet and real
stock price data set test iocation this
is the same thing we did when we prepped
the data in the first place so let's go
ahead and go through this code and we
can see we've labeled it part three
making the predictions and visualizing
the results so the first thing we need
to do is go ahead and read the data in
from our test CSV and you see I've
changed the path on it for my computer
and uh then we'll call it the real stock
price and again we're doing just the one
column here and the values from I
location so it's all the rows and just
the values from these that one location
that's the open Stock open and let's go
ahead and run that so that's loaded in
there and then let's go ahead and uh
create we have our inputs we're going to
create inputs here and this should all
look familiar this is the same thing we
did before we're going to take our data
set total we're going to do a little
Panda concat from the data set train now
remember the end of the data set train
is part of the data going in in and
let's just visualize that just a little
bit here's our train data let me just
put TR for train and it went up to this
value here but each one of these values
generated a bunch of columns it was 60
across and this value here equals this
one and this value here equals this one
and this value here equals this one and
so we need these top 60 to go into our
new data CU that's part of the next data
or it's actually the top 59 so that's
what this first setup is over here is
we're going in we're doing the real
stock price price and we're going to
just take the data set test and we're
going to load that in and then the real
stock price is our data test. test
location so we're just looking at that
first uh column the open price and then
our data set total we're going to take
pandas and we're going to concat and
we're going to take our data set train
for the open and our data set test open
and this is one way you can reference
these columns we've referenced them a
couple different ways we've reference
them up here with the one two but we
know it's labeled as a panda set is open
so pandas is great that way lots of
versatility there and we'll go ahead and
go back up here and run this there we go
and uh you'll notice this is the same as
what we did before we have our open data
set we pended our two different or
concatenated our two data sets together
we have our inputs equals data set total
length data set total minus length the
data set minus test minus 60 values so
we're going to run this over all of them
and you'll see why this works because
normally when you're running your test
set versus your training set you run
them completely separate but when we
graph this you'll see that we're just
going to be we'll be looking at the part
that uh we didn't train it with to see
how well it graphs and we have our
inputs equals inputs. reshapes or
reshaping like we did before we're
Transforming Our inputs so if you
remember from the transform between zero
and one and uh finally we want to go
ahead and take our X test and we're
going to create that X test and for I in
range 60 to 80 so here's our X test and
we're appending our inputs I to 60 which
remember is 0 to 59 and I comma 0 on the
other side so it's just the First Column
which is our open column and uh once
again we take our X test we convert it
to a numpy array we do the same reshape
we did before and uh then we get down to
the final two lines and here we have
something new right here on these last
two lines let me just highlight those or
or mark them predicted stock price
equals regressor do predicts X test so
we're predicting all the stock including
both the training and the testing model
here and then we want take this
prediction and we want to inverse the
transform so remember we put it between
zero and one well that's not going to
mean very much to me to look at a at a
float number between Z one I want the
dollar amounts I want to know what the
cash value is and we'll go ahead and run
this and you'll see it runs much quicker
than the training that's what's so
wonderful about these neural networks
once you put them together it takes just
a second to run the same neural network
that took us what a half hour to train
ahead and plot the data we're going to
plot what we think it's going to be and
we're going to plot it against the real
data what what the Google stock actually
did so let's go ahead and take a look at
that in code and let's uh pull this code
up so we have our PLT that's our uh oh
if you remember from the very beginning
let me just go back up to the top we
have our matplot library. pyplot as PLT
that's where that comes in and we come
down here we're going to plot let me get
my drawing thing out again we're going
to go ahead and PLT is basically kind of
like an object it's one of the things
that always threw me when I'm doing
graphs in Python because I always think
you have to create an object and then it
loads that class in there well in this
case PLT is like a canvas you're putting
stuff on so if you've done HTML 5 you'll
have the canvas object this is the
canvas so we're going to plot the real
stock price that's what it actually is
and we're going to give that color red
so it's going to be in bright red we're
going to label it real Google stock
price and then we're going to do our
predicted stock and we're going to do it
in blue and it's going to be labeled
predicted and we'll give it a title
because it's always nice to give a title
to your H graph especially if you're
going to present this to somebody you
know to your shareholders in the office
and uh the xlabel is going to be time
cuz is it's a Time series and we didn't
actually put the actual date and times
on here but that's fine we just know
they're incremented by time and then of
course the Y Lael is the actual stock
price pt. Legend tells us to build the
legend on here so that the color red and
and real Google stock price show up on
there and then the plot shows us that
actual graph so let's go ahead and run
this and see what that looks like and
you can see here we have a nice graph
and let's talk just a little bit about
this graph before we wrap it up here's
our Legend I was telling you about
that's why we have the legend to showed
the prices we have our title and
everything and you'll notice on the
bottom we have a Time sequence we didn't
put the actual time in here now we could
have we could have gone ahead and um
plotted the X since we know what the the
dates are and plotted this to dates but
we also know it's only the last piece of
data that we're looking at so last piece
of data which ends somewhere probably
around here on the graph I think it's
like about 20% of the data probably less
than that we have the Google price and
the Google price has this little up jump
and then down and you'll see that the
actual Google instead of a a turn down
here just didn't go up as high and
didn't low go uh down so our prediction
has the same pattern but the overall
value is pretty far off as far as um
stock but then again we're only looking
at one column we're only looking at the
open price we're not looking at how many
volumes were traded like I was pointing
out earlier we talk about stock just
right off the bat there's six columns
there's open high low close volume then
there's WEA uh I mean volume shares then
there's the adjusted open adjusted High
adjusted low adjusted close they have a
special formula to predict exactly what
it would really be worth based on the
value of the stock and then from there
there's all kinds of other stuff you can
put in here so we're only looking at one
small aspect the opening price of the
stock and as you can see here we did a
pretty good job this curve follows the
curve pretty well it has like a you know
little jumps on it bins they don't quite
match up so so this Bend here does not
quite match up with that bend there but
it's pretty darn close we have the basic
shape of it and the prediction isn't too
far off and you can imagine that as we
add more data in and look at different
aspects in the specific domain of stock
we should be able to get a better
representation each time we drill in
deeper of course this took a half hour
for my program my computer to train so
you can imagine that if I was running it
across all those different variables
might take a little bit longer to train
the data not so good for doing a quick
tutorial like this so we're going to
dive right into what is carass we'll
also uh go all the way through this into
a couple of tutorials because that's
where you really learn a lot is when you
roll up your sleeves so we talk about
what is carass carass is a highlevel
deep learning API written in Python for
easy impl implementation of neural
networks uses deep learning Frameworks
such as tensorflow pytorch Etc is back
in to make computation
faster and this is really nice because
as a programmer there is so much stuff
out there and it's evolving so fast it
can get confusing and having some kind
of high level order in there we can
actually view it and easily program
these different neural networks uh is
really powerful it's really powerful to
to um uh have something out really quick
and also be able to start testing your
models and seeing where you're going so
cross works by using complex deep
learning Frameworks such as tensorflow
pytorch um ml play Etc as the back end
for fast computation while providing a
userfriendly and easy tolearn front end
and you can see here we have the carass
API uh specifications and under that
you'd have like TF carass for tensor
flow thano carass and so on and then you
have your tensor flow workflow that this
is all sitting on top
of and this is like I said it organizes
everything the heavy lifting is still
done by tensor flow or whatever you know
underlying package you put in there and
this is really nice because you don't
have to um dig as deeply into the heavy
end stuff while still having a very
robust package you can get up and
running rather quickly and it doesn't
distract from the processing time
because all the heavy lifting is done by
packages like tensor flow this is the
organization on top of it so the working
principle of
carass uh the working principle of
carass is carass uses computational
graphs to to express and evaluate
mathematical
Expressions you can see here we put them
in blue they have the expression um
expressing complex problems as a
combination of simple mathematical
operators uh where we have like the
percentage or in this case in Python
that's usually your uh left your um
remainder or multiplication uh you might
have the operator of x uh to the power
of point3 and it us is useful for
calculating derivatives by using uh back
propagation so for we're doing with
neural networks we send the error back
up to figure out how to change it uh
this makes it really easy to do that
without really having not banging your
head and having to hand write everything
it's easier to implement distributed
computation and for solving complex
problems uh specify input and outputs
and make sure all nodes are
connected and so this is really nice as
you come in through is that um as your
layers are going in there you can get
some very complicated uh different
setups now which we'll look at in just a
second and this just makes it really
easy to start spinning this stuff up and
trying out the different models so when
we look at caros models uh caros model
you have a sequential model sequential
model is a linear stack of layers where
the previous layer leads into the next
layer and this if you've done anything
else even like the sklearn with their
neural networks and propagation and any
of these setups this should look
familiar you should have your input
layer it goes into your layer one layer
two and then to the output layer and
it's useful for simple classifier
decoder models and you can see down here
we have the model equals a coros
sequential this is the actual code you
can see how easy it is uh we have a
layer that's dense your layer one has an
activation now they're using the Rao in
this particular example and then you
have your name layer one layer dense
raylo name Layer Two and so forth uh and
they just feed right into each other so
it's really easy just to stab as you can
see here and it automatically takes care
of everything else for you and then
there's a functional model and this is
really where things are at this is new
make sure you update your caros or
you'll find yourself running this um
doing the functional model you'll run
into an error code because this is a
fairly new release and he uses
multi-input and multi-output model the
complex model which Forks into two or
more branches and you can see here we
have our image inputs equals your carass
input shape equals 32x 32x 3 you have
your dense layers dense 64 activation
Rao this should look similar to what you
already saw before uh but if you look at
the graph on the right it's going to be
a lot easier to see what's going on you
have two different
inputs uh and one way you could think of
this is maybe one of those is a small
image and one of those is a full-sized
image and that feedback goes into you
might feed both of them into one note CU
it's looking for one thing and then only
into one node for the other one and so
you can start to get kind of an idea
that there's a lot of use for this kind
of split and this kind of setup uh where
we have multiple information coming in
but the information's very different
even though it overlaps and you don't
want it to send it through the same
neural network um and they're finding
that this trains faster and is also has
a better result depending on how you
split the data up and and how you Fork
the models coming
down and so in here we do have the two
complex uh models coming in uh we have
our image inputs which is a 32x 32 by3
or three channels or four if you're
having an alpha channel uh you have your
dense your layers dense is 64 activation
using the railu very common uh x equals
dense inputs X layers dense x64
activation equals Ru X outputs equals
layers dense 10 X model equals coros
model inputs equals inputs outputs
equals outpos name equals nin
model uh so we add a little name on
there and again this is this kind of
split here this is setting us up to um
have the input go into different areas
so if you're already looking at corus
you probably already have this answer
what are neural networks uh but it's
always good to get on the same page and
for those people who don't fully
understand neural networks to dive into
them a little bit or do a quick overview
neural networks are deep learning
algorithms modeled after the human brain
they use multiple neurons which are
mathematical operations to break down
and solve complex maical
problems and so just like the neuron one
neuron fires in and it fires out to all
these other neurons or nodes as we call
them and eventually they all come down
to your output layer and you can see
here we have the really standard graph
input layer a hidden layer and an output
layer one of the biggest parts of any
data processing is your data
pre-processing
uh so we always have to touch base on
that with the neural network like many
of these models they're kind of uh when
you first start using them they're like
a black box you put your data in you
train it and you test it and see how
good it was and you have to pre-process
that data because bad data in is uh bad
outputs so in data pre-processing we
will create our own data examples set
with carass the data consists of a
clinical trial conducted on 2100
patients ranging from ages 13 to 100
with a the patients under 65 and the
other half over 65 years of age we want
to find the possibility of a patient
experiencing side effects due to their
age and you can think of this in today's
world with uh coid uh what's going to
happen on there and we're going to go
ahead and do an example of that in our
uh life handson like I said most of this
you really need to have handson to
understand so let's go ahead and bring
up our anaconda and uh open that up and
open up a Jupiter notebook for doing the
python code in now if you're not
familiar with those you can use pretty
much any of your uh setups I just like
those for doing demos and uh showing
people especially shareholders it really
helps it's a nice visual so let me go
and flip over to our anaconda and the
Anaconda has a lot of cool to tools they
just added datal lore and IBM Watson
Studio clad into the Anaconda framework
but we'll be in the jupyter lab or
jupyter notebook um I'm going to do
Jupiter notebook for this because I use
the lab for like large projects with
multiple pieces because it has a
multiple tabs where the notebook will
work fine for what we're doing and this
opens up in our browser window because
that's how jupter notebook sorry jupyter
notebook is set to run and we'll go
under new create a new Python 3 and uh
it creates an Untitled python we'll go
ahead and give this a title and we'll
just call this uh k
tutorial and let's change that to
Capital there we go we going and just
rename that and the first thing we want
to go ahead and do is uh get some
pre-processing tools involved and so we
need to go ahead and import some stuff
for that like our numpy do some random
number
Generation Um I mentioned sklearn or
your s kit if you're installing sklearn
the SK learn and stuff it's a site kit
you want to look
up that should be a tool of anybody who
is uh doing data science if you if
you're not if you're not familiar with
the sklearn
toolkit it's huge uh but there's so many
things in there that we always go back
to and we want to go ahead and create
some train labels and train samples uh
for training our
data and then just a note of what we're
we're actually doing in here uh let me
go ahead and change this this is kind of
a fun thing you can do we can change the
code to
markdown and then markdown code is nice
for doing examples once you've already
built this uh our example data we're
going to do
experimental there we go experimental
drug was tested on 2100 individuals
between 13 to 100 years of age half the
participants are under 65 and 95% of
participants are under 65 experim
experien no side effects well 95% of
participants over 65 um experience side
effects so that's kind of where we're
starting at um and this is just a real
quick example because we're going to do
another one with a little bit more uh
complicated
information uh and so we want to go
ahead and
generate our setup uh so we want to do
for I in range and we want to go ahead
and create if you look here we have
random
integers train the labels pin so we're
just creating some random
data uh let me go ahead and just run
that and so once we've created our
random data and if you if I mean you can
certainly ask for a copy of the code
from Simply learn they'll send you a
copy of this or you can zoom in on the
video and see how we went ahead and did
our train samples a pin um and we're
just using this I do this kind of stuff
all the time I was running a thing on uh
that had to do with errors following a
bell-shaped curve curve on uh a standard
distribution error and so what do I do I
generate the data on a standard
distribution error to see what it looks
like and how my code processes it since
that was the Baseline I was looking for
in this we're just doing uh uh
generating random data for our setup on
here and uh we could actually go in uh
print some of the data up let's just do
this
print um we'll do
train sample
and we'll just do the first um five
pieces of data in there to see what that
looks like and you can see the first
five pieces of data in our train samples
is 49 85 41 68 19 just random numbers
generated in there that's all that is uh
and we generated significantly more than
that um let's see 50 up here 1,000 yeah
so there's 1,00 here 1,000 numbers we
generated and we could also if we wanted
to find that out we could do a quick uh
print the length of it
and so or you could do a shape kind of
thing and if you're using
numpy although the link for this is just
fine and there we go it's actually 2100
like we said in the demo setup in
there and then we want to go ahead and
take our labels oh that was our train
labels we also did samples didn't
we uh so we could also print do the same
thing
oh
labels um and let's change this
to
labels and
[Music]
labels and run that just to double check
and sure enough we have 2100 and they're
labeled one Z one0 one0 I guess that's
if they have symptoms or not one
symptoms uh zero none and so we want to
go ahead and take our train labels and
we'll convert it into a numpy array and
the same thing with our samples and
let's go ahead and run that and we also
Shuffle uh this is just a neat feature
you can do in uh numpy right here put my
drawing thing on which I didn't have on
earlier um I can take the data and I can
Shuffle it uh so we have our so it's it
just randomizes it that's all that's
doing um we've already randomized it so
it's kind of an Overkill it's not really
necessary
but if you're doing uh a larger package
where the data is coming in and a lot of
times it's organized somehow and you
want to randomize it just to make sure
that that you know the input doesn't
follow a certain pattern uh that might
create a bias in your model and we go
ahe and create a scaler uh the scaler
range uh minimum Max scaler feature
range 0 to
one uh then we go ahead and scale the uh
scaled train samples we're going to go
ahead and fit and transform the data uh
so it's nice and scaled and that is the
age uh so you can see up here we have 49
85 41 we're just moving that so it's
going to be uh between zero and one and
so this is true with any of your neural
networks you really want to convert the
data uh to zero and one otherwise you
create a bias uh so if you have like a
100 creates a bias
versus the math behind it gets really
complicated um if you start multiplying
stuff because a lot of multiplication
addition going on in there that higher
end value will eventually multiply down
and it will have a huge bias as to how
the model fits it and then it will not
fit as well and then one of the fun
things we can do in jupter Notebook is
that if you have a variable and you're
not doing anything with it it's the last
one on the line it will automatically
print um and we're just going to look at
the first five samples on here and so
it's going to print the first five
samples and you can see here we go uh 9
1 195 791 so everything's between 0 and
one and that just shows us that we
scaled it properly and it looks good uh
it really helps a lot to do these kind
of print UPS halfway through uh you
never know what's going to go on
there I don't know how many times I've
gotten down and found out that the data
sent to me that I thought was scaled was
not and then I have to go back and track
it down and figure it out on
there uh so let's go ahead and create
our artificial neural
network and for doing that this is where
we start diving into tensor flow and
carass uh tensor
flow if you don't know the history of
tensor
flow it helps to uh jump into we'll just
use
Wikipedia careful don't quote Wikipedia
on these things because you get in
trouble uh but it's a good place to
start uh back in 2011 Google brain built
disbelief as a proprietary machine
learning setup tensor flow became the
open source for it uh so tensor flow was
a Google product and then it became uh
open sourced and now it's just become
probably one of the defos when it comes
for neural networks as far as where
we're at uh so when you see the
tensorflow
setup it it's got like a huge following
there are some other setups like a um
the S kit under the sklearn has our own
little neural network uh but the
tensorflow is the most robust one out
there right now and carass sitting on
top of it makes it a very powerful tool
so we can leverage both the carass uh
easiness in which we can build a
sequential setup on top of tensor flow
and so in here we're going to go ahead
and do our input of tensor flow uh and
then we have the rest of this is all
carass here here from number two down uh
we're going to import from tensorflow
the caros uh connection and then you
have your tensorflow cross models import
sequential it's a specific kind of model
we'll look at that in just a second if
you remember from the files that means
it goes from one layer to the next layer
to the next layer there's no funky
splits or anything like
that uh and then we have from tensor
flow cross layers we're going to import
our activation and our dense
layer and we have our Optimizer atom um
this is a big thing to be aware of how
you optimize uh your data when you first
do it atom's as good as any atom is
usually uh there's a number of Optimizer
out there there's about uh there's a
couple main ons but atom is usually
assigned to bigger data uh it works fine
usually the lower data does it just find
but atom is probably the mostly used but
there are some more out there and
depending on what you're doing with your
layers your different layers might have
different activations on them and then
finally down here you'll see um our
setup where we want to go ahead and use
the
metrics and we're going to use the
tensorflow cross metrics um for
categorical cross centropy uh so we can
see how everything performs when we're
done that's all that is um a lot of
times you'll see us go back and forth
between tensor flow and then pyit has a
lot of really good metrics also for
measuring these things
um again it's the end of the you know at
the end of the story how good does your
model do and we'll go ahead and load all
that and then comes the fun part um I
actually like to spend hours messing
with these
things and uh four lines of code you're
like ah you're G to spend hours on four
lines of code um no we don't spend hours
on four lines of code that's not what
we're talking about when I say spend
hours on four lines of code uh what we
have here I'm GNA explain that in just a
second we have a model and it's a
sequential model if you remember
correctly we mentioned the sequential up
here where it goes from one layer to the
next and our first layer is going to be
your
input it's going to be uh what they call
D which is um you usually it's just D
and then you have your input and your
activation um how many units are coming
in we have 16 uh what's the shape What's
the activation and this is where it gets
interesting um because we have in here
uh
railu on two of these and soft Max
activation on one of these there are so
many different options for what these
mean um and how they function how does
the rayu how does the softmax
function and they do a lot of different
things um we're not going to go into the
activations in here that is what really
you spend hours doing is looking at
these different activations
um and just some of it is just U um
almost like you're playing with it like
an artist you start getting a fill for
like a uh inverse tangent activation or
the tan
activation takes up a huge processing
amount uh so you don't see it a lot yet
it comes up with a better solution
especially when you're doing uh when
you're analyzing Word documents and
you're tokenizing the words and so
you'll see this shift from one to the
other because you're both trying to
build a better model and if you're
working on a huge data set um it'll
crash the system it'll just take too
long to process um and then you see
things like soft Max uh soft Max
generates an interesting um
setup where a lot of these when you talk
about Ru oops let me do this uh Ru there
we go Ru has um a setup where if it's
it's less than zero it's zero and then
it goes up um and then you might have
what they call lazy uh setup where it
has a slight negative to it so that the
errors can translate better same thing
with softmax it has a slight laziness to
it so that errors translate better all
these little
details make a huge different on your
model um so one of the really cool
things about data science that I like is
you build your uh what they call you
build def and it's an interesting uh
design setup oops I forgot the end of my
code
here the concept to build a fail is you
want the model as a whole to work so you
can test your model
out so it's you can do uh you can get to
the end and you can do your let's see
where was it overshot down here you can
test your test out the the quality of
your setup on there and see where did I
do my tensor flow oh here we go I did it
was right above me here we go we start
doing your cross enty and stuff like
that is you need a full functional set
of code so that when you run
it you can then test your model out and
say hey it's either this model works
better than this model and this is why
um and then you can start swapping in
these models and so when I say I spend a
huge amount of time on pre-processing
data is probably 80% of your programming
time um well between those two it's like
80 20 you'll spend a lot of time on the
models once you get the model down once
you get the whole code and the flow down
uh set depending on your data your
models get more and more robust as you
start experimenting with different
inputs different data streams and all
kinds of things and we can do a simple
model summary
here uh here's our sequential here's our
layer our output our
parameter this is one of the nice things
about carass is you just you can see
right here here's our sequential one
model boom boom boom boom everything's
set and clear and easy to read so once
we have our model built uh the next
thing we're going to want to do is we're
want to go ahead and train that
model and so the next step is of course
model
training and when we come in here this a
lot of times is just paired with the
model because it's so straightforward
it's nice to print out the model setup
so you can have a track
but here's our model uh the key word in
carass is
compile Optimizer atom learning rate
another term right there that we're just
skipping right over that really becomes
the meat of um the setup is your
learning rate uh so whoops I forgot that
I had an arrow but I'll just underline
it a lot of times the learning rate set
to 0.0 uh set to 0.01 uh depending on
what you're doing this learning rate um
can overfit and underfit uh so you'd
want to look up I know we have a number
of tutorials out on overfitting and
underfitting that are really worth
reading once you get to that point in
understanding and we have our loss um
sparse categorical cross entropy so this
is going to tell carass how far to go
until it stops and then we're looking
for metrics of accuracy so we'll go
ahead and run that and now that we've
compiled our
model we want to go ahead and um run it
fit it so here's our model fit um we
have our scaled train
samples our train labels our validation
split um in this case we're going to use
10% of the data for
validation uh batch size another number
you kind of play with not a huge
difference as far as how it works but it
does affect how long it takes to run and
it can also affect the bias a little bit
uh most of the time though a batch size
is between 10 to 100 um depending on
just how much data you're processing in
there we want to go ahead and Shuffle it
uh we're going to go through 30 epics
and uh put a verbose of two let me just
go and run this and you can see right
here here's our epic here's our training
um here's our loss now if you remember
correctly up here we set the loss see
where was it um compiled our
data there we go loss uh so it's looking
at the sparse categorical cross
entropy this tells us that as it goes
how how how much um how how much does
the um error go down uh is the best way
to look at that and you can see here the
lower the number the better it just
keeps going down and vice versa accuracy
we want let's see where's my
accuracy value accuracy at the end uh
and you can see point 619 69. 74 it's
going up we want the accuracy would be
ideal if I made it all the way to one
but we also the loss is more important
because it's a balance um you can have
100% accuracy and your model doesn't
work because it's overfitted uh again
you w't look up overfitting and
underfitting
models and we went ahead and went
through uh 30 epics it's always fun to
kind of watch your code going
um to be honest I usually uh um the
first time I run it I'm like oh that's
cool I get to see what it does and after
the second time of running it I'm like
i' like to just not see that and you can
repress those of course in your code uh
repress the warnings in the
printing and so the next step is going
to be building a test set and predicting
it now uh so here we go we want to go
ahead and build our test set and we have
just like we did our training set
a lot of times you just split your your
initial set up uh but we'll go ahead and
do a separate set on here and this is
just what we did above uh there's no
difference as far as
um the randomness that we're using to
build this set on here uh the only
difference is
that we already uh did our scaler up
here well it doesn't matter because the
the data is going to be across the same
thing but this should just be just
transform down here instead of fit
transform uh because you don't want to
refit your data um on your testing
data there we go now we're just
transforming it because you never want
to transform the test data um easy
mistake to make especially on an example
like this where we're not doing um you
know we're randomizing the data anyway
so it doesn't matter too much because
we're not expecting something
weird and then we went ahead and do our
predictions the whole reason we built
the model is we take our model we
predict and we're going to do here's our
xcal data batch size 10 verbose and now
we have our predictions in here and we
could go ahead and do a um oh we'll
print
predictions and then I guess I could
just put down predictions in five so we
can look at the first five of the
predictions and what we have here is we
have our age and uh the prediction on
this age versus on what what we think
it's going to be what what we think is
going to they going to have uh symptoms
or not and the first thing we notice is
that's hard to read because we really
want a yes no answer uh so we'll go
ahead and just uh round off the
predictions using the argmax um the
numpy argmax uh for prediction so it
just goes to a
01 and if you remember this is Jupiter
notebook so I don't have to put the
print I can just put in uh rounded
predictions and we'll just do the first
five and you can see here 0 one 0 0 0 so
that's what the predictions are that we
have coming out of this um is no
symptoms symptoms no symptoms symptoms
no symptoms and just as uh we were
talking about at the beginning we want
to go ahead and um take a look at this
there we go confusion matrixes for
accuracy check um most important
important part when you get down to the
end of the story how accurate is your
model before you go and play with the
model and see if you can get a better
accuracy out of it and for this we'll go
ahead and use the pyit um the SK learn
metrics uh pyit being where that comes
from import confusion Matrix uh some
iteration tools and of course a nice map
plot library that makes a big difference
so it's always nice to
um have a nice graph to look at um
pictures worth a thousand
words um and then we'll go ahead call it
CM for confusion Matrix y true equals
test labels y predict rounded
predictions and we'll go ahead and load
in our
cm and I'm not going to spend too much
time on the plotting um going over the
different plotting
code um you can spend uh like whole we
have whole tutorials on how to do your
different plotting on there uh but we do
have here is we're going to do a plot
confusion Matrix there's our CM our
classes normalized false title confusion
Matrix cmap is going to be in
blues and you can see here we have uh to
the nearest cmap titles all the
different pieces whether you put tick
marks or not the marks the classes the
color bar um so a lot of different
information on here as far as how we're
doing the printing of the of the
confusion Matrix
you can also just dump the confusion
Matrix um into a caborn and real quick
get an output it's worth knowing how to
do all this uh when you're doing a
presentation to the shareholders you
don't want to do this on the Fly you
want to take the time to make it look
really nice uh like our guys in the back
did and uh let's go ahead and do this
forgot to put together our CM plot
labels we'll go and run
that and then we'll go ahead and call
the little the definition
for our
mapping and you can see here plot
confusion Matrix that's our the the
little script we just wrote and we're
going to dump our data into it um so our
confusion Matrix our classes um title
confusion Matrix and let's just go ahead
and run
that and you can see here we have our
basic setup uh no side effects
195 had side effects uh 200 no side
effects that had side effects so we
predicted the 10 of them who actually
had side effects and that's pretty good
I mean I I don't know about you but you
know that's five% error on this and this
is because there's 200 here that's where
I get 5% is uh divide these both by by
two and you get five out of a 100 uh you
can do the same kind of math up here not
as quick on the flight it's 15 and 195
not an easily rounded number but you can
see here where they have 15
people who predicted to have no uh with
the no side effects but had side effects
kind of setup on there and these
confusion Matrix are so important at the
end of the day this is really where
where you show uh whatever you're
working on comes up and you can actually
show them hey this is how good we are or
not how messed up it
is so this was a uh I spent a lot of
time on some of the parts uh but you can
see here is really simple uh we did the
random generation of data but when we
actually built the model coming up here
uh here's our model
summary and we just have a the layers on
here that we built with our model on
this and then we went ahead and trained
it and ran the prediction now we can get
a lot more complicated uh let me flip
back on over here because we're going to
do another uh demo so that was our basic
introduction to it we talked about the
uh oops here we go okay so implementing
a neural network with carass after
creating our samples and labels we need
to create our cross neural network model
we will be working with a sequential
model which has three layers and this is
what we did we had our input layer our
hidden layers and our output layers and
you can see the input layer uh coming in
uh was the age Factor we had our hidden
layer and then we had the output are you
going to have symptoms or not so we're
going to go ahead and go with something
a little bit more complicated um
training our model is a twep process we
first compile our model and then we
train it in our training data set uh so
we have compiling compiling converts the
code into a form of understandable by
Machine we use the atom in the last
example a gradient descent algorithm to
optimize a model and then we trained our
model which means it let it uh learn on
training data uh and I actually had a
little backwards there but this is what
we just did is we if you remember from
our code we just had let me go back here
um here's our model that we
created summarized IED uh we come down
here and we compile it so it tells it
hey we're ready to build this model and
use it uh and then we train it this is
the part where we go ahead and fit our
model and and put that information in
here and it goes through the training on
there and of course we scaled the data
which was really important to do and
then you saw we did the creating a
confusion Matrix with carass um as we
are performing classifications on our
data we need a confusion Matrix to check
the results a confusion Matrix breaks
down the various
misclassifications as well as correct
classifications to get the
accuracy um and so you can see here this
is what we did with the true positive
false positive true negative false
negative and that is what we went over
let me just scroll down
here on the end we printed it out and
you can see we have a nice print out of
our confusion
Matrix uh with the true positive false
positive false negative true negative
and so the blue ones uh we want those to
be the biggest numbers because those are
the better side and then uh we have our
false predictions on here uh as far as
this one so it had no side effects but
we predicted let's see no side effects
predicting side effects and vice versa
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scaleup by simply learn click
on the link in the description to no
more now uh saving and loading models
with carass we're going to dive into a
more complicated
demo um and you're going to say oh that
was a lot of complication before well if
you broke it down we randomized some
data we created the um carass setup we
compiled it we trained it we predicted
and we ran our
Matrix uh so we're going to dive into
something a lot a little bit more fun is
we're going to do a face mask detection
with carass uh so we're going to build a
cross model to check if a person is
wearing a mask or not in real time and
this might be important if you're at the
front of a store this is something today
which is um might be very useful as far
as some of our you know making sure
people are
safe uh and so we're going to look at
mask and no mask and let's start with a
little bit on the
data and so in my data I have with a
mask you can see they just have a number
of images showing the people in masks
and again if you want some of this
information uh contact simply learn and
they can send you some of the
information as far as people with and
without masks so you can try it on your
own and this is just such a wonderful
example of this setup on here so before
I dive into the mass detection uh
talking about being in the current with
uh coid and seeing that people are
wearing masks this particular example I
had to go ahead and update to a python
3.8 version uh it might run in a 37 I'm
not sure I hav I kind of skipped 37 and
installed 38 uh so I'll be running in a
three python 38 um and then you also
want to make sure your tensor flow is up
to date because the um the call
functional uh layers that's where they
split if you remember correctly from
back uh oh let's take a look at this
remember from here the functional model
and a functional layer allows us to feed
in the different layers into different
you know different nodes into different
layers and split them uh very powerful
tool very popular right now in the edge
of where things are with neural networks
and creating a better model so I've
upgraded to python 3.8 and let's go
ahead and open that up and go through uh
our next example which includes uh
multiple layers um programming it to
recognize whether someone wears a mask
or not and then uh saving that model so
we can use it in real time so we're
actually almost a full um end to end
development of a product here uh of
course this is a very simplified version
and there'd be a lot more to it you'd
also have to do like uh recognizing
whether it's someone's face or not all
kinds of other things go into this so
let's go ahead and jump into that code
and we'll open up a new Python 3 oops
Python 3 it's working on it there we
go um and then we want to go ahead and
train our mask we'll just call this
train
mask and we want to go ahead and train
mask
and save it uh so it's it's uh save mask
train mask detection not to be confused
with masking data a little bit different
we're actually talking about a physical
mask on your
face and then from the cross standpoint
we got a lot of imports to do here and
I'm not going to dig too deep on the
Imports uh we're just going to go ahead
and notice a few of them uh so we have
in here let me go alt D there we go have
something to draw with a little bit here
we have our uh image
processing and the image processing
right here me underline that uh deals
with how do we bring images in because
most images are like a a square grid and
then each value in there has three
values for the three different colors uh
carass and tensorflow do a really good
job of uh working with that so you don't
have to do all the heavy listening and
figuring out what's going to go on uh
and we have the mobile net average
pooling 2D um this again is how do we
deal with the images and pulling them uh
dropout's a cool thing worth looking up
if you haven't when as you get more and
more into carass and tensor flow uh
it'll Auto drop out certain notes that
way you'll get a better um the notes
just kind of die uh and they find that
they actually create more of a biased
and help and they also add processing
time so they remove them um and then we
have our flatten that's where you take
that huge array with the three different
colors and you find a way to flatten it
so it's just a one-dimensional array
instead of a 2X two
by3 uh dents input we did that in the
other one so that should look a little
familiar oops there we go our input um
our model again these are things we had
on the last one here's our Optimizer
with our atom
um we have some pre-processing on the
input that goes along with bringing in
the data in uh more pre-processing with
image to array loading the image um this
stuff is so nice it looks like a lot of
work you have to import all these
different modules in here but the truth
is is it does everything for you you're
not doing a lot of pre-processing you're
letting the software do the
pre-processing um and we're going to be
working with the setting something to
categorical again that's just a
conversion from a number to a category
uh 01 doesn't really mean anything it's
like true false um label binarized the
same thing uh we're changing our labels
around and then there's our train test
split classification report um our IM
utilities let me just go ahead and
scroll down here Notch for these this is
something a little different going on
down here this is not part of the uh
tensor flow or the SK learn this this is
the S kit setup in tensor flow above uh
the path this is part of um open CV and
we'll actually have another tutorial
going out with the open CV so if you
want to know more about Open CV you'll
get a glance on it in uh this software
especially the ne the second piece when
we reload up the data and hook it up to
a video camera we're going to do that on
this round um but this is part of the
open CV thing and you'll see CV2 is
usually how that's referenced um but the
IM utilities has to do with how do you
rotate pictures around and stuff like
that uh and resize them and then the map
plot library for plotting because it's
nice to have a graph tells us how good
we're doing and then of course our numpy
numbers array and just a straight OS
access wow so that was a lot of imports
uh like I said I'm not going to spend I
spent a little time going through them
uh but we didn't want to go too much
into
them and then I'm going to create um
some variables that we need to go ahead
and initialize we have the learning rate
number of epics to train for and the
batch size and if you remember correctly
we talked about the learning rate uh to
the negative4
.001 um a lot of times it's 0.001 or
0.001 usually it's in that uh variation
depending on what you're doing and how
many epics and they kind of play with
the epics the epics is how many times
are we going to go through all the
data now I have it as two um the actual
setup is for 20 and 20 works great the
reason I have it for two is it takes a
long time to process one of the
downsides of
Jupiter is that Jupiter isolates it to a
single kernel so even though I'm on an8
core processor uh with 16 dedicated
threads only one thread is running on
this no matter what so it doesn't matter
uh so it takes a lot longer to run even
though um tensor flow really scales up
nicely and the batch size is how many
pictures do we load at once in process
again those are numbers you have to
learn to play with depending on your
data and what's coming in and the last
thing we want to go ahead and do is
there's a directory with a data set
we're going to
run uh and this just has images of mass
and not
masks and if we go in here you'll see
data
set um and you have pictures with mass
they're just images of people with mass
on their face uh and then we have the
opposite let me go back up here without
masks so it's pretty straightforward
they look kind of a skew because they
tried to format them into very similar
uh setup on there so they're they're qu
mostly squares you'll see some that are
slightly different on here and that's
kind of an important thing to do on a
lot of these data sets get them as close
as you can to each other and we'll we
actually will run in the in this
processing of images up here and the
cross uh layers and importing and and
dealing with images it does such a
wonderful job of converting the and a
lot of it we don't have to do a whole
lot with uh so you have a couple things
going on there and so uh we're now going
to be this is now loading the um images
and let me see and we'll go ahead and uh
create data and labels here's our um uh
here's the features going in which is
going to be our pictures and our labels
going out and then for categories in our
list directory directory and if you
remember I just flashed that at you I
had uh uh face mask or or no face mask
those are the two options and we're just
going to load into that we're going to
pin the image itself and the labels so
we're just create a huge array uh and
you can see right now this could be an
issue if you had more data at some point
um thankfully I have a a 32 gig hard
drive or
Ram even that does you could do with a
lot less of that probably under 16 or
even eight gigs would easily load all
this stuff um and there's a conversion
going on in here I told you about how we
are going to convert the size of the
image so it resizes all the images that
way our data is all identical the way it
comes
in and you can see here with our labels
we have without mask without mask
without mask uh the other one would be
with mask those are the two that we have
going in
there uh and then we need to change it
to the one not hot
encoding and this is going to take our
um
up here we had what was it labels and
data uh we want the labels to be
categorical so we're going to take
labels and change it to categorical and
our labels then equal a categorical list
uh we'll run that and again if we do uh
labels and we just do the last or the
first 10 let's do the last 10 just
because um minus 10 to the end there we
go just so we can see what the other
side looks like we now have one that
means they have have a mask one 0 one
0er so
on uh one being they have a mask and
zero no mask and if we did this in
Reverse I just realized that this might
not make sense if you've never done this
before let me run this
01 so zero is uh do they have a mask on
zero do they not have a mask on one so
this is the same as what we saw up here
without mask one equals um the second
value is without mask so with mask
without mask uh and that's just to with
any of your data
processing we can't really a zero if you
have a01
output uh it causes issues as far as
training and setting it up so we always
want to use a one hot encoder if the
values are not actual uh linear value or
regression values they not actual
numbers if they represent present a
thing and so now we need to go ahead and
do our train X test X train y test y um
train split test data and we'll go ahead
and make sure it's going to be uh random
and we'll take 20% of it for testing and
the rest for um setting it up as far as
training their model this is something
that's become so cool when they're
training these Set uh they realize we
can augment the data what does augment
mean well if I rotate the data around
and I zoom in I zoom out I rotate it um
share it a little bit flip it
horizontally um fil mode as I do all
these different things to the data it um
is able to it's kind of like increasing
the number of samples I have uh so if I
have all these perfect samples what
happens when we only have part of the
face or the face is tilted sideways or
all those little shifts cause a problem
if you're doing just a standard set of
data so we're going to create an augment
in our image data generator um which is
going to rotate zoom and do all kinds of
cool thing and this is worth looking up
this image data generator and all the
different features it has um a lot of
times I'll the first time through my
models I'll leave that out so I want to
make sure there's a thing we call build
def fail which is just cool to know you
build a whole process and then you start
adding these different things in uh so
you can better train your model and so
we go and run this and then we're going
to load um and then we need to go ahead
and you probably would have gotten an
error if you hadn't put this piece in
right here um I haven't run it myself
cuz the guys in the back did this uh we
take our base model and one of the
things we want to do is we want to do a
mobile net
V2 um and this what we this is a big
thing right here include the top equals
false a lot of data comes in with a
label on the top row uh so we want to
make sure that that is not the case uh
and then the construction of the head of
the model that will be placed on the top
of the base model uh we want to go ahead
and set that
up and you'll see a warning here I'm
kind of ignoring the warning because it
has to do with the uh size of the
pictures and the weights for input shape
um so they'll it'll switch things to
defaults to saying hey we're going to
Auto shape some of this stuff for you
you should be aware that with this kind
of imagery we're already aug ing it by
moving it around and flipping it and
doing all kinds of things to it uh so
that's not a bad thing in this but
another data it might be if you're
working a different
domain and so we're going to go back
here and we're going to have we have our
base model we're going to do our head
model equals our base model
output um and what we got here is we
have an average pooling 2D pool size 77
head model um head model flatten so
we're flattening the data uh so this is
all all processing and flattening the
images and the pooling has to do with
some of the ways it can process some of
the data we'll look at that a little bit
when we get down to the lower level in
this processing it um and then we have
our dents we've already talked a little
bit about a dense just what you think
about and then the head model has a
Dropout of 0. five uh what we can do
with a
Dropout the Dropout says that we're
going to drop out a certain amount of of
nodes while training uh so when you
actually use the model you will use all
the nodes but this drops certain ones
out and it helps stop biases from up
forming uh so it's really a cool feature
on here they discovered this a while
back uh we have another DSE mode and
this time we're using soft Max
activation lots of different activation
options here soft Max is a real popular
one for a lot of things U so was the
ru and you know there we could do a
whole talk on on activation formulas uh
and why what their different uses are
and how they work when you first start
out you'll you'll use mostly the rayu
and the softmax for a lot of them uh
just because they're they're some of the
basic setups it's a good place to
start uh and then we have our model
equals model inputs equals base model.
input outputs equals head model so again
we're still building our model here
we'll go ahead and run
that and then we're going to Loop over
all the layers in the base model and
freeze them so they will not be updated
during the first training
process uh so for layer and base model
layers layers. trable equals False A lot
of times when you go through your data
um you want to kind of jump in partway
through um I I'm not sure why in the
back they did this for this particular
example um but I do this a lot when I'm
working with series and and specifically
in stock data I wanted to iterate
through the first set of 30 Data before
it does
anything um I would have to look deeper
to see why they froze it on this
particular one and then we're going to
compile our model uh so compiling the
model
atom AIT layer Decay um initial learning
rate over epics and we go ahead and
compile our loss is going to be the
binary cross entropy which we'll have
that print out Optimizer for opt
metric's accuracy same thing we had
before not a huge jump as far as um the
previous
code and then we go ahead and we've gone
through all this and now we need to go
ahead and fit our model uh so train the
head of the network print info training
head
run now I skipped a little time because
it you'll see the run time here is um at
80 seconds per epic takes a couple
minutes for it to get through on a
single current
one of the things I want you to notice
on here while we're while it's finishing
the
processing is that we have up here our
augment going on so anytime the train X
and train y go in there's some
Randomness going on there and is
jiggling it around what's going into our
setup uh of course we're batch sizing it
uh so it's going through whatever we set
for the batch values how many we process
at a time and then we have the steps per
epic uh the train X the batch size
validation data here's our test X and
Test Y where we're sending that
in uh and this again it's validation one
of the important things to know about
validation is our um when both our
training data and our test data have
about the same accuracy that's when you
want to stop that means that our model
isn't biased if you have a higher
accuracy on your uh testing you know
you've trained it and your accuracy is
higher on your actual test data then
something in there is probably uh has a
bias and it's overfitted uh so that's
what this is really about right here
with the validation data and validation
steps so it looks like it's let me go
ahead and see if it's done processing
looks like we've gone ahead and gone
through two epics again you could run
this through about 20 with this amount
of data and it would give you a nice
refined uh model at the end will to stop
at 2 cuz I really don't want to sit
around all afternoon and I'm running
this on a single thread so now that
we've done this we're going to need to
evaluate our model and see how good it
is and to do that we need to go ahead
and make our
predictions um these are our predictions
on our test X to see what it thinks are
going to be uh so now it's going to be
evaluating the network and then we'll go
ahead and go down here and we will need
to uh turn the index in CU remember it's
it's it's either zero or one it's uh 0
one 0 one so you have two outputs uh not
wearing uh wearing a mask not wearing a
mask and so we need to go ahead and take
that argument at the end and change
those predictions to a zero or one
coming out uh and then to finish that
off we want to go ahead and let me just
put this right in here and do it all in
one shot we want to show a nicely
formatted classification report so we
can see what that looks like on here and
there we have it we have our Precision
uh it's 97% with a mask there's our F1
score support without a mask
97% um so that's pretty high high uh
setup on there you know three people are
going to sneak into the store who are
without a mask and that thinks they have
a mask and there's going to be three
people with a mask that's going to flag
the person at the front to go oh hey
look at this person you might not have a
mask um that's if I guess it's a set up
in front of a store um so there there
you have it and of course one of the
other cool things about this is if
someone's walking into the store and you
take multiple pictures of them um you
know this is just an it it would be a
way of flagging and then you can take
that average of those pictures and make
sure they match or don't match if you're
on the back end and this is an important
step because we're g to this is just
cool I love doing this stuff uh so we're
going to go ahead and take our model and
we're going to save it uh so model save
Mass detector. model we're going to give
it a name
uh we're going to save the format um in
this case we're going to use the H5
format and so this model we just
programmed has just been saved uh so now
I can load it up into say another
program what's cool about this is let's
say I want to have somebody work on the
other part of the program well I just
saved the model they upload the model
now they can use it for whatever and
then if I get more information uh and we
start working with that at some point
I might want to update this model um
make a better model and this is true of
so many things where I take this model
and maybe I'm uh running a prediction on
uh making money for a company and as my
model gets
better I want to keep updating it and
then it's really easy just to push that
out to the actual end user uh and here
we have a nice graph you can see the
training loss and accuracy as we go
through the epics uh we only did the you
know only shows just the one Epic coming
in here but you can see right here as
the uh um value loss train accuracy and
value
accuracy starts switching and they start
converging and you'll hear converging
this is a convergence they're talking
about when they say you're you're um I
know when I work in the S kit with
sklearn neural networks this is what
they're talking about a convergence is
our loss and our accuracy come together
and also up here and this is why I'd run
it more than just two epics as you can
see they still haven't converged all the
way uh so that would be a cue for me to
keep
going but what we want to do is we want
to go ahead and create a new Python
program and we just did our train mask
so now we're going to go ahead and
import that and use it and show you in a
live action um get a view of uh both
myself in the afternoon along with my
background of an office which is in the
middle still of reconstruction for
another
month and we'll call this uh
mask
detector and then we're going to grab a
bunch of um a few items coming
in uh we have our um mobilet V2 import
pre-processing input so we're still
going to need that um we still have our
tensor floral IM image to array we have
our load model that's where most of the
stuff's going on this is our CV2 or open
CV again I'm not going to dig too deep
into that we're going to flash a little
open CV code at you uh and we actually
have a tutorial on that coming out um
our numpy array our IM utilities which
is part of the open CV or CV2
setup uh and then we have of course time
and just our operating system so those
are the things we're going to go ahead
and set up up on here and then we're
going to create this takes just a
moment our module here which is going to
do all the heavy
lifting uh so we're going to detect and
predict a mask we have frame face net
Mass net these are going to be generated
by our open CV we have our frame coming
in and then we want to go ahead and and
create a mask around the face it's going
to try to detect the face
and then set that up so we know what
we're going to be processing through our
model um and then there's a frame shape
here this is just our height versus
width that's all HW stands for um
they've called it blob which is a CV2
DNN blob form image frame so this is
reformatting this Frame that's going to
be coming in literally from my camera
and we'll show you that in a minute that
little piece of code that shoots that in
here
uh and we're going to pass the blob
through the network and obtain the face
detections uh so faet do set inport blob
detections face net forward print
detections
shape uh so these is this is what's
going on here this is that model we just
created we're going to send that in
there and I'll show you in a second
where that is but it's going to be under
face
net uh and then we go ahead and
initialize our list of faces their
corresponding locations and the list of
predictions from from our face mask
Network we're going to Loop over the
detections and this is a little bit more
work than you think um as far as looking
for different faces what happens if you
have a fa a crowd of faces um so We're
looping through the detections and the
shapes going through here and
probability associated with the
detection uh here's our confidence of
detections we're going to filter out
weak detection by ensuring the
confidence is greater than the minimum
confidence
uh so we' said it remember 0er to one so
0 five would be our minimal confidence
probably is pretty good um and then
we're going to put in compute bounding
boxes for the object if I'm zipping
through this it's because we're going to
do an open CV and I really want to stick
to just the carass
part and so I'm I'm just kind of jumping
through all this code you can get a copy
of this code from Simply learn and take
it apart or look for the open CV coming
out
and we'll create a box uh the box sets
it around the
image ensure the bounding boxes fall
within dimensions of the
frame uh so we create a box around
what's going we hope it's going to be
the face extract the face Roi convert it
from BGR to RGB
Channel again this is an open CV issue
not really an issue but it has to do
with the order um I don't know how many
times I've forgotten to check the order
colors working with open CV because
there all kinds of the fun things when
red becomes blue and blue becomes red uh
then we're going to go ahead and resize
it process it frame it uh face frame
setup again the face the CBT color we're
going to convert it uh we're going to
resize it image to array pre-process the
input uh pin the face locate face. x.y
and x boy that was just a huge amount
and I skipped over a ton of it but the
bottom line is we're building a box
around the face and that box because the
open CV does a decent job of finding the
face and that box is going to go in
there and see hey does this person have
a mask on
it uh and so that's what that's what all
this is doing on here and then finally
we get down to this where it says
predictions equals mass net. predict
faces batch size
32 uh so these different images of where
we're guessing where the face is are
then going to go through an generate an
array of faces if you will and we're
going to look through and say does this
face have a mask on it and that's what's
going right here is our prediction
that's the big thing that we're working
for and then we return the locations and
the predictions the locations just tells
where on the picture it is and then the
um prediction tells us what it is is it
a mask or is it not a mask all right so
we've loaded that all up so we're going
to load our serialized face detector
model from dis um and we have our the
path that it was saved in obviously
you're going to put it in a different
path depending on where you have it or
however you want to do it and how you
saved it on the last one where we
trained it uh then we have our weights
path um and so finally our face net here
it is equals CB2 dn. read net uh protot
text path weights path and we're going
to load that up on here so let me go
ahead and run
that and then we also need to I'll just
put it right down here here I always
hate separating these things in there um
and then we're going to load the actual
mass detector model from dis this is the
the the model that we saved so let's go
ahead and run that on there also so this
is pulling in all the different pieces
we need for our model and then the next
part is we're going to create open up
our video uh and this is just kind of
fun because it's all part of the open
CV video
setup and let me just put this all in as
one there we go uh so we're going to go
ahead and open up our video we're going
to start it and we're going to run it
until we're
done and this is where we get some real
like kind of liveaction stuff which is
fun this is what I like working about
with images and videos is that when you
start working with images and videos
it's all like right there in front of
you it's Visual and you can see what's
going on uh so we're going to start our
video streaming this is grabbing our
video stream Source zero
start uh that means it's C grabbing my
main camera I have hooked up um and then
you know starting video you're going to
print it out here's our video Source
equals zero start Loop over the frames
from the video
stream oops a little redundancy there um
let me
close I'll just leave it that's how they
had it in the code so uh so while true
we're going to grab the frame from the
threaded video stream and resize it to
have the maximum width of 400 pixels so
here's our frame we're going to read it
uh from our visual uh stream we're going
to resize
it and then we have a returning remember
we returned from the our procedure the
location and the prediction so detect
and predict mask we're sending it the
frame we're sending it the face net and
the mass net so we're sending all the
different pieces that say this is what's
going through on
here and then it returns our location
and predictions and then for our box and
predictions in the location and
predictions um and the box is is again
this is an open CV set that says hey
this is a box coming in from the
location um because you have the two
different points on there and then we're
going to unpack the box and predictions
and we're going to go ahead and do mask
without a mask equals
prediction we're going to create our
label no mask we create color if the
label equals mask
l225 and you know this is going to make
a lot more sense when I hit the Run
button here uh but we have the
probability of the label we're going to
display the label and bounding box
rectangle on the output
frame uh and then we're going to go
ahead and show the output from the frame
CV2 IM show frame frame and then the key
equals CV2 wait key1 we're just going to
wait till the next one comes through
from our
feed and we're going to do this until we
hit the stop button pretty much so are
you ready for this let's see if it works
we've distributed our our model we've
loaded it up into our distributed uh
code here we've got it hooked into our
camera and we're going to go ahead and
run
it and there it goes it's going to be
running and we can see the data coming
down here and we're waiting for the
popup and there I am in my office with
my funky headset
on uh and you can see in the background
my unfinished wall and it says up here
no mask oh no I don't have a mask on uh
I wonder if I cover my mouth what would
happen uh you can see my no
mask goes down a little bit I wish I'd
brought a mask into my office it's up at
the house but you can see here that this
says you know there's a 95 98% chance
that I don't have a mask on and it's
true I don't have a mask on right now
and this could be distributed this is
actually an excellent little piece of
script that you could start you know you
install somewhere on a a video feed on a
on a security camera or something and
then You' this really neat uh setup
saying hey do you have a mask on when
you enter a store or public
transportation or whatever it is or the
require to wear a mask uh let me go
ahead and stop
that now if you want a copy of this uh
code definitely give us a huler we will
be going into open CV in another one so
I skipped a lot of the open CV um code
in here as far as going into detail
really focusing on the carass uh saving
the model uploading the model and then
processing a streaming video through it
so you can see that the model works we
actually have this working model that
hooks into the video
camera which is just pretty cool and a
lot of
fun so I told you we're going to dive in
and really Roll Up Our Sleeve and do a
lot of coating today uh we did the basic
uh demo up above for just pulling in a
carass and then we went into a cross
model uh where we pulled in data to see
whether someone was wearing a mask or
not so very very useful in today's world
as far as a fully running
application and we're going to take a
look at image classification using coros
and the basic setup we'll actually look
at two different demos on
here uh what's in it for you today what
is image
classification Intel image
classification data creating neural
networks with carass and the vgg16
model what is image
classification the process of image
classification refers to assigning
classes to an entire image images can be
classified based on different categories
like we it is a nighttime or daytime
shot what the image represents Etc and
you can see here we have uh mountains
looking for mountains we'll actually be
doing some uh uh pictures of scenery and
stuff like that in deep learning we
perform image classification by using
neural networks to extract features from
images and classifies them based on
these
features and you can see here where it
says like what computer sees and it says
oh yeah we see mostly Forest maybe a
little bit of mountains because the way
the image is um and this is really where
one of the areas that neural networks
really shines um if you try to run this
stuff through uh more like a linear
regression model you'll still get
results uh but the results kind of miss
a lot of things as they as the neural
networks get better better at what they
do with different tools we have out
there uh so Intel image classification
data the data being used is the Intel
image classification data set which
consists of images of six types of land
areas and so we have Forest building
glaciers and mountains sea and Street uh
you can see here there's a couple of the
images out of there as a setup in the in
the um uh Intel image classification
data that they use
and then we're going to go into creating
a neural networks with
carass the convolutional neural network
that we are creating from scratch looks
uh as showing
below you see here we have our input
layer
um they have a listed Max pooling uh so
you have as you're coming in with the
input layer and this the input layer is
actually um before this but the first
layer that it's going to go into is
going to be a convolutional neural
network uh then you have a Max pooling
that pulls those the the convolutional
neural Network's returns uh in this case
they have two of those that is very
standard with convolutional neural
networks uh one of the ones that I was
looking at earlier that was standard
being used by um I want one of the
larger companies I can't remember which
one for doing a large amount of
identification had two convolutional
neural networks each with their Max
pooling and then about 17 dents layer
after it we're not going to do that
heavy duty of a of a code but we'll get
you head in the right direction and that
gives you an idea of what you're
actually going to be looking at when you
look at the flattened part and then the
dense we're talking like 17 dense layers
afterwards uh I find that a lot of the
stuff I've been working on I end up
maxing it out right around nine dense
layers it really depends on what you
have going in and what you're working
with and the vgg16
model uh V tg16 is a pre-trained CNN
model which is used for image
classification it is trained on a large
varied data set and fine-tune to fit
image classification data sets with
ease and you can see down here we have
the input coming in uh the convolutional
neural network 1: one 1:2 and then
pooling and then we do 2:1 2:2
convolutional Network then pooling 3 to2
and you can see there's just this huge
layering of convolution neural networks
and in this case they have five such
layers going in and then three dents
going out or uh more now when they took
this setup this actually won an award uh
back in 2019 for this particular
setup uh and it does it does really good
except that again um we only show the
three dense layers here and as you find
out depending on your data going in and
what you have set up uh that really is n
enough on one of these setups and I'm
going to show you why we restricted it
because it does take up a lot of
processing power in some of these things
so let's go Ahad and roll up our sleeves
and we're going to look at both the
setups we're going to start with the um
uh the first
classification um and then we'll go into
the vgg16 and show you how that's set up
now I'm going to be using anaconda and
let me flip over to my anaconda so you
can see what that looks like now I'm
running in the Anaconda here uh you'll
see that I've set up a main
python uh 38 I always put that in there
this is where I'm doing like most of my
kind of playing around uh this is done
in Python version 3.8 we're not going to
dig too much into versions uh at this
point you should already have carass
installed on there usually carass takes
a number of extra
steps and then our usual um uh setup is
the numpy the pandas uh your SK your s
kit which is going to be the sklearn
your caborn and I'll I'll show you those
in just a minute um and then I'm just
going to be in the Jupiter lab where
I've created a new um notebook in here
and let's flip on over there to my blank
notebook now I'm there's a couple cool
things to note in here is that um one I
used the the um Anaconda jupyter
notebook setup because it keeps
everything separate uh except for carass
uh carass is actually running separately
in the back I believe it's a a c program
uh what's nice about that is that it
utilizes the multiprocessors on the
computer and I'll mention that just in a
little bit when we actually get down to
running the
code and when we look in here uh a
couple things to note is here's our uh
um oops I thought I grabbed the other
drawing thing uh but here's our numpy
and our pandas right here and our
operating system this is our s kit you
always import it as sklearn for the
classification report uh we're going to
be using well usually import like
Seaborn brings in all of your pip plot
Library
also kind of nice to throw that in there
I can't remember if we're actually using
caborn if they just the people in the
back just threw that together um and
then we have the sklearn shuffle for
shuffling data here's our map plot
library that the Seaborn is pretty much
built on um CV2 if you're not familiar
with that that is our image um module
for importing the image and then of
course we have our tents or flow down
here which is what we're really working
with and then the last thing is just for
visual effect while we're running this
um if you're doing a demo and you're
working with uh the partners or the
shareholders uh this tqdm is really kind
of cool it's an extensible progress bar
for Python and I I'll show you that too
remember data science is not I mean you
know most this code when I'm looking
through this code I'm not going to show
half of this stuff to the shareholders
or anybody I'm working with they don't
really care about pandas and all that we
do because we want to understand how it
works uh so we need to go ahead and
import those different um uh setup on
there and then the next thing is we're
going to go ahead and set up our
classes uh now we remember if we had
Mountain Street Glacier building sea and
Forest those were the different images
that we have coming
in and we're going to go ahead and just
do class name labels and we're going to
kind of match that class name of I for I
class name uh equals the class names so
our labels are going to match the names
up
here uh and then we have the number of
uh
classes and print the class names and
the labels and we'll go ahead and set
the image size this is important that we
resize everything because if you're
remember with neural networks
they take one siiz data coming in and so
when you're working with images you
really want to make sure they're all
resized to the same uh setup it might
squish them it might stretch them that
generally does not cause a problem in
these uh in some of the other tricks you
can do with if you if you need more data
um and this is one that's used regularly
we're not going to do it in here is you
can also take these images and not only
resize them but you can tilt them one
way or the other crop parts of them um
so they process slightly differently and
it'll actually increase your accuracy of
some of these predictions uh and so you
can see here we have Mountain equals Zer
that's what this class name label is
Street equals 1 Glacier equals 2
buildings equals 3 C4 Forest equals
5 now we did this as an enumerator so
each one is 0 through five uh a lot of
times we do this instead as um uh uh 0
one 0 one 01 so you have five outputs
and each one's a zero or a one coming
out so the next thing we really want to
do is we want to go ahead and load the
data up and just put a label in there
loading
data just just so you know what we're
doing we going to put in the loading
data down here uh make sure it's well
labeled uh and we'll create a definition
for this and this is all part of your
preprocessing at this point you could
replace this with all kinds of different
things depending on what you're working
on and if you once you download you can
go download this data set uh send a note
to the simply learn team here in YouTube
um and they'll be happy to direct you in
the right direction and make sure you
get this path here um so you have right
whatever wherever you saved it a lot of
times I'll just abbreviate the path or
put it as a sub thing and just get rid
of the directory um but again double
check your paths um we're going to
separate this into a segment for
training and a segment for testing and
that's actually how it is in the folder
let me just show you what that looks
like so when I have my uh lengthy path
here where I keep all my programming
simply learned this particular setup
we're working on image classification
and image classification clearly you
probably wouldn't have that lengthy of a
list and when we go in here uh you'll
see sequence train sequence test they've
already split this up this is what we're
going to train the data in and again you
can see build Forest Glacier Mountain
Sea Street uh and if we double click
let's go under Forest you can see all
these different Forest uh images and and
there's a lot of variety here I mean we
have wintertime we have
summertime um so it's kind of
interesting you know here's like a
Fallen Tree versus um a road going down
the middle that's really hard to train
and if you look at the
buildings A lot of these buildings
you're looking up a skyscraper we're
looking down the setup
here's some trees with one I want to
highlight this one it has trees in it uh
let me just open that up so you can see
it a little
closer the reason I want to highlight
this is I want you to think about this
we have trees growing is this the city
or a
forest um so this kind of imagery makes
it really hard for a classifier and if
you start looking at these you'll see a
lot of these images do have trees and
other things in the foreground weird
angles really a hard thing for a
computer to sort out and figure out
whether it's going to be a forest or a
um
city and so in our loading of data uh
one we have to have the path the
directory we're going to come in here we
have our images and our labels so we're
going to load the images in one section
the labels in another
um and if you look through here it just
goes through the different folders uh in
fact let me do this let
me there we go uh as we look at this
we're just going to Loop through the
three the six different folders that
have the different Landscapes and then
we're going to go through and pull each
file
out and each label uh so we set the
label we set the folder for file and
list uh here's our image path join the
paths this is all kind of n General
stuff um so I'm kind of skipping through
it really
quick and here's our image setup uh if
you remember we're talking about the
images we have our CV2 reader so it
reads the the image in uh it's going to
go ahead and take the image and convert
it to from blue green red to red green
green blue this is a CV2 thing um almost
all the time it Imports it and instead
of importing it as a standard it's used
just about everywhere it Imports it with
the BGR versus RGB um RGB is pretty much
much a standard in here you have to
remember that was CV2 uh and then we're
going to go ahead and resize it this is
the important part right here we've set
it we've decided what the size is and we
want to make sure all the images have
the same size on
them and then we just take our images
and we're just going to pin the image
pin the label um and then the images
it's going to turn into a numpy array
this just makes it easier to process and
manipulate and then the labels is also a
numpy array and then we just return the
output append images and labels and we
return the output down
here so we've loaded these all into
memory uh we haven't talked to much
there'd be a different setup in there
because there is ways to feed the files
directly into your cross model uh but we
want to go ahead and just load them all
really for today's processing and that
what our computers can handle that's not
a big deal and then we go ahead and set
the uh train images train labels test
images test labels and this going to be
returned in our output app pinned and
you can see here we did um uh images and
labels set up in there and it just loads
them in there so we'll have these four
different categories let me just go
ahead and run
that
uh so now we've gone ahead and loaded
everything on
there and then if you remember from
before uh we imported just go back up
there Shuffle here we go here's our
sklearn utilities import Shuffle and so
we want to take these labels and shuffle
them around a little bit um just mix
them up so it's not having the same if
you run the same process over and over
uh then you might run into some problems
on
there and just real quick let's go ahead
and do uh um a plot so we can just you
know we we've looked at them as far as
from outside of our code we pulled up
the files and I showed you what that was
going on we can go and just display them
here too and tell you when you're
working with different
people this should be highlighted right
here um this thing is like when I'm
working on code and I'm looking at this
data and I'm trying to figure out what
I'm doing I skip this process the second
I get into a meeting and I'm showing
what's going on to other people I skip
everything we just did so and go right
to here where we want to go ahead and
display some images and take a look at
it and in this display um I've taken
them and I've resized the images to 20x
20 that's pretty small uh so we're going
to lose just a massive amount of detail
and you can see here these nice
pixelated images um I might even just
stick with the folder showing them what
images we're
processing uh again this is you got to
be a little careful this maybe resizing
it was a bad idea um in fact let me try
it without resizing it and see what
happens oops so I took out the image
size and then we put this straight in
here one of the things again this is
um put the D there we go one of the
things again that we want to
know whenever we're working on these
things uh is the CV2
there are so many different uh image
classification setups it's really a
powerful package when you're doing
images but you do need to switch it
around so that it works with the p plot
and so make sure you take your numpy
array and change it to a u integer 8
format uh because it comes in as a float
otherwise you'll get some weird images
down there um and so this is just
basically we' split up our we've created
a plot we went ahead and did the plot 20
20 by 20 um or the plot figure size is
20 by 20 um and then we're doing 25 so a
5x5 subplot um nothing really going on
here too exciting but you can see here
where we get the images and really when
you're showing people what's going on
this is what they want to see uh so you
skip over all the code and you have your
meeting you say okay here's our images
of the
building um don't get caught up in how
much work you do get caught up in what
they want to see so if you want to work
in data science that's really important
to
know and this is where we're going to
start uh having fun uh here's our model
this is where it gets exciting when
you're digging into these models and you
have here uh let me
get there we
go when you have here if you look here
here's our convolutional neural network
uh
2D and uh 2D is an image you have two
different dimensions XY and even though
there's three colors it's still
considered 2D if you're running a video
you'd be convolution neural network 3D
if you're doing a series going across um
a Time series it might be
1D and on these you need to go ahead and
have your convolutional n network if you
look here there's a lot of really cool
settings going on to dig into um we have
our input shape so everything's been set
to 150 by 150 uh and it has of course
three different color schemes in it
that's important to notice um
activation default is Ru uh this is
small amounts of data being processed on
a bunch of
little um neural
networks and right here is the 32 that's
how many of these convolutional null
networks are being strung up on here and
then the 3X3
uh when it's doing its steps it's
actually looking at uh a little 3x3
Square on each image and so that's
what's going on here and with
convolutional noral networks the window
floats across and adds up all these
numbers going across on this data and
then eventually it comes up with 30 in
this case 32 different feature options
uh that it's looking for and of course
you can change that 32 you can change
the 3X3 so might have a larger setup and
you know if you're going across
150 um by 150 that's a lot of steps so
we might run this as uh 15 by 15 uh
there's all kinds of different things
you can do here we're just putting this
together again that would be something
you would play with to find out which
ones are going to work better on this
setup um and there's a lot of play
involved that's really where it becomes
an art form is guessing at what that's
going to be the second part I mentioned
earlier and I I can only begin to
highlight this um when you get to these
dense layers one is the activation is a
Rilo they use a railu in a softmax here
um it's a whole whole uh setup just
explaining why these are different um
and how they're different because
there's also an exponential there's a
tangent in fact uh there's just a ton of
these and you can build your own custom
activations depending on what you're
doing a lot of different things go into
these activations uh there are two or
three major thoughts on these
activations and Ru and softmax are uh U
well Ru uh you're really looking at just
the number you're adding all the numbers
together and you're looking at ukian
geometry um ax plus b X2 plus
cx3 plus a bias with soft Max this
belongs to the party of um it's
activated or or it's not except it's
they call it softmax because when you
get the the to zero instead of it just
being zero uh it's actually slightly a
little bit less than zero so that when
it trains it doesn't get lost um there's
a whole series of these activations
another activation is the
tangent um where it just drops off and
you have like a very narrow area where
you have from minus1 to one or
exponential which is 0 to one so there a
lot lot of different ways to do the
activation again we can do that' be a
whole separate lesson on here we're
looking at the convolutional neural
network um and we're doing the two pools
this is so common you'll see two two
convolutional neural networks St on top
of each other each with its own Max pull
underneath and let's go ahead and run
that so we built our model there and
then we need to go ahead and
um compile the model so let's go ahead
and do
that
uh we are going to use the atom uh
Optimizer the bigger the data the atom
fits better on there there's some other
Optimizer but I think Adam's a default
um I don't really play with the
optimizer too much that's like the if
once you get a model that works really
good you might try some different
optimizers uh but Adam's usually the
most and then we're looking at a
loss pretty standard we want to minimize
our LW we want
to maximize the loss of error and then
we're going to look at accuracy um
everybody likes say accuracy I'm going
to tell you right
now I start talking to people and like
okay what's what's the loss on this and
that and as a data science yeah I want
to know how the law what what's going on
with that and we'll show you why in a
minute but everybody wants to see
accuracy we want to know how accurate
this is uh and then we're going to run
the fit and I wanted to do this just so
I can show you even though we're in uh
python setup in here where Jupiter
notebook is using only a single
processor I'm going to bring over my
little CPU Tool uh this is eight cores
on 16 dedicated threats so it shows up
as 16
processors and actually I got to run
this and then move it over so we're
going to run this and hopefully it
doesn't destroy my
mic uh and as it comes in you can see
it's starting to do go through the epics
and we said I set it for five epics and
then this is really nice because carass
uses all the different uh threads
available so it does a really good job
of doing that uh this is going to take a
while if you look at here it's um ETA 2
minutes and 25 seconds 24 seconds so
this is roughly 2 and a half minutes per
epic uh and we're doing five epics so
this is going to be done in roughly 15
minutes I don't know about you but I
don't think you want to sit here for 15
minutes watching The Green bars go
across so we'll go ahead and let that
run and there we go uh there was our 15
minutes it's actually less than that uh
because I did when I went in here
realized that uh uh where was
it here we go here's our model compile
here's our model flit uh fit and here's
our epics uh so I did four epics so a
little bit better more like 10 to 11
minutes minutes instead of uh uh doing
the full uh 15 and when we look at this
here's our model we did talked about the
compiler uh here's our history we're
going to um history equals the model fit
we'll go into that in just a
minute and what we're looking at is we
have our epics um here's our validation
split so as we train it uh we're
weighing the accuracy versus you kind of
pull some data off to the side uh while
while you're training it and the reason
we do that is that um you don't want to
overfit and we'll look at that chart in
just a
minute uh here's batch
size this is just how many images you're
sending through at a time the larger the
batch it actually increases the
processing speed um and there's reasons
to go up or down on the batch size
because of the U the the smaller the
batch there's a certain point where um
you get too large of a batch and it's
trying to fit everything at once uh so I
128 is kind of big U depends on the
computer you're on what it can handle
and then of course we have our train
images and our train labels going in
telling it what we're going to train
on and then we look at our four epics
here uh here's our accuracy we want the
accuracy to go up and we get all the way
up to 8 three or
83% now this is actual percentage based
pretty much and we can see over here our
loss we want our loss to go down really
fluctuates uh 55 1.2
7748 uh so we have a lot of things going
on there let's go ahead and graph
those turn that off and our our team in
the back did a wonderful job of putting
together
um this basic plot setup um here's our
subplot coming in we're going to be
looking at um uh from the history we're
going to send it the accuracy and the
value
accuracy labels and set up on there um
and we're going to also look at loss and
value loss so you can see what this
looks like what's really interesting
about this setup and let me let me just
go ahead and show you because uh without
actually seeing the plots it doesn't
make a whole lot of sense uh it's just
basic plotting of uh uh of the data
using the piip plot library and I want
you to look at this this is really
interesting uh when I ran this the first
time I had very different
results um and they they vary greatly
and you can see here our accuracy
continues to
climb um and there's a crossover
here put it in here right here is our
crossover and I point that that out
because as we get to the right of that
crossover where our
accuracy U and we're like oh yeah I got
8% we're starting to get an overfit here
that's what this this switch over means
um as our value um as a training set
versus the value um accuracy stays the
same and so that this is the one we're
actually really want to be aware of and
where it
crosses is kind of where you want to
stop at um and we can see that also with
the train loss versus the value loss
right here we did one Epic and look how
it just flatlines right there with our
loss so really one Epic is probably
enough and you're going to say wow okay
8% um certainly if I was working with
the shareholders um telling them that it
has an 80% accuracy isn't quite true and
and we'll look at that a little deeper
it really comes out here that the
accuracy of our actual values is closer
to 41% right here um even after running
at this number of times and so you
really want to stop right here at that
crossover one Epic would have been
enough um so the DAT is a little
overfitted on this when we do four
epics and uh oops there we are
okay my drawing won't go away um let me
see if and get there we
go U for some reason I've killed my
drawing ability on my
recorder all right took a couple extra
clicks uh so let's go ahead and take a
look at our actual test loss um so you
see where a cross is over that's where
I'm looking at that's where we start
overfitting the model and this is where
if uh we were going to go back and
continually upgrade the model we would
start taking a look at the images and
start rotating them uh we might start
playing with the convolutional neural
network instead of doing the 3X3 window
um we might expand that or you know find
different things that might make a big
difference as far as the way it
processes these things um so let's go
ahead and take a click at our uh our
test loss now remember we had our
training data now we're going to look at
our test images and our test
labels for our test loss here and this
is just model evaluate uh just like like
we did fit up here where was it um one
more model fit with our training data
going in now we're going to evaluate it
on the and and this data has not been
touched yet so this model's never seen
this data this is on uh completely new
information as far as the model is
concerned of course we already know what
it is from the labels we
have and this is what I was talking
about here's the actual accuracy right
here 0 4
48 uh or
4847 so this 49% of the Time guesses
what the image
is uh and I mean really that's a bottom
dollar uh does this work for what you're
needing does 49% work do we need to
upgrade the model more um in some cases
this might be uh oh what was I doing I
was working on uh stock
evaluations and we were looking at what
stocks were the top
performers well if I get that 50%
correct on top
performers uh I'm good with that um
that's actually pretty good for stock
evaluation in fact the number I had for
stock was more like uh um 30 something
percent as far as being a top performer
stock much harder to predict um but at
that point you're like well I'm you'll
make money off of that so again this
number right here depends a lot on the
domain you're working
on and then we want to go ahead and
bring this home a little bit more uh as
far as looking at the different setup in
here and one of the uh from SK learn if
you remember actually let's go back to
the top uh we had the classification
report and this came in from our sklearn
or S kit setup and that's right here you
can see it right here on the
um see there we go uh classification
report right here uh sklearn metrics
import classification report that's what
we're going to look at
next a lot of this stuff uh depends on
who you're working with so when we start
looking at um
Precision you know this is like for each
value I can't remember what one one one
was probably mountains so if 44% is not
good enough if if you're doing like um
you're in the medical department and
you're doing can is it is this cancerous
or not and I'm only 44% accurate not a
good deal you know I would not go with
that um so it depends on what you're
working with on the different labels and
what they're used for Facebook you know
44% I'm guessing the right person I
would hope it does a little bit better
than that um but here's our main
accuracy this is what almost everybody
looks at they say oh 48% that's what's
important um again it depends on what
domain you're in and what you're working
with and now we're going to do the same
model oh somehow I got my there it goes
I thought I was going to get stuck on
there again uh this time we're going to
be using the
vgg16 and remember this one has uh all
those layers going into it so it's
basically a bunch of convolutional n
networks getting smaller and smaller on
here uh and so we need to go ahead and
um import all our different stuff from
carass uh we're importing the main one
is the V g16 setup on there just aim
that there we go
um there's kind of a pre-processing
images um applications pre-process input
this is all part of the VG g16 setup on
there uh and once we have all those we
need to go ahead and create our
model and we're just going to create cre
a
V16 model in here um inputs model inputs
outputs model inputs I'm not going to
spend as much time as I did on the other
one uh we're going to go through it
really quickly one of the first things I
would do is if you remember in carass
you can trate treat a model like you
would a
layer um and so at this point I would
probably add a lot of dense layers on
after the vgg16 model and create a new
model with all those things in there and
we'll go ahead and uh run this uh
because here's our model coming in and
our setup and it'll take it just a
moment to compile that what's funny
about this is I'm I'm waiting for it to
download the um package since I prean
this um it takes it a couple minutes to
download the vgg16 model into here um
and so we want to go ahead and train
features for the model we're going to
predict the we're going to predict the
train images and we're going to test
features on the predict test images on
here and then I told you I was going to
create another model too and the people
in the back uh did not disappoint me
they went ahead and did just that and
this is really an important part um this
is worth stopping for I told you I going
to go through this really quick so
here's our
uh we we have our model
two um coming in and we we've created a
model up here with the vgg16 model
equals model inputs model inputs and so
we have our
vgg16 this has already been
pre-programmed uh and then we come down
here and I want you to notice on this um
right here layer model two layers minus
4 to1 x layer X um we're basically
taking this model and we're adding stuff
onto it and so uh we've taken we've just
basically duplicated this model we could
have done the same thing by using model
up here as a layer um we could have had
the input go to this model and then have
that go down here so we've added on this
whole setup this whole block of code
from 13 to 17 has been added on to our
vgg16 model and we have a new model uh
with the layer input an X down here
let's go ahead and run that and compile
it and that was a lot to go through
right there uh when you're building
these models this is the part that gets
so
complicated that you get stuck playing
in and yet it's so fun uh it's like a
puzzle how can I Loop these models
together and in this case you can see
right here that the layers uh we're just
copying layers over and adding each
layer in um this is one way to build a
new model and we'll go ahead and run
that like I said the other way is you
can actually use the model as a layer
I've had a little trouble playing with
it uh sometimes when you're using the
Straight model over you run into issues
um it seems like it's going to work and
then you mess up on uh the input and the
output layers there's all kinds of
things that come
up let's go ahead and do the new model
we're going to compile it uh again
here's our metrics accuracy sparse
categorical loss uh pretty
straightforward just like we did before
you got to compile the
model and just like before we're going
to take our create a history U the
history is going to be uh new model fit
train
128 and just like before if you remember
when we started running this stuff we're
going to have to go ahead and it's going
to light up our uh setup on here and
this is going to take a little bit to
get us all set up uh it's not going to
just happen in a couple minutes so let
me goe and pause the video and run it
and then we'll talk about what
happened okay now when I ran that these
actually took about six minutes each um
so it's a good thing I put it on hold we
did four epics I actually had to stop it
it's at 10 and switch it to four because
I didn't want to wait an
hour and you can see here our
accuracy um and our loss numbers going
down and just at a
glance it actually performed if you look
at the
accuracy.
2658 um so our accuracy is going down or
you know
26% um 34% 35% and you can see here at
some point it just kind of kicks a
bucket again this is
overfitting that's always an issue when
you're running on uh programming these
different neural
networks and then we're going to go
ahead and plot the accuracy um history
we built that nice little sub routine up
above so we might as well use it and you
can see it right
here uh um there's that crossover
again and if you look at this look how
the how the um uh the red shifts up how
the uh our loss functions and everything
crosses over we're overfitting after one
Epic um we're
clearly not helping the problem or doing
better um we're just going to it's just
going to Baseline this one actually
shows with the training versus the
loss um value loss maybe second epic so
on here we're now talking between the
first and the SE second epic and and
that also shows kind of here so
somewhere in here it starts
overfitting and right about now you
should be saying uhoh uh something went
wrong there I thought that um when we
went up here and ran this look at this
we have the accuracy up here is hitting
that
48% and we're down here
um you look at the score down here that
looks closer to 20% not nearly anywhere
in the ballpark of what we're looking
for and we'll go ahead and run it
through the uh the actual test features
here and and there it is um we actually
run this on the Unseen data and
everything
8 or
18% um I don't know about you but I
wouldn't want you know at 18% this did a
lot worse than the other one I thought
this is supposed to be the super model
the model that beats all models the
vgg16 that won the awards and everything
well the reason is is that um one we're
not pre-processing the data uh so it
needs to be more there needs to be more
um as far as like rotating the data at
you know 45 degree angle taking partials
of it so you can create a lot more data
to go through here um and that would
actually greatly change the outcome on
here and then we went up here we only
added a couple dense layers um we added
a couple convolutional neural
networks this huge pre-train setup is
looking for a lot more information
coming in as far as how it's going to
train and so uh this is one of those
things where I thought it would have
done better and I had to go back and
research it and look at it and say why
didn't this work why am I getting only
uh 18% here instead of 44% or better and
that would be wise it doesn't have
enough training data coming in uh and
again you can make your own training
data so it's not that we have a shortage
of data it's that that some of that has
to be switched around and moved around a
little bit and this is interesting right
here too if you look at the
Precision we're getting it on number two
and yet we had zero on everything else
so for some reason is not
seeing uh the different variables in
here so it'd be something else to look
in and try to find track down um and
that probably has to do with the input
but you can see right here we have a
really good solid 0 48 up here uh and
that's where I'd really go with is
starting with this model and then we
look at this model and find out why are
these numbers not coming up better is it
the data coming in um where's the setup
on there and that is the art of data
science right there is finding out which
models work better and
why so sequential models uh so what
makes this a sequential model sequential
models are linear stacks of layers where
one layer leads to the next it is simple
and easy to implement and you just have
to make sure that the previous layer is
the input to the next layer so uh you
have used for plain stack of layers
where each layer has one input and one
output tensor and this is what tensor
flow is named after is um each one of
these layers is like a tensor each each
node is a tensor and then the layer is
also considered a tensor of
values and it's used for simple
classifier declassify models you can
it's also used for regression models too
so it's not just about uh this is
something this is a teapot this is a cat
this is a dog um it's also used for
generating um uh reget the actual values
you know this is worth $10 that's worth
$30 uh the weather's going to be 90° out
or whatever it is so you can use it for
both classifier and declassify uh
models and one more note when we talk
about sequential models the term
sequential is used a lot and it's used
in different areas and different
notations when you're in data science so
when we talk about time series we'll
talk about sequential that is something
very different uh sequential in this
case means it goes from the input to
layer one to Layer Two to the output so
it's very directional it's important to
note this because if you have a
sequential model can you have a
non-sequential model and the answer is
yes uh if you master the basics of A
quential model you can just as easily
have another model that shares layers um
you can have another model where they
you have an input coming in and it
splits and then you have one set that's
doing one set of uh nodes maybe they're
doing a yes no kind of node where it's
either putting out a zero or a one a
classifier and the other one might be
regression it's just processing numbers
and then you recombine them for the
output um that's what they call a cross
the cross
API so there's a lot of different
availabilities in here and all kinds of
cool things you can do as far as
encoding and decoding and all kinds of
things and you can share layers and
things like that we're just focusing on
the basic cross model with the
sequential
model so let's dive into the meat of the
matter let's do a and do a demo on here
uh today's demo in this demo we will be
performing flower classification using
sequential model and carass and we'll
use our model to classify between five
different types of
flowers now for this demo and you can do
this demo on whatever platform you want
or whatever um user interface for
developing python um I'm actually using
anaconda and then I'm using Jupiter
notebooks to develop in and if you're
not familiar with this um you can go
under environment once you've created
environment you can come in here to open
a terminal window and if if you don't
have the different modules in here you
can do youra install whatever module it
is um just happened that this particular
setup didn't have a caborn in it which I
already installed uh so here's our
anaconda and then I'm going to go
back and start up my jupyter
notebook where I already created a uh
new uh python project Python 3 I'm in
Python 3.8 on this particular one um um
sequential model for flowers so lots of
fun there uh so we're going to jump
right into this the first thing is to
make sure you have all your modules
installed so if you don't have uh numpy
pandas matplot library and Seaborn and
the carass um and sklearn or sidekit
it's not actually sklearn you'll need to
go ahead and install all of those now
having done this for years and having
switched environments and doing
different things uh
I get all my imports done and then we
just run it and if we get an error we
know we have to go back and install
something um right off the bat though we
have numpy pandas matplot Library
Seaborn these are built on top of each
other pandas the data frame and built on
top of numpy the uh um data array and
then we bring in our SK learn or S kit
this is the S kit setup SCI uh kit even
though you use sklearn to bring it in
it's a PS kit and then our carass we
have our pre-processing the images image
data generator um our model this is our
basic model or sequential
model uh and then we bring in from caros
layers uh import dents um
optimizers these optimizers a lot of
them already come in these are your
different optimizers and it's almost a
lot of this is so automatic now um atom
is the a lot of times the default
because you're dealing with a large data
uh and then we get our SGD which is
smaller data does better on smaller
pieces of data and I'm not going to go
into all of these uh different
optimizers we didn't even use these in
the actual demo you just have to be
aware that they are different optimizers
and the Digger the more you dig into
these models um you'll hit a point where
you do need to play with these a little
bit but for the most part leave it at
the default when you're first starting
out and we're doing just the sequential
you'll see here layers dents
and then if we come down a little bit
more uh when they put this together and
they're running the dense layers you'll
also see they have Dropout they have
flatten they have
activation uh they have the uh
convolutional layer 2D Max pooling 2D
batch
normalization what are all these layers
uh and when we get to the model we're
going to talk about them uh a lot of
times when you're just starting you can
just uh uh import cross. layers and then
you have your droing out your flatten uh
your convolutional uh neural network 2D
and we'll we'll cover what these do in
the actual example when we get down
there uh what I want you take from here
though is you need to run your Imports
um and load your different aspects of
this and of course your tensorflow TF
because this is all built on tensor
flow and then finally uh import random
is RN just for random
generation and then we get down here we
have our uh
CV2 that is your um open image or your
open CV they call it for processing
images that's what the CV2
is uh we have our
tqdm the tqdm is for um is a progress
bar just a fancy way um of adding when
you're running a process you can view
the bar going across in the Jupiter uh
setup not really necessary but it's kind
ofun to have um we want to be able to
shuffle some files uh again these are
all different things pill is another um
image processor it goes with the CV2 a
lot of times you'll see both of those
and so we run those we're got to bring
them all
in and the next thing is to set up our
directories and so when we come into the
directories there's an important thing
to note on here other than we're looking
at a lot of flowers which is fun uh uh
as we get down here we have our
directory archive flowers that just
happens to be where the different files
for different flowers are put in we're
noting an X and a z and the x is the
data of the image and the Z is the tag
for it what kind of flower is this uh
and the image size is really important
because we have to resize everything if
you have a neural network and if you
remember from our neural networks uh let
me flip back to that slide
we look at this slide we have two input
nodes here uh with an image you have an
input node depending on how you set it
up for each pixel and that pixel has
three different color schemes usually in
it sometimes four so if you have a
picture that's 150 by
150 uh you multiply 150 * 150 * 3 that's
how many nodes input layers coming in I
mean so this is a massive input a lot of
times you think oh yeah it's just a a
small amount of data or something like
that uh no it's a full image coming in
then you have your hidden layers A lot
of times they match what the image size
is coming in so each one of those is
also just as big and then we get down to
just a single output so that's kind of a
a thing to note in here what's going on
behind the scenes and of course each one
of these layers has a lot of processes
and stuff going
on and then we have our our different uh
directories on here let me go and run
that so I'm just setting the directories
that's all this is um archive flowers
Daisy sunflower tulip dandelion Rose uh
just our different directories that
we're going to be looking
at uh and then we want to go ahead and
we're need to assign labels remember we
defined x and
z so we're just going to create a uh uh
definition here um and the first thing
is uh return flower type
okay just returns it what kind of flower
it is I guess assign label to it uh but
we're going to go ahead and make our
train data and when you look at this
there's a couple things to take away
from here uh the first one is we're just
appending right onto to our numpy array
the image we're going to let numpy
handle all that different aspects as far
as 150 by 150 by 3 uh we just dump it
right into the numpy which makes it
really easy we don't have to do anything
funky on the processing and we want to
leave it like that and I'm going to talk
about that in a minute uh and then of
course we have to have the string a pin
the label on there and I want you to
notice right here uh we're going to read
the image
in and then we're going to size it and
this is important because we're just
changing this to 150 by 150 we're
resizing the image so it's uniform every
image comes in identical to the other
ones uh this is something that's so
important is um when you're resizing or
reformatting your data you really have
to be aware of what's going on with
images it's not a big deal because with
an image you just resize it so it looks
squishy or spread out or stretched um
the neural network picks up on that and
it doesn't really change how it
processes
it so let's go ahead and run that uh and
now we've got our definition set up on
there and then we want to go ahead and
make our uh
training data uh so make the train data
uh daisy flower daisy directory uh print
length of X so here we go let's go and
run that and we're just loading up the
flower daisy uh so this is going all in
there and it's setting um it's adding it
in to the our setup on there to our x
and z setup and we see we have
769 um and then of course you can see
this nice bar here this is the bar going
across is that little added uh code in
there that just makes it really cool for
doing demos uh not necessarily when
you're building your own model or
something like that but if you're going
to display this to other people adding
that little what was it called
um tqdm I can never remember that uh but
the tqdm module in there is really nice
and we'll go ahead and do sunflowers and
of course you could have just uh created
an array of these um but this has an
interesting problem that's going to come
up and I want to show you something
it doesn't matter how good the people in
the back are or how good you are at
programming errors are going to come up
and you got to figure out how to handle
them uh and so when we get all the way
down
to the um where is it dandelion here's
our dandelion directory we're going to
build
um Jupiter has some cool things it does
which makes this really easy to deal
with but at the same time you would want
to go back in there depending on how
many times you rerun this how many times
you pull this so when you're finding
errors uh going in here there's a couple
things you can do and we're just going
to um oh it wasn't there it is there's
our error I knew there was an error this
processed
1,62 out of
1065 now I can do a couple things one I
can go back into our definition and I
can just put in here try and so if it
has a bad conversion because this is
where the errors is coming from uh just
skip it that's one way to do it um when
you're doing a lot of work in data
science and you look at something like
this where you're losing three points of
uh date at the end you just say okay I
lost three points who cares um or you
can go in there and try to delete it um
it really doesn't matter for this
particular demo and so we're just going
to leave that error right alone and skip
over because it's already added all the
other files in there and this is a
wonderful thing about Jupiter notebook
is that I can just continue on there in
the x and z which which we're creating
is still uh running and we'll just go
right into the next flower row so all
these flowers are in there um that's
just a cool thing about Jupiter
notebook uh and then we can go ahead and
just take a quick look and
see what we're dealing with and this is
of course really when you're dealing
with a other people and showing them
stuff this is just kind of fun where we
can display it on the plot Library here
and we're just going to go through and
um let's see what we got here uh looks
like we're going to do like five of each
of them I think is that how they set
this up um plot Library 5 by two okay oh
I see how they did it okay so two each
so we have 5x two set up on our axes and
we're just going to go in and look at a
couple of these
flowers it's always a good thing to look
at some of your data uh no matter what
you're doing we re formatted this to 150
by 150 you can see how it really blurs
this one up here on the Tulip that is
that resize to 150 by 150 um and these
are what's actually going in these are
all 150 by 150 images you can check the
dimensions on the side and you can see
uh just a quick sampling of the flowers
we're actually going to process on here
and again like I said at the beginning
most of your work in data science is
reprocessing this different information
so we need to go ahead and take our
labels uh and run a label encoder on
there and then we're just going to Le as
a label encoder one of the things we
imported and then we always use the
fit um to categorical y comma 5 uh X
here's our array um X so if you look at
this here's our fit we're going to
transform
Z that's our Z array we
created um and then we have Y which
equals that and then we go ahead and do
uh to categorical we want five different
categories and then we create our x uh
NP array of x x = x over
255 so what's going on here there's two
different Transformations one we've
turned our categories into 0 1 2 3 4 5
as the output and we have taken our X
array and remember the X array is three
values of your different
colors this is so important to
understand when we do this across a
numpy array this takes every one of
those three colors so we have 150 by 150
pixels out of those 150 by 150 pixels
they each have three um color arrays and
those color arrays ra range from0 to 250
so when we take the xal X over
255 I'm sorry range from 0 to 255 this
converts all those pixels to a number
between 0o and one and you really want
to do that when you're working with
neural networks uh now if you do a
linear regression model um it doesn't
affect it as much and so you don't have
to do that conversion if you're doing
straight numbers but when you're running
neural networks if you don't do this
you're going to create a huge bias and
that means they'll do really good on
predicting one or two things and they'll
just totally die on a lot of other
predictions so now we have our um X and
Y values uh X being the data n y being
our no one
output and with any good setup we want
to divide this data into our training so
we have X train uh we have our X test
this is the data we're not going to
program the model with and of course
your y train corresponds to your X train
and your y test corresponds to your X
test the outputs and this is uh when we
do the train test split this was from
the S kit s k learn we imported train
test split and we're just going to go
ahead and do the test size at about a
quarter of the data 0.25 and of course
random is always good this is such a
good tool I mean certainly you can do
your own division um you know you could
just take the first you know 0.25 of the
data or whatever do the length of the
data not real hard to do but this is
randomized so that if you're running
this test a few times you can kind of
get an idea whether it's going to work
or
not sometimes what I will do is um I'll
just split the data into three parts and
then I'll test it on two with one being
the U or train it on two of those parts
with one being the test and I rotate it
so I come up with three different
answers which is a good way of finding
out just how good your model is uh but
for setting up let's stick with the X
train X test and the SK learn
package and then we're going to go ahead
and uh do a random
seed uh now a lot of times the cross
actually does this automatically but
we're going to go ahead and set it up on
here and you can see we did an NP random
seed um from 42 and we get a nice RN
number um and then we do TF random we
set the seed so you can set your
Randomness at the beginning of your
tensor flow and that's what the tf.
random. set
is so that's a lot of prep um all this
prep and then we finally get to the
exciting part um this is where you
probably spend once you have the data
prepped and you have your pipeline going
and you have everything set up on there
this is the part that's exciting is
building these
models and so we look at this model one
we're going to designate it sequential
um they have the API which is a cross
the cross tensorflow API versus
sequential sequential means we're going
one layer to the next so we're not going
to split the layer and bring it back
together it looks almost the same with
the exception of um bringing it back
together so it's not a huge step to go
from this to an
API and the first thing we're going to
look at is um our convolutional neural
network in 2D uh so what's going on here
there's a lot of stuff that's going on
here um the default for well let's start
with the beginning what is a
convolutional 2d
Network well convolutional 2D Network
creates a number of small windows and
those small Windows float over the
picture and each one of them is her own
neural network and it's basically um
becomes like a um categorization and
then it looks at that and it says oh if
we add these numbers up a certain way uh
we can find out whether this is the
right flower based on this this little
window floating around which looks at
different things and we have filters 32
so this is actually creating 32 Windows
is what that's
doing and the kernel size is 5x5 so
we're looking at a 5x5 Square remember
it's 150 by 150 so this narrows it down
to a 5x5
it's a 2d so it has your XY coordinates
um and when we look at this 5x5 remember
each one of these is is actually looking
at 5x5
by3 uh so we're actually looking at 15
by 15 different um
pixels and padding is just um uh usually
I just ignore that activation by default
is railu we went ahead and put the ru in
there there's a lot of different
activations rilu is for your smaller
uh when you remember I mentioned atom
when you have a lot of data data use an
atom kind of activation or use an atom
processing we're using the railu here uh
it kind of gives you a yes or no but it
it doesn't give you a full yes or no it
has a um a zero and then it kind of
shoots off at an angle very common it's
the most common one and then of course
here's our input shape 150 by 150 by 3
pixels
and then we have to pull it so whenever
you have a two convolutional 2D um uh
layer we have to bring this back
together and pull this into uh neural
network and then we're going to go ahead
and repeat
this uh so we're going to add another
Network here one of the cool things if
you look at this is that it as it comes
in it just kind of automatically assumes
you're going down to the next layer and
so we have another convolutional null
network uh 2D here's our Max pooling
again we're going to do that again Max
pooling uh and we're just going to
filter on down now one of the things
they did on this one is they changed the
kernel size they changed the number of
filters and so each one of these steps
kind of looks at the data a little bit
differently and that's kind of cool
because then you get a little added
filtering on there this is where you
start playing with the model you might
be looking at a convolutional no network
which is great for image
classifications um
we get down to here one of the things we
see is flatten so we had we just flatten
it remember this is 150 by 150 by 3 well
and actually the pool size changes so
it's actually smaller than that flatten
just puts that into a 1D array uh so
instead of being you know a tensor of
this really complexity with the the
pixels and everything it's just flat and
then the
DSE is just another activation on there
um by default it is probably Ru as as
far as this
activation and then oh yeah here we go
in sequential they actually added the
activation as Rao so this just because
this is sequential this activation is
attached to the dents uh and there's a
lot of different activations but Ru is
the most common one and then we also see
a soft Max uh soft Max is similar but it
has its own kind of variation and one of
the cool things you know what let me
bring this up because if we if you don't
know about these activations this
doesn't make sense
and I just did a quick Google search on
images of tensor flow
activations um I should probably look at
which website this is but this is the
output of the values uh so as your X as
it adds in all those uh weighted X
values going into the node it's going to
activate it a certain way and that's a
sigmoid activation and you can see it
goes between zero and one and has a nice
curve there this also shows the
derivatives um and if we come down the 7
popular activation functions nonlinear
activations there's a lot of different
options on this let me see if I can find
[Music]
the O let me see we can find this
specific to
Rao so this is a leaky
railo and you can see instead of it just
being zero and then a value between uh
going up it has a little leaky there
otherwise your railu loses some notes
they just become inactive um but you can
see there's a lot of different options
here here's a good one right here here
with The Rao you can see the railu
function on the upper on the upper left
here and then the Leaky raayo over here
on the right which is very commonly used
also one of the things I use with
processing um language is the S the
exponential one or the tangent H the
hyperbolic tangent because they have
that nice uh funky curve that comes in
that um has a whole different meaning
and captures word use better again these
are very specific to domain and you can
spend a lot of time playing with
different models for our basic model uh
we'll stick to the railu and the softmax
on here and we'll go a and run and build
this
model so now that we've had fun playing
with all these different models that we
can add in there uh we need to go ahead
and have a batch size on here uh
128 epics
10 this means that we're going to send
128 uh row rows of data or flowers at a
time to be processed and the Epic 10
that's how many times we're going to
Loop through all the
data um and then there's all kinds of
stuff you can do again this is now built
into a lot of carass models already by
default
um so there's different ways to reduce
um the values and verbose verbose equals
one means that we're going to show
what's going on um value monitor what
we're monitoring we'll see that as we
actually train the model this is what's
what's going to come out of there if you
set the verbos equal to zero um you
don't have to watch it train the model
although it is kind of nice to actually
know what's going on
sometimes and since we're still working
on uh bringing the data in here's our
batch site here's our epics we need to
go ahead and create a data generator uh
this is our image data
generator and it has all the different
settings in here almost all of these are
defaults uh so if you're looking at this
going oh my gosh this is confusing most
of the time you can actually just ignore
most of this um vertical flip so you can
randomly flip pictures you can randomly
horizontally flip them um you can shift
the picture around this kind of helps
gives you multiple data off of them uh
zooming rotation there's all kinds of
different things you can do with images
most of these we're just going to leave
as false we don't really need to do all
that um um setup because we already have
a huge amount of data if you're short
data you can start flipping like a
horizontal picture and it will generate
it's like doubling your data almost um
so the upside is you double your data
the downside is that if you already have
a bias in your data you already have um
5,000 sunflowers and only two roses
that's a huge bias it's also going to
double that bias uh that is the downside
of
that and so we have our model compile
and this you're going to see in all the
carass we're going to take this model
here we're going to take all this
information as far as how we want it to
go and we're going to compile it this
actually builds the model and so we're
going to run that and I want you to
notice uh learning
rate very important this is the default
001 um there's there you really don't
this is how slowly it adjusts to find
the right answer and the more data you
have you might actually make this a
smaller number um with larger with you
have a very small sample of data you
might go even larger than that and then
we're going to look at the loss
categorically categorical cross entropy
most commonly used and this is uh how
how much it improves the model is
improving is what this number means or
yeah that's that's important on there
and then the accuracy we want to know
just how good our model is on the
accuracy and then uh one of the cool
things to do is is if you're in a group
of people who are studying the model if
you're in shareholders you don't want to
do this is you can run the model summary
I do this by default and you can see the
different layers that you built into
this model just a quick summary on there
so we went ahead and we're going to go
ahead and create a
um we'll call it history but we want to
do a model fit
generator and so what this history is
doing is this is tracking what's going
on as wallet fits the
model now there's a lot of new setups in
here where they just use fit and then
you put the generator in here um we're
going to leave it like this even though
the new default um is a little different
on that doesn't really matter it does
the same thing and we'll go ahead and
just run
that and you can see while it's running
right here uh we're going through the
epics we have one of 10 now we're going
through six of 25 here's our loss we're
printing that out so you can see how
it's improving and our accuracy the
accuracy gets better and better and this
is 6 out of 25 this is going to take a
couple minutes to process uh because we
are training 150 by 150 by 3 pixels
across uh six layers or eight layers
whatever it was that is a huge amount of
processing so this will take a few
minutes to process this is when we talk
about the hardware and the problems that
come up in data science sence and why
it's only now just exploding being able
to do neural networks this is why this
process takes a long
time now you should have seen a jump on
the screen here because I did uh uh
pause the recorder to let this go ahead
and run all the way through its epics
let's go ahead and take a look and see
what these epics are and um if you set
the verbos to zero instead of one it
won't show what's going on in the behind
the scenes has is training it so when we
look at this Epic 10 epic so we went
through all the data 10 times uh if I
remember correctly there's roughly a gig
of data there so that's a lot of data
the first thing you're going to notice
is the 270 seconds um that's how much
each of those epics took to run and so
if you divide 60 in there you roughly
get about five minutes worth of each
epic so if I have 10 epics that's 50
minutes almost an hour of
runtime that's a big deal we talk about
processing uh on this particular
computer um I actually have what is it
uh eight cores with 16 dedicated threads
so it runs like a 16 core computer it
alternates the threads going in and it
still takes it five minutes for each one
of these epics so you start to see that
if you have a lot of data this is going
to be a problem if you have a number of
models you want to Fe find out how good
the models are doing and what model to
use and so each of those models could
take all night to run in fact I have a
model I'm running now that takes over uh
takes about a day and a half to test
each model um it takes four days to do
with the whole data uh so what I do is I
actually take a small piece of the
data test it out to find out uh get an
idea of of how the different setups are
going to do and then I increase that
size of the data and then increase it
again and I can just take that that
curve and kind of say okay if um the
data is doing this then I need to add in
more dense layers or whatever um so you
can do a small chunks of data then
figure out what it costs to do a large
set of data and what kind of model you
want the loss as we see here continues
to go down uh this is the error this is
how much errors is in there it really
isn't a um userfriendly number other
than the more it Trends down the better
and so if you continue to see the loss
going down eventually get to the point
where it stops going down and it goes up
and down and kind of waivers a little
bit that point you know know you you've
run too many epics you're you're
starting to get a bias in there and it's
not going to give you a good model fit
the accuracy just turns this into
something that uh we can use and so the
accuracy is what percentage of guesses
in this case it's categorical so this is
the percentage of guesses are correct um
value loss is similar you know it's a
minus a value loss and then you have the
value accuracy and you'll see the value
accuracy is pretty similar to the
accuracy um just rounds it off basically
and so a lot of times you come down here
and you go okay we're doing 0.5
6 7 and that is 70% accuracy or in this
case 68 uh 59% accuracy that's a very
usable number and it's very important to
have if you're identifying uh flowers
that's probably good enough if you can
get within a close distance and knowing
what flower you're you're identifying uh
if you're trying to figure out whether
someone's going to die from a heart
attack or not might want to rethink it a
little bit or uh rekey how you're
building your model so if I'm working
with a uh uh a group of um clients um
shareholders in a company or something
like that you don't really want to show
them this um you don't want to show them
hey you know this is what's going on
with the accuracy these are just numbers
and so we want to go and put the
finishing touches just like when you are
building a house and you put in the
frame and the trim on the house it's
nice to have something a nice view of
what's going on and so we'll go ahead
and do a Pi plot and we'll just plot the
history of the loss uh the history of
the value
loss over here um epics train and test
and so we're just going to compute these
this is really important uh and what I
want you to notice right here is when we
get to about oh five epics a little more
than five six epics you see a cross over
here and it starts Crossing as far as
the um uh value loss and what's going on
here is you have the loss in your actual
model and your actual data and you have
the value loss where it's testing it
against the the test data the the data
wasn't used to program your model wasn't
used to train your model on and so when
we see this crossing over this is where
the bias is coming in this is becoming
overfitted and so when you put these two
together uh right around five and six
you start to see how it does this this
switch over here and that's really where
you need to stop right around five yeah
six um it's always hard to guess cuz at
this point the model's kind of a black
box uh see but you know that right
around here if you're saving your model
after each run you want to use the one
that's right around five epics because
that's the one that's going to have the
least amount of bias so this is really
important as far as guessing what's
going on with your model and its
accuracy and when to stop uh it also is
you know I don't show people this mess
up here um I show somebody this kind of
model and I say this is where the
training and the testing comes in on
this model uh it just makes it easier to
see and people can understand what's
going
on so that completes our demo and you
can see we did what we were set out to
do we took our flowers and we're able to
classify them uh within about you 68 70%
accuracy whether it's going to be a
dollia sunflower cherry blossom Rose um
a lot of other things you can do with
your output as far as a uh different
tables to see where the errors are
coming from and what problems are coming
up so here we wrap up full course on
artificial intelligence if you have any
questions post them in the comment
section like share and subscribe for
more updates from Simply learn thanks
for watching staying ahead in your
career requires continuous learning and
upscaling whether you're a student
aiming to learn today's top skills or a
working professional looking to advance
your career career we've got you covered
explore our impressive catalog of
certification programs in cuttingedge
domains including data science cloud
computing cyber security AI machine
learning or digital marketing designed
in collaboration with leading
universities and top corporations and
delivered by industry experts choose any
of our programs and set yourself on the
path to Career Success click the link in
the descript description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click
here